&GT;&GT; THE SENATE WILL COME TO
ORDER.
THE SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
&GT;&GT; ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GILMAN.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY.
ATKINS.
BECKER.
BLAKESPEAR
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
CORTEZ.
DALY.
DODD.
EGGMAN.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GROVE.
HURTADO.
JONES.
LAIRD.
LIMON.
MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
MIN.
NEWMAN.
NGUYEN.
NILO.
OCHOA.
PADILLA.
PORTANTINO.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
SATO.
SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
STERN.
UMBERG.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
WILK.
MEMBERS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SESSION.
TODAY I SEE WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
TWINS IN THE HOUSE.
WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
RECOGNIZE THEM.
I'D LIKE TO ASK MEMBERS AND
GUESTS BE ON
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING
BY OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER
MICHELLE,
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG.
SISTER MICHELLE.
&GT;&GT; AND ALSO ON THIS WORLD
DAY FOR CULTURAL DIVERSITY,
WE PRAY, HOLY MYSTERY YOU,
THE ONE FROM WHOM ON DIFFERENT
PATHS ALL OF US HAVE COME.
YOU THE ONE TO WHOM,
ON DIFFERENT PATHS ALL OF US ARE
GOING.
MAKE STRONG IN OUR HEARTS WHAT
UNITES US.
BUILD BRIDGES ACROSS WHAT
DIVIDES US.
UNITED.
MAKE US REJOICE IN OUR
DIVERSITY.
MAKE US ONE IN OUR WITNESS TO
YOUR PEACE.
A RAINBOW TO YOUR GLORY.
AMEN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE TO
OUR FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
&GT;&GT; ONE NATION UNDER GOD
IS.
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
WE WILL BEGIN WITH PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR.
THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED RED.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP.
WE WILL.
OH, EXCUSE ME, SENATOR CORTEZ.
&GT;&GT; MR.
PRESIDENT, IS THIS THE PLACE TO
MOVE
ITEMS TO THE INACTIVE FILE?
YES, SIR.
ALL RIGHT, I WOULD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE SOME MEMBER
TINGS.
AB 347 FROM THE FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE.
REMOVE AB 347 FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THE DESK WILL NOTE ANY FURTHER
MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS OR NOTICES.
MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE.
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE SECRETARY.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH SECOND READING.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 936, 1054, 1282 1414
1348, 1494.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE AN ITEM UP
IN A FEW MINUTES.
AND ON UNFINISHED RIGHT.
I'M JUST NOTING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO COME
BACK TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS IN A
MOMENT,
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
SENATE THIRD READING.
MEMBERS, IF YOU WANT TO KNOW THE
SCHEDULE
OF ACTIVITIES THIS MORNING,
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A HEADS UP
SO YOU CAN BE AWARE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH SENATE
THIRD READING.
WE HAVE FIVE BILLS UP.
THEY ARE FILE ITEM.
IF YOU WANT TO NOTE THIS 24, 28,
29, 30 AND 34.
FOLLOWING THAT, WE WILL MOVE
BACK TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM 21 TO
CONCUR
IN ASSEMBLY AMENDMENT.
SO THAT'S THE DOCKET FOR THIS
MORNING.
ABOUT ON CALL AND MEMBERS,
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A MEMBER OFF
THE FLOOR.
THIS MORNING WE WILL BE GOING
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE
TIME AND THEN PUTTING PUTTING
MATTERS ON CALL.
SO BE AWARE OF THAT FOR THIS
MORNING.
OKAY.
WE'LL GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE
TIME.
ALL RIGHT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
FILE ITEM 24.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1001 BY
SENATOR SKINNER.
SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1001 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
AN ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE.
SENATOR SKINNER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, PLEASED TO PRESENT SB
1000.
2001.
OKAY.
YES.
SORRY, I THOUGHT I WAS GOING
WITH THE OTHER ONE FIRST.
ALL RIGHT.
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB 1001,
WHICH ESTABLISHES A PROCESS FOR
A PERSON WHO
HAS RECEIVED A DEATH PENALTY
SENTENCE.
BUT WHO HAS A DEVELOPMENTAL
OR INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY.
WHILE REFER FROM THIS POINT ON
AS INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY.
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE EXPERT
EVIDENCE
THAT THEIR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY MANIFESTED PRIOR TO
THE AGE OF 25.
NOW, UNDER OUR CURRENT LAW,
IF YOU HAVE A DIAGNOSIS THAT
THAT YOU HAD SUCH A DISABILITY
BEFORE THE AGE OF 25,
AND THAT DIAGNOSIS IS PRESENT
WHEN YOU FACE A CONVICTION.
YOU ARE INELIGIBLE FOR A DEATH
SENTENCE,
AND THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
EIGHTH AMENDMENT.
BUT WE HAVE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
PEOPLE
WITH THESE INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES,
FOR ANY NUMBER OF REASONS,
DID NOT RECEIVE THAT DIAGNOSIS.
YOU COULD IMAGINE THAT PERSON
DIDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
THEY WEREN'T AT SCHOOLS THAT DID
SUCH TESTING.
THERE'S ANY NUMBER OF REASONS
WHY THEY MAY NOT
HAVE HAD THAT DIAGNOSIS BEFORE
THE AGE OF 25.
NOW, THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
OUR CURRENT STATUTE IN
THAT THE PRESENCE OF THE
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY
OR THE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
MUST HAVE
BEEN PRESENT IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL PERIOD.
SO IT MUST HAVE BEEN PRESENT
BEFORE THE AGE OF 25.
MY BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
TOUCH OR THWART THAT.
THAT IS STILL THE LAW.
BUT WHAT IT DOES DO IS ALLOW,
IF A PERSON CAN PROVIDE
THE CREDIBLE EVIDENCE WITH
EXPERTS
WHO DO SUCH TESTING,
MEDICAL AND OTHER EXPERTS,
THEN THEY WOULD AVOID THE DEATH
PENALTY.
THEY WOULD STILL HAVE LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE,
BUT THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BE
EXECUTED.
NOW YOU MAY WONDER, WHY AM I
BRINGING THIS BILL?
NOW WE HAVE A MORATORIUM ON
EXECUTIONS,
BUT THE FACT IS,
THE DEATH PENALTY IS STILL LAW
IN CALIFORNIA
AND EXECUTIONS COULD BEGIN
AGAIN.
AND WHAT THIS DOES IS HELPS
US ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE EIGHTH
AMENDMENT
AND PROTECTS AGAINST THE
EXECUTION OF PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL?
ANY DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN.
ALVARO GIL.
HI, ARCHULETA.
HI, ASHBY.
I ATKINS.
I BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ.
I DELHI.
NO.
DODD I DURAZZO.
I EGGMAN.
GLASER I.
I.
GONZALEZ.
GROVE.
HURTADO.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD.
A LIMO.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
NEWMAN I.
WAYNE.
NO.
NEELO.
OKOBO.
BUT HERE I PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
RUBIO I CIERTO.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMALL GRAVIS.
I STERN I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WOKE.
NO MEMBERS.
I'VE BEEN INFORMED THAT WE DO
HAVE A FULL HOUSE NOW,
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN.
EGGMAN I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
MEN.
OTOBOKE.
NO.
ROTH.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
HURTADO.
MEN.
ROTH.
ON A VOTE OF 28 TO 8.
THE MEASURE CARRIES MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 28.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1272 BY
SENATOR LAIRD.
HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1272 BY SENATOR
LAIRD.
AN ACT RELATING TO CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
SENATOR LAIRD.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR.
PRESIDENT.
CONSUMERS HAVE HAD THE OPTION TO
ASK
STORES TO REDEEM THE REMAINING
BALANCE OF A GIFT CARD BELOW
$10 FOR THE LAST 16 YEARS.
THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT
INFLATION SINCE
THEN AND THE BUYING POWER HAS
DROPPED.
THIS BILL WOULD RAISE THE
REDEEMABLE
DOLLAR AMOUNT TO $25,
WITH AN ANNUAL ADJUSTMENT FOR
INFLATION
ROUNDED TO THE NEAREST WHOLE
DOLLAR,
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL RETAIL
FEDERATION.
THERE IS THE MOST POPULAR GIFT
OF THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
CNN REPORTS THAT THERE'S $21
BILLION
SITTING IN UNUSED GIFT CARDS.
THIS WILL UPDATE IT FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN THE 16 YEARS.
THERE HAVE BEEN A FEW ARGUMENTS
AGAINST THIS.
ONE IS IS THAT IT WOULD REQUIRE
STORES
TO KEEP EXTRA CASH ON HAND.
CASH IS NOT THE REQUIREMENT FOR
REDEEMING
AND THAT IS NOT USED BY EVERYONE
NOW.
THERE HAVE BEEN CONCERNS ABOUT
RETAIL THEFT.
WE HAVE ASKED FOR DATA.
WE HAVE RECEIVED NONE.
IF WE RECEIVE ANY, WE WILL LOOK
AT THIS.
AND THERE'S ALSO CONCERN ABOUT A
FEDERAL LIMIT.
BUT MASSACHUSETTS HAS A SCHEME
THAT HAS A LIMIT
THAT'S HIGHER THAN THE ONE IN
THIS BILL.
SO IT'S TIME TO UPDATE THIS FOR
THE CONSUMERS.
I THINK IT'S FAIR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN I.
RODA-GIL.
ARCHULETA.
RUSHBY.
I ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR I.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ.
I DALLY?
NO, DODD.
I TORAZO I EGGMAN.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
JONES.
NO LAIRD I.
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I.
NEWMAN.
I.
WAYNE.
NO NILO.
NO OKOBO.
PEDDUR I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO NO
SKINNER I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG.
I.
BY WIENER I.
WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
I RODRIGO, I ARCHULETA.
OR DODO I OKOBOJI.
WILKE.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 6.
THE MEASURE CARRIES MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 29.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1300 BY
SENATOR CORTESE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1300 BY SENATOR
CORTESE,
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES.
SENATOR CORTESE, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
CORTESE YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES,
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT SB 1300.
SB 1300 WILL HELP COMMUNITIES
PREPARE FOR THE CLOSURES OF
PSYCHIATRIC UNITS AND MATERNITY
WARDS AND HOSPITALS.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE HEALTH
FACILITY TO PROVIDE 120 DAY
PUBLIC NOTICE OF THE ELIMINATION
OF ITS INPATIENT,
PSYCHIATRIC OR MATERNITY WARD
UNIT.
IT ALSO REQUIRES A HEALTH
FACILITY
TO PREPARE A REPORT THAT
ANALYZES
THE IMPACT OF THE CLOSURE ON THE
SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY'S HEALTH SYSTEM.
FINALLY, THE BILL INCREASES
PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY BY STRONGLY
ENCOURAGING EACH COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO POST
A REPORT ONLINE AND HOLD A
PUBLIC HEARING TO PROVIDE
THE COMMUNITY WITH AN OVERVIEW
OF THE IMPACT REPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ISSUE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I'LL RATHER GO.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
BECKER.
I BLAKESWARE.
I BRADFORD.
I.
CABRERO.
I CORTAZZI.
I DALLY.
NO.
DODD.
THE REASON WHY I.
EGGMAN!
GLASER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
I JONES.
NO LAIRD I LEMAN I MAGUIRE I
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO!
NILO.
OKOBO.
PEDDUR.
I PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
I RUBIO.
SATO.
NO, SKINNER, I SMILED CUEVAS I
STERN.
I UMMER.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL KNOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
I'LL RODA-GIL.
NO ARCHULETA I ATKINS I EGGMAN.
GLASER.
OKOBO.
RUBIO I.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
ON A VOTE OF 27 TO 9.
THE MEASURE CARRIES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER 30.
THIS IS SB 1401 BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1401 BY SENATOR
BLAKE.
SPERM AND ACT RELATING TO CHILD
CARE.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES,
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1401,
WHICH WAIVES STATE LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS
FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WHO EXCLUSIVELY CARE FOR
CHILDREN
OF MILITARY PERSONNEL IF THEY
ARE ALREADY CERTIFIED BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
AND ADDRESSES A 50% SHORTAGE OF
IN-HOME
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS FOR
MILITARY FAMILIES
BY CREATING NEW MILITARY CHILD
CARE SPOTS.
SB 1401 WILL ALSO HELP ALLEVIATE
LONG CHILD
CARE WAIT LISTS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS,
AS FEWER MILITARY FAMILIES WILL
NEED TO USE CIVILIAN OPTIONS.
THIS BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION
AND VERY MUCH SUPPORTS OUR
MILITARY FAMILIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION.
SCENE NINE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN.
I'LL RODA-GIL.
I ARCHULETTA.
I ASHBY.
I ATKINS.
I BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ I DALLY, I DODD.
I OSO I EGGMAN.
GLASER I.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
I OR DODO I JONES I LAYARD I
LEMAN I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN I NILO.
I OKOBO I PODIUM.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO I CIERTO I
SKINNER I SMILED CUEVAS.
I STERN, I UMBERG, I WAHAB.
A WIENER.
I WILL.
BYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
EGGMAN.
I.
MCGUIRE.
ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0.
THE MEASURE CARRIES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 34.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 924 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 924 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD.
AN ACT RELATING TO TENANCY.
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
924 SIMPLY REMOVES THE.
&GT;&GT; SUNSET DATE OF JULY
1ST,
2025 FROM A MEASURE I PASSED IN
2020 SB
1157 THAT REQUIRES LANDLORDS OF
SUBSIDIZED
ASSISTED DEVELOPMENTS
TO OFFER THE OPTION TO RENTERS
TO HAVE THEIR CREDIT REPORTED,
REPORTED, AND EFFECTIVELY MAKE
THIS PERMANENT.
A RENT REPORTING HAS HELPED
INDIVIDUALS
ESTABLISH CREDIT AND HELPS
INDIVIDUALS WITH NON-PRIME
CREDIT
IMPROVE THEIR CREDIT SCORES.
IT'S A STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE
AND I SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN.
I'D RATHER GO.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ.
I DALLY.
DODD.
I DURAZZO I EGMOND.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
POTATO I.
JONES.
LAIRD, I THE MOM.
MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NEELO.
NO CHOBO NO BEDIA.
I PONCENO.
I BROUGHT.
I RUBIO, I SATO.
MISS SKINNER.
I SMILED.
WAS I STERN?
I UMBERG.
I WAHHAB.
I WIENER I AWOKE I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
DELHI.
GROVE I.
JONES.
I.
LEHMAN.
MCGUIRE.
WHEN?
CIERTO?
NO.
ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 3.
THE MEASURE CARRIES MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM TO TAKE UP.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 21.
AGAIN ON UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
THIS IS SB 233 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 233 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS
AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, PLEASED TO PRESENT SB
233,
WHICH WILL TEMPORARILY
ALLOW LICENSED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS,
SPECIFICALLY ARIZONA DOCTORS,
TO BE ABLE TO GET A TEMPORARY
MEDICAL LICENSE IN
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO PRACTICE
IN CALIFORNIA
TO PROVIDE ABORTION CARE TO
THEIR ARIZONA
PATIENTS WHO TRAVEL TO
CALIFORNIA.
THESE PROVISIONS SUNSET ON
NOVEMBER 30TH,
2020 FOR ARIZONANS BEGINNING ON
JUNE 6TH,
FACE A TOTAL ABORTION BAN BASED
ON AN 1864 LAW.
THAT BAN TRIGGERS 2 TO 5 YEAR
PRISON
SENTENCES FOR DOCTORS WHO
PROVIDE
CARE AND OTHER SENTENCING FOR
ANY
WOMAN WHO RECEIVES SUCH CARE.
NOW, WHILE I'M SURE YOU'VE READ
THE ARIZONA
LEGISLATURE HAS NOW RESCINDED
THE 1864 LAW,
AND I GUESS YOU'RE WONDERING,
WHY DO WE NEED THIS LAW TODAY?
BECAUSE, LIKE CALIFORNIA, YOU
KNOW,
WHEN WE PASS A LAW,
EVEN WHEN THE GOVERNOR SIGNS IT,
IT DOESN'T COME INTO EFFECT
UNTIL A CERTAIN
PERIOD OF TIME AFTER OUR
SESSION.
AND MOST CASES IN OUR SESSION,
IT WOULD START IN JANUARY 1ST OF
THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
IN ARIZONA, BILLS TAKE EFFECT 90
DAYS
AFTER THE END OF THEIR SESSION.
THEIR SESSION IS NOT SCHEDULED
TO END UNTIL THE END OF JULY.
THUS, ARIZONANS WILL NOT HAVE
SUCH PROTECTION UNTIL
AT LEAST THE END OF OCTOBER OR
NOVEMBER.
THIS IS WHY SB 233 IS STILL
NEEDED, AND UNDER 233,
THE ARIZONA DOCTOR MUST HOLD
AND VERIFY THAT THEY HAVE
A MEDICAL LICENSE IN GOOD
STANDING FROM ARIZONA,
AND MUST HAVE PERFORMED AT LEAST
ONE ABORTION UNDER
THEIR ARIZONA LICENSE WITHIN THE
LAST TWO YEARS.
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES
PROTECTION
PRIVACY PROTECTION
FOR THOSE PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS.
UM.
AND WITH THAT.
I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER.
THAT'S AN I VOTE ON ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS
TO BE CONCURRED IN.
RIGHT, SENATOR NILO.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I EVERYTHING THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM
BERKELEY JUST SAID IS TRUE.
BUT SHE LEFT SOMETHING OUT AND
THAT IS THAT.
UM, THE GOVERNOR OF ARIZONA,
THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER,
IS PROHIBITING LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS
FROM PROSECUTING UH,
UNDER THE CIVIL WAR ERA LAW.
AND ONLY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
CAN.
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
SAID THAT.
THEIR OFFICE WILL DECLINE TO
ENFORCE
THAT CIVIL WAR ERA LAW.
SO THE RELEVANT PERIOD OF THIS
ENABLEMENT
IS ABOUT FOUR WEEKS.
BUT IN ARIZONA, IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE NEEDED.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NILO.
SENATOR WAHAB.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB 233.
I WILL SAY THAT THIS IS LIFE
SAVING CARE FOR MANY WOMEN.
WE CANNOT OVERSTATE THIS ENOUGH.
MORE SPECIFICALLY, I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT
THE FACT THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE,
AS MUCH AS WE TALK ABOUT WOMEN'S
RIGHTS,
UM, THE DECISION OVER ONE'S BODY
IS STILL
IN QUESTION HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
UM, MATERNAL MORTALITY RATE
IN THE UNITED STATES IS SO
MUCH WORSE THAN NEARLY ANY OTHER
DEVELOPED COUNTRY.
IN 2022, THERE WERE 22.3
DEATHS PER 100,000 LIVE BIRTHS.
THESE RATES ARE FAR WORSE WHEN
WE
SHIFT OUR LENS TO WOMEN OF
COLOR.
SPECIFICALLY, CALIFORNIA IS THE
STATE WHERE WE
TRY TO PROVIDE FOR EVERY SINGLE
COMMUNITY,
INCLUDING OUR NEIGHBORS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING.
IT WAS ALSO THE ARIZONA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S
CALL TO ACTION THAT PROMPTED
THIS EFFORT FROM A NEIGHBORING
STATE,
LIKE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
IN RESPONSE TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FAIR OAKS,
AND I HOPE I HAVE THE CORRECT
JURISDICTION.
UM.
I THINK, AS HE WELL KNOWS AND
ALL OF US KNOW,
AND I KNOW THAT GOVERNORS WOULD
LIKE THEIR EXECUTIVE
ORDERS TO HAVE THE FORCE OF
STATUTE.
THEY UNFORTUNATELY DO NOT.
AND WHILE IN MOST CASES, UH,
ENTITIES LIKE PROSECUTORS OR
OTHERS
WILL FOLLOW AN EXECUTIVE ORDER,
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER DOES NOT
HAVE THE FORCE OF LAW.
AND SO ONE COULD IMAGINE THERE
COULD
BE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THERE
WOULD
BE PROSECUTORS IN ARIZONA WHO DO
NOT AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR.
UM, AS YOU HAD A COURT IN
ARIZONA WHO ALLOWED
THE UPHOLDING OF A, AS YOU
MENTIONED,
A CIVIL WAR ERA LAW, A LAW WHICH
I WILL NOTE
WAS PASSED WHEN WOMEN COULD NOT
VOTE,
WHEN WOMEN COULD NOT OWN
PROPERTY,
WHEN IT WAS LEGAL FOR HUSBANDS
TO BEAT WOMEN,
AND A VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS I
COULD LIST.
BUT I WON'T GO FURTHER.
UM, SO THIS OUR LAW IS STILL
NEEDED.
I HOPE THAT THE CASES THE THAT
THERE
IS NO PROSECUTOR WHO CHOOSES
TO DEFY THE GOVERNOR OF
ARIZONA'S EXECUTIVE ORDER,
BUT AT LEAST WE WILL BE ACTING
IN SUCH
A WAY THAT ARIZONA DOCTORS WILL
BE ABLE
TO DETERMINE HOW BEST TO MEET
THEIR MEDICAL
OBLIGATIONS TO THEIR PATIENTS.
AND ARIZONA WOMEN WHO REQUIRE
THIS ESSENTIAL
HEALTH CARE WOULD BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN IT.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLAN OVER OTAGO.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER
I BLAKE SPEAR I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLY.
NO, DAD, I.
DORADO I.
EGGMAN.
GLASER I.
GONZALEZ, I.
GROVE.
NO.
OR DOTTO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
LEMON.
I.
MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I.
MEN.
I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
OKOBO.
NO.
PADILLA.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
STERN I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER, I WILL.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
BRADFORD I.
EGGMAN I.
MCGUIRE.
SMALL QUAVERS.
I.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 8 ON THE
URGENCY,
30 TO 8 ON THE MEASURE.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
&GT;&GT; MEMBERS.
WE HAVE SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES
OFF THE FLOOR.
SO FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF BILLS,
WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING THE ROLL
CALL
JUST ONCE AND THEN PUTTING IT ON
UNTIL OUR MEMBERS COME BACK.
NEXT ON THE FILE ITEM LIST,
WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER 35.
SENATOR LAIRD, ARE YOU PREPARED?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1280 BY SENATOR
LAIRD,
AN ACT RELATING TO WASTE
MANAGEMENT.
SENATOR LAIRD, THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
AND AT THE BEGINNING, I
RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST PERMISSION
TO USE A PROP DURING THIS
PRESENTATION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
OKAY, I HEARD MIGHT OBJECT,
SO I'M GOING TO MOVE AHEAD.
UM, SENATE BILL 1280 SIMPLY
TRANSITIONS CALIFORNIA
TO MORE SUSTAINABLE OUTDOOR
RECREATION
BY REQUIRING SMALL PROPANE
CYLINDERS SOLD IN
THE STATE TO BE REUSABLE OR
REFILLABLE.
STARTING ON JANUARY 1ST, 2028.
MANY OF YOU MAY THINK THIS BILL
LOOKS FAMILIAR.
THIS BILL IN THIS FORM HAS
PASSED
THIS HOUSE TWICE BEFORE.
AND THE PROBLEM IS.
WHICH THE PROBLEM IS THIS.
RIGHT NOW CITIES, COUNTIES,
PARKS,
BEACHES EVERYBODY HAS TO DISPOSE
OF THESE THEMSELVES.
THIS IS A PICTURE OF YOSEMITE
NATIONAL PARK,
WHERE THEY HAVE COLLECTED THESE
AND PUT THEM IN TRUCKS AND
CARTED OFF.
COST THEM $75,000 A YEAR.
TO DO THIS.
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE TO DO THE SAME
THING.
THERE'S A REASON THAT THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES,
THE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES,
RURAL COUNTIES ALL SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE WHILE
IT COSTS 5 TO $10 TO BUY THESE
ON THE MARKETPLACE,
THE COST VARIES FROM 15 TO $30
OR HIGHER
TO DISPOSE OF THEM OR TAKE THEM
AWAY.
MANY TIMES WE HAVE HERE DECIDED
THAT THE MARKET
IS THE BEST PLACE TO DEAL WITH
THESE,
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS DOES.
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY,
THE LATEST VERSION OF MORE
EFFICIENT
TOILETS FAILED WHEN IT WAS GOING
TO BE PUT IN THE BUILDING CODE,
BUT WHEN IT GAVE THE MARKET A
FEW
YEARS TO PHASE IT IN, IT PASSED.
AND THAT WORKED FOR BUSINESSES
AND THAT WORKED FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS DOES.
WE ARE IN 2024, AND THIS BILL
WILL
NOT TAKE EFFECT UNTIL 2028.
THE OPPONENTS SAY A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT
SOMEHOW YOU HAVE TO CART MANY
CANISTERS
INTO THE INTO THE PARKS WHEN
IT'S REFILLABLE
AND YOU HAVE ONE, IT IS REALLY
ONE.
IT IS NOT MULTIPLE ONES.
OPPONENTS SAY THIS IS A BAN.
THIS IS NOT A BAN.
THIS ESTABLISHES A REQUIREMENT
FOR
REFILLABLE AND ALLOWS A NUMBER
OF YEARS FOR THE MARKET TO
CATCH UP AND MAKE IT WORK.
UM, IT IS REALLY RIGHT NOW A
BURDEN
ON TAXPAYERS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THOSE OF US THAT HAVE
BEACHES OR STATE PARKS,
AND I RIVAL SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
HAVING AS MANY
STATE PARKS AS ANY SENATOR ON
THIS FLOOR,
YOU JUST GO AND YOU SEE THEM IN
TRASH CANS,
AND IF THERE'S PROPANE LEFT
IN THEM, THAT'S HAZARDOUS.
AND SO THE REAL ISSUE HERE IS TO
HAVE SOME EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY BY HAVING A
RECYCLABLE
PROPANE CYLINDER.
IT IS PASSED THIS HOUSE TWICE.
IT IS SUPPORTED WIDELY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
SEN SHAKESPEARE.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
YES, THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
I ALSO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB 1280.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE,
THERE ARE 4 MILLION OF THOSE
SINGLE CANISTER,
£1 PROPANE CYLINDERS THAT ARE
SOLD.
AND AS THE AUTHOR JUST SAID,
THE COST IS BORNE BY TAXPAYERS,
BUT IT'S ALSO BORNE BY THE
ENVIRONMENT.
IF YOU BACKPACK, YOU SEE PILES
OF THESE CYLINDERS
OUT IN THE BACKCOUNTRY BECAUSE
THEY ARE HEAVY AND THEY'RE NOT
REFILLABLE,
AND PEOPLE LEAVE THEM IN NATURE.
SO THIS IS A FORM OF, UM,
PREVENTABLE WASTE.
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOUR I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SENATOR LAIRD, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS.
AND I JUST REMIND YOU,
THIS PICTURE IS OF THE STATUS
QUO.
IF WE DON'T HAVE ANY SOLUTION.
THIS CONTINUES ACROSS OUR PARKS
AND BEACHES IN CITIES
AND COUNTIES AT THE EXPENSE OF
OUR TAXPAYERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I WROTE A GIRL I ARCHULETA.
ASHBY I ATKINS I.
BECKER, I.
BLAKE.
SPEAR I.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO I CORTEZI, I DALLY.
DODD.
THE RAZO.
I EGGMAN, I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO, I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD, I.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
MEN.
I MEAN, EXCUSE ME.
NEWMAN.
I WHEN?
NO NIILO.
I OKOBO.
PER DIEM I PORTANTINO.
ROD I.
RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
I STERN, I UMBERG WAHAB.
A WIENER.
I WILL I.
MEMBER MOVES TO CALL.
NEXT ON THE LIST IS FILE ITEM
38.
SENATOR CABALLERO, ARE YOU
PREPARED?
THE SENATOR IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1140 BY SENATOR
CAPITO.
AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR CABALLERO.
&GT;&GT; GOOD MORNING, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB 1140,
WHICH WILL REFORM ENHANCED
INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS,
APHIDS AND CLIMATE RESILIENT
DISTRICTS,
OR CRDS, TO STREAMLINE AND
CREATE EFFICIENCIES
IN THE FORMATION PROCESS,
PROCESS AND EXPAND THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS
THESE TOOLS CAN FINANCE.
SB 1140 WILL REDUCE THE
MANDATORY
MEETINGS FROM 4 TO 3.
IT BROADENS THE ALTERNATIVE
MAILING AND NOTIFICATION
METHODS TO INCORPORATE IT ALL.
AIFD FORMATION MEETINGS, ANNUAL
REPORTS,
AND POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS.
SB 1140 ELIMINATES THE MANDATE
FOR THE PUBLIC FINANCING
AUTHORITY TO PUBLISH MEETING
NOTICES IN NEWSPAPERS.
INSTEAD, IT ENABLES THE FORMING
DISTRICT
TO ELECTRONICALLY SUBMIT ITS
RESOLUTION
OF INTENTION TO ESTABLISH THE
DISTRICT
TO OTHER TAXING ENTITIES.
FURTHERMORE, IT REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT TO MAIL
ANNUAL REPORT NOTICES VIA FIRST
CLASS MAIL.
AS YOU CAN TELL, THIS IS AN
EFFICIENCY AND
A REORGANIZATION OF THE WAY THE
PROCESS WORKS.
AS SB 1140 EXPANDS, THE TYPE OF
PROJECTS THAT IFDS AND CRDS
CAN FINANCE TO INCLUDE PROJECTS
THAT IMPROVE AIR QUALITY,
THESE BENEFITS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVE THE ABILITY
FOR IFDS AND CRDS TO ADVANCE
THEIR MISSION TO
SUPPORT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
SPUR CLIMATE CHANGE
RESILIENCY IN COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OF OUR ITEM 38.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I'VE GOTTA GO.
I ARCHULETA, I ASHBY.
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKESBURG I
BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY.
DAD I DURAZZO I EGMOND.
I.
GLASER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
FOR DATO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I LEMAN I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I.
MEN I.
NEWMAN, I WIN.
NILA.
BOCOBO.
NO PODIUM.
I PORTANTINO.
I, ROD.
I.
RUBIO.
SERATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE, A STERN I
UMMAT.
WAHAB.
A WINNER.
I WOKE I.
THE SENATOR MOVES TO CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 30.
39.
SENATOR DODD, ARE YOU PREPARED?
HE IS READY.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 904 BY SENATOR DODD
AND AQUILINA.
TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR.
MADAM PRESIDENT, MEMBERS, TODAY.
&GT;&GT; I'M PRESENTING SB 904.
THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL THAT
UPDATES
THE ENABLING LEGISLATION
OF THE SONOMA-MARIN AREA RAIL
TRANSIT DISTRICT,
OR SMART TRAIN, AS THEY CALL IT,
AND AUTHORIZES SMART SPECIAL
DISTRICT
TO UTILIZE A VOTER INITIATIVE
IN ORDER TO ENSURE GREATER
FINANCIAL STABILITY.
THE SMART TRAIN IS AN INCREDIBLE
EXAMPLE
OF A PUBLIC TRANSIT PROJECT THAT
ADVANCES MANY OF OUR STATE'S TOP
GOALS
INCREASED RAIL AND BICYCLE USE,
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT,
AND COLLABORATION BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS
AT A REGIONAL SCALE.
SINCE COMING INTO SERVICE IN
2017,
SMART HAS OVERCOME WILDFIRES,
FLOODS AND A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THAT
DEVASTATED PUBLIC TRANSIT.
DESPITE THOSE OBSTACLES, THEY
KEEP CHUGGING
ALONG AND AT THE END OF 2023,
BECAME THE FIRST TRANSIT SYSTEM
IN THE BAY AREA TO
RECOVER TO THEIR PRE-PANDEMIC
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS.
THIS BILL ALSO EMPOWERS THE
VOTERS OF
THIS SPECIAL DISTRICT FOR THE
FIRST
TIME TO PURSUE THEIR OWN BALLOT
MEASURES
THROUGH A VOTER INITIATIVE.
A VOTER APPROVED, QUALIFIED
INITIATIVE
PROCESS WILL PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENHANCE
COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND ENSURE
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
DIRECTION FOR HOW TO BEST
DEDICATE FUTURE RESOURCES TO
OPERATE A SMALL SYSTEM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM 39?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALI AL RODA-GIL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
HI.
BLAKE.
SPERM.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
I DALLY.
NO DODD, I DURAZZO, I EDWIN I
GLASER.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO I JONES.
LAIRD I LAMONI.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO NILO.
NO, NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
A ROTTEN.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS I STERN I UMBER
WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL.
NO.
SENATOR DODD MOVES MOVING
TOWARDS FINAL ITEM 40.
SENATOR BECKER, HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1018 BY SENATOR
BECKER.
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
SENATOR BECKER.
&GT;&GT; I THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW HYDROGEN
PRODUCERS
TO USE RENEWABLE ENERGY
DIRECTLY FROM SOLAR OR WIND
FARMS
TO MAKE GREEN HYDROGEN,
AND WILL ALLOW FACTORIES TO DO
THE SAME THING,
TO PROVIDE HEAT,
TO RUN THEIR PROCESSES WITH
CLEAN ELECTRICITY
RATHER THAN FOSSIL FUELS.
OUR SCOPING PLAN PREDICTS TEN
GIGAWATTS
OF HYDROGEN PRODUCTION
POWERED DIRECTLY FROM OFF GRID
RENEWABLES.
BUT THERE IS A PROBLEM.
YOU CANNOT DO THIS TODAY BECAUSE
OF SOMETHING
CALLED THE OVER THE FENCE RULE.
THIS RULE SAYS THAT IF YOU SELL
POWER TO ANYONE,
YOU MUST BE REGULATED AS A
PUBLIC UTILITY,
WHICH WOULD KILL ANY PROJECT.
THERE ARE A FEW EXEMPTIONS TO
THIS LIMITED TO POWER
PRODUCED ON THE SAME PROPERTY AS
THE BUYER,
OR A SINGLE ADJACENT PROPERTY,
HENCE THE NAME OVER THE FENCE
RULE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT TO GENERATE
ENOUGH POWER
TO PRODUCE HYDROGEN OR ELECTRIFY
FACTORY,
YOU NEED A LOT MORE SPACE FOR
SOLAR OR WIND
THAN JUST A SINGLE ADJACENT
PROPERTY.
SB 1018 SOLVES THIS PROBLEM BY
ALLOWING A LARGE SOLAR OR WIND
FARM TO SELL THEIR OUTPUT
DIRECTLY
TO A SINGLE CUSTOMER,
WHO WILL USE THAT POWER FOR
PRODUCING HYDROGEN
OR PROVIDING INDUSTRIAL HEAT.
BY LIMITING THIS EXEMPTION TO
ALLOW
SALES TO A SINGLE CUSTOMER,
WE ARE KEEPING THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS
UNDER CURRENT LAW IN PLACE.
THIS BILL WILL SUPPORT THE
GROWTH OF GREEN HYDROGEN
AND INDUSTRIAL ELECTRIFICATION
USING OFF GRID RENEWABLES,
WHICH WILL ENSURE IT MAKES USE
OF
CLEAN ENERGY AND AVOIDS PUTTING
NEW STRESS ON THE GRID OR
IMPACTING
ELECTRICITY RATES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION ON
ITEM 40?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YEAH.
OH I'LL GO I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKESBURG I
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CORTEZI.
I DALLI.
NO.
DOD.
TORAZO I AGMON I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO DATO.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
I MAGUIRE.
MINGYUAN I.
MEN I.
NUMAN I WIN.
NO!
NILO.
NO.
OKOBO.
PODIUM.
PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
I RUBIO, I SATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
EASTERN HIGH UMMAT WAHAB I
WIENER.
I WELL KNOW.
SENATOR BECKER MOVES TO CALL.
THE NEXT THREE ITEMS ON OUR LIST
ARE FILE ITEM 41, 42, AND 43.
SENATOR ROTH, YOU'RE UP FIRST.
IS THE SENATOR PREPARED?
HE IS SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1249 BY SENATOR
ROTH.
AN ACT RELATING TO OLDER ADULTS.
PLEASE PROCEED, SENATOR.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
RAPIDLY
AGING POPULATION BY MODERNIZING
CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER CALIFORNIANS
ACT.
THE BILL PROPOSES TO REFORM
THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT
TO CONFORM TO RECENT CHANGES IN
FEDERAL REGULATIONS
WHICH IMPLEMENT THE FEDERAL
OLDER AMERICANS ACT
AND INTRODUCES ACCOUNTABILITY
AND PERFORMANCE MEASURES,
UPDATES GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES,
AND ESTABLISHES
TIMEFRAMES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO ENGAGE
IN STAKEHOLDER CONSULTATION.
AS FOR AN I VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I
BECKER.
I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO.
I CORTEZI.
I DALLY.
DUD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
GONZALEZ.
A GROVE.
RICARDO.
I.
JONES.
I LAYERED.
I LEMON I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN I WIN.
NILO.
WHICH HOBO?
PEDDUR PORCINUM.
I ROTH I RUBIO I CIERTO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
I STERN I UMBERG.
WAHA I WIENER I WILK.
SENATOR BROCK.
SENATOR ROTH MOVES TO CALL.
MAJORITY LEADER, ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR ITEM 42?
SHE IS READY.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
JUST NEED A COUPLE OF SECONDS
HERE.
THERE WE GO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
42.
SENATE BILL 1337 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS.
PLEASE PROCEED.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB 1337,
WHICH WILL PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT THE FUNDERS OF REFERENDUM
PETITIONS
SEEKING TO OVERTURN STATE LAW.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE TOP
THREE FUNDERS
BE LISTED DIRECTLY ON EACH
SIGNATURE PAGE.
AS WE KNOW, DIRECT DEMOCRACY IS
AN IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR CALIFORNIANS, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY,
LARGE CORPORATIONS ARE ABUSING
THIS PROCESS TO
OVERTURN LEGISLATION PASSED BY
THIS VERY BODY.
AND RECENT PETITION CAMPAIGNS TO
QUALIFY REFERENDUMS HAVE BEEN
RIFE WITH EXAMPLES OF PAID
SIGNATURE
GATHERERS MISREPRESENTING
WHAT A MEASURE WOULD DO AND
REFUSING TO PRODUCE
THE TOP FUNDERS SHEET ALREADY
REQUIRED UNDER LAW.
SB 1337 WILL ENSURE VOTERS CAN
MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS AND ARE AWARE OF WHO
IS FUNDING EFFORTS TO OVERTURN
LAWS
BEFORE DECIDING TO SIGN A
PETITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR.
I VOTE ON SB 1337.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
ANY DISCUSSION ON FINAL ITEM 42
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
OVERALL.
YOU KNOW ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER
I BLAKE SPUR I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO.
COURTESY I DALLY NO DODD TORAZO
I EGGMAN I GLASER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO I JONES.
LAIRD I LIMON.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I.
MEN I.
NEWMAN I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
OKOBO.
NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE, A STERN.
I UMBERG.
WHAT A WIENER!
I WILL.
NO SENATOR MOVES TO CALL.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 43.
SENATOR HURTADO IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
43.
SENATE BILL 1367 BY SENATOR
HURTADO.
AN ACT RELATING TO AGRICULTURE
AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION, THEREFORE.
SENATE.
HURTADO.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT.
SB 1367 SEEKS TO SAFEGUARD
FUNDING FOR THE SAFE
ANIMAL FEED EDUCATION PROGRAM BY
EXTENDING
THE SUNSET FOR THE PROGRAM FROM
JANUARY 1ST,
2025 TO JANUARY 1ST, 2031.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE COMMITTEE
PROCESS,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
EYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM I'M
SEEING?
NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLAN.
OVER.
OTAGO.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE
SPEAR I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ.
I DALLY, I DUD I DURAZZO I
EGMOND I GLASER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
I OR DODO I JONES, I LAIRD I
LAMONI.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I NEWMAN, I WIN, I NILO,
I OJOBO.
I BELIEVE I PORTANTINO I ROD
I RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER
I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN I UMMAT
WAHAB I WEINER.
I WILL.
I SENATOR HURTADO MOVES TO CALL.
THE NEXT THREE ITEMS ON OUR LIST
ARE FILE ITEM 46, 47 AND 48.
SENATOR EGGMAN IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1184 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN AND AQUILINA.
MENTAL HEALTH.
SENATOR.
PLEASE PROCEED.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM PRESIDENT, THIS BILL GOES
TO TRY TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE DO NOT COMPENSATE
DURING A HOLD,
DO THE LACK OF MEDICATION THAT
SAYS
THAT THE ORDER AND THE HEARING
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED ON THEIR
FIRST HOLD WILL LAST UNTIL
THE THE PERSON REGAINS CAPACITY
OR THE NEXT HEARING IS
HELD IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
TREATMENT IS NOT DISRUPTED
AND PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO RETURN
TO THE HIGHEST CAPACITY
THEY CAN AND TO MAKE SURE THEIR
RIGHTS ARE ENSURED.
I ASK FOR YOUR.
ANY DISCUSSION ON ITEM 46.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO GILMAN A
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS I.
BECKER I.
BLAKE SPEAR I.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ I.
DALY.
I.
DODD.
DORADO I.
EGGMAN I.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
I HURTADO I.
JONES.
I.
LAIRD, I.
LEHMAN.
I.
MCGUIRE.
MENJIVAR I MEN I.
NEWMAN I WIN.
I NILA I OKOBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I BRAD I RUBIO
I SATO I SKINNER I SMALL GRAVIS
I STERN I UMMER.
WAHAB I WIENER.
I WILL.
I'M SENATOR EGGMAN MOVES TO CALL
COLLEAGUES A LITTLE
CHANGE IN WHAT ORDER I GAVE YOU
EARLIER.
THE NEXT THREE ARE FILE ITEM 47,
52 AND 53.
SENATOR, MEN ARE PREPARED.
HE IS SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1174 BY SENATOR MEN
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS.
SENATOR MANN.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT.
SB 1174 WOULD ENSURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CANNOT IMPLEMENT
THEIR OWN VOTER IDENTIFICATION
LAWS IN LOCAL ELECTIONS.
IT IS VERY CLEAR ALREADY,
AS A MATTER OF EXISTING LAW,
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS,
INCLUDING CHARTER CITIES,
ARE NOT PERMITTED TO IMPOSE
VOTER IDENTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT WOULD IMPACT
CHARTERS,
COUNTY ELECTIONS, STATE
ELECTIONS
OR FEDERAL ELECTIONS.
HOWEVER, THERE IS SOME
AMBIGUITY, AS I READ IT IN
THE LAW RIGHT NOW REGARDING
WHETHER CHARTER CITIES
CAN IMPLEMENT THEIR OWN VOTER ID
REQUIREMENTS ON
A DIFFERENT TIME AND PLACE FOR
THEIR OWN ELECTIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD CLOSE THAT ANY
AMBIGUITY,
AND MAKE CLEAR THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS
CANNOT IMPLEMENT A HUNDRED
DIFFERENT
VOTER ID REQUIREMENTS.
THIS SHOULD BE A STATE MATTER TO
DECIDE.
AND OF COURSE, MY LOCAL CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH HAS TRIED
TO PASS THIS OR HAS PASSED A
VOTER ID REQUIREMENT,
PURPORTEDLY WHICH IS UNDER
LITIGATION
BASED ON REPORTS OF VOTER FRAUD,
SUCH AS THE BIG LIE,
WHICH HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO BE
FALSE.
IF EVIDENCE WAS PRESENTED TO
THIS BODY OF
THE NEED FOR VOTER
IDENTIFICATION CHANGES,
I THINK IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
FOR US TO ACT.
NO SUCH EVIDENCE HAS BEEN
PRESENTED,
AND ORANGE COUNTY, OF COURSE,
IS KNOWN FOR HAVING SOME OF THE
SAFEST AND MOST
SECURE VOTING IN THE STATE IN
THE COUNTRY.
AND SO SB 1174 WOULD TRY TO
ADDRESS
THIS MATTER AND ENSURE THAT
LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CANNOT IMPOSE
THEIR
OWN VOTER ID REQUIREMENTS,
TO TRY TO ENGAGE IN CULTURE WARS
AND TRY TO DISENFRANCHISE
VOTERS.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE.
SENATORS, DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
I SEE NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
OF RODRIGO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER
I BLAKE SPEAR I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DALLY KNOW DODD I
DURAZZO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO I JONES.
LAIRD I THE MOM I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO NILO.
NO OKOBO.
NO BEDIA.
I PORTANTINO.
I WROTE A REVIEW.
I SAY NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
I STERN I UMMAT WAHHAB I WINER I
WILL NO.
SEN MEN MOVES TO CALL MOVE IT ON
TO FILE ITEM 52.
SENATOR SKINNER, ARE YOU
PREPARED?
SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1210 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
AN ACT RELATING TO UTILITY
SERVICE.
SENATOR SKINNER.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I THINK YOU'VE ALL BEEN
FAMILIAR WITH, UH,
EITHER INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF, UH,
BUILDING A RESIDENTIAL UNIT OR
EVEN
A COMMERCIAL UNIT, FOR THAT
MATTER,
OR LARGE ENTITIES WHO ARE, UM,
BUILDING SUCH UNITS.
AND THEY ARE THEN FACING VERY
HIGH COSTS
OF VARIETY OF UTILITY HOOKUPS,
WHETHER FOR SEWAGE,
ELECTRICITY, WATER, GAS, YOU
NAME IT,
AND ALSO TIME LINES THAT CAN BE
CONSIDERED ABSURD.
THERE ARE MANY, MANY RESIDENTIAL
UNITS
THAT ARE READY FOR OCCUPANCY
AND YET CANNOT BE OCCUPIED
BECAUSE THEY
NOT HAVE NOT YET HAD THAT
HOOKUP.
NOW, WHILE MY BILL ORIGINALLY
TRIED TO ADDRESS ALL OF THAT,
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
WAS IT WAS IT'S NECESSARY,
BUT IT WAS TOO AMBITIOUS.
WHAT I'VE DONE INSTEAD WITH THIS
BILL IS AT LEAST
PROVIDED SOME TRANSPARENCY SO
THAT YOU CAN.
UH, CONTACT WHICHEVER UTILITY
ENTITY,
WHETHER IT'S ELECTRICITY,
GAS OR WATER THAT IS GOING TO DO
THAT.
YOU WILL NEED A HOOKUP FOR.
AND YOU CAN DETERMINE IN ADVANCE
WHAT
THE COST OF THAT HOOKUP WILL BE.
SO THIS IS SIMPLY AND SOLELY A
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE.
IT PURELY REQUIRES THOSE
ENTITIES,
MEANING CALIFORNIA UTILITIES
TO PROVIDE UTILITY HOOKUP
SERVICE TO HAVE LIST
THEIR FEE SCHEDULE SO THAT
WE KNOW IN ADVANCE WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO EXPECT AS TO WHAT
THIS COST WILL BE.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
COLLEAGUES, DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
GOING ONCE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY.
I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ I DALLY.
NO DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
OR DATA.
HI, JONES.
LAIRD I.
LEMONY.
I.
MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO, NILO.
OKOBO.
VIDEO.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I REVIEW I SATO NO
SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG WAHAB I
WIENER.
I WILL.
I, SENATOR SKINNER, MOVES A CALL
CENTRE
SKINNER TO PREPARE FOR THE NEXT
ITEM.
SHE IS SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1211 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
AN ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS.
UH, ADUS ARE ONE OF OUR
CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING SUCCESS STORIES.
THEY ARE RELATIVELY AFFORDABLE
TO CONSTRUCT,
AND I SAY RELATIVELY.
UM, THEY ARE AN EFFICIENT USE
OF EXISTING RESIDENTIAL
LAND AND EXISTING HOUSING STOCK.
AND THEY ARE NOW WE'VE I THINK
THE RECENT NUMBERS SHOW THAT
SINCE WE
BEGAN TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
REMOVE
SOME OF THE OBSTACLES FOR ADUS,
SOME 100,000 IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN HAVE BEEN CONSTRUCTED.
SO THAT'S SINCE ABOUT 2018.
UM, CURRENT LAW ALLOWS FOR ADUS
ON MULTIFAMILY PROPERTIES,
BUT IT UNNECESSARILY RESTRICTS
WHAT IS CALLED DETACHED ADUS.
SO OUR CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
THE ADUS ON A MULTIFAMILY
PROPERTY
TO BE A CONVERSION OF SOMETHING
WITHIN THE BUILDING ENVELOPE.
BUT I THINK ALL OF US ARE AWARE
THAT THERE ARE SOME MULTIFAMILY
COMPLEXES THAT HAVE LOTS OF LAND
ASSOCIATED WITH THE COMPLEX,
WHERE IT COULD BE APPROPRIATE
TO HAVE A DETACHED ADU.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY
WHERE ADUS CAN BE SITED ON
MULTIFAMILY PROPERTIES,
AND ALLOWS MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
OF UP TO EIGHT
DETACHED ADUS ON THAT
MULTIFAMILY PROPERTY,
AS LONG AS IT DOESN'T DOUBLE
THE EXISTING UNITS ON THE BILL.
SO WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM?
ITEM 53.
I AM SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL I.
ARCHULETA.
I.
ASHBY.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR I BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLY.
NO.
DUD I.
DORADO I.
EGGMAN I.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO I JONES.
LAIRD I, LAMO I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
MEN I NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO, NEIL.
WATCHABLE.
NO, BUT I PORTANTINO.
ROD I.
RUBIO.
SOURTOE.
NO.
SKINNER A SMALL CREVICE.
I STERN I UMMER I WAHAB, I
WIENER, I WILL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NYLANDERM ALLEN.
BECKER.
GLASER.
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR A I.
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO I.
WELL NOW.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
ALAN.
BECKER.
GLASER.
MCGUIRE.
PORTANTINO.
SENATOR GLAZER MOVES TO A CALL.
IT MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 56.
WE HAVE 56, 57 AND 58.
ALL THREE ON DECK.
SENATOR WILK LOOKS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1495 BY SENATOR
WILK.
AN ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES.
SENATOR WILK.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS,
I PRESENT SB 1495,
WHICH WOULD ALLOW ALCOHOL
LICENSEES
TO SPONSOR EVENTS OR PURCHASE
ADVERTISING SPACE FROM THE WORLD
FAMOUS HOLLYWOOD
FOREVER CEMETERY IN LOS ANGELES,
THE HOME VENUE OF THE
ROASTMASTER HIMSELF.
WHAT'S HIS NAME?
JEFF.
WHAT?
YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW WHO THE
ROAST MASTER IS?
NO, NOT JEFF STONE.
THE CEMETERY IS CURRENTLY A
PERMANENT RETAIL ON
SALE LICENSE HOLDER WITH A TYPE
88 LICENSE,
WHICH DOESN'T ALLOW FOR THIS
ARRANGEMENT.
THE NARROW TIED HOUSE EXEMPTION
ALLOWED
FOR UNDER THIS BILL WOULD
HELP GENERATE IMPORTANT REVENUES
FOR THE CARE, MAINTENANCE,
AND IMPROVEMENT OF THE CEMETERY
GROUNDS AND ITS ABILITY
TO CONTINUE TO HOST MANY POPULAR
CULTURAL EVENTS.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION.
THE BILL PASSED OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE 16 TO
0 RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
JEFF.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON ITEM 56?
I AM SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER, I.
BLAKE.
SPEAR I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CABALLERO.
CORTEZ.
I.
DALY.
DODD.
I.
DURAZZO.
EGGMAN.
I.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ A GROVE.
I OR DIDO.
I JONES I LAIRD, I LEMON.
I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
NEWMAN, I WIN.
I NILO I OKOBO I PODIUM I
PORTANTINO.
I WROTE A REVIEW.
SATO I.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
STERN I.
UMBER I.
WAHHAB I.
WIENER I.
WILK.
I.
SENATOR WILK MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACKWARDS.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM 45.
SENATOR UMBERG, ARE YOU
PREPARED?
HE IS READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 940 BY SENATOR
UMBERG.
AN ACT RELATING TO CIVIL
DISPUTES.
SENATOR UMBERG, YOU MAY BEGIN.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES,
THIS IS A BILL THAT ADDRESSES
BOTH CONSUMER ARBITRATION AND
OTHER
KINDS OF MEDIATION AND
ARBITRATION.
AS I THINK MOST OF US KNOW,
IT'S BECOMING INCREASINGLY, UM,
EVIDENT THAT DISPUTES ARE OFTEN
NOW BEING EITHER REQUIRED
TO GO TO ARBITRATION OR REFERRED
TO ARBITRATION.
UM, CONSUMER ARBITRATION IS OF A
DIFFERENT SORT.
IF YOU'VE BOUGHT A CELL PHONE,
YOU'VE PROBABLY BEEN ENGAGED IN
A CONSUMER ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT,
WHETHER YOU KNOW IT OR NOT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS THAT IF
YOU'VE GOT
A DISPUTE THAT'S $12,500 OR
LESS,
YOU CAN OPT TO GO TO SMALL
CLAIMS COURT
RATHER THAN GOING THROUGH
ARBITRATION.
UM, IF YOU DO GO TO ARBITRATION,
THAT ARBITRATION HAS TO BE
CONDUCTED,
FOR EXAMPLE, IN CALIFORNIA
VERSUS SOME OTHER PLACE.
UH, THERE ARE SOME OTHER
ELEMENTS OF THE BILL.
ONE OTHER ELEMENT OF THE BILL
SAYS THAT
THE STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA CAN,
UM, ADOPT A PROCESS OF
CERTIFYING THAT
ARBITRATION MEDIATION ENTITIES,
ALTERNATE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
ENTITIES CAN
APPLY TO BE CERTIFIED IN THAT
THEY
QUALIFY BECAUSE THEY FOLLOW
CERTAIN ETHICAL GUIDELINES,
THAT KIND OF THING.
UM, AND IT ALSO HAS PROVISIONS
THAT DEAL WITH
CONFLICT OF INTEREST OF
ARBITRATION FIRMS.
WITH THAT, I URGE AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
ANY DISCUSSION?
I AM SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
NO ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKESBURG I
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I CORTEZI.
UH, DELI.
NO.
DODD.
BARROSO I EGGMAN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
POTATO.
I.
JONES.
LAIRD.
I THE MOM?
MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
UH, NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO NO NO NO NO.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROT, I RUBIO.
THEATRE.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
I STERN I HAMBURG I WAHA I
WIENER.
WELL, NO.
SECRETARY.
SENATOR UMBERG MOVES A CAR.
THE NEXT THREE WE HAVE ON COMING
UP ON FILE
ARE GOING TO BE FILE ITEMS 57,
58 AND 62.
STARTING OFF WITH SENATOR
SKINNER, FILE ITEM 57.
IF THE SENATOR IS PREPARED.
SHE IS SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 898 BY
SENATOR SKINNER,
AN ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES.
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS.
UM, THERE'S AN INTERESTING
PHENOMENON,
WELL DOCUMENTED,
OF A HIGH INCIDENCE OF LEFT
SIDED
SKIN CANCERS ON YOUR ARMS FACE.
AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY DOMINANT
WITHIN
PEOPLE WHO DRIVE FOR A LIVING.
THE SAME PHENOMENON IS, UH,
FOR RIGHT SIDED SKIN CANCERS
IS EVIDENT IN THOSE COUNTRIES
WHERE YOU DRIVE,
THE DRIVER'S SEAT IS ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF
THE CAR VERSUS THE LEFT SIDE OF
THE CAR.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS.
PROVIDE FOR UV WINDOW FILTERING
JUST ON THE PASSENGER OR,
EXCUSE ME, THE DRIVER'S SIDE
WINDOW.
FOR COMMERCIAL VEHICLES WHERE
PEOPLE
ARE DRIVING FOR A LIVING.
TO PROTECT THOSE DRIVERS FROM
THIS SKIN CANCER.
AND THIS SKIN CANCER
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
BUS AND TRUCK DRIVERS WHO
OBVIOUSLY,
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR LIVING,
OFTEN RECEIVE SIX HOURS OF UV
EXPOSURE
WHILE DRIVING PER DAY.
SO THE BILL PURELY APPLIES TO
THE WINDOWS ON THE DRIVER'S
SIDE.
JUST THAT ONE LARGE WINDOW FOR
SPECIFIED LARGE TRUCKS.
COMMERCIAL TRUCKS.
NOT, UH, WHAT, LIKE LIGHT DUTY
UTILITY TRUCKS
ARE NOT PASSENGER CARS AND
TRUCKS.
AND THE EFFECTIVE DATE IS MOVED
TO 2032.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
SENATOR SATO, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
I JUST HAVE.
SOMETHING FOR.
THE BODY TO CONSIDER HERE.
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT BILLS
LIKE THIS.
UM, ONE OF THEM IS THERE ARE THE
MAIN
ISSUE I HAVE WITH THIS BILL,
EVEN THOUGH IT IS NOW JUST FOR
TRUCKS
AND COMMERCIAL VEHICLES,
IS SIDE WINDOWS ARE TEMPERED
GLASS,
AND TEMPERED GLASS IS EASILY
WHEN YOU PUNCH IT,
IT BREAKS INTO LITTLE BITS AND
FALLS DOWN.
SO YOU HAVE A REALLY QUICK
ACCESS TO GET
INSIDE IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY.
UM, WHEN YOU PUT A LAMINATE
INSIDE THE WINDOW,
IT MAKES IT MUCH LIKE A
WINDSHIELD AND A WINDSHIELD.
YOU CANNOT JUST PUNCH OUT THE
WINDSHIELD.
TAKES A WHILE BEFORE YOU CAN
ACTUALLY GET SOMEBODY
OUT OF A VEHICLE VIA THE
WINDSHIELD.
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO, UH,
REQUIRE THIS TYPE OF,
OF TREATMENT TO THE WINDOW,
NOT ONLY DOES IT RAISE THE PRICE
OF THE CAR MIGHT NOT BE I MEAN,
THE VEHICLE MIGHT NOT BE THAT
MUCH,
BUT I'M MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
QUICK ACCESS,
NOT JUST BY, UM, BY EMERGENCY
WORKERS,
BUT ALSO BY PASSERS BY WHO ARE
USUALLY
THE FIRST ON SCENE OF ANY OF
THESE ACCIDENTS.
AND WHEN IT MAKES THE MOST
DIFFERENCE
IS WHEN THESE VEHICLES
ARE ON FIRE AND THE GLASS HASN'T
BROKEN OUT.
UM, THE QUICKEST WAY TO GET TO
THEM
IS TO PUNCH OUT THAT WINDOW.
THERE ARE AFTER MARKET
TREATMENTS THAT CAN BE
USED FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THE
BUSINESS,
AND THAT ARE AFFECTED BY THESE
TYPE OF,
BY THE UV RAYS.
UM, AND, AND SO THOSE CAN BE
APPLIED AS NEEDED
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
CONCERNS THAT,
THAT THEY ARE BEING EXPOSED.
SO, YOU KNOW, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M GOING TO BE OPPOSING THIS
BILL.
UM, AND THOSE LIKE IT BECAUSE
THOSE FEW SECONDS ARE
FEW MINUTES THAT IT TAKES TO
GAIN BETTER ACCESS,
OR TO GO TO THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE VEHICLE
AND TRY TO ACCESS IT FROM THE
OTHER SIDE.
UM, CAN MEAN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOMEBODY
SURVIVING A VERY BAD ACCIDENT
AND NOT.
AND SO AND I'VE SEEN A FEW OF
THOSE AND THOSE AREN'T FUN.
SO WITH THAT, I'LL BE OPPOSING
IT.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER
THAT WHEN YOU'RE VOTING ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
UM, THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT,
TO RESPOND TO THAT.
WHILE IT IS MORE COMMON FOR
GLASS MANUFACTURERS
TO USE LAMINATE TO ADD THAT UV
PROTECTION,
TEMPERED GLASS CAN ALSO HAVE UV
PROTECTION.
AND THERE ARE COMPANIES WHO DO
THAT.
AND YOU WILL NOTE THAT THE BILL
THIS
WOULD NOT GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL
2032.
SO THERE'S PLENTY OF TIME FOR
MORE COMPANIES TO BE ABLE
TO TO USE THE UV PROTECTION WITH
TEMPERED GLASS,
WHICH ADDRESSES THE SAFETY
CONCERNS.
AND THE BILL DOES NOT PREEMPT
FEDERAL LAW BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE VEHICLE
SAFETY STANDARDS.
THEY'RE ALREADY 20% OF CARS THAT
HAVE SUCH UV PROTECTION ON.
THEY'RE ON THOSE SIDE WINDOWS.
UM, AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER
I BLAKE SPERM I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO.
COURTESY, I DALLY NO DODD.
TORAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
GONZALEZ I GROVE NO DATO.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NIILO, NO.
JOBO.
NO.
PURDUE.
I PORTANTINO.
ROD.
RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL.
CUEVAS A STERN.
UMMER.
I WAHAB, I WIENER.
WELL, NO.
SENATOR SKINNER MOVES A CAR.
FILE ITEM 58.
SENATOR GIARRUSSO IS READY.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1350 BY SENATOR
DURAZZO,
AN ACT RELATING TO PRIVATE
EMPLOYMENT.
SENATOR DURAZZO.
&GT;&GT; MADAM PRESIDENT, SB
1350 SIMPLY REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON POLICIES
THE STATE MAY ADOPT TO PROTECT
DOMESTIC WORKERS FROM WORK
RELATED
INJURIES AND ILLNESSES.
DESPITE CARING FOR OUR, UM, WHAT
WE HOLD MOST DEAR,
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR HOMES,
DOMESTIC WORKERS REMAIN WITHOUT
ANY
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS.
A YEAR INTO THE PANDEMIC,
DOMESTIC WORKERS WERE THREE
TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE CONTRACTED COVID
19 THAN THE GENERAL POPULATION.
ADDITIONALLY, CLIMATE
ACCELERATED,
ACCELERATED DISASTERS MAGNIFY
THE VULNERABILITY
AND DANGERS THAT DOMESTIC
WORKERS
AND DAY LABORERS FACE ON A DAILY
BASIS.
DURING THE WILDFIRES THAT
DEVASTATED CALIFORNIA,
DOMESTIC WORKERS WERE ASKED TO
STAY BEHIND TO FIGHT FIRES,
GUARD HOMES OR PETS, WORK IN
SMOKY CONDITIONS,
AND CLEAN UP TOXIC ASH.
BEYOND THESE EXTREME DANGERS,
DOMESTIC WORKERS ALSO FACE
THE RISK OF INJURY AND ILLNESS
IN THEIR DAY TO DAY WORK RELATED
TO LIFTING,
CHEMICAL HANDLING, AND
REPETITIVE STRAIN.
SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S VETO LAST
YEAR OF MY PRIOR
LEGISLATION REMOVING THE
EXCLUSION OF
PRIVATE PAY HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE WORKERS
FROM HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS.
I HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATION
WITH HIS OFFICE REGARDING
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
DOMESTIC WORKERS.
I AM HOPEFUL THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL RESULT
IN A MEANINGFUL STEP FORWARD
THIS YEAR
IN ADDRESSING THE LEGITIMATE
HEALTH AND SAFETY
RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH DOMESTIC
WORK.
THIS MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
SENATOR DAWLEY, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT.
I MUST RISE IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
FOR TRIAL ATTORNEYS TO HAVE
A FIELD DAY WITH SOMEBODY THAT'S
MOWING YOUR LAWN OR.
OR WORKING AROUND YOUR PROPERTY.
WE HAVE OSHA RULES FOR
BUSINESSES,
AND THIS IS JUST ONE STEP
FURTHER.
THAT'S WHY THE BILL GOT VETOED
LAST YEAR.
FOR THOSE REASONS, I WILL ASK
FOR A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
I QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR,
PLEASE.
WILL THE AUTHOR TAKE A QUESTION?
YES SHE WILL.
I'LL RESPOND IN MY CLOSING.
YES, SENATOR.
PLEASE PROCEED.
IT WITH THE QUESTION,
OR DID SHE WANT TO RESPOND
LATER?
OKAY.
THE QUESTION IS,
WHICH DOMESTIC WORKERS ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT FULL TIME
WORKERS,
OR ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE
PERSON THAT MIGHT
COME BY AND LEAVE THEIR CARD ON
YOUR DOOR BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO TRIM YOUR PALM
TREES?
OR ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE THE
PERSON
THAT MIGHT CLEAN 5 OR 6 HOUSES
A WEEK BUT ONLY COMES TO ONE
HOUSE
MAYBE ONCE EVERY COUPLE OF
WEEKS,
OR ONCE EVERY COUPLE OF, YOU
KNOW,
FOUR WEEKS, ONCE A MONTH.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT ALL OF
THEM?
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE?
I'M NOT.
DONE.
I JUST NEEDED TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED THAT SHE
WOULD
ANSWER IT IN HER CLOSING, SO.
I'M GOING TO ASSUME THAT IT
INCLUDES ALL OF THEM.
AND IF THAT'S THE CASE, THEN WE
CAN CALL THIS
THE DOMESTIC WORKER UNEMPLOYMENT
ACT,
BECAUSE NOBODY IS GOING TO HAVE
OSHA COME IN AND CERTIFY
THEIR HOME TO BE ABLE TO HIRE
SOMEBODY TO COME,
AND THAT WANTS TO COME OVER AND,
YOU KNOW,
TRIM THEIR PALM TREES, FOR
INSTANCE.
UM, BECAUSE THAT IS A VERY YOU
KNOW,
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
SEEKING.
THEY'RE SEEKING A, A TEMPORARY
WORK,
DOING A SPECIFIC TASK THAT
THEY'RE ONLY
GOING TO BE THERE FOR A LITTLE
BIT.
UM, IF HOMEOWNERS ARE GOING TO
BE,
UM, CHARGED WITH THE,
THE TASK OR BE SUBJECT TO, UH,
BEING SUED,
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER HAS
STATED, UH,
THEY'RE JUST NOT GOING TO HIRE
PEOPLE THAT
PROBABLY NEED THAT WORK THE
MOST.
REMEMBER, WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
BE ASKING PEOPLE IF THEY ARE
IMMIGRANTS OR ILLEGAL OR LEGAL
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
YOU'RE JUST LEFT TO EITHER HIRE
SOMEBODY OR NOT.
AND IF YOU DON'T.
IF YOU CAN'T BECAUSE YOU'RE
AFRAID OF OF BEING SUED.
PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT THERE
SEEKING THAT JOB,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE WORK.
AND SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS IS GOING TO HELP THEM.
UH, IT CERTAINLY ISN'T GOING TO
HELP HOMEOWNERS.
AND IT JUST ADDS TO WHAT IS
BASICALLY A POLICY
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE WITH
BUSINESSES,
AND IT EXPOSES THEM TO
LIABILITY.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I WILL BE
OPPOSING THIS BILL.
AND I OPPOSED IT LAST YEAR,
AND I CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT IT THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
SENATOR DRAZIL, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
LET ME JUST CLARIFY HERE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES SIMPLY
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THERE IS NO VOTE ON CHANGING THE
LAW.
IT'S TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE LEGISLATURE
ON POLICIES THAT THE STATE MAY
ADOPT,
MAY ADOPT TO PROTECT DOMESTIC
WORKERS FROM
WORK RELATED INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES.
THIS IS NOT.
UNFORTUNATELY, REMOVING, UH,
THE EXCLUSION OF DOMESTIC
WORKERS FROM WHAT SHOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT WE ALL SUPPORT
BECAUSE
WE WANT SAFE ENVIRONMENT IN OUR
HOMES.
THAT'S WHERE WE LIVE.
THAT'S WHERE OUR KIDS LIVE.
UH, WE SHOULD WANT THE SAFEST
POSSIBLE PLACE.
IT IS A WORKPLACE.
THERE'S NO DISPUTING THAT.
BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING,
THIS BILL IS ONLY TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON POLICIES
THE STATE MAY ADOPT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON.
FINAL ITEM 58.
ELLEN ALVARADO.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER
I BLAKE SPUR I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DALLY KNOW DODD I
DURAZZO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
UH, MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO NILO, NO CHOCOBO, NO PODIUM.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMALL QUAVERS I STERNE I UMMAT
I WAHHAB.
A WIENER.
WELL, NO.
SENATOR DURAZZO MOVES A CALL.
SENATORS, THESE ARE THE THREE
NEXT ON DECK.
WE STILL HAVE MEMBERS OFF THE
FLOOR.
ROLL CALL WILL STILL BE PLACED
ON
ON A CALL AFTER THE FIRST ROUND.
WE HAVE UP NEXT FILE ITEM 64, 65
AND 66.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS IS
PREPARED WITH FILE ITEM 64.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1137 BY SENATOR
SAMUEL CUEVAS.
AN ACT RELATING TO
DISCRIMINATION.
SENATOR.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT,
AND GOOD MORNING, MEMBERS.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT SB 1137,
WHICH WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA THE
PIONEERING STATE
TO RECOGNIZE INTERSECTIONALITY
IN OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS BY CLARIFYING
THAT DISCRIMINATION IS
PROHIBITED NOT
ONLY BECAUSE OF ONE PROTECTED
TRAIT,
BUT BY ANY COMBINATION OF TWO
OR MORE PROTECTED TRAITS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, ALL
INDIVIDUALS
ARE PROTECTED FROM
DISCRIMINATION,
BUT THESE CASES ARE EXACERBATED
WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL
HAS EXPERIENCED DISCRIMINATION
BASED ON A COMBINATION OF
INTERSECTIONS
OF PROTECTED CLASSES.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN A BLACK WOMAN
BRINGS
FORWARD A DISCRIMINATION CASE,
SHE MAY BE FORCED TO ADDRESS HER
RACE
AND GENDER CLAIMS SEPARATELY.
IN CASES WHERE INTERSECTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION OCCURS,
THE DEFENSE MAY ATTEMPT TO USE
THE SEPARATION OF
CHARACTERISTICS TO DEFEAT THE
CLAIM ENTIRELY.
COURTS THROUGHOUT THE NATION
HAVE RULED ON THESE CASES,
AND CONSISTENTLY AND LARGELY
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
THE INTERSECTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION
IS NOT LIMITED TO RACE,
AND GENDER DISCRIMINATION CAN BE
EXPRESSED BASED ON ONE'S AGE,
RACE, NATIONAL ORIGIN, OR ANY
COMBINATION OF SUCH CLASSES.
THOSE OF US WHO LIVE AT THE
INTERSECTIONS
OF MULTIPLE PROTECTED CLASSES
KNOW THAT THESE EXPERIENCES CAN
ALL
CANNOT ALWAYS BE NEATLY
SEPARATED.
WE ARE ONE WHOLE SELF, AND WE
CARRY ALL
OF OUR IDENTITIES WITH US AT ALL
TIMES.
AND IT IS NECESSARY THAT OUR
LAWS REFLECT THAT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM?
I SEE NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO I.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS I.
BECKER I.
BLAKE.
SPEER I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CABALLERO.
CORTEZ.
I.
DALY.
DAD I TORAZO I EGGMAN, I GLASER.
GONZALEZ A GROVE.
HURTADO.
I.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD.
I.
I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
I NUMAN.
I WANE.
NO, NILO.
A THROWBACK.
PEDDUR I.
PORTANTINO I.
ROTH.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE I STERN, I
UMBERG, I WAHAB.
A WIENER.
WELL, NO.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD MOVES THE
CALL.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM 44.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1170 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1170 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR.
AN ACT RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF 1974.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
GETTING A LITTLE BIT OF WHIPLASH
HERE.
WE'RE GOING BACK AND FORTH.
UM, I'M RISING FOR SB 1170.
WHEN CANDIDATES RUN FOR OFFICE,
THEY FACE MANY ISSUES,
ISSUES CONCERNING THEIR SAFETY
AND WELL-BEING TO THREATS,
HARASSMENT AND HOSTILITY OFTEN
RECEIVED DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
THESE INSTANCES CAN TAKE A TOLL
ON A CANDIDATE'S MENTAL HEALTH,
AND THAT CAN ALL LOOK
DIFFERENTLY FOR THE CANDIDATE,
BUT RUN THE GAMUT OF INCREASED
ANXIETY,
SLEEP DISTURBANCE, AND PANIC
ATTACKS.
SB 1170 WILL ALLOW NON-INCUMBENT
CANDIDATES
RUNNING FOR POLITICAL OFFICE
TO USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR
CAMPAIGN RELATED
MENTAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE AS
WHERE MAY
IS MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS
MONTH,
AWARENESS MONTH,
THAT WE LOOK TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE CLOSING
THE GAPS IN THIS AREA AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
A 2023 SURVEY CONDUCTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S LIST FOUND THAT
OVER 100 CALIFORNIANS WHO RAN
FOR
OFFICE BETWEEN 2016 AND 2023,
MORE THAN 80% OF THEM REPORTED
RECEIVING ONLINE ABUSE
AND OVER 50% EXPERIENCED
HARASSMENT IN PERSON.
OVER 50% OF WOMEN OF COLOR AND
LGBTQ+ WOMEN
EXPERIENCED STALKING ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
AND OVER ONE THIRD OF THEM
EXPERIENCED
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE.
THE COVERAGE WOULD BE FOR
SERVICES INCLUDING THERAPY
PROVIDED IN A GROUP OR PRIVATE
SETTING,
EITHER VIRTUALLY OR IN PERSON BY
A PROFESSIONAL.
LICENSED BY THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES TO
ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
OR AN ASSOCIATE OCCURRING.
OR AN ASSOCIATE OR BY AN
ASSOCIATE.
OCCURRING.
OCCURRING THE HOURS FOR SUCH A
LICENSE.
WE CAN'T STOP THE HARASSMENT
FROM OCCURRING BY ALLOWING
CAMPAIGN FUNDS TO BE USED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
COSTS THAT ARE DIRECTLY FROM UM,
RELATED TO EXPERIENCES IN THE
CAMPAIGN
WILL HELP STRIVE TO INCREASE
THEIR
DIVERSITY OF VOICES IN
GOVERNMENT.
WITH THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN I VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER,
I BLAKE SPEER.
I BRADFORD I.
COURTESY.
BYE, DOLLY.
NO, DODD.
I EGGMAN!
I LASER.
I GONZALEZ, I GROVE.
RIDOTTO.
JONES.
NO LAIRD I NAMEMY.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I.
MEN.
NEWMAN.
I.
WYNN.
NO NIILO.
NO.
AKOBO.
NO PODIA.
I PORTANTINO.
ROTH I RUBIO.
CIERTO.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
WILK.
NO.
SENATOR MENGIBAR MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 59.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1103 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1103 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR.
AN ACT RELATING TO TENANCY.
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
BACK UP ON NOW SB 1103.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S SMALL
COMMUNITY,
SERVING BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS
ARE BEING DISPLACED AND GOING
OUT
OF BUSINESS AT AN ALARMING RATE.
UNCLEAR AND UNFAIR LEASE TERMS,
AS WELL AS EXORBITANT ADDED
FEES,
MAKE IT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO
FIND
AND STAY IN A COMMERCIAL SPACE.
AFTER WORKING WITH A LOT OF
MEMBERS
AND THE CHAIR IN YIDDISH,
I TOOK A LOT OF AMENDMENTS THAT
TRIMMED THIS BILL.
TO BE CLEAR NOW, SB 1103 WILL
DEFINE WHAT
IS A QUALIFIED COMMERCIAL
TENANT.
REQUIRE THE TENANT TO NOTIFY THE
LANDLORD THAT
THEY ARE A QUALIFIED COMMERCIAL
TENANT.
WILL THEN REQUIRE THE LANDLORD
AS A RESPONSE TO INFORM
THE TENANT TO REVIEW SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTATION
THAT JUSTIFIES AN INCREASE IN
CAMP FEES,
WHICH ARE MAINTENANCE FEES THAT
CAN BE.
COMPARED TO AN HOA FEE FOR
RESIDENTIAL.
IT REQUIRES THE LANDLORD,
UPON REQUEST OF THE QUALIFIED
COMMERCIAL TENANT,
TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTATION THAT
JUSTIFIES AN INCREASE IN CAMP
FEES,
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE BEING USED
FOR WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE USED FOR.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT CERTAIN
PARAMETERS ON
HOW THE CAMP FEES CAN BE
CHARGED, AGAIN,
ENSURING THAT THEY'RE USED FOR
WHAT
LEGALLY THEY'RE ALLOWED TO BE
USED.
AND FINALLY, WE'RE GOING TO
REQUIRE THAT
THE COMMERCIAL LEASE CONTRACTS
ARE NEGOTIATED IN
FIVE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES TO
INCLUDE SPANISH,
CHINESE, TAGALOG, VIETNAMESE, OR
KOREAN.
THIS BILL DOES NOT LIMIT
COMMERCIAL RENT OR
IMPOSE ANY FORM OF COMMERCIAL
RENT CONTROL,
AND IT DOES NOT IMPOSE OR CHANGE
ANY REQUIREMENTS
FOR OTHER CONTRACTS OR FINANCIAL
DOCUMENTS.
IT ONLY AFFECTS A VERY SMALL
SUBSET OF COMMERCIAL LEASES,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN.
ALBORADA DEL.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY.
I ATKINS.
I BEGGAR.
I BLAKESBURG.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I QUOTESI.
DOLLY.
NO.
DODD.
NO TORAZO I EGGMAN, I GLASER.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO, I.
JONES.
NO LAIRD I LEMAN I MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR I MEN I NEWMAN.
WHEN?
NO.
NILO.
NO OKOBO.
NO.
PADILLA I PORTENTINO.
ROD A RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS.
STERN I.
UMBER I.
WAHHAB I.
WIENER.
WELL, NO.
SENATOR MENGIBAR MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO OUR
FILE ORDER MEMBERS.
THIS WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
FILE ITEM 65.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1223 BY
SENATOR BECKER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1223 BY SENATOR
BECKER.
AN ACT RELATING TO PRIVACY.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A BILL
ABOUT REGULATING BRAIN DATA.
YES.
BRAIN DATA.
UH, AND IF THAT SOUNDS
FUTURISTIC,
I CAN TELL YOU EVERYONE WHO
WAS IN A JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
THAT
DAY LISTENING TO MY EXPERTS,
INCLUDING RAFA USTA, WHO
INSPIRED PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S BRAIN INITIATIVE,
EVERYBODY WAS PAYING RAPT
ATTENTION.
NOBODY WAS ON THEIR PHONES.
NOBODY WAS READING ANYTHING BUT
PAYING ATTENTION
TO HEAR HIM TALK ABOUT HIS
OPPENHEIMER MOMENT,
WHEN HE REALIZED THAT HE WAS
ABLE TO
NOT JUST READ THE THOUGHTS OF
MICE,
BUT TO IMPLANT THOUGHTS INTO
MICE.
SO THIS IS NOT SCIENCE FICTION.
UM, AND A LOT OF THIS RESEARCH
IS HAPPENING HERE IN OUR AREA,
AND THE EXPERTS THEMSELVES ARE
THE ONES RAISING THE RED FLAG ON
THIS.
THERE'S BEEN ABOUT $19 BILLION
INVESTED GLOBALLY
IN OVER 200 NEUROSCIENCE
COMPANIES,
INCLUDING A WRISTBAND THAT WILL
ATTEMPT TO TRANSLATE, UM,
INFORMATION ABOUT INTENTIONS
AND GESTURES FROM YOUR WRIST.
SO, UH, INVASIVE TECHNOLOGIES
LIKE YOU'VE
HEARD OF MAYBE ELON MUSK'S
NEURALINK,
INVASIVE DEVICES LIKE THAT
ACTUALLY ARE
ALREADY REGULATED AS MEDICAL
DEVICES.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE NOW OVER 30
CLASS OF NEUROTECH COMPANIES
THAT ARE DOING NON-INVASIVE
NEUROTECH PRODUCTS.
THESE DEVICES RECORD BRAIN DATA
USING EEG SENSORS,
BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
CONSIDERED MEDICAL DEVICES,
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT SO TIGHTLY
REGULATED.
SO THAT ALLOWS COMPANIES TO
COLLECT AND SELL
USER DATA WITHOUT CONSUMER
PERMISSION.
AND THERE'S JUST A RECENT
ANALYSIS OF THE PRIVACY
POLICIES OF ALL OF THESE
COMPANIES.
AND YES, THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DO WHATEVER
THEY WANT WITH BRAIN DATA.
IN ALMOST ALL CASES, UM, AND THE
CCPA
PROTECTS PERSONAL INFORMATION,
BUT AGAIN, IT DOESN'T COVER
NEURAL DATA.
SO WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO WILL
MAKE SURE THAT NEURAL
DATA IS COVERED BY OUR CCPA BY
DEFINING
AND CLASSIFYING IT AS SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION
AND EXTENDING CCPA PROTECTIONS
TO NEURAL DATA.
REGULATING NEURAL TECHNOLOGY
EARLY
IS CRUCIAL TO ENSURE ETHICAL
USE,
PROTECT PRIVACY, ESTABLISH
STANDARDS,
AND ADDRESS FUTURE CHALLENGES.
AGAIN, IF YOU HAVEN'T HEARD
ABOUT THIS,
YOU WILL IN THE NEAR FUTURE,
AND WE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE THE
CHANCE TO GET AHEAD
OF THIS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BECKER.
SENATOR BECKER, DO YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M THINKING?
YES.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
HEY.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE?
SENATOR BECKER KNEW THAT.
ALL RIGHT, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I.
ATKINS I.
BECKER I.
BLAKE.
SPERM.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I CORTEZI.
DALLY I.
DODD, I.
OSO I.
EGGMAN, I.
GLAZER I.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE I.
DATO.
I JONES, I LAIRD, I LAMONT.
I.
MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
MEN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN.
I NEED.
OKAY I I JOE PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH, I RUBIO.
CIERTO.
SKINNER A SMALL QUAVERS I.
STERNE I.
UMBERG I.
WAHAB, I.
WIENER.
WILK.
SENATOR BECKER THINKS A CALL.
MOVES A CALL.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 66.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1224 BY
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH.
SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1224 BY SENATOR
OKOBO.
AN ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES.
SENATOR OKOBO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL 1224 WILL ALLOW THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS IN INDIO TO SERVE
ALCOHOL ON
SITE AS LONG AS FOOD SERVICE IS
AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC AT ALL TIMES DURING
THE EVENTS.
THIS CHANGE ENSURES THE FAIR CAN
CONTINUE OPERATING
AS IT HAS FOR ALMOST TWO
DECADES,
ALLOWING THE COMMUNITY TO
BENEFIT
FROM THE SUBSTANTIAL REVENUE
THAT FAIR EVENTS CONTRIBUTE TO
THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MATTER,
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SCENE NINE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
OF RODRIGO.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER
I BLAKE SPEAR I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO.
I CORTEZI.
I DALLY, I DUD.
I THOUGHT ALSO.
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE.
I OR DODO I JONES I LAIRD I
LEMON.
BY MAGUIRE MENJIVAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WAYNE.
I KNEW.
MATOBO I BIDYA.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SATO.
I SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS I STERN
I UMMER.
&GT;&GT; I FORGOT.
I WAHAB, I WIENER.
WELL, I.
NILA I.
&GT;&GT; SENATOR OCHOA BOGH
MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 67 AND 68.
THESE ARE BOTH MEASURES BY
SENATOR MINH.
START WITH FILE ITEM 67 SB 1271.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1271 BY SENATOR
MINH.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
SB 1271 WOULD ENHANCE THE SAFETY
AND REGULATORY COMPLIANCE OF
ELECTRIC
BICYCLES AND ELECTRIC SCOOTERS
BY REQUIRING
ALL E-BIKES AND E-SCOOTERS
TO BE MANUFACTURED WITH
BATTERIES
THAT MEET THE STRINGENT
STANDARDS
OF THE EUROPEAN UNION AND
UNDERWRITERS LABORATORIES.
IT WOULD ALSO MODIFY THE
DEFINITION OF E-BIKE
CLASSES TO CLARIFY WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE
CLASS FOR A SWITCHABLE E-BIKE
IS, IF ANY,
HELPING WITH SAFETY CONCERNS.
IN RECENT YEARS, THE SALE OF
E-BIKES HAS SKYROCKETED,
AND IN TURN,
THIS HAS INCREASED THE CONCERNS
ABOUT
POTENTIAL SPEED AND FIRE RISKS.
THIS MEASURE WOULD HELP
CONSUMERS
BY MODIFYING THE DEFINITION
OF E-BIKE CLASSES TO CLARIFY
WHAT CONSTITUTES AN E-BIKE,
AS WELL AS REMOVING LOWER
QUALITY,
HIGH FIRE RISK PERSONAL
MOBILITY DEVICE BATTERIES FROM
THE MARKET.
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN I
VOTE.
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN.
OH RODRIGO I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS.
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ I DALLY, I DODD.
I DORADO I EGGMAN.
GLASER, I.
GONZALEZ, I.
GROVE.
I OR DODO.
I JONES, I LAIRD I LAMONI.
I.
MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
MAN I NEWMAN.
I WHEN I NILO I OKOBO I PODIUM.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO, I SATO, I
SKINNER.
ON A SMALL CANVAS I STERN I
UMBERG I.
WIENER MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE AGAIN,
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ATKINS I.
EGGMAN.
I MAGUIRE, I MENGIBAR, I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL.
I.
HERE WE GO.
AND A VOTE OF 39 TO 0.
THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 68.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1286 BY
SENATOR MEN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1286 BY SENATOR
MINH.
AN ACT RELATING TO DEBT
COLLECTION.
SENATOR MIN.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
IN RECENT YEARS, WE'VE SEEN A
RISE
IN PREDATORY DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES TARGETED AT SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
SB 1286 WOULD TRY TO ADDRESS
THIS
BY PROTECTING SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS UNDER THE ROSENTHAL FAIR
DEBT COLLECTION
ACT IS COLLECTIONS ACT WHEN
THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE PERSONALLY SIGNED FOR THEIR
BUSINESS DEBT.
THERE ARE OVER 30 MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA RUN BY
INDIVIDUALS,
AND THESE BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
OPERATING
VERY SIMILARLY TO INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMERS WHEN NAVIGATING THE
FINANCIAL MARKETPLACE.
THIS WAS PARTICULARLY TRUE AFTER
THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
AS THEY STRUGGLED TO ACQUIRE
CAPITAL,
ESPECIALLY FOR MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES
THAT OFTEN STRUGGLE TO FIND
CREDIT.
PROVIDING A PERSONAL GUARANTEE
FOR BUSINESS DEBT OPENS
THE DOOR FOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS TO BE SUBJECTED
PERSONALLY TO ABUSIVE DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES OF
THE KIND THAT THE ROSENTHAL
ACT WAS MEANT TO PROHIBIT,
INCLUDING THREATS, CONTACTING
BORROWERS
AT INCONVENIENT HOURS,
USING FALSE STATEMENTS,
OR ADDING UNAUTHORIZED INTEREST
OR FEES TO THE AMOUNTS OWED.
UNDER SB 1286, BORROWERS WOULD
STILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING THESE
DEBTS,
BUT WOULD BE PROTECTED FROM
UNFAIR, DECEPTIVE,
OR ABUSIVE COLLECTION PRACTICES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
MEMBERS.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY I ATKINS I.
BECKER.
I.
BLAKE.
SPERM.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CORTEZI.
I DALLY?
NO, DODD.
THAT ALSO.
THE THOUGHT I THOUGHT ALTHOUGH
I.
EGGMAN.
I GLASER I I GONZALEZ, I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO, I.
JONES.
NO LAIRD I NAMEMY, I MAGUIRE, I
MENGIBAR.
WHEN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NEELO.
OKOBOJI.
NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
I ROT.
RUBIO.
CO2?
NO, SKINNER.
A SMALL QUAVERS I STERN I UMMER,
I WAHAB I WIENER.
I WILL KNOW.
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE, SO WE'RE
GOING TO
GO THROUGH THE ROLL ONE LAST
TIME.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
ALVARADO YOU KNOW ARCHULETA I
BRADFORD
MENGIBAR I WRATH RUBIO I.
ON A VOTE OF 28 TO 9.
THE MEASURE CARRIES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 69.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1354 BY
SENATOR WAHAB.
SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1354 BY SENATOR
WAHAB,
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES.
SENATOR WAHAB.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1354,
THE PROTECT SENIORS AT ALL COSTS
ACT.
SB 1354 ALIGNS THE LAW WITH
REGULATIONS
REGARDING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES
AND PROTECTS THE RIGHTS OF
RESIDENTS,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR PAYMENT
SOURCE.
SB 1354 ALSO REQUIRES RESIDENTS
BEING
TRANSFERRED OR DISCHARGED,
BE INFORMED THAT THEY MAY BE
ELIGIBLE
FOR MEDI-CAL LONG TERM
CARE PROGRAM TO HELP PAY FOR
THEIR
STAY PAYMENT SOURCE
DISCRIMINATION
FORCES LOW INCOME SENIORS TO
MOVE AWAY FROM FAMILY,
FRIENDS, AND THEIR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS IN ORDER
TO ACCESS A FACILITY THAT WILL
ACCEPT MEDI-CAL,
SOMETIMES HUNDREDS OF MILES
AWAY.
THIS PRACTICE ONLY EXISTS SO
SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES CAN MAKE
SPACE FOR MORE LUCRATIVE PRIVATE
PAY OR MEDICARE RESIDENTS.
SB 1354 WILL STRENGTHEN AND
ENHANCE
THE RIGHTS OF RESIDENTS IN THESE
FACILITIES
AND PROTECT AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION
BASED ON THEIR PAYMENT SOURCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I.
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY.
I ATKINS.
BECKER.
I BLAKE.
SPEER.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
I DALLY KNOW DODD I DURAZZO I
EGGMAN, I GLASER.
I GONZALEZ, I GROVE KNOW
HURTADO.
I JONES.
LAIRD I LIMON.
I MCGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
MIN I NEWMAN, I WANE.
NO.
NEELO.
OJOBO.
NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO, I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
SALATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN.
I'M BURKE.
STERN I UMBERG, I WAHAB, I
WEINER.
I WILL NOW PLEASE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN I'LL RODA-GIL.
NO.
ATKINS I JONES.
MENGIBAR I RUBIO I.
I HAD A VOTE OF 30 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE ABOUT TO GO INTO
RECESS.
I TO BE TO RETURN HERE TO THE
CHAMBERS
AT 130 SHARP, 130 SHARP.
PRIOR TO THAT, I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE
THE MAJORITY LEADER,
SENATOR GONZALES.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT.
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE LUNCH AT 12:00.
AS MENTIONED BY THE PRESIDING
OFFICER AND THEN A 12:20 P.M.
CAUCUS.
THANK YOU.
AND THE MADI LOUNGE, THANK YOU.
AND RECOGNIZING THE MINORITY
LEADER, SENATOR JONES.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS.
SAME FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
LUNCH IS BEING PROVIDED AND WE
WILL MEET
IN ROOM 215 FOR OUR CAUCUS
MEETING.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS FOR A PRODUCTIVE
MORNING.
WE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL 130
SHARP.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS.
THE SENATE WILL CONVENE IN 30S.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MEMBERS.
WE ARE BACK FROM RECESS.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THIRD
READING.
GIVE YOU A HEADS UP TO THE BILLS
THAT WILL BE COMING TO YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM 71,
MOVING ON TO 77 AND THEN TO 177.
THAT'S OUT OF ORDER.
FILE ITEM 177.
SO WITH THE COOPERATION OF OUR
BUILDERS IN THE VICINITY,
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
SENATOR DODDS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 71 SB 1379.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1379 BY SENATOR
DODD,
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
RETIREMENT
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY
THEREOF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR DODD, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
PLEASE GIVE HIM YOUR ATTENTION,
MEMBERS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB
1379.
THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL TO
TEMPORARILY WAIVE
THE 960 HOUR LIMIT FOR RETIRED
ANNUITANTS
WORKING FOR THE SOLANO COUNTY
SHERIFF TO ADDRESS
A CRITICAL STAFFING NEED IN
VALLEJO.
THE BILL WILL SUNSET AFTER THREE
YEARS.
CAN I REPEAT THAT?
THE BILL WILL SUNSET AFTER THREE
YEARS.
THE VALLEJO CITY COUNCIL
DECLARED
A STATE OF EMERGENCY LAST
YEAR DURING A MAJOR POLICE
OFFICER STAFFING SHORTAGE.
DESPITE BEING AUTHORIZED FOR 132
OFFICERS,
VALLEJO PD CURRENTLY ONLY HAS 32
PATROL
OFFICERS AND FOUR DETECTIVES.
AS A RESULT OF SOLANO COUNTY,
SHERIFF IS TAXED WITH RESPONDING
TO EMERGENCY CALLS IN VALLEJO,
AND THIS BILL IS ESSENTIAL TO
ASSIST
THEM WITH RESPONDING TO THESE
CALLS.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE SHERIFF
TO TRY TO HIRE FULL TIME
ACTIVE DEPUTIES BEFORE USING A
RETIRED ANNUITY,
AND IT REQUIRES THOROUGH
BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON ANYONE BEING HIRED.
THERE'S PRECEDENT FOR WAIVING
THE THE HOUR LIMIT WHEN NEEDED.
LAST YEAR, GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER
IN RESPONSE TO WINTER STORMS
WAVE THIS
960 HOUR LIMIT FOR RETIRED
ANNUITANTS
WORKING FOR THE STATE RECOVERY
ROLES.
GIVEN VALLEJO'S IMMEDIATE PUBLIC
SAFETY CRISIS,
THE CITY CAN'T AFFORD TO WAIT
FOR
MORE OFFICERS TO BE TRAINED.
WITHOUT THIS BILL, THE SOLANO
COUNTY SHERIFF WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO THE
NEEDS OF VALLEJO.
THE BILL HAS BROAD LOCAL SUPPORT
AND NO RECORDED OPPOSITION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR DODD.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY DISCUSSION MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO I'M GOING TO ASK
THE SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL.
BUT LET ME REMIND MEMBERS TO
PLEASE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL TWICE.
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE.
PLEASE DON'T SHOUT OUT YOUR NAME
AT THE COMPLETION OF THE ROLL.
WE'LL CALL BACK THROUGH AT
ANOTHER TIME SO YOU CAN
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND
TO YOUR NAME.
SO WITH THAT, WITH SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL I ARCHULETA, I ASHBY I
ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO CORTEZ
I DALLY DODD I DORADO I EGGMAN
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE
I HURTADO I JONES KNOW LAIRD
I LIMON I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR MIN
I NEWMAN I WYNN.
NILO I OKOBO PADILLA OCHOA I
PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO.
SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS.
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN CABALLERO I DALLY.
NO.
MENGIBAR I WYNN.
SATO.
NO.
SMALL CUEVAS.
SMALL QUIVERS I.
AYES 35.
NOES FOUR.
THE MEASURE PASSES ON THE
URGENCY.
AYES 35.
NOES FOUR.
ON THE MEASURE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
77.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1418 BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1418 BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA.
AN ACT RELATING TO LAND USE.
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL 1418.
SENATE BILL 1418 SIMPLY
STREAMLINES THE HYDROGEN
FUELING STATION PERMITTING
PROCESS
IN THE SAME WAY THAT WE DO FOR
THE BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS.
A FEW CONSIDERATIONS WERE RAISED
IN
THE POLICY COMMITTEE THAT THIS
STREAMLINED
PERMITTING PROCESS HAS A
POTENTIAL TO
BE OVERBURDENSOME FOR SMALLER
CITIES.
WE'VE TAKEN THE SURVEY.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS,
I AMENDED THE BILL ON THE SENATE
FLOOR TO DELAY
THE COMPLIANCE PERIOD FOR
SMALLER CITIES
BY AN ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS.
ADDITIONALLY, I READJUSTED
THE POPULATION THRESHOLD TO
EXTEND
THIS EXTENDED COMPLIANCE PERIOD
TO EVEN MORE CITIES.
IN SHORT, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE
OF THE FEDERAL FUNDING COMING
INTO CALIFORNIA THROUGH OUR
SUCCESSFUL
HYDROGEN HUB APPLICATION.
WE ARE GOING TO NEED POLICY IN
PLACE
TO EXPEDITE AND DEVELOPMENT
AND DEPLOYMENT OF HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SB 1418 IS ONE SUCH POLICY AND
WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION TO A
CLEANER,
MORE SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
FUTURE.
FOR THESE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ARCHULETA.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SENATOR STERN?
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
UM, I APPRECIATE THE SENATOR'S
EFFORTS.
MY MY CONCERN TODAY ABOUT THE
MEASURE IS
THE INCLUSION OF STORAGE
FACILITIES,
WHICH CAN HAVE SAFETY
IMPLICATIONS.
UM, FUELING STATIONS, ONE THING.
BUT WE KNOW HYDROGEN IS AN
EXTREMELY
COMBUSTIBLE FUEL.
SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S
STILL LOCAL CONTROL.
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY,
UH, FINDING A WAY TO.
YES, IN THE FUTURE, BUT WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE TODAY.
THANKS.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION, MEMBERS?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR ARCHULETA, YOU MAY
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN.
ELROD.
EAGLE EYE.
ARCHULETA.
EYE.
ASHBY.
ATKINS.
EYE.
BECKER.
BLAKE.
SPERM.
EYE.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
CORTAZZI I.
DALLEY I.
DODD I.
DURAZZO I.
EGGMAN.
GLAZER I.
GONZALEZ.
GROVE.
HURTADO I.
JONES, I.
LAIRD, I.
LEHMAN.
MCGUIRE, I.
MENGIBAR I.
MEN.
I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NILO.
OKOBO.
I PADILLA, I PORTANTINO ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SATO.
SKINNER.
I SMALL CUEVAS.
I STERN.
BLUMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILL
I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN.
CABALLERO I EGGMAN I GONZALEZ
GROVE
I NAMEMY WIN NILO PORTANTINO I.
CIERTO.
STERN.
ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE A DETOUR
AND CONTINUE WITH OUR FILE.
ONE MORE ITEM BEFORE WE MOVE TO
FILE ITEM 177.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 77,
SENATE BILL 1418 BY SENATOR
ROTH.
EXCUSE ME.
FILE ITEM 78.
THIS IS SB 902 BY SENATOR ROTH.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 902 BY SENATOR ROTH.
AN ACT RELATING TO FIREARMS.
SENATOR ROTH.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL WILL ADD AN AUTOMATIC
TEN YEAR FIREARMS PROHIBITION
TO MISDEMEANOR ANIMAL ABUSE
CONVICTIONS.
THE BILL PASSED OUT OF THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AS YOU KNOW, CALIFORNIA HAS A
HISTORY
OF ENSURING THAT FIREARMS
DO NOT FALL INTO THE HANDS OF
THOSE WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED
VIOLENT TENDENCIES IN AN ATTEMPT
TO PREVENT FUTURE
VIOLENCE AGAINST OTHERS CRIMES
SUCH AS STALKING,
ENDANGERING THE HEALTH OF A
CHILD AND ENDANGERING
THE HEALTH OF AN ELDER OR A
DEPENDENT ADULT.
RESEARCH REFLECTS THAT 41% OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
OFFENDERS HAD HISTORIES OF
ANIMAL CRUELTY AND THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO COMMIT ANIMAL
ABUSE ARE FIVE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO COMMIT VIOLENT CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANS.
BASED ON THE CONNECTION.
IN 2016, THE FBI AMENDED THE
NATIONAL
INCIDENT BASED REPORTING
SYSTEM TO START COLLECTING DATA
ON ANIMAL ABUSE.
NOW, A SENATOR, AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT
SERIOUS ANIMAL CRUELTY HERE,
INCIDENTS, CONVICTIONS OF PENAL
CODE SECTION 597.
CONVICTIONS FOR THE MALICIOUS
AND INTENTIONAL MAIMING,
MUTILATION, TORTURE,
WOUNDING OR KILLING OF AN
ANIMAL.
GIVEN THE NUMEROUS STUDIES
SHOWING THAT ANIMAL ABUSE
IS A PREDICTOR OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST HUMANS,
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE WITH A HISTORY OF ANIMAL
CRUELTY ARE PROHIBITED FROM
OWNING
AND POSSESSING FIREARMS.
FOR AT LEAST TEN YEARS,
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED WITH THOSE
IN SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE,
AND WE TOOK AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
THE FELONY FOR
NON-COMPLIANCE WITH THE FIREARMS
PROHIBITION,
THUS LIMITING THE PENALTY TO A
MISDEMEANOR.
I WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
EYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA.
I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKE.
SPEER.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLEY.
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I,
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HURTADO I JONES NO, LAIRD I
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN,
I NEWMAN I WIN NILO I OKOBO I
PADILLA.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROD.
I RUBIO.
I SATO.
I SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS.
I STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WAHHAB.
I WEINER.
I WILL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN THALLU GROVE.
WHEN?
NO.
WHEN I.
ON A VOTE OF 36 TO 1.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO
MAKE SURE YOU'RE PAYING
ATTENTION.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 126.
OF COURSE.
UH, THIS IS US SENATE BILL 915
BY SENATOR CORTEZ.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 915 BY SENATOR
CORTEZ,
AN ACT RELATING TO AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES.
SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
&GT;&GT; WELL, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, SB 915 ALLOWS CITIES
WITH
A POPULATION GREATER THAN
250,000
TO PASS ORDINANCES REGULATING
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES,
SERVICES, OR AVS.
THIS IS COMMERCIAL SERVICE.
ANY SMALLER BORDERING CITIES MAY
PASS A SIMILAR ORDINANCE.
THESE PROVISIONS PROMOTE A
BALANCE BETWEEN
LOCAL CONTROL AND REGIONAL
CONSISTENCY.
CURRENTLY, THE DMV AND PUC
AUTHORIZED AV SERVICES.
THEY HOLD PROCEEDINGS TO GATHER
PUBLIC INPUT,
BUT THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THE
STATE WILL CONSIDER
LOCAL CONCERNS OR HAS THE
CAPACITY TO DO SO.
GOVERNANCE OF LOCAL STREETS AND
ROADS, OF COURSE,
HAS LONG FALLEN UNDER THE SHARED
JURISDICTION
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND STATE
GOVERNMENT.
THE OPERATIONS OF THESE VEHICLES
SHOULD BE NO
DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER MOTOR
VEHICLES.
ORDINANCES CANNOT BE USED TO
BAN THE OPERATION OF THESE
SERVICES PER VERY EXPRESS
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
THERE'S LITERALLY A NO BAN
CLAUSE IN THE BILL.
THE BILL ALSO ENSURES EQUITABLE
ACCESS
FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES,
AND IT REQUIRES ALL OF THESE
VEHICLES
TO HAVE AN OVERRIDE SYSTEM FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS TO ADDRESS
RECENT
ISSUES THAT HAVE OCCURRED.
THANK YOU.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR CORTEZ.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE?
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
SENATOR BECKER.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
UM, I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I
KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A BUNCH OF CONCERN FROM,
UH, FROM THE TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY.
SOME OF THE COMPANIES AFFECTED
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROVISIONS.
I KNOW THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE JUST TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT, THAT TRY
TO KIND OF CLARIFY.
I THINK THERE'S A CONCERN ABOUT
KIND OF CREATING ANY KIND OF
PATCHWORK SYSTEM THAT WOULD JUST
BE BE REALLY UNWORKABLE.
BUT I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR.
I KNOW HE'S BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO, TO,
UH, KIND OF AVOID THAT THAT
SCENARIO AND,
YOU KNOW, HAS WE'VE DISCUSSED
SOME IDEAS TO
CONTINUE LOOKING AT THAT GOING
FORWARD.
SO, UM, WITH THAT, I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM GOING FORWARD.
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR BECKER, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MEMBERS,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER
I BLAKESBERG BRADFORD I
CABALLERO.
CORTEZ.
I DELI.
NO DODD THOUGHT OSO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER
GONZALEZ I GROVE HURTADO I JONES
NO LAIRD I LEHMAN I MCGUIRE I
MENGIBAR I MEN,
I NEWMAN I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
OKOBO NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO.
SATO NO.
SKINNER I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
STERN I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
NO.
WELL, NO.
SENATOR CORTESE MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO OUR
THIRD READING FILE ORDER,
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM 79,
FOLLOWED BY 80 AND 81.
WE'LL FIRST BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
79.
THIS IS SB 907 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 907 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO COUNTY BOARDS
OF EDUCATION.
SENATOR NEWMAN.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
SB 907 IS A DISTRICT BILL WHICH
WILL IMPROVE REPRESENTATION
AND ELECTORAL PARTICIPATION IN
ORANGE COUNTY BY MAKING TWO VERY
SENSIBLE CHANGES
TO THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
ONE, INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
TRUSTEES
FROM THE CURRENT 5 TO 7,
AND TWO SHIFTING THE BOARD'S
ELECTION
CYCLE FROM THE PRIMARY BALLOT
AS CURRENTLY CONDUCTED AND INTO
THE GENERAL ELECTION IN
NOVEMBER.
IN.
SINCE ORANGE COUNTY'S DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION
WAS ESTABLISHED IN ITS MODERN
FORM,
THE POPULATION OF OC HAS NEARLY
DOUBLED FROM 1.8
MILLION TO IN 1977 TO ITS
CURRENT
POPULATION OF NEARLY 3.2
MILLION.
THAT MAKES IT THE THIRD LARGEST
COUNTY BY POPULATION
IN THE STATE OF THE STATE'S TEN
LARGEST COUNTIES.
ORANGE COUNTY IS CURRENTLY ONE
OF ONLY FOUR WHOSE COUNTY
BOARDS OF EDUCATION HAVE ONLY
FIVE TRUSTEES.
OF THE COUNTIES WHICH STILL HAVE
FIVE TRUSTEES,
THE ONLY ONE COMPARABLE IN SIZE
TO ORANGE
COUNTY AS THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO.
IN THE NEARLY FIVE DECADES SINCE
THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION,
ORANGE COUNTY'S POPULATION HAS
ALSO
BECOME INFINITELY MORE DIVERSE.
ACCORDING TO THE 2000 CENSUS,
MORE THAN 50% OF POPULATION AT
THAT TIME WAS WHITE.
BY THE TIME OF THE MOST RECENT
CENSUS,
THAT SHARE HAD DROPPED TO LESS
THAN 37%,
WITH OC NOW HAVING BECOME A
RESOUNDINGLY
MAJORITY MINORITY COUNTY.
EXPANDING THE BOARD FROM ITS
CURRENT FIVE
TRUSTEES TO SEVEN WILL ENSURE
THAT
THIS BOARD MORE FULLY REFLECTS
THAT DIVERSITY
WITHIN ITS ELECTED MEMBERSHIP.
MOVING THE ELECTION OF THE OC,
BOE TRUSTEES INTO THE NOVEMBER
GENERAL
WILL ENSURE HIGHER PARTICIPATION
BY THAT MORE DIVERSE ELECTORATE.
THAT WOULD BE A POSITIVE
DEVELOPMENT
IN NOT ONE, BUT TWO DIRECTIONS.
FIRST, AS MENTIONED, IT WILL
RESULT OVER TIME IN A BOARD
THAT MORE CLOSELY REFLECTS OC S
CHANGING POPULATION.
SECONDLY, AND JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY,
INCLUDING THE VOTE FOR COUNTY
BOARD
OF TRUSTEES ON THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT
WILL GIVE VOTERS A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
AND CONNECT WITH CANDIDATES AND
THE EVENTUAL
ELECTED BOARD MEMBERS AS PART OF
THAT CRITICAL TASK
OF CONNECTING RESIDENTS TO CIVIC
INSTITUTIONS
ABOUT WHICH THEY ARE
INCREASINGLY UNINFORMED
AND FROM WHICH THEY ARE
INCREASINGLY DISCONNECTED.
AS I'VE EMPHASIZED IN MY
CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND WITH
OTHERS,
THE IMPETUS FOR THIS BILL DOES
NOT ARISE OUT OF POLITICS,
ENHANCING THE RESPONSIVENESS OF
A GOVERNING
BODY AND IMPROVING PARTICIPATION
IN THE ELECTION OF THAT BODY
ARE OBJECTIVELY GOOD GOALS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL SEEK TO DO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE I SEE
MICROPHONES UP
FROM SENATOR MINH AND AND
SENATOR NGUYEN.
START WITH SENATOR MINH.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I RISE AS A PROUD CO-AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, I AUTHORED
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY DID NOT MAKE
IT ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
THAT WOULD HAVE DONE A
SUBSTANTIALLY MUCH OF THIS.
UM, AND THE PROBLEM IN ORANGE
COUNTY IS
THAT THIS IS THE ONLY ELECTED
BODY
IN THE COUNTY THAT IS DECIDED ON
A ONE
AND DONE IN THE PRIMARY
ELECTION.
NO OTHER ELECTION IN ORANGE
COUNTY IS LIKE THIS.
AND SO VOTERS ARE GENUINELY
CONFUSED
WHEN I TALK TO THEM ABOUT
THEY MOST OF THEM DON'T
UNDERSTAND
THAT THE VOTE THAT THEY
CAST OR CHOOSE NOT TO CAST IN
THE PRIMARY IS THE ONLY VOTE
THEY'LL HAVE FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION.
THERE IS NO RUNOFF.
THERE IS NO GENERAL ELECTION.
THERE IS NO TOP TWO.
AS WITH OTHER ELECTIONS AT
THE SAME TIME AS AS MY AUTHOR,
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FULLERTON,
IS APTLY POINTED OUT, UH,
ORANGE COUNTY HAS GOTTEN VERY
BIG AND VERY DIVERSE.
AND I THINK GIVEN THE LOW
TURNOUT
IN THESE PRIMARY ELECTIONS,
GIVEN THE CONFUSION AMONG
VOTERS,
AND JUST BY WAY OF CONTEXT,
IN THE MARCH 2024 ELECTION,
WE ONLY HAD 37% TURNOUT, UH,
FOR ORANGE COUNTY GENERALLY.
CERTAINLY, IT WAS MUCH, MUCH
LOWER FOR
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
SO THIS IS NOT A BODY THAT THAT
IS FULLY ELECTED
WITH THE FULL REPRESENTATION IN
MIND.
SO I WOULD URGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO VOTE I ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR MINH, SENATOR NGUYEN.
&GT;&GT; THANK THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I, I ACTUALLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
REPRESENTING
MAJORITY OF ORANGE COUNTY IN MY
DISTRICT.
THIS BILL IS PURE POLITICS.
IF IT WAS A GOOD POLICY BILL, IT
SHOULD BE A BILL
FOR ALL THE COUNTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
NO, IT IS SPECIFICALLY TARGETED
TO ORANGE COUNTY.
AND THE REASON IS BECAUSE OF THE
OPPOSITION
HAS CONTINUOUSLY LOST ELECTIONS
IN ORANGE COUNTY TO THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION THIS LAST ELECTION.
ALL THE MEMBERS WERE REELECTED
ALMOST 50 OVER 50,
MAYBE EVEN 60% OF THE TOTAL
VOTES.
SO I BELIEVE THAT IF IT'S GOING
TO BE IF IT'S A GOOD POLICY,
IF THE AUTHOR TRULY BELIEVES
IT'S A GOOD POLICY,
LET'S MAKE IT STATEWIDE.
LET'S MAKE IT EVERY COUNTY,
EVERY BOARD OF EDUCATION IN
ORANGE IN CALIFORNIA,
AND NOT JUST TARGET TO ORANGE
COUNTY.
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NGUYEN.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
A NO VOTE.
SENATOR WINS.
NGUYEN'S ASKING FOR THE NO VOTE.
I SEE SENATOR OCHOA BOGH.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I DO NOT LIVE IN ORANGE COUNTY,
BUT I DO.
BUT I AM THE VICE CHAIR FOR
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION,
AND THIS IS THE SECOND TIME
WE'VE
SEEN THIS BILL IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND AGAIN, I'M GOING TO RISE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL.
AND THE REASON BEING IS THAT
ORANGE COUNTY, UH.
THE THE PEOPLE IN ORANGE COUNTY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THIS LOCALLY WITHIN THEIR
SCHOOL,
THEIR OWN SCHOOL BOARD.
THE PEOPLE IN THE ORANGE COUNTY
HAVE THE ABILITY
TO REQUEST THIS TO BE DONE
LOCALLY,
AND THEY HAVE NOT REQUESTED IT
TO DO IT LOCALLY.
THEY HAVE NOT, UM, DONE SO AT
ANY
IN THE PAST AT ALL WHATSOEVER.
AND YET WE'RE WE'RE TAKING THIS
STEP HERE FORWARD AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO SAY THIS IS
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO.
IF THEY DID NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY IN
THE PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO DO SO
LOCALLY,
THEN PERHAPS THE STATE SHOULD
COME IN
AND STEP IN AND ACT UPON OR ACT
FOR THEM.
BUT IN THIS CASE, THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
THEY HAVE CHOSEN NOT TO DO THIS
LOCALLY.
AND THIS IS WHY IT'S AN
OVERREACH BY
THE STATE TO TO COME IN AND SAY,
THIS IS WHAT YOU NEED TO DO.
AND IF IT WERE GOOD POLICY WITH
REGARDS TO REPRESENTATION,
THIS WOULD BE ALSO APPLIED TO
THE MOST POPULOUS COUNTY,
UM, IN WHICH WOULD BE LOS
ANGELES,
WHICH HAS A POPULATION OF 10
MILLION RESIDENTS.
AND THEY DO NOT EVEN ELECT THEIR
TRUSTEES
ON THE BOARD OF EDUCATION,
WHO ARE APPOINTED BY A55 MEMBER
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
SO IF THIS WERE ACTUALLY A GOOD
POLICY,
IT WOULD ACTUALLY APPLY TO
COUNTIES SUCH AS LA.
SO I HAVE TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
UH.
THAT IT IS POLITICS.
WE SHOULD LET LOCALS ALLOW TO
USE
THEIR LOCAL SYSTEMS TO CHANGE
THE SYSTEMS IF THEY SEE FIT, AND
IF THEY SEE A NEED.
IN THIS CASE, THEY DO NOT.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NGUYEN.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
SEEING NONE SEN.
NEWMAN, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION.
I DON'T THINK IT IS TRUE TO SAY
THAT,
THAT THE VOTERS OF ORANGE COUNTY
DON'T WANT TO SEE THIS CHANGE.
I THINK IT IS MORE ACCURATE THAT
THIS PARTICULAR
BOARD WOULD LIKE NOT TO SEE THIS
CHANGE.
AND I WOULD ASSERT, I THINK
YOU'D ALL AGREE,
AND I THINK WE WOULD ALL
SUBSCRIBE
TO THE IDEA THAT ANY ELECTION
THAT INVOLVES MORE VOTERS IS A
BETTER ELECTION.
ANY BOARD THAT RESULTS FROM
AN ELECTION THAT INCLUDES MORE,
NOT FEWER VOTERS IS A MORE
REPRESENTATIVE
PUBLIC BODY.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF
FIXING PROBLEMS AT THE DISTRICT
LEVEL.
IN THIS CASE, WE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY ARE TRYING
TO SOLVE A PROBLEM FOR ORANGE
COUNTY,
A PROBLEM THAT HAS SUPPORT FROM
THE VOTERS OF ORANGE COUNTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I'LL GO.
NO ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER
I BLAKESBURG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DAWLEY NO DODD I
DURAZZO
I EGGMAN I GLASER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
I JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I LEMON, I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I.
MEN I.
NEWMAN I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
OKOBO.
NO.
PERDUE.
I PORTANTINO I ROTH, I RUBIO, I
SATO.
NO.
SKINNER, I SMALL CUEVAS.
STERN I.
UMBER I.
WAHAB, I.
WIENER, I WILL.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENTEES ONE
LAST TIME.
ALAN.
MCGUIRE.
SMALL QUAVERS.
HI.
ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO NOW LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM 126.
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
THIS WILL BE OUR SECOND TIME
THROUGH THE ROLL.
SENATOR CORTEZ'S BILL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ELLEN.
BLAKESBURG.
CABALLERO I.
DUD.
GLASER.
NO, NO.
GROVE.
RUBIO.
SMALL QUAVERS.
I.
ALL RIGHT.
ON A VOTE OF 26 TO 9, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 80 FOLLOWED
BY 81 AND 82 I THINK ACTUALLY
FILE ITEM 8081.
AND THEN I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
62 AND 63.
SO LET'S BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
80.
THIS IS SP 930 BY SENATOR LAIRD.
HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 930 BY SENATOR
LAIRD.
AN ACT RELATING TO HIGHWAYS.
SENATOR LAIRD, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR.
PRESIDENT OF THE 642 MEMORIAL
HIGHWAYS
AND TRANSPORTATION STRUCTURES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, 82%
ARE NAMED FOR MEN,
A TOO LONG WOMEN WHO MAKE UP
HALF THE POPULATION
AND NEXT YEAR QUITE LIKELY WILL
MAKE UP HALF OF THIS BODY HAVE
BEEN WOEFULLY
DISADVANTAGED IN THE MEMORIAL.
NAMING OF TRANSPORTATION
STRUCTURES.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY SIGNAGE FUND
TO PROMOTE EQUITY AND MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY DESIGNATIONS.
IT DOES NOT MEAN WE WILL NOT
CONTINUE TO NAME
MEMORIAL HIGHWAYS FOR FALLEN
OFFICERS,
PUBLIC OFFICIALS OR OTHERS WHO
ARE MEN.
BUT THIS BILL JUST CREATES A
PROCESS FOR EQUITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT OVER TIME WE
CATCH UP.
SIGNS COST BETWEEN 8000 AND
$10,000.
SOMETIMES THAT VERY COST TURNS
AWAY PEOPLE FROM BEING
ABLE TO DESIGNATED OR BEING PART
OF THAT EQUITY.
FOR THIS REASON, THIS BILL
BUILDS ON CONTINUED WORK
AND SETS UP A PROCESS WHERE
OVER TIME WE CAN CATCH UP.
THERE'S NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR LAIRD, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
I SEE MICROPHONES UP FROM
SENATOR
GROVE AND SENATOR SKINNER.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH SENATOR GROVE.
&GT;&GT; DAME.
WE HEARD YOU.
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
WERE PAYING ATTENTION.
SENATOR GROVE, LET'S TRY THAT
AGAIN.
SENATOR GROVE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
&GT;&GT; COMING FROM HER BRAIN.
&GT;&GT; I THINK THAT WAS A
REPUBLICAN THING
THAT YOU GUYS DID TO ME JUST
THEN.
UM, RESPECTFULLY, IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL, YOU KNOW,
WE DESIGNATE HIGHWAY SIGNS AND
HIGHWAY MEMORIALS.
I RECENTLY DID ONE FOR OFFICER
PHILIP CAMPUS,
A SWAT TEAM MEMBER WHO PUT HIS
LIFE
ON THE LINE AND LOST HIS LIFE,
LEFT HIS WIFE AND THREE KIDS,
YOUNG KIDS, BECAUSE HE WAS
SAVING A YOUNG
GIRL FROM HIS HER ESTRANGED
FATHER,
WHO HAD ALREADY KILLED ANOTHER
MEMBER OF THEIR FAMILY.
THAT'S A HEROES, UM, A HERO.
PHILIP CAMPUS IS A HERO.
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS
VETERAN CAME BACK,
JOINED THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE,
BECAME AN ELITE SWAT TEAM MEMBER
A VERY YOUNG AGE TAKEN FROM US.
AND SO I THINK THAT THE POLICY
THAT WE HAVE
NOW IS THAT RESOURCES HAVE TO BE
RAISED,
LIKE WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
RAISE
MONEY FOR THAT SIGN TO
BE REPLACED BY CALTRANS EVERY, I
THINK, EIGHT YEARS.
UM, SO THAT THE SIGN REMAINS IN
GOOD CONDITION AND,
UM, I DON'T I AM UNAWARE, I
GUESS.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
WHERE IS THROUGH THE CHAIR
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR?
WILL THE AUTHOR TAKE A QUESTION?
HMM.
I'LL TAKE THAT AS A YES, SENATOR
GROVE.
NO, I SAID YES.
SORRY, I SAID YES.
OKAY, TERRIFIC.
SO JUST CURIOUS, WHERE ARE THE
RESOURCES
COMING FROM THAT ARE GOING
TO GO IN THIS SPECIAL FUND THAT
CALTRANS WILL ADMINISTER?
WHERE DO THOSE RESOURCES COME
FROM?
I'M SORRY, MR.
PRESIDENT, I CAN'T HEAR.
UH, THERE'S A LITTLE DRILLING IN
THE BACKGROUND.
WHICH ARE YOU DOING THAT ON
PURPOSE?
WHERE DO THE THE RESOURCES COME
FROM THAT GO
INTO THE CALTRANS FUND TO
DISTRIBUTE THE.
UNDER THIS BILL, IT SETS UP A
FUND
THAT WOULD ACCEPT DONATIONS
FROM INTERESTED PARTIES TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT,
AND IT WOULD STILL LEAVE
THE DESIGNATION OF ANY STRUCTURE
TO THIS BODY AS THROUGH THE
TRADITIONAL PROCESS.
BUT IT WILL ALLOW FOR A FUNDING
MECHANISM,
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE'S
GENERALLY
ESTABLISHED SOURCES FOR THOSE
CERTAIN
OF THOSE THAT ARE DONE.
AND THIS WOULD MAKE SURE THERE'S
A FUNDING SOURCE FOR EVERYBODY.
ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR GROVE, ON YOUR TIME.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU.
SO I GUESS, UM, MY UNDERSTANDING
IS,
IS THAT THE FUNDING MECHANISM
NOW IS FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO DONATE TO SUPPORT THESE
PROJECTS THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE HONORED.
UM, IF THERE'S ALREADY A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DONATE
TO THESE PROJECTS,
I DON'T SEE HOW THE BILL IS
NECESSARY
SO THAT IT COULD ACTUALLY
SET UP A FUND SO PEOPLE COULD
DONATE TO THESE PROJECTS.
THESE PROJECTS ARE PUT ON ALL
OVER THE STATE.
I JUST SHARED ONE THAT WE DID
LAST YEAR
FOR SENATE OR TWO YEARS AGO FOR
SENATE.
UM, FOR, EXCUSE ME, UH, SWAT
TEAM MEMBER CAMPUS.
AND, UM, SO JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE.
SENATOR SKINNER.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
I HOPE THAT THE RESULT OF IT IS
THAT SOME
MORE THINGS GET NAMED AFTER
WOMEN.
I HAPPEN TO HAVE DONE ASKED OUR
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
TO DO A LITTLE NUMBER CRUNCHING
FOR ME.
AND IN THE PAST, IS IT TEN
YEARS?
AND I'M SURE IF WE DID IT OVER A
20 YEAR PERIOD,
THIS PERCENT WOULD BE EVEN
LOWER.
IN THE PAST TEN YEARS.
THE PERCENT OF THINGS ROADS OR
HIGHWAYS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS NAMED AFTER A WOMAN IS LESS
THAN 7%.
IF WE WERE TO ADD UP AND DO
NUMBER CRUNCHING ON
ANYTHING THAT WE NAMED, IT WOULD
EVEN BE LOWER.
UH, AND I BASICALLY, WITH NO
DISRESPECT
TO THE MEN THAT WE MAY HAVE
NAMED SOMETHING AFTER I STOPPED
VOTING ON ALL OF THE BILLS THAT
NAMED SOMETHING AFTER A MAN
BECAUSE
I FELT THAT BEFORE I DIE,
THERE WOULD BE NO PUBLIC SPACE
LEFT
TO NAME ANYTHING AFTER A WOMAN.
AND I THINK THAT THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS
IS THAT IT DOES COST MONEY TO
NAME.
AND USUALLY AND THIS IS, AGAIN,
WITH NO DISRESPECT TO NAMING ANY
OF OUR
HIGHWAYS AFTER A AN OFFICER WHO
DIED
IN DUTY IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
UM, BUT IF OFTENTIMES IT IS
THE UNION OF THAT OFFICER THAT
WILL
PAY THE COSTS FOR THE NAMING OF
THE,
UH, ROADWAY OR HIGHWAY,
AND THAT AS THERE ARE LESS WOMEN
IN SWORN
OFFICERS AND IT CLEARLY WE
SHOULD
NOT ONLY BE NAMING THINGS AFTER
PEOPLE
THAT DIE IN THE LINE OF DUTY,
SINCE WE DON'T EVEN WANT ANYONE
TO
BE DYING IN THE LINE OF DUTY,
BUT RATHER IF WE ARE NAMING
ROADWAYS
OR HIGHWAYS AFTER FOLKS,
IT IS LESS LIKELY THAT A WOMAN
THAT WE MIGHT SUGGEST
WOULD HAVE AN ENTITY LIKE A
LABOR UNION
OR OTHERS THAT IS GOING TO COVER
THE COSTS,
WHICH IS WHY SUCH A FUND WOULD
BE HELPFUL.
BUT I THINK THE KEY POINT IS
THAT WE
SHOULD BE AWARE OF THE THE
DEARTH
OF OUR NAMING PUBLIC SPACES
AFTER WOMEN,
AND WE SHOULD DO BETTER.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR DOLLY, THANK YOU.
QUESTION THE AUTHOR, IF I MAY.
THE AUTHOR TAKE A QUESTION.
YES, YES, I WOULD.
LIKE TO GET SOME CLARIFICATION
ON
THE I SAW THIS IN
TRANSPORTATION.
I WAS UNDER THE ASSUMPTION THAT
IT
WAS GOING TO BE TAXPAYER FUNDED.
BUT WHAT I'M HEARING YOU SAY,
AND I JUST WANT FOR THE RECORD
TO BE CLEAR,
THAT THIS IS PEOPLE DONATING
INTO THE FUND,
AND THAT FUND WOULD BE USED IN
FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
RESOURCES,
SUCH AS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
LIKES.
THAT IS CORRECT.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DOLLY.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MEMBERS?
SEEING NONE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SENATOR LAIRD, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE DEBATE.
AND THE SENATOR FROM BERKELEY, I
THINK,
DID A LOT OF WHAT I WOULD DONE
HAVE DONE IN A CLOSE.
LET ME JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT,
WHICH IS I THINK THERE WAS SOME
CONFUSION IN THE COMMITTEE OVER
THE FACT THAT THERE ARE MANY,
MANY HIGHWAYS AND TRANSPORTATION
STRUCTURES NAMED
AFTER PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT FALLEN
OFFICERS.
AND IF IF YOU LOOK, THERE ARE A
NUMBER
AND I JUST SITTING HERE AT MY
DESK,
PULLED OUT THE NAMES OF THE
FOLLOWING LEGISLATURE.
LEGISLATORS.
ACHADJIAN.
MELLO, JOHNSON.
BELLOTTI, BOATWRIGHT, STURGEON,
FERRON, BROWN, UM,
GIBSON, MILLER, NEJEDLY THAT
WERE ALL MEMBERS,
MANY OF THEM MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY OR MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT WERE
NAMED.
AND I REMIND EVERYONE THERE WAS
NOT A WOMAN
ELECTED TO THIS BODY UNTIL 1976.
SO IF WE WERE NAMING A ROADS
AFTER SENATORS,
WE WERE NOT DISPROPORTIONATELY
WE WERE TOTALLY NAMING THEM
AFTER MEN.
AND SO THIS IS MUCH BROADER THAN
FALLEN OFFICERS,
WHICH, AS I SAID IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT,
WILL STILL HAPPEN AND WILL WILL
STILL HAPPEN
AS APPROPRIATE WITH THE EXACT
DEFERENCE
THAT IS DESERVED IN THE
STATEMENT
OF THE SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD.
THIS JUST MAKES SURE THERE'S
EQUITY ACROSS
THE BOARD OVER TIME IN WHAT WE
DO WITH
OUR DESIGNATIONS THAT REFLECTS
THE POPULATION
OF THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD.
THE DEBATE HAS CLOSED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OH, AND I BROUGHT A GIRL.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS,
I BECKER I BLAKE SPERM I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DALLY I DODD I
DURAZZO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
NO POTATO I JONES.
NO LAIRD, I LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
UH, NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO NEELO.
NO JOB, NO PADILLA.
I PORTENTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO KNOW SKINNER.
I SMALL QUAVERS.
I STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL.
I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
MAGUIRE ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 6.
THE MEASURE CARRIES THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBER MEMBERS, WE
WERE GOING
TO BEGIN NEXT WITH FILE ITEM 81.
WE DO NOT HAVE A FLOOR ANALYSIS
OUT ON THAT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO DEFER THAT
FOR THE MOMENT AND INSTEAD
MOVE TO TWO OTHER BILLS BY
SENATOR WEINER.
FIRST FILE ITEM 62, FOLLOWED BY
FILE ITEM 63.
FINAL ITEM 62 IS SENATE BILL
961.
SENATOR WEINER IS PREPARED.
THE SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 961 BY SENATOR
WEINER.
AN ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES.
SENATOR WEINER.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES.
SB 961 IS A BILL DESIGNED TO
MAKE OUR ROADS SAFER AND TO
MAKE PEOPLE MORE AWARE OF
SPEEDING
AND TO REDUCE SPEEDS.
SPECIFICALLY, SB 961 WILL
REQUIRE
NEW CARS MANUFACTURED
OR SOLD IN CALIFORNIA TO EMPLOY
AN EXISTING TECHNOLOGY.
IT ALREADY EXISTS TO NOTIFY
DRIVERS IF THEY IF THEY GO
MORE THAN TEN MILES AN HOUR OVER
THE SPEED LIMIT.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE PHYSICALLY
PREVENTED
PEOPLE FROM DRIVING MORE THAN
TEN MILES
AN HOUR OVER THE SPEED LIMIT.
THE VERSION BEFORE YOU NOTIFIES
PEOPLE, UH,
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THIS
DOES HAVE
AN IMPACT IN GETTING PEOPLE TO
SLOW DOWN,
PARTICULARLY SINCE SOME PEOPLE
DRIVE OVER DON'T
EVEN REALIZE HOW FAST THEIR CAR
IS GOING.
UH, COLLEAGUES, WE KNOW THAT
4000 PEOPLE
A YEAR DIE ON CALIFORNIA ROADS.
SPEED IS A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR,
AND WE HAVE TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL
HELP GET PEOPLE TO SLOW DOWN.
IT WILL SAVE LIVES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GILBERT NOE
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR, A BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I QUOTESI, I DALLY.
NO.
DODD.
THE RATHER EGGMAN GLAZER I
GONZALEZ
I GROVE NO OR AUTO I JONES NO.
LAIRD I THE MOM I MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
NO JOBO.
NO.
PADILLA.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
RUBIO.
CIERTO.
NO SKINNER, A SMALL CUEVAS,
A STERN, A UMBERG, A WAHAB.
WIENER.
I WILL KNOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
ARCHULETA.
BECKER.
NO.
BRADFORD.
DODD.
DURAZZO I.
EGGMAN.
NO.
MCGUIRE.
MEN.
ROD.
RUBIO.
I MEAN.
NO.
WAHAB.
WAHABBI.
UMMER.
GAETANO.
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ARCHULETA.
BRADFORD DODD.
MCGUIRE.
RATH.
RUBIO.
SENATOR WIENER MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 63.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1037, ALSO
BY SENATOR WIENER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1037 BY SENATOR
WIENER.
AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING.
SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES.
SB 1037 IS A MEASURE THAT IS
SPONSORED
BY OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AS YOU KNOW, WE HAVE WORKED VERY
HARD IN RECENT
YEARS TO ENABLE THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE MANY,
MANY NEW HOMES THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LAWS
THAT WE PASS AS A LEGISLATURE
ARE ACTUALLY BEING FOLLOWED AND
ENFORCED.
THERE IS A LOOPHOLE IN
THE LAW RIGHT NOW WHERE CITIES
CAN FLAGRANTLY VIOLATE STATE
HOUSING LAWS,
SIMPLY BLOW THEM OFF AND REFUSE
TO FOLLOW THEM.
AND IF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
FILES
A LAWSUIT AGAINST THOSE CITIES,
TAKES IT ALL THE WAY THROUGH
LITIGATION
AND PREVAILS AND WINS A COURT
JUDGMENT,
THERE IS NO PENALTY AGAINST THAT
CITY.
UM, UNLESS THEY WAIT MANY MORE
MONTHS
BEFORE COMING INTO COMPLIANCE.
SO A CITY HAS VERY LITTLE
INCENTIVE
OTHER THAN PAYING
ATTORNEYS FEES TO ACTUALLY
FOLLOW THE LAW.
SB 1037 WILL PROVIDE THAT.
IF A CITY, UH, IF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SUES THE CITY,
GOES ALL THE WAY THROUGH
LITIGATION AND WINS,
UH, THEN THE COURT CAN CAN
IMPOSE
PENALTIES ON THE CITY.
THOSE FINES THOSE PENALTIES WILL
BE PLACED, HELD IN,
IN ESCROW FOR THAT CITY, FOR
AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THAT CITY.
SO THEY'RE NOT TAKEN INTO THE
GENERAL
FUND OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
UH, THIS IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT,
UH, MEASURE,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
EYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER.
SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I RESPECTFULLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION.
AND THIS IS, I THINK, ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEMS WITH CALIFORNIA AND THE
LEGISLATURE
IS THINKING THAT IF YOU SUE SOME
CITY,
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
WELL, FIRST OFF.
DEVELOPERS BUILD HOUSES, NOT
CITIES OR COUNTIES.
AND THE REASON DEVELOPERS DON'T
BUILD
HOUSES IS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
PROCESS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS SO
CUMBERSOME
AND SO EXPENSIVE AND SO RISKY.
WE HAVE SEQUA, WE HAVE ALL
THESE, UH, DESIGN BUILD,
WE HAVE LABOR AGREEMENTS,
YOU NAME IT, TO BUILD A HOME,
EVEN IF IT'S LOW INCOME.
AND SO NOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS GOING
TO GO AND SUE THESE CITIES
AGAIN.
CITIES DON'T BUILD HOUSES.
DEVELOPERS DO.
IF WE WOULD REDUCE SOME OF
THE BURDENS IN CALIFORNIA,
WE COULD BUILD HOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE CONTINUE TO INCREASE THE
THE COST OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND QUITE SIMPLY, CITIES
AND COUNTIES DON'T BUILD HOUSES.
WHY ARE YOU SUING THEM?
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MEET THEIR
ELEMENT.
THEY THEY DO A GENERAL PLAN.
THEY SAY, HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BUILD THE HOUSES.
AND IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T COME
AND INVEST AND BUILD THE HOUSES,
WE'RE GOING TO SUE THEM.
WHAT'S THAT GOING TO DO?
IT'S GOING TO DO NOTHING BUT
JUST CAUSE LITIGATION.
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WE NEED TO DRIVE DOWN THE COST
OF HOUSING BY REDUCING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS,
THE COST OF BUILDING HOUSES, AND
ALLOW DEVELOPERS
TO BUILD HOUSES IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR THOSE REASONS, I OPPOSE SB
1037.
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR WIENER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
YEAH, I JUST, UM, I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE
ACROSS THE AISLE FOR THOSE
COMMENTS.
AND I AGREE THAT CITIES ARE NOT
THE ONES.
SOMETIMES THEY DO, BUT TYPICALLY
ARE
NOT THE ONES BUILDING HOUSING.
BUT WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT IS
WHEN CITIES
REFUSE TO GRANT PERMITS TO
DEVELOPERS WHO
ARE READY TO BUILD HOUSING AND
ARE ENTITLED
TO THOSE PERMITS UNDER STATE
LAW.
AND THE CITY SAYS, I'M NOT WE'RE
NOT GOING
TO GIVE YOU THE PERMIT TO DO IT.
SO YES, CITY IS NOT THE ONE
BUILDING THE HOUSING,
BUT THE CITY HAS THE POWER TO
OBSTRUCT
DEVELOPERS FROM BUILDING THOSE
HOMES.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT,
WHEN CITIES ARE ACTUALLY
OBSTRUCTING THE ABILITY OF
PEOPLE TO BUILD NEW HOMES.
AND I WANT TO ALSO STRESS THAT
THIS
ONLY APPLIES WHEN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS TAKEN THE
EXTRAORDINARY
STEP OF SUING A CITY,
AND WHEN THE CITY HAS ACTED
ARBITRARILY
AND CAPRICIOUSLY.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT HONEST
MISTAKES,
OR SOMEONE MESSES UP THE
PAPERWORK.
THIS IS WHEN A CITY HAS
ARBITRARILY
AND CAPRICIOUSLY REFUSED TO
DO SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE
REQUIRED
TO DO UNDER STATE LAW.
AFTER NO DOUBT BEING TOLD MANY
TIMES THIS
IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO, THEY'RE
SUED.
IT GOES ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
LITIGATION.
JUDGMENT IS ENTERED.
THERE SHOULD BE A CONSEQUENCE,
AND THE CONSEQUENCE
IS THAT YOU PAY A FINE THAT THEN
GETS HELD IN ESCROW FOR YOU AS A
CITY TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY.
I.
ATKINS.
BECKER.
BLAKE.
SPUR.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ.
DALLY.
NO.
DODD.
I DURAZZO.
I.
ECKMAN.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD.
I.
LEEMAN MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I NEWMAN.
WHEN?
NO.
NILO.
CHOBOQ.
NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
ROD.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG.
WELL, I WIENER, I WILL NOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN RODRIGO.
ARCHULETA.
BECKER.
GLASER DEMONN.
MCGUIRE.
NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
UMBERG I.
SENATOR WIENER MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM 81,
ALSO BY SENATOR WIENER.
THIS IS SB 957.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 957 BY SENATOR
WIENER.
AN ACT RELATING TO DATA
COLLECTION.
SENATOR WIENER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, IF THIS SEEMS
FAMILIAR,
IT'S BECAUSE MANY OF YOU HAVE
VOTED,
SOMETIMES REPEATEDLY,
TO REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO COLLECT
HEALTH
DATA AROUND BASED ON SEXUAL
ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY.
FOR ANYONE WHO ACCESSES THE
HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM AND FILLS OUT FORMS,
YOU'LL KNOW THAT IT WILL ASK YOU
VOLUNTARY QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT IS YOUR AGE, WHAT IS
YOUR GENDER?
WHAT IS YOUR RACE?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION,
BUT MOST PEOPLE DO,
AND IT ALLOWS US TO GATHER
IMPORTANT HEALTH
DATA RELATING TO DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES.
IT'S THE REASON WHY WE KNEW THAT
WHEN COVID 19 HIT,
THAT OLDER PEOPLE WERE AT MUCH
GREATER
RISK OF DYING THAN YOUNGER
PEOPLE.
UNFORTUNATELY, OVERWHELMINGLY,
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE NOT
ASKING
THE QUESTION ABOUT SEXUAL
ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY.
AND SO WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATA.
AND WE KNOW BASED ON OTHER DATA
THAT WE HAVE,
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
DISPARITIES
IMPACTING LGBTQ PEOPLE,
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THAT COMING
FROM OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM IN THE WAY THAT IT
SHOULD.
IN 2020, WE REQUIRED THE
DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO DO MORE.
WE THEN HAD THE STATE AUDITOR DO
AN AUDIT,
WHICH SHOWED THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH WAS FALLING
SHORT AND ON THE LARGE MAJORITY
OF ITS FORM WASN'T FORMS,
WAS NOT EVEN ASKING THE
QUESTION.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO IMPLEMENT THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WEINER.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ISSUE?
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
OVERALL I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKE SPERM I
BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY
KNOW
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN.
GLASER I.
GONZALEZ, I.
GROVE, NO.
HURTADO, I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD, I.
KNEEBONE, I.
MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I.
MEN.
I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
JOBO.
NO.
PADILLA, I.
PORTANTINO I.
ROTH I.
RUBIO.
CIERTO.
RUBIO I.
NO.
SKINNER.
SMALL.
CUEVAS.
ICE.
STERM I UMBERG I WAHAB I WEINER
I WOKE.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN EGGMAN I.
MCGUIRE.
SKINNER, I.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM 62.
I'LL LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
62.
THIS IS SB 961 BY SENATOR
WEINER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ARCHULETA.
BRADFORD I.
DODD.
MCGUIRE.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
ON A VOTE OF 21 TO 13.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ONE MOMENT.
CAN WE GET A CLARIFICATION ON
THE LAST MEASURE?
SENATOR RUBIO, DID YOU VOTE ON
THAT LAST MEASURE?
WHAT WAS YOUR VOTE?
I OKAY PROPERLY RECORDED.
THANK YOU.
SO THAT WOULD BE A VOTE OF I
DIDN'T CLOSE.
RUBIO I.
THAT WOULD BE A VOTE OF 22 TO
13.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 82.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 983 BY
SENATOR WAHAB.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 983 BY SENATOR
WAHAB.
AN ACT RELATING TO ENERGY.
SENATOR WAHAB, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 983, THE
ALTERNATIVE
FUELS INFRASTRUCTURE TASK FORCE.
MY ULTIMATE VISION IS TO PUT
ALTERNATIVE
FUEL OPTIONS IN GAS STATIONS
TO ALLOW FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
BE ABLE TO USE A CLEAN VEHICLE,
EVEN THOSE THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS
TO CHARGING STATIONS.
THIS TASK FORCE WILL DETERMINE
THE FASTEST AND MOST COST
EFFECTIVE
PATH FORWARD FOR ZERO EMISSION
FUEL ALTERNATIVES,
WHILE USING OUR EXISTING
GASOLINE
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHOUT
PUTTING THE FINGER ON THE SCALES
OR BEING SHORT SIGHTED.
REGARDING TECHNOLOGIES OF THE
FUTURE.
CURRENT INVESTMENTS INTO
ALTERNATIVE
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURES ARE
ONLY HALF OF WHAT IS NEEDED TO
TRANSITION BY 2050 OR EARLIER.
SB 983 IS A CRUCIAL STEP TO MEET
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S MANDATE
TO TRANSITION VEHICLES TO ZERO
EMISSION SOURCES BY 2035.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE,
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO I ARCHULETA,
I ASHBY I ATKINS, I BECKER.
BLAKE SPEER.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLY
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ GROVE HURTADO I JONES
I LAIRD
I LEMON MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN I WAYNE NILO OKOBO
PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO
I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER BLAKE SPEER I DALLEY
I GONZALEZ GROVE I LEMON
MCGUIRE.
WAYNE.
NILO.
TROBO I STERN.
WEINER.
IT'S CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ONE MORE TIME.
ALLEN, IF WE CAN ASK THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT
GO TO THE BACK SO MEMBERS CAN
HEAR.
CALL THE CALL THE ROLL ONE MORE
TIME.
GONZALEZ.
LAMONT MCGUIRE WIN.
NILO.
STERN.
WIENER.
ALL RIGHT.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
I'M GOING TO MOVE NOW TO FILE
ITEM 83.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 999 BY
SENATOR CORTEZ.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 999 BY SENATOR
CORTESE.
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE.
SENATOR CORTESE.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB 999.
SB 9999 WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING
FROM MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS
EITHER OR CAN ACCESS THE LEVEL
OF TREATMENT
NECESSARY FOR A FULL AND LASTING
RECOVERY.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT
UTILIZATION
REVIEW DETERMINATIONS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS
ARE PERFORMED BY A REVIEWER,
WITH APPROPRIATE TRAINING AND
RELEVANT
EXPERIENCE IN THE CLINICAL
SPECIALTY.
SB 999 REQUIRES REVIEWERS TO
DISCLOSE THEIR NAME,
CREDENTIALS, AND BASIS FOR A
TREATMENT DENIAL,
INCLUDING A CITATION OF THE
CLINICAL
GUIDELINES THAT WERE FOLLOWED.
THIS BILL WILL SAVE LIVES BY
COMBATING
OVERDOSE DEATHS AND SUICIDES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA.
I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKESBERG I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CABALLERO.
CORTEZ.
I.
DALLY.
NO.
DODD.
I.
RAZO I.
EGGMAN.
I.
GLAZER, I I.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE.
MENJIVAR, I MEAN.
I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NILO.
NO OKOBO.
NO VIDEO I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO, I SATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL QUAVERS.
I'M STERN I AM BURKE, I WAHAB, I
WEINER, I WILL NOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN MCGUIRE.
WHEN SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 7.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 84.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1022 BY
SENATOR SKINNER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1022 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
AN ACT RELATING TO CIVIL RIGHTS.
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS SB 1022 PROVIDES OUR
DEPARTMENT OF OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT THE TIME
NEEDED TO
EFFECTIVELY INVESTIGATE AND
RESPOND TO SYSTEMIC
DISCRIMINATION IN WORKPLACES OR
HOUSING.
AND WHEN I SAY SYSTEMIC, I MEAN
MULTIPLE
COMPLAINTS OVER A MULTIPLE TIME
PERIOD.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATES
THOUSANDS OF THESE VIOLATIONS
ANNUALLY,
AND THEY MEDIATE AND SETTLE MANY
CASES.
BUT THERE ARE SOME COMPLAINTS
THESE ONES
WERE REFERENCING AS SYSTEMIC
THAT CAN
COME FROM MULTIPLE PARTIES
AGAINST
THE SAME ENTITY OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME.
AND SUCH COMPLAINTS, ONCE THEY
BEGIN
TO BE INVESTIGATED AS A GROUP,
ARE REFERRED TO AS DIRECTORS
COMPLAINTS,
AND THEY CAN BE COMPLEX AND
REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO INVESTIGATE.
SB 1022 ADDRESSES THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE BY GIVING
THE DEPARTMENT THE ABILITY TO
INVESTIGATE
THE DIRECTOR'S COMPLAINTS OVER
NO MORE
THAN A SEVEN YEAR TIME PERIOD.
NOTE THAT SB 1022 DOES NOT
CHANGE
ANY STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS,
SO IF AN INDIVIDUAL WANTS TO
FILE A LAWSUIT
ABOUT A COMPLAINT THAT THEY
MADE,
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
HOLDS,
IT DOES NOT CHANGE ANY STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS.
IT PURELY GIVES THE OFFICE OF
CIVIL RIGHTS
THE ABILITY TO INVESTIGATE THESE
DIRECTORS
COMPLAINTS OR SYSTEMIC
VIOLATIONS OVER
NO MORE THAN A SEVEN YEAR TIME
PERIOD.
IT ADDITIONALLY GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT
TIME TO NEGOTIATE
AND REACH SETTLEMENTS RATHER
THAN ONLY PURSUING LAWSUITS,
BECAUSE UNDER CURRENT LAW,
THEY WOULD HAVE TO INITIATE
A LAWSUIT IN JUST ONE YEAR.
SO IF PART OF OUR OBJECTIVE IS
TO
LESSEN THE NUMBER OF LAWSUITS,
THEN GIVING THEM MORE TIME TO
INVESTIGATE AND TO WORK WITH
THE ENTITIES FOR WHOM THE
COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN
LODGED TO TRY TO WORK OUT
AGREEMENTS,
THEN WE WILL HAVE LESS LAWSUITS.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER.
ANY DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DEBATE MEMBERS?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
NO.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY, I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
I BLAKESBURG.
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ.
I DALLY.
DAD I DARAZO I EGGMAN.
I GLASER, I.
I.
GONZALEZ.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD, I LAMENT.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I.
MEN I.
NEWMAN I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
PADILLA.
I PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
I RUBIO I SATO NO SKINNER I
SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG.
I WILL HAVE.
A WIENER.
I WILL KNOW.
THIS.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
DALLY?
NO.
HURTADO I.
MCGUIRE.
ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 85,
FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM 88 AND 89.
FILE ITEM 85 IS SB 1045 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1045 BY SENATOR
BLAKE.
AN ACT RELATING TO COMPOSTING.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES,
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1045,
WHICH REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING
AND RESEARCH TO DEVELOP A MODEL
ORDINANCE
FOR SITING COMPOST FACILITIES
AND REQUIRES
LOCALS TO CONSIDER THIS
ADVISORY.
DEVELOPING THIS MUCH NEEDED
ORGANIC
WASTE INFRASTRUCTURE IS CRITICAL
IN
HAVING US MEET OUR SB 1383
TARGETS,
WHICH WE ARE FAR FROM ACHIEVING.
IN ORDER TO MEET THESE TARGETS,
CALRECYCLE ESTIMATES THAT
THE STATE NEEDS APPROXIMATELY
50 TO 100 NEW OR EXPANDED
ORGANIC
WASTE RECYCLING FACILITIES.
RIGHT NOW, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PROVIDE THE NEEDED
TOOLS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
A MODEL ORDINANCE WILL SAVE TIME
AND THE NEED
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO START
FROM SCRATCH,
IN AN AREA WHERE MANY LACK
EXPERTISE.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY GREAT
ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE,
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES CRC,
REPUBLIC SERVICES,
WASTE MANAGEMENT AND MORE.
THERE IS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ I DALLY.
DAD I TORRAZZO I EGGMAN.
I GLASER.
I I.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I LEHMAN.
I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO NILO.
NO CHOBO, NO PADILLA.
I PORTANTINO.
I WROTE.
I RUBIO.
SATO.
NO.
SKINNER A SMALL.
STERN I UMBERG.
OKAY, WAHAB.
A WIENER.
I WILL I.
LUMBER GUY.
SENATOR BLAKE'S REMOVES A CALL
TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 88.
THIS IS SB 1066.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1066 BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR.
AN ACT RELATING TO HAZARDOUS
WASTE.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES,
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1066,
WHICH WOULD CREATE AN EXTENDED
PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM
TO ENSURE THE SAFE DISPOSAL OF
PYROTECHNIC MARINE FLARES.
CALIFORNIA'S DIVISION OF BOATING
AND WATERWAYS ESTIMATES 174,000
FLARES EXPIRE IN THE STATE EACH
YEAR,
BUT THERE ARE NO FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA
THAT ACCEPT AND DISPOSE OF THEM.
WITHOUT VIABLE OPTIONS, EXPIRED
FLARES
CAN OFTEN END UP DANGEROUSLY
LEFT IN THE TRASH IN FRONT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS,
LIKE POLICE OR FIRE STATIONS,
OR EVEN DISPOSED OF IN OUR
PRECIOUS WATERWAYS.
THESE COSTS ARE LOCALIZED ONTO
LOCAL TAXPAYERS
INSTEAD OF THE BOATERS WHO USE
THEM.
SB 1066 IS SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
PARK DISTRICTS, TEAMSTERS,
FIREFIGHTERS, WASTE HAULERS,
HARBOR DISTRICTS,
AND ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS.
IT RECEIVED UNANIMOUS APPROVAL
IN ALL COMMITTEE VOTES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GUILLERM I
ARCHULETTA I ASHBY,
I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I CORTAZZI, I DALLY, I DUD.
TORAZO I AGVAN.
GLASER, I.
GONZALEZ, I.
GROVE.
I HURTADO I.
JONES.
I.
LAIRD, I.
LEHMAN, I.
MCGUIRE, MENGIBAR I.
MEN I NEWMAN I WIN I.
NILO I OJOBO I PODIUM I.
PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO I SKINNER I SMILED CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG.
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I WE.
HAVE A MEMBER OFF THE FLOOR
MEMBERS.
SO SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR MOVES A
CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 89.
THIS IS SB 1094 BY SENATOR
LIEBERMAN.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1094 BY SENATOR
LEHMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
INSTRUCTION.
SENATOR LEHMAN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES.
SB 1094 PROMOTES CIVIC LEARNING
IN GRADES ONE
THROUGH EIGHT BY REQUIRING
INSTRUCTION
IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT OR
EXPERIENCE WITH
A GOVERNMENTAL INSTITUTION AT
THE LOCAL,
STATE OR NATIONAL LEVEL AT LEAST
ONCE BETWEEN GRADES ONE
THROUGH SIX AND ONCE BETWEEN
GRADES SEVEN THROUGH EIGHT.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN I RODRIGO, I ARCHULETA, I
ASHBY.
I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD CABALLERO.
I CORTEZI.
I DALLY.
DAD, I TORRAZZO.
I, EGGMAN.
GLASER, I.
GONZALEZ, I.
GROVE.
HURTADO I.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD, I LAMENT.
I.
MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NILO.
I OKOBO I PODIUM, I PORTANTINO I
ROTH.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO.
NO SKINNER A SMALL GRAVIS I
STERNE I UMBER I WAHAB.
WINNER.
I WILL.
I.
SENATOR LAMONT MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 93.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1142 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1142 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
UTILITIES.
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
&GT;&GT; SB 1142 IS SEEKING TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
RATEPAYERS WHO ARE BEHIND ON
THEIR ELECTRICITY BILLS AND IN
JEOPARDY
OF A SHUT OFF BY DIRECTING
THE CPUC TO REVIEW STATUTE AND
CONSIDER
LIMITING THE AMOUNT A UTILITY
CAN REQUEST FROM A CUSTOMER TO
AVOID A SHUT OFF A SHUT OFF.
SPECIFICALLY, WE'RE LOOKING TO
REQUIRE AN ELECTRICAL OR GAS
CORPORATION TO RESTORE SERVICE
TO A RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMER
UPON THE CUSTOMER PAYING
THE AGREED UPON AMOUNT DECIDED
IN THE AMORTIZATION AGREEMENT
NOT TO EXCEED 24 HOURS.
WE'RE LOOKING TO REQUIRE
THE CPUC ON OR BEFORE JULY 1ST,
2025, TO DETERMINE WHETHER TO
DIRECT ELECTRICAL AND GAS
CORPORATIONS TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT
A CUSTOMER'S ABILITY
TO PAY BEFORE TERMINATING OR
RECONNECTING SERVICES.
WE'RE ALSO ASKING THE CPUC TO
DETERMINE WHETHER
TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT AN
ELECTRICAL
CORPORATION CAN COLLECT UP TO
20% OF
THE CUSTOMER'S OUTSTANDING
BALANCE.
CURRENTLY, THE UTILITIES HAVE NO
GUIDANCE
ON HOW MUCH THEY CAN AND SHOULD
REQUEST
FROM A CUSTOMER TO AVOID A SHUT
OFF OR
GET RECONNECTED AFTER A SHUT
OFF.
WHEN IT COMES WHEN CUSTOMERS ARE
NOT PROVIDED WITH REASONABLE
PAYMENT OPTIONS TO KEEP OR
RESTORE SERVICE.
WE ARE PUTTING COMMUNITIES IN
A COMPROMISING SITUATION.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF FAMILIES
LIVING WITHOUT
ENERGY INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD
OF THESE FAMILIES WILL FALL INTO
FURTHER BAD SITUATIONS.
WITH THAT RESPECT, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING YOUR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MENGIBAR.
ANY FURTHER CONVERSATION
DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE, SENATOR DOLLY?
&GT;&GT; JUST A QUESTION.
THE AUTHOR, IF I MAY.
WILL YOU TAKE THAT QUESTION?
I WILL.
SO IF THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO PAY
AND THEY
TURN THEM BACK ON, THEN WHO
PAYS?
FOR THE GAS THAT WAS USED.
THROUGH THE BAR.
OR THE ELECTRICITY.
I GUESS IT IS.
UH, THROUGH THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT.
UM, SO THIS IS ASKING AFTER
THE CUSTOMER REACHES OUT,
HAS A CONVERSATION WITH THE
UTILITY COMPANY,
COMES TO AN AGREEMENT ON WHAT
PERCENTAGE
OR WHAT AMOUNT CAN BE PAID.
THIS IS ONLY AFTER A CERTAIN
AMOUNT.
WHATEVER IS AGREED UPON IS PAID
FOR
THE FOR THE UTILITY COMPANY TO
BE ABLE
TO RESTORE THE SERVICES WITHIN
24 HOURS,
NOT WITHOUT PAYING ANYTHING.
IT'S ONLY DETERMINED AFTER
THE AGREEMENT HAS BEEN MADE.
SENATOR DOLLY.
SO MAYBE JUST A LITTLE MORE
FOLLOW UP
TO GET A LITTLE MORE
CLARIFICATION,
IF I MAY, THROUGH THE THROUGH
THE CHAIR.
SO.
THEY'RE, THEY'RE GETTING THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT GETTING IT SHUT OFF.
THEY'RE GETTING IT TURNED ON
AFTER AN AGREEMENT.
BUT IF THEY AREN'T ABLE TO PAY
IN THE FUTURE,
DOES THAT COST GET SHIFTED TO
THE OTHER RATEPAYERS?
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THE ONLY THING WE'RE LOOKING TO
DO RIGHT
NOW IS TO ENSURE THAT AFTER AN
AGREEMENT
IS MADE BETWEEN THE THE CUSTOMER
AND THE UTILITY COMPANY ON A
PERCENTAGE,
WHETHER THAT BE TEN, 20, 15,
WHATEVER THEY AGREE UPON,
THAT THE SERVICES GET CONNECTED.
THAT'S THE ONLY AUTOMATIC THING
THAT MY BILL IS LOOKING TO DO.
THE OTHER THINGS THAT I
MENTIONED ARE
FOR THE CPUC TO CONSIDER
ADOPTING
THE OTHER ITEMS THAT THE SENATOR
FROM BIEBER HAS MENTIONED.
A NO, NOTHING WILL CHANGE.
IT'S ONLY FOR THEM TO CONSIDER.
ADDITIONALLY, THEY'RE ALSO
REQUIRED THROUGH THIS,
THROUGH THE LEGISLATION TO
CONSIDER HOW ANY FUTURE
CHANGES WOULD IMPACT CUSTOMERS
THAT ARE IMPACTED
IN THE IN THE ISSUES WE'RE
LOOKING TO ADDRESS.
SO IT'S ONLY FOR THEM TO START
THE CONVERSATION ON THESE
ISSUES.
NOTHING WOULD CHANGE.
IT'S JUST I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT
THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE
HAPPENING,
AND THEY COME TOGETHER WITH A
PLAN TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DALI.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE,
ANY FURTHER DEBATE?
MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
SENATOR MENGIBAR, YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN.
OH, RODRIGO.
NO.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY.
I ATKINS, I BECKER.
BLAKE SPERM I.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLY.
DUD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN.
GLASER.
I GONZALEZ, I GROVE.
HURTADO.
HI, JONES.
LAIRD.
I THE MOM?
I.
MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
I, NEWMAN, I WIN.
NILO.
OKOBO.
THE VIDEO I PORTANTINO.
A ROD.
I RUBIO.
SOURTOE.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
I STERN I AM.
I WAHAB I WIENER, I WILK.
NO.
SENATOR MENGIBAR MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 94.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1178 BY
SENATOR PADILLA.
HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1178 BY SENATOR
PADILLA.
AN ACT RELATING TO WATER
QUALITY.
SENATOR PADILLA.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL 1178,
THE CALIFORNIA WATER QUALITY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION
ACT.
SB 1178 BUILDS OFF A LONG
STANDING EXISTING
STATUTE IN THE WATER CODE,
SIGNING THE LAW BY CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR RONALD REAGAN
THAT EXPLICITLY STATES THAT ANY
CALIFORNIA COMPANY
THAT DISCHARGES WASTE OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA
IN A MANNER THAT COULD AFFECT
THE QUALITY
OF THE WATERS OF THE STATE
WITHIN ANY REGION,
TO REPORT THOSE DISCHARGES.
FOR GENERATIONS, SEWAGE AND
POLLUTION CROSSING
THROUGH THE TIJUANA RIVER HAVE
BEEN WASHING ASHORE IN MY
DISTRICT
AND POISONING OUR COMMUNITY AND
STATE.
IT IS LOCATED AT THE US MEXICO
BORDER,
AND WAS RECENTLY NAMED ONE OF
THE TEN MOST
POLLUTED RIVERS IN THE UNITED
STATES.
JUST THIS PAST JANUARY, STORM
SURGE CAUSED 14.5
BILLION WITH A B GALLONS OF RAW
SEWAGE AND POLLUTION
TO WASH UP ON THE BANKS OF THE
RIVER,
AS WELL AS TO OVERFLOW INTO
NEARBY COASTAL WETLANDS,
ONE OF THE FEW REMAINING SUCH
ECOSYSTEMS
LEFT IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE EXISTING SEWAGE TREATMENT
FACILITIES
HAVE BEEN OVERWHELMED
BY THE SHEER VOLUME OF
WASTEWATER
FLOWING INTO THE RIVER,
A PROBLEM THAT HAS PERSISTED FOR
YEARS.
MEANWHILE, THE HEALTH CONCERNS
CAUSED BY THIS SEWAGE
HAVE FORCED CITIES LIKE IMPERIAL
BEACH,
CALIFORNIA, TO BE CLOSED THEIR
BEACHES
FOR MORE THAN TWO YEARS NOW.
BUT THE BACTERIA PRESENT IN THE
SEWAGE HASN'T
RESTRICTED ITSELF TO OCEAN
WATER.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF GALLONS OF
RAW SEWAGE DUMPED
EVERY DAY INTO THE RIVER ENDS UP
IN THE OCEAN,
AND DUE TO WAVE ACTIVITY,
THAT BACTERIA GETS INTO THE AIR
COLUMN AND FLOATS MILES INLAND.
THIS CRISIS HAS BEEN MAKING
PEOPLE
SICK AND SUBJECTED TO HORRIBLE
STENCH THAT LINGERS OVER HOMES,
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS ALIKE.
MORE OF CONCERN RECENT STUDIES,
CONDUCTED BY THE WORLD RENOWNED
SCRIPPS INSTITUTE OF
OCEANOGRAPHY
DISTRIBUTED OVER 34,000
ILLNESSES IN 2017 ALONE TO WATER
QUALITY,
BIOLOGICAL AND INDUSTRIAL
CONTAMINATION.
IN THIS LOCATION, LARGE
MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE FOR FREE OF FREE
TRADE,
FREE TRADE AGREEMENTS,
CHEAP LABOR AND NEAR
NON-EXISTENT
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
THAT TO BUILD PRODUCTS CHEAPER
AND SELL THEM IN CALIFORNIA.
UNLIKE MOST CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES,
THEY DISCHARGE HEAVY METALS,
INDUSTRIAL WASTE AND CHEMICALS
AND YES,
RAW SEWAGE INTO THE RIVER WHILE
AVOIDING
ANY KIND OF OVERSIGHT OR
RESPONSIBILITY.
THIS BILL REQUIRES LARGE
CORPORATIONS WHO
DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A
DISCHARGE PERMIT,
AND I WOULD NOTE THAT MOST OF
OUR CALIFORNIA
REGISTERED CORP'S ARE IN
COMPLIANCE.
BUT THOSE THAT ARE NOT NEED TO
TO DISCLOSE
THEIR DISCHARGES AND WOULD
BE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO
TO
BASICALLY MITIGATE SELF
MITIGATE.
BUT IF THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE BOARD TO QUANTIFY
THE COSTS OF MITIGATION FOR THE
STATE,
BE ABLE TO ASSESS A FEE AND
UTILIZE THOSE FEES
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACTS TO
CALIFORNIA.
THE LAST NOTE I WILL MAKE IS
THAT
THE CORPORATION SAYS THAT THIS
WOULD
APPLY TO WHO ARE DELIBERATELY
ENGAGING
IN THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR,
SHOULD NOT HAVE A BUSINESS
ADVANTAGE OVER THOSE
THAT ARE COMPLYING WITH EXISTING
STATUTE.
WITH RESPECT TO THIS PART OF THE
STATE.
IN MY DISTRICT, SAN DIEGANS ARE
FED UP
AND BUSINESS AT THE BORDER
SHOULD BE AS USUAL,
SHOULD BE OVER AND DONE WITH.
WE CAN NO LONGER TOLERATE THIS
CONTINUED POISONING
OF OUR WATERS AND OUR CITIZENS.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN EYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR PADILLA.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEE.
NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO.
NO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS, I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER,
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
DELHI.
NO.
DODD I TORRAZZO.
I EGGMAN.
GLAZER I GONZALEZ.
BY GROVE.
HURTADO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
LEHMAN, I.
MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
MEN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NILO.
NO AKOBO.
NO PODIUM.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH, I RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMALL QUAVERS.
STERN.
I UMMER.
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I.
SENATOR PADILLA MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 95.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1213 BY
SENATOR ATKINS.
THE SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1213 BY
SENATOR ATKINS,
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS.
SENATOR ATKINS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1213.
THIS WOULD INCREASE THE
ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLD
FOR THE EVERY WOMAN COUNTS
PROGRAM AND
THE BREAST AND CERVICAL CANCER
TREATMENT PROGRAM
FROM 200% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL,
WHICH IS $30,120 PER YEAR FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL,
TO 300% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL,
WHICH IS $45,180 PER YEAR.
THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE FREE
BREAST AND CERVICAL CANCER
SCREENINGS AND TREATMENT TO
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS,
ENSURING THAT WOMEN CAN ACCESS
THE TIMELY,
QUALITY CARE THAT THEY NEED.
CURRENTLY, MANY LOWER INCOME
WOMEN WITH
AN INCOME ABOVE THAT 200% OF THE
FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD
INSURANCE OR THE PREMIUMS,
AND OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES THAT
CAN BE OVER $10,000 PER YEAR.
THEY MAY CHOOSE TO SKIP
SCREENINGS ALTOGETHER
OR DELAY CARE DUE TO COST.
AND THAT, OF COURSE, INCREASES
THE RISK
OF LATE STAGE CANCER AND CANCER
DEATH.
THE BILL IS A CRITICAL PART OF
OUR EFFORTS TO DECREASE CANCER
DEATHS AND CONTINUE MAKING
HEALTH
CARE MORE ACCESSIBLE.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ATKINS.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO, A ARCHULETA.
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKESBURG I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY I
DODD.
A TERRAZZO.
I EGGMAN GLASER, I I GONZALEZ.
I GROVE I OR DATO.
I JONES I LAIRD I LEHMAN I
MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR MEN I NEWMAN.
WHEN I NILO I OKOBO I PODIUM.
I PORTANTINO.
I RATHER.
I RUBIO CIERTO.
I SKINNER, I SMILED CUEVAS
STERN.
I UMMAR.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL.
I.
SENATOR ATKINS MOVES A CALL.
I KNOW MANY OF THE MEMBERS SHARE
MY THOUGHTS
TO OUR NEIGHBORS TO THE NORTH.
LET THEM KNOW WE HEAR THEM.
AND WE'LL TAKE THEIR CONCERNS
INTO CONSIDERATION.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM 96.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1221 BY
SENATOR MINH.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1221 BY SENATOR
MINH.
AN ACT RELATING TO GAS
CORPORATIONS.
SENATOR MINH, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
SB 1221 WOULD REQUIRE THE CPUC
TO EVALUATE ZERO EMISSION
ALTERNATIVES TO GAS PIPELINE
REPLACEMENT PROJECTS,
THEREBY ENCOURAGING UTILITIES
TO PILOT COST EFFECTIVE
ZERO EMISSION ALTERNATIVE
PROJECTS.
CURRENTLY, THERE IS NO PROCESS
IN PLACE
FOR THE CPUC TO CONSIDER ZERO
EMISSION
ALTERNATIVES TO LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS
IN THE NATURAL GAS SYSTEM.
INSTEAD, DOLLAR AMOUNTS ARE
APPROVED
FOR SPENDING CATEGORIES,
SUCH AS PIPELINE REPLACEMENTS
THAT CAN COST
RATEPAYERS OVER $3 MILLION PER
MILE.
THAT RESULTS IN CALIFORNIA
RATEPAYERS COMMITTING
DECADES OF PAYMENTS INTO AN
ENERGY SYSTEM THAT
OUR OWN MANDATES AND
REQUIREMENTS DICTATE MUST BE
OBSOLETE BEFORE THOSE EXPENSES
ARE PAID OFF.
WE NEED A PATHWAY TO
DECARBONIZING OUR GRID,
AND THIS BILL WOULD START TO
OPEN
THE DOORS TO THAT BY PILOTING
COST EFFECTIVE
ZERO EMISSION ALTERNATIVE
PROJECTS,
THEREBY SAVING RATEPAYERS MONEY,
POTENTIALLY REDUCING EMISSIONS,
AND BETTER INFORMING THE CPU'S
LONG
TERM GAS PLANNING RULEMAKING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MINH.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SENATOR DALI.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I RISE IN OPPOSITION.
LOOK, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
YES,
WE HAVE STATED GOALS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO
DECARBONIZE CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
GOING
TO SUPPOSEDLY MOVE AWAY FROM
GAS.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, THIS
IS ABOUT SAFETY.
IF YOU DON'T MAINTAIN AND TAKE
CARE OF THOSE PIPELINES.
WE SAW SAN BRUNO WHERE WE HAD
EXPLOSIONS OF PIPELINES.
PEOPLE DIED.
THAT WAS A NEGLIGENCE,
OBVIOUSLY,
FROM SOME OF THE CORPORATIONS.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE'RE
NOT SURE BY 2035
IF WE'RE REALLY GOING TO BE NOT
USING NATURAL GAS.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I
THINK FOR SAFETY,
WE NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL IN
THIS AREA
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE CARE
OF THOSE PIPELINES UNTIL THERE'S
A SURE PATHWAY THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO SOME
OTHER SOURCE OF ENERGY.
FOR THOSE REASONS, I OPPOSE SB
1221.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DALI.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE, SENATOR, MEN YOU
MAY CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE THE SENATOR'S
CONCERNS.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, THIS IS
A SET OF PILOT PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD TRY TO DEAL WITH AGING
PIPELINE INFRASTRUCTURE,
ADDRESSING THE VERY PROBLEM THE
SENATOR RAISES.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I'LL RODA-GIL.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY.
I.
ATKINS.
BECKER.
I.
BLAKESBERG.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
A DALLY.
NO.
DODD I DURAZZO.
I, EGGMAN.
GLAZER.
I I GONZALEZ.
GROWTH.
RIDOTTO.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD, I LAMENT.
I.
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
MEN I.
NEWMAN I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
OKOBO.
NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO.
SATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED, QUIVERS.
STERN I UMBERG.
WHILE A WINNER, I WILL.
NO.
SENATOR MIN MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS, OUR APOLOGIES FOR
MOVING
AROUND ON THE FILE TODAY,
BUT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMMODATE
MEMBERS
WHO ARE ON OR OFF THE FLOOR.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM 90.
MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM 90.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1116 BY
SENATOR PORTENTINO.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1116 BY SENATOR
PORTENTINO,
AN ACT RELATING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION.
THEREFORE, SENATOR PORTENTINO.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1116,
WHICH WOULD EXTEND UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFIT TO
STRIKING WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
ON STRIKE LONGER.
THAN TWO.
WEEKS.
WE HAVE COME OFF A TUMULTUOUS
YEAR.
THE HOT.
&GT;&GT; SUMMER FROM LAST YEAR,
WE'VE SEEN ACROSS
MANY INDUSTRIES ANGST, TO SAY
THE LEAST.
UM, NO ONE GOES ON STRIKE AS A
FIRST
RESORT AND STRIKES ARE NOT
ROMANTIC.
I STILL REMEMBER MY MOTHER IN
LAW
TALKING ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT
MY FATHER IN LAW'S STRIKE HAD
ON HER FAMILY 40 YEARS AGO.
SO THIS IDEA THAT SOMEHOW
STRIKES ARE ROMANTIC.
SOMEHOW THEY'RE THIS BEAUTIFUL,
WONDERFUL THING IS ONLY
SOMETHING FOR HOLLYWOOD.
IN REALITY, IT IS FAMILIES
STRUGGLING
TO PUT FOOD ON THEIR TABLE.
AND IF WE COULD PROVIDE A
MODICUM OF BENEFITS
DURING THOSE LONG TERM STRIKES
TO
HELP PEOPLE PAY THEIR RENT
AND PUT FOOD ON THEIR TABLE,
WE SHOULD DO THAT.
AND THIS BILL GOT OFF THE SENATE
FLOOR LAST YEAR WITH 27 VOTES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE TODAY
TO PROVIDE A MODICUM OF
CERTAINTY
AND BENEFIT TO THOSE STRIKING
FAMILIES
AND THOSE STRIKING WORKERS.
THANK YOU.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, SENATOR
PORTENTINO.
I SEE MIKE'S UP FROM SENATOR
CIERTO
AND SENATOR DOLLY'S SENATOR
SHEHATA.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
UH, OUR CURRENT UI DEBT IS $21
BILLION.
UH, THIS TIME OF THE YEAR IT
GOES UP AS OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
HAS GONE UP TO 5.3 IS THE LAST
NUMBER.
AND WE JUST HAD TO MOVE $100
MILLION AWAY FROM
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WHERE
IT'S BEING
PROPOSED THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE $100 MILLION
FROM WORKFORCE WORKPLACE
DEVELOPMENT.
AND PART OF THOSE PROGRAMS, $10
MILLION FOR WOMEN IN
THE WORKPLACE IN IN CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAM GOING AWAY.
WE'RE GOING TO ELIMINATE IT SO
THAT WE COULD MAKE
THE ADDITIONAL INTEREST PAYMENT
ON THE UI DEBT.
AS IT STANDS TODAY BY ITSELF,
IT'S A HALF $1 BILLION.
THAT'S HOW MUCH OUR UI DEBT IS.
AND THE REASON THAT UI DEBT
IS A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
IS BECAUSE INSTEAD OF TAKING THE
$46.8
BILLION THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GAVE US TWO
YEARS AGO TO WHITTLE DOWN SOME
OF THOSE COSTS,
WE DIDN'T USE IT TO PAY OFF OUR
UI DEBT.
OUR DEBT IS INCREASING EVERY
DAY.
THIS IS A NICE THOUGHT FOR
PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO VOLUNTARILY DECIDE NOT TO
WORK.
BUT WE CAN'T AFFORD IT.
JUST LIKE A LOT OF OTHER OF OUR
NICE THOUGHTS,
WE SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD THIS.
MEMBERS, I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
ON THIS.
SENATOR DOLLY.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS.
I TOO IS A BUSINESS OWNER.
I RISE IN OPPOSITION.
THERE'S NOTHING SEXY ABOUT
RUNNING
A BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS THE MOST HORRIBLE STATE
IN THE UNION TO DO BUSINESS.
THIS BASICALLY INCENTIVIZES
WORKERS
TO NOT WORK AND NEGOTIATE FOR.
HIGHER PAY, MORE TIME OFF.
YOU NAME IT.
UM, THIS.
THERE'S A GOOD REASON THAT ONE
OF
THE MOST LIBERAL GOVERNORS IN
THIS,
IN THIS NATION, VETOED THIS
BILL,
BECAUSE THIS IS A BAD BILL.
I URGE A NO VOTE ON BEHALF OF
ALL THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ACTUALLY EMPLOY PEOPLE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
UM, I RISE TODAY TO SHARE, UM,
A LITTLE BIT OF OF FEEDBACK ON
THIS BILL.
SO I'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
THIS
BILL FOR QUITE SOME TIME,
INCLUDING VOTING NO ON A SIMILAR
MEASURE LAST YEAR,
UM, SHARING MANY OF CONCERNS
AROUND
THE UI FEE FUND AS WELL AS
OTHERS.
AND I'VE BEEN SHARING THESE
CONCERNS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
AND HAVE NOW BROUGHT INTO
DISTRICT
INTO THE DISTRICT.
AND SINCE THEN I'VE HAD VERY,
UM,
A HANDFUL OF GOOD FAITH
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR LOCAL
LABOR LEADERS AND RANK AND FILE
MEMBERS
OF THE NORTH VALLEY LABOR
FEDERATION.
I'VE ALSO HEARD FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHO
CONTINUE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
AND SOLIDARITY ON THIS BILL.
UM, SO ALTHOUGH I CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE,
I WANT TO, UM,
SHARE MY SUPPORT AND I'M WILLING
TO GIVE THIS BILL AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LEAVE OUR HOUSE AND CONTINUE
IN THE PROCESS.
I WILL BE MONITORING THIS BILL.
AS YOU KNOW, I'M A FISCALLY
CONSERVATIVE,
UM, MEMBER OF OUR MAJORITY
PARTY.
UM, BUT I ALSO SUPPORT WORKERS,
AND I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS TO
WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION IN THE ASSEMBLY
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
A COHESIVE BILL THAT MAKES IT
ALL THE WAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE MATTER,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR PORTENTINO, YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES.
FRANKLY, IT WAS MY HOPE THAT
THIS
BILL WOULD WOULD STIMULATE,
STIMULATE THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
WE DO NEED A FUND THAT HAS LONG
TERM SOLVENCY.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT HOW THE
BUSINESSES
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT FUND.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT HOW OUR
WORKFORCE
BENEFITS FROM THAT FUND.
AND I WILL SAY, THE SHEER
PERCENTAGE
OF WORKERS THAT THIS
WOULD APPLY TO IN THE LONG RUN
IS RELATIVELY SMALL,
GIVEN TO THE THE NUMBER OF
OVERALL WORKERS
THAT BENEFIT FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE.
AND FOR ME, I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING
THAT THE STATE CAN AFFORD TO DO.
CERTAINLY THOSE WORKERS WHO WILL
BENEFIT
FROM IT WILL APPRECIATE IT,
AND NOBODY GOES ON STRIKE
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO.
THERE'S NO INCENTIVE TO DRIVE
ANYBODY ON STRIKE.
A STRIKE IS TRULY A TOOL OF A
LAST RESORT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
&GT;&GT; ELLEN ALVARADO GILL I
ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS, I BECKER.
BLAKESBURG.
I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
CORTAZZI.
I DELI?
NO.
DUD, NO DORADO I EGGMAN, NO
GLASER.
NO.
GONZALEZ.
GLAZER.
NO.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
ODOARDO I.
JONES.
NO LAIRD I LIMO I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
NEWMAN.
NO.
WHEN?
NO NILO.
NO AKOBO, NO PODIA.
PONTINO I.
I RUBIO.
SATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS A STERN.
UMMAT.
WAHAB.
WIENER I.
WILK.
NO.
SENATOR PORTENTINO MOVES A CALL.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE
UP TWO BILLS BY SENATOR EGGMAN
NEXT.
WE HAVE FILED ITEM 97, FOLLOWED
BY FILE ITEM 91.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 97.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1238.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1238 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
SEN.
EGGMAN, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
&GT;&GT; UH, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR.
SPEAKER.
UM, THIS YEAR, THE SENATE OR
LAST YEAR,
THE SENATE PASSED GRAVELY
DISABLED SB 43.
THIS IS A CLEAN UP BILL TO BE
ABLE TO MORE STREAMLINE,
IMPLEMENT THIS IN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS
AND THE ADMINISTRATION.
I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE,
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO I ARCHULETA, I
ASHBY I ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKE SPURR I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
CORTEZI.
I.
DALLI.
DAD, I.
OSO I.
EGGMAN.
GLASER I I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO
I JONES I LAIRD I LIMON.
I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
I NILO I OKOBO I PADILLA
I BERNARDINO I ROTH I RUBIO.
SATO I SKINNER.
I SMILED QUAVERS, I STERN, I
UMMAT, I WAHHAB.
WIENER WAHHAB I WIENER I WILK I.
SENATOR EGGMAN MOVES A CALL.
GOING TO MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM
90.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1116.
EXCUSE ME, 91, THIS IS SENATE
BILL 1118.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1118 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY ENSURES
THE SOMA PROGRAM THAT WE STARTED
SOME YEARS BACK IS ABLE TO ALSO
INCORPORATE TRIBAL LANDS.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN OVERALL TO GO.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER
I BLAKE SPERM I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLY.
DAD I DURAZZO, I EGGMAN I
GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ, I GROVE.
HURTADO I.
JONES.
LAIRD.
BY THE MONEY.
GUY MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
NEWMAN I WHEN?
NILO OKOBO PODIUM.
PORTANTINO.
A-ROD.
I IF RUBIO.
I SAY.
SKINNER.
A SMALL QUIVERS, A STERN
AYZENBERG,
A WAHHAB, A WEINER.
I WILL.
HOLD ON.
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE NOW.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK THROUGH
THE ROLL ONE LAST TIME.
MEMBERS.
THE SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
DOLLY.
GROVE I.
JONES.
NELL MCGUIRE.
MEN, I WIN.
NILO NO KOBO.
VIDEO.
SEE ALSO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME.
ALAN.
DALLY.
NO.
MAGUIRE.
WHEN BOCOBO PADILLA I CIERTO.
ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 3.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO BACK TO
FILE ITEM.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE AHEAD TO
FILE ITEM 98,
FOLLOWED BY 99 AND 102 BEGINNING
WITH 98.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1255 BY
SENATOR DURAZZO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1255 BY SENATOR
DURAZZO.
AN ACT RELATING TO DRINKING
WATER.
SENATOR DURAZZO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
SB 1255 WILL REQUIRE THE STATE
WATER
BOARD TO UPDATE ITS ANNUAL
NEEDS ASSESSMENT FOR WATER
SYSTEMS
UNDER THE SAFER PROGRAM
TO INCLUDE THE NEED TO MAKE
WATER
RATES AFFORDABLE FOR SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS WITH UNDER 3000
SERVICE CONNECTIONS,
CALIFORNIA IS AT THE EPICENTER
OF WATER
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESS CRISIS,
ESPECIALLY FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
MORE THAN 1.6 MILLION HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE AN AVERAGE
OF $500 WATER AND OR SEWER
UTILITY DEBT,
WITH MORE THAN 150,000 OF THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS
HAVING A DANGEROUSLY HIGHER DEBT
OWED.
OF $1,000 OR MORE IN 2022.
WATER.
UM.
UH, GOVERNOR NEWSOM CALLED ON
THE WATER UTILITY SECTOR TO
ADDRESS
THE COST BURDENS ON LOW INCOME
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY.
SB 1255 IS TAKING THE GOVERNOR'S
LEAD
BY HAVING THE STATE BOARD
UNDERSTAND
THE COST TO SUPPORT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
TO ACHIEVE WATER AFFORDABILITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DURAZZO.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY.
OH, EXCUSE ME, SENATOR GROVE.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I REALIZE THAT THERE ON THE
ANALYSIS THAT SAYS IT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT'S JUST GOING
TO SIT ON
THE SHELF AND NOT BE USED BY THE
STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD,
BUT WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
OUR CITY IN MCFARLAND, WHICH IS
JUST NORTH OF MY DISTRICT,
IS REALLY STRUGGLING WITH
PROVIDING
ADEQUATE WATER AND RESOURCES.
IT'S A POOR FARMING COMMUNITY.
PROBABLY 99% OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT LIVE THERE
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND WORK IN
THE FIELDS.
IT'S A FARMING TOWN.
IT'S WHERE THE ORIGINAL
MCFARLAND RENTERS COME FROM.
AND THE PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
THERE
IS THE TWO WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PLANTS AND THE WATER THAT THEY
PROVIDE TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
THROUGH THE WINTER TIME, WE WERE
OKAY.
BUT WITH THE SUMMER AND THE
INCREASED WATER USE,
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A LOT OF
TROUBLE.
AND SO IF ANYTHING CAN HELP
THESE INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER,
I WOULD SUPPORT IT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
SENATOR GIARRUSSO YOU MAY CLOSE.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE
FOR HER REMARKS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I WROTE AGO I ARCHULETA, I
ASHBY.
ATKINS I BECKER I.
BLAKE.
SPERM I.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLY.
DODD I.
TORAZO I.
EGGMAN I.
GLASER.
I.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
I HURTADO I JONES NO.
LAIRD I LEMAN I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR
I MEN I NEWMAN I WIN NILO.
NO.
CHOBOQ.
NO VIDEO.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I.
RUBIO.
I.
SATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED QUAVERS I STERN I
UMBERG
WAHA I WIENER I WILK I.
SENATOR DURAZZO MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO FILE
ITEM 99.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1289 BY
SENATOR ROTH.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1289 BY SENATOR
RATH.
AN ACT RELATING TO MEDI-CAL.
SENATOR RATH.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES,
DHS TO COLLECT DATA AND DEVELOP
STANDARDS FOR
CALL CENTERS OPERATED BY
THE COUNTIES TO ASSIST PEOPLE
WITH THEIR MEDI-CAL CLAIMS AND
ENROLLMENT.
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW REQUIRES
THAT PEOPLE BE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR MEDI-CAL AS
QUESTIONS,
TURN IN INFORMATION FOR THEIR
MEDI-CAL DETERMINATIONS,
AND CALL FOR HELP OVER THE
PHONE.
HOWEVER, THE WAIT TIMES FACED
BY MANY MEDI-CAL RECIPIENTS
TO REACH THEIR COUNTY WORKERS
BY PHONE ARE WAY TOO LONG.
SOME PEOPLE REPORT WAITING FOR
HOURS,
SOME REPORT NEVER GETTING
THROUGH AT ALL,
AND OTHERS REPORT CALLING IN
ONLY TO
HAVE THE SYSTEM HANG UP ON THEM.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE COUNTIES
TO SUBMIT
DATA REGARDING CALL CENTER WAIT
TIMES,
AND WILL REQUIRE DCS TO
ESTABLISH STANDARDS
SO THAT PEOPLE ON MEDI-CAL
CAN GET THE ASSISTANCE THAT
THEY NEED AND THEY DESERVE.
REQUEST.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL I.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS I.
BECKER I.
BLAKE.
SPUR I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CABALLERO.
CORTEZ.
I.
DALY.
I DOD I DURAZZO.
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE.
I HURTADO I JONES I LAIRD I
LEHMAN
I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MEAN I
NEWMAN
I WIN I NILO I OCHOA I PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO.
CIERTO I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS
I STERN
I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK
I.
WE HAVE ALL MEMBERS NOW ARE BACK
ON THE FLOOR.
SO WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE
ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN TORAZO I MCGUIRE.
RUBIO.
I ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO TO A
SPECIAL
CALENDAR ITEM HERE ON THE FLOOR.
THERE ARE FOUR MEASURES THAT
WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR IN ORDER.
THEY WILL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
172,
FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM 171, 140
AND 148.
SPECIAL ORDER FOR THOSE FOUR
MEASURES.
EVERYBODY UP TO SPEED OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM 172.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1403 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1403 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD
AND AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR BRADFORD, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I'M HERE PROUDLY TO PRESENT
1403,
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN FREEDMEN AFFAIRS AGENCY
FOR
THE PURPOSE OF IMPLEMENTATION,
OVERSIGHT, AND MONITORING THE
POLICIES
AND LAWS ENACTED RELATING TO
REPARATIONS.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE AGENCY
TO OVERSEE
AND MONITOR EXISTING STATE
AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS TASKED WITH
DIRECT IMPLEMENTATION
OF REPARATIONS POLICIES.
THIS BILL IS A RECOMMENDATION
FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TASK FORCE FINAL
REPORT,
WHICH WAS SUBMITTED JUNE OF LAST
YEAR AND IS AMONG
THE MOST ESSENTIAL OF THE
REPORT'S
115 RECOMMENDATIONS.
DURING THE LAST TWO YEARS,
I HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING
ON THE FIRST IN THE NATIONS TASK
FORCE,
HELPING US TO EXPLORE THE HARMS
OF SLAVERY IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE TASK FORCE WORK WAS WELL
DOCUMENTED IN GREAT
DETAIL THE HISTORY OF SLAVERY IN
CALIFORNIA,
THE PATTERNS OF SYSTEMIC RACIAL
INJUSTICE
THAT CONTINUE LONG AFTER SLAVERY
ENDED.
PEOPLE WILL OFTEN SAY, WHY
CALIFORNIA?
AND WHY SHOULD THEY PROVIDE
REPARATIONS?
CALIFORNIA WAS A FREE STATE.
IT WAS A FREE STATE AND NAME
ONLY.
CALIFORNIA PRACTICED EVERY
PRACTICE OF A SLAVE STATE.
IF YOU CAME HERE AS A SLAVE,
YOU WERE TREATED AS SUCH.
IF YOU GAVE BIRTH HERE AS A
SLAVE,
YOUR CHILD WAS BORN A SLAVE.
IF YOU RAN AWAY, THERE WAS A
FUGITIVE
SLAVE ACT THAT RETURNED
YOU TO THE STATE AND THE
PLANTATION
THAT YOU ESCAPED FROM.
PEOPLE WILL ALSO SAY, I DIDN'T
OWN A SLAVE.
WHY SHOULD I HAVE TO PAY?
BUT YOUR ANCESTORS DID.
I WOULD SAY TO THEM, IF YOU CAN
INHERIT GENERATIONAL WEALTH,
YOU CAN INHERIT GENERATIONAL
DEBT.
THIS IS A DEBT.
REPARATIONS.
REPARATIONS IS A DEBT THAT'S
OWED
TO DESCENDANTS OF SLAVERY.
THEY ARE.
THESE ARE NOT A HANDOUT OR
CHARITY BY ANY MEASURE.
IT IS WHAT WAS PROMISED.
IT'S WHAT IT'S OLD.
AND WHAT IS 160 YEARS OVERDUE.
THIS AGENCY WILL BE NECESSARY
FOUNDATION FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION AND SUCCESS
OF REPARATIONS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY
OF THIS AGENCY WILL HAVE IS
TO DETERMINE WHICH INDIVIDUALS
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR REPARATIONS.
BASED ON THE DEFINITION OF
DESCENDANTS RECOMMENDED BY
THE TASK FORCE TO DESCENDANTS OF
CHATTEL SLAVERY,
OR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARRIVED IN
THIS
COUNTRY PRIOR TO THE 1900S.
SB 1403 WILL CREATE AN OFFICE OF
RESEARCH
AND CONFIRM AN INDIVIDUAL'S
LINEAGE.
WHILE IN NO WAY DOES THIS BILL
EXCUSE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM TAKING
THEIR OWN ACTIONS,
CALIFORNIA STILL BEARS GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
THE STATE GOVERNMENT PERMITTED
AND COMMITTED
GRAVE INJUSTICES AGAINST AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
THESE INJUSTICES INCLUDE
ENSLAVEMENT,
LEGAL AND PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SEGREGATION,
DISCRIMINATION IN STATE FUNDING
AND PROGRAMMING,
AND STIGMATIZING AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
AGREE THAT
THE HARMS OF SLAVERY ARE STILL
FELT TODAY.
THE AGENCY IS THE FIRST STEP
CALIFORNIA
CAN TAKE IN WRITING THESE
WRONGS.
SB 1403 IS ABOUT DEMONSTRATING
OUR STATE'S COMMITMENT
TO NOT ONLY RECOGNIZING THE
PAST,
BUT ALSO TAKING MEANINGFUL
ACTIONS
TOWARD AN EQUITABLE FUTURE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BRADFORD.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEE.
NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO I.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS I.
BECKER I.
BLAKE.
SPUR I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CABALLERO.
CORTEZ.
I.
DALY.
NO.
DODD.
I TORAZO.
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I, GONZALEZ I
GROVE NO.
HURTADO I JONES NO.
LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE I
MENGIBAR.
MEN.
NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
I ROD I RUBIO.
I CIERTO?
NO, SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS A STERN.
AYZENBERG I WAHAB I WEINER I
WILK.
THIS IS CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ALAN.
MENJIVAR, I MEAN.
WILK.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 7.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 171.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1331, ALSO
BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1331 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AND AQUILINA.
STATE GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS A FOLLOW UP.
THE COST OF REPARATIONS WILL BE
HIGH,
BUT SO IS THE HARM TO AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE HARM AND THE DISPARITIES IT
CREATED
CONTINUES TO THIS VERY DAY.
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING AGAIN ON
IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE LAST
14 YEARS,
AND WE HAVE VOTED ON DOZENS
OF BILLS ABOUT WAGE THEFT.
THERE HAS BEEN 250 YEARS OF WAGE
THEFT FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS WHO WERE SLAVES IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THE HARM OF THIS WAGE THEFT
STILL EXISTS TODAY.
HOW WILL CALIFORNIA PAY FOR
REPARATIONS?
SB 1331 WOULD ESTABLISH A FUND
FOR REPARATIONS
AND REPARATIVE JUSTICE,
AND AUTHORIZE IT TO RECEIVE
GRANTS FROM FEDERAL,
STATE, LOCAL, AND PRIVATE
ENTITIES.
THE REPARATIONS TASK FORCE HAS
PAINSTAKINGLY
DOCUMENTED CALIFORNIA'S ROLE
IN SLAVERY AND THE DECADES OF
SYSTEMIC
DISCRIMINATION THAT FOLLOWED.
PEOPLE CAN CHOOSE TO IGNORE IT.
THEY CAN BE UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
OUR HISTORY,
BUT THEY CANNOT DENY THE TRUTH.
NOW IS THE TIME TO FACE IT,
TO OWN UP TO THE DEBT THAT IS
OWED.
TO THE RIGHT.
THE HISTORIC WRONGS TO RESTORE
AND REPAIR DAMAGE THAT
HAS BEEN DONE WITH THIS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
I VOTE FOR SB 1331.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BRADFORD.
SENATOR SKINNER.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
MR..
PRESIDENT MEMBERS, I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1331,
AND I WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE
FROM GARDENA FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND FOR HIS WORK ON
THE REPARATIONS TASK FORCE
AND ALSO APPRECIATION TO THE
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE.
UM, WHILE AS A COUNTRY OR A
STATE,
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ALL THAT GOOD
ABOUT REPARATIONS FOR A VARIETY
OF
POPULATIONS THAT DESERVE SUCH,
I HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE TO,
WHEN I WAS ON THE BERKELEY CITY
COUNCIL,
TO BE PART OF AN EFFORT AND FOR
OUR CITY TO PASS,
WHERE WE PROVIDED REPARATIONS TO
ALL OF THE JAPANESE AMERICANS
WHO HAD WORKED FOR EITHER THE
CITY
OF BERKELEY OR THE BERKELEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THEN
WERE INTERNED.
AND SO WE PROVIDED THEM THEIR
BACK WAGES FOR
THE TIME FOR WHICH THEY WERE
INTERNED.
NOW, WHILE THIS FUND THAT'S
BEING ESTABLISHED
AND THE OTHER WORK THAT'S BEING,
DOING,
BEING, BEING DONE FOR
REPARATIONS FOR SLAVERY
DOES NOT HAVE THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL.
IT DOES ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
RESULT OF CHATTEL
SLAVERY HAS HAD SERIOUS NEGATIVE
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES ON ALL OF
THE DESCENDANTS OF CHATTEL
SLAVERY,
AND THUS IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO TO ESTABLISH
MECHANISMS FOR US TO ADDRESS
THAT.
AND WITH THAT, I SUPPORT THE
BILL
AND ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON SB 1331?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
CNN.
SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU MAY CLOSE.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BERKELEY
FOR DRAWING THAT COMPARISON.
WE HAVE PROVIDED REPARATIONS
AND FUNDING FOR SO MANY
PROGRAMS.
WE OFTEN SAY THE BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION
OF OUR PRIORITIES.
THIS SHOULD BE ONE OF OUR
PRIORITIES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO I.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ I DALLY.
NO DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROVE NO HURTADO I JONES NO.
LAIRD I LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
I MEAN, JABBAR, I MEAN.
NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO, NEELA, NO OKOBO.
NO PODIUM.
I PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
I RUBIO.
ACIERTO.
NO SKINNER, A SMALL.
CUEVAS A STERN.
UMMER.
A WAHAB.
I WIENER, I WOKE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
MEN.
STONE.
WORLK NOW.
ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 140.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1050.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1050 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD.
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL IS A PRIORITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
SB 1050 CREATES A PATHWAY FOR
RESTITUTION
TO CALIFORNIANS WHO HIT
THEIR LAND OR PROPERTY TAKEN BY
THE STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
BY RACIALLY MOTIVATED REASONS
AND NO OTHER REASON.
MANY PEOPLE ARE NOW FAMILIAR
WITH BRUCE'S BEACH,
THE PARCEL OF LAND, AND
MANHATTAN BEACH.
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO AUTHOR
THAT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THREE YEARS AGO
THAT LED
TO THE RETURN OF THE PROPERTY OF
THE DESCENDANTS
OF CHARLES AND WILLA BRUCE,
A FAMILY THAT HAD PURCHASED
THIS PROPERTY IN 1912 WITH
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF CREATING A
CAFE, A LODGE,
AND AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS
TO ENJOY BEACH LIFE
JUST LIKE ANYONE ELSE IN
CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THIS NATION.
BUT THE CITY OF MANHATTAN BEACH
RESENTED
THE BRUCE'S SUCCESS AND
POPULARITY,
AND THE FACT THAT BLACK FOLKS
WERE WRECKING,
RECREATING, AND HAVING A GOOD
TIME JUST AS THEY
DID AND WANTED TO PUT THEM OUT
OF BUSINESS.
THE CITY USED THE POWER OF
EMINENT
DOMAIN TO TAKE THE BRUCE'S LAND,
AND DO SO FOR FAR LESS THAN FAIR
MARKET VALUE.
AGAIN, IN 2022, I AUTHORED
LEGISLATION THAT
ALLOWED THE CURRENT OWNERS TO LA
COUNTY.
UH, LOS ANGELES COUNTY, I SHOULD
SAY,
TO RETURN THE LAND TO THE
DESCENDANTS
OF CHARLES AND WILLA BRUCE.
JUST LIKE BRUCE'S BEACH.
SB 1050 WILL PROVIDE A PATHWAY
TO JUSTICE FOR OTHERS HARMED
BY SIMILAR RACIST POLICIES
AND PRACTICES OF THE PAST.
WE'RE LOOKING AT JUST NOW IN
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA,
A BLACK BUSINESS OWNER BY THE
NAME OF SILAS WHITE
ACQUIRED A PIECE OF PROPERTY ON
PICO BOULEVARD
IN SANTA MONICA IN 1958 WITH
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF CREATING
THE EBONY BEACH CLUB FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ONLY FOR THE CITY TO DECIDE TWO
YEARS LATER.
OH, WE NEED THIS PROPERTY FOR A
PARKING LOT.
WELL, HERE WE ARE 65 YEARS
LATER,
AFTER THE CITY ACQUIRED IT.
AND KNOW WHAT SITS THERE?
A FOUR STAR HOTEL THAT THE CITY
OWNS THE LAND
AND COLLECTS RENT FROM ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS.
THAT REVENUE, IF NOT THE
PROPERTY,
SHOULD BE RETURNED TO
THE DESCENDANTS OF THE WHITE
FAMILY OF SILAS WHITE.
THE POWER OF EMINENT DOMAIN HAS
BEEN USED REPEATEDLY TO ABUSE,
TO MOVE BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
OFF OF
THEIR LAND AND DESTROY THEIR
HOMES.
WE'VE SEEN RECENT EXAMPLES,
EVEN IN CITY OF PALM SPRINGS,
SECTION 14,
WHERE THE PALM SPRINGS POLICE
FIRE DEPARTMENT
BURNED OUT THESE FAMILIES AND
TOOK THE LAND.
THESE ACTIONS HAVE DEVASTATED
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR FAMILIES TO
BUILD INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH
THROUGH THE OWNING OF LAND.
AS WE ALL KNOW, GENERATIONAL
WEALTH IS PASSED
ON IN THIS COUNTRY THROUGH LAND.
SB 1050 WILL CREATE A WAY FOR
THE STATE TO REVIEW CLAIMS
OF ABUSE AND DETERMINE WHAT
COMPENSATION IS WARRANTED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BRADFORD.
I SEE MICROPHONES UP FROM
SENATOR SMALLWOOD,
AND SENATOR NILA WILL BEGIN
FIRST
WITH SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
AND I RISE AS A MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF MY GREAT
COLLEAGUE, SENATOR BRADFORD.
AND I WANT TO APPLAUD ALL OF HIS
WORK
AS PART OF THE TASK FORCE OVER
THESE MANY YEARS TO BRING
REPARATIONS
TO THIS HISTORIC DAY.
OUR ANCESTORS ARE SMILING ON US
IN THIS MOMENT.
I WANT TO SAY THAT THE BILL
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT,
SB 1050 STUDIES,
HAVE SHOWN THAT CALIFORNIA
ALLOWED
FOR EARLY SETTLERS TO
BRING THEIR ENSLAVED AFRICANS
TO WORK AND DIG FOR GOLD.
IN MANY CASES, THESE SLAVES WERE
ABLE TO EVENTUALLY BUY THEIR
FREEDOM FROM THE GOLD THEY FOUND
AND TO PURCHASE LAND.
BUT THIS LAND, THROUGH JIM CROW,
THROUGH BLACK CODES,
THROUGH INSTITUTIONAL RACISM AND
RACIAL TERROR,
LEFT SO MANY FAMILIES BANKRUPT.
INSTEAD OF PEOPLE WHO HAD
PURCHASED
THEIR FREEDOM AND THEIR LAND
BEING
HAVE BEING ABLE TO PASS IT ON TO
THEIR DESCENDANTS,
IT WAS STOLEN.
STOLEN THROUGH SYSTEMIC RACIST
PROPERTY
LAWS THAT HAVE DRIVEN OUR
COMMUNITIES
OFF OF THEIR LAND THROUGH
VIOLENCE
AND INTIMIDATION BY THEIR WHITE
NEIGHBORS,
AND ALSO ADDED TO MORE AND MORE
ATROCITIES
THAT WE SEE GENERATIONAL HARM
DONE TODAY.
THIS WAS THE CALIFORNIA GOLD
RUSH, THE LAND,
THE ABILITY TO OWN PROPERTY THAT
IS
WORTH MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TODAY,
LAND THAT MANY WHITE FAMILIES
HAVE BUILT THEIR
FORTUNES ON AT THE PERIL OF
BLACK COMMUNITIES.
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE TALKED ABOUT
BRUCE'S BEACH AND HOW IN 1924,
THE MANHATTAN BEACH CITY COUNCIL
PASSED THIS ORDINANCE TO 63,
CLAIMING EMINENT DOMAIN FOR THIS
PUBLIC PARK LAND,
WHICH ALLOWED THE GOVERNMENT TO
SEIZE
THE PROPERTIES THAT WERE OWNED
BY BLACK
RESIDENTS AND ELIMINATED THE
OPPORTUNITY
FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN UH
FAMILIES,
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO OWN
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN BRUCE'S.
BRUCE'S BEACH RESORT.
TO HAVE OPPORTUNITY OF DIGNITY
FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND FOR GENERATIONS.
AND IT WAS IN 2021,
WITH THE HELP OF THE GREAT
SENATOR,
ALONG WITH MANY LEADERS HERE IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND THE
LOS
ANGELES LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS, I MIGHT SAY,
WHO VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO APPROVE
THE RETURNING OF THAT
LAND TO THE RIGHTFUL HEIRS OF
CHARLES AND WILLA BRUCE,
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO SELL THIS
LAND
FOR A PROFIT OF $20 MILLION.
THIS IS JUST ONE STORY OF
COUNTLESS OTHERS
OF FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST
WEALTH.
AND THIS BILL IS IS REALLY ABOUT
HOW DO WE RESTORE BLACK
CALIFORNIA AND RESTORE ALL OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE PROCESS.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR NILO.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO SUPPORT THE PRINCIPLE
OF THIS BILL.
&GT;&GT; AS I DISCUSSED IN
COMMITTEE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GARDENA THAT WHEN I FIRST
SAW THIS BILL,
IT MADE GOOD SENSE TO ME TO
RESTORE ANY INJUSTICE OF
PROPERTY THAT WAS TAKEN FROM
ANYBODY MOTIVATED,
AT LEAST PARTIALLY, UH, BY
RACIAL ISSUES.
PARTICULARLY IF
UNDER-COMPENSATED.
BUT THE CONCERN I HAVE WITH THIS
BILL IS IT
MAKES IT THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE STATE.
THE INJUSTICE OF MANHATTAN BEACH
UNDER THIS BILL.
WOULD BE PAID FOR BY THE
TAXPAYERS OF LOS ANGELES,
SAN DIEGO, FRESNO, SAN
FRANCISCO.
MODOC COUNTY.
NOT DIRECTLY BY THE ENTITY THAT
CREATED
THE INJUSTICE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AND THAT SEEMS TO ME TO BE A BIT
OF
AN INJUSTICE IN AND OF ITSELF.
SO AGAIN, THE PRINCIPLE.
THE INTENT OF THE BILL.
I DO SUPPORT THAT AND I WISH I
COULD SUPPORT THIS,
BUT I CAN'T UNDER THE WAY THAT
IT'S BEING EXECUTED.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
UH, AND I WOULD THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
FOR HER WORDS AND SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
AND JUST TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO,
THIS MEASURE DOES NOTHING TO
IMPACT OTHER JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE RACIAL TAKING OF LAND.
IT HAS TO DO SPECIFICALLY, AS WE
GAVE THOSE EXAMPLES
OF BRUCE'S BEACH AGAIN HERE IN
SANTA MONICA,
WE CAN LOOK BACK IN JULIAN AND
SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND ON AND ON.
IT'S HUNDREDS, IF NOT THOUSANDS
OF EXAMPLES.
AND IF THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENTS
ITSELF UNIQUELY,
LIKE WE SAW IN MANHATTAN BEACH,
TO RETURN OR COMPENSATE THOSE
FAMILIES
ON PROPERTY THAT'S STILL
CONTROLLED
EITHER BY A LOCAL ENTITY OR A
STATE
ENTITY OR FEDERAL ENTITY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS MEASURE WILL
DO.
SIMPLY, IT'S NOT TAKING IT FROM
PRIVATE
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT OWN IT NOW,
BECAUSE SADLY, THE STATE,
MOST OF THAT PROPERTY THAT IS
TAKEN FROM AFRICAN AMERICANS,
THEIR FREEWAYS AND ROADS.
NOW, BELIEVE ME, YOU TALK ABOUT
SUGAR
HILL ON THE WEST SIDE OF LA,
ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT
AFRICAN AMERICAN
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THIS COUNTRY.
A FREEWAY GOES THROUGH IT.
TODAY.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE 105 FREEWAY
THAT
GOES IN THE MIDDLE OF MY
DISTRICT.
I TOOK MUSIC LESSONS FROM A A
MUSIC TEACHER WHO WAS
IN THE LA PHILHARMONIC
ORCHESTRA, WHO LIVED THERE,
WHO HAD HIS PROPERTY TAKEN FOR A
FREEWAY
THAT WASN'T BUILT FOR 30 YEARS
LATER.
SO WE HAVE PLENTY OF EXAMPLES
WHERE THE GOVERNMENT
OWNS THIS PROPERTY AND WHERE WE
CAN PROVIDE
RESTITUTION OR SOME TYPE OF
PAYMENT OR RETURN
OF THOSE LANDS AND WHERE THEY
EXIST.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL INTENDS TO
DO.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN I.
RODA-GIL.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I
BECKER.
I BLAKESBERG.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ, I.
DALLY.
DODD.
I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
OR DODO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD, I.
I MAGUIRE.
I MEAN, JABBAR, I MEAN.
I MEAN.
NO.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO NILO.
NO AQUEBOGUE.
PEDDUR.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO NO SKINNER
I SMALL CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I
WIENER.
I WOKE I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BREAKSPEAR I.
DOLLY I.
GROVE.
AQUEBOGUE.
ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 5.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM 148.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1089.
SENATE BILL 1089.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1089 BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AN ACT RELATING TO FOOD AND
PRESCRIPTION ACCESS.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND GOOD AFTERNOON,
COLLEAGUES.
I PROUDLY RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB 1089,
WHICH IS PART OF THE 2024
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS
REPARATION PRIORITY PACKAGE,
RESTORING BLACK CALIFORNIA AS A
WAY
TO RESTORE ALL OF CALIFORNIA,
SB 1089 WILL ENSURE THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND RELEVANT STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE ADVANCED
NOTICE AND ACCESS TO
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED IN
THESE
SITUATIONS LIKE JOB LOSS,
PRESCRIPTION TRANSFERS, OR
DECREASED FOOD ACCESS.
SB 1089 REQUIRES GROCERY STORES
AND PHARMACIES WITH
FIVE OR MORE EMPLOYEES TO
PROVIDE A 60 DAY NOTICE
OF CLOSURE AND A 30 DAY NOTICE
FOR STORES WITH FIVE
OR FEWER AND INSTANCES OF
PHARMACY CLOSURES.
THIS BILL REQUIRES PHARMACIES TO
TELL THEIR PATIENTS
WHERE THEIR PRESCRIPTIONS WILL
BE TRANSFERRED.
THIS BILL ALSO ENSURES THAT
EMPLOYERS
PROVIDE THEIR WORKERS WITH
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED FROM
LOCAL
AGENCIES REGARDING THE BENEFITS,
LIKE UNEMPLOYMENT, IN INSTANCES
WHERE JOBS ARE LOST.
SINCE THIS BILL HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED, WE HAVE MADE
AMENDMENTS TO DECREASE THE
NOTICE PERIOD.
WE'VE NARROWED THE REQUIREMENTS.
WE WORKED WITH OUR COLLEAGUES ON
THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE CAPPING PENALTIES
AT $10,000 PER CLOSURE.
AND AS THIS BILL MOVES, I AM
COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS
DUE TO THE INDUSTRY'S LONG
STANDING
DISINVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT BLACK
COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THIS STATE
ARE ALREADY MORE THAN LIKELY
TO FACE FOOD INSECURITY.
THEY ARE MORE THAN LIKELY TO
LIVE IN FOOD DESERTS,
HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO
PRESCRIPTION AND MEDICATION.
OFTEN IN MY DISTRICT, THE
CRENSHAW CORRIDOR,
ONE OF THE MOST DENSE
POPULATIONS OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE,
A PREDOMINANTLY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOOD ONCE
HOME TO THREE UNIONIZED GROCERY
STORES,
ALL OF WHICH HAVE CLOSED EXCEPT
FOR ONE.
THESE CLOSURES ONLY FURTHER
EXACERBATE
THE DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH AND WEALTH OF OUR BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES,
AND OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES DESERVE
TO KNOW WHEN THEY MAY LOSE
ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES THAT THEY RELY ON
FOR
THE MOST BASIC NECESSITIES,
FOOD AND MEDICINE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THIS IS A WAY OF ADDRESSING THE
HARMS
THAT EXIST IN OUR COMMUNITIES,
FROM A HISTORIC PATTERN OF
MISTREATMENT
OF BLACK AND BROWN AND
VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
ACCESSING HEALTHY FOOD.
IN COMMITTEE, WE TALKED ABOUT
THE WAYS IN WHICH STORES
DETERMINE WHERE THEIR BUSINESSES
WILL BE LOCATED,
AND IT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH THE
WEALTH
AND THE EDUCATION LEVEL OF A
COMMUNITY,
AND BECAUSE OF HISTORIC
INJUSTICES,
BECAUSE OF INSTITUTIONALIZED
RACISM,
BECAUSE OF JIM CROW AND SLAVERY
AND ALL OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE HAS LAID
OUT IN A 100 PAGE REPORT.
WE KNOW THAT ACCESS TO FOOD AND
PHARMACY
NECESSITIES ARE IN JEOPARDY
BECAUSE THESE STORES ARE NOT
LOCATED IN OUR COMMUNITY,
THE VERY LEAST WE CAN DO IS
PROVIDE ADEQUATE
ACCESS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES,
PARTICULARLY THE MOST
VULNERABLE,
TO HAVE NOTIFICATION.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR GONZALEZ.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I TOO WANT TO RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE LATINO
CAUCUS ON THIS BILL AND URGE AN
I VOTE.
I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
WORKING SO VERY
HARD SPECIFICALLY ON THE
CERTIFICATION PIECE,
BUT IN GENERAL, ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK
CAUCUS FOR THE ISSUE OF
REPARATIONS.
AND SO WITH THAT, I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO EXTEND MY SUPPORT.
I URGE ALL OF OUR MEMBERS TO
VOTE.
I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MEMBERS,
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS, YOU MAY CLOSE.
I WANT TO THANK MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE
FROM LONG BEACH FOR HER
COMMENTS,
AND THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO ACT,
TO ACT FOR THE GRIEVANCES OF THE
PAST AND TO REPAIR
THE HARM IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
AND CERTAINLY, NOTIFICATION
OF LACK OF ACCESS TO FOOD
AND MEDICINE IS SOMETHING THAT
THIS SENATE CAN DO TODAY.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY CALL
FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO GILL ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKE
SPEAR I BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DALLY KNOW DODD
I DURAZZO I EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ
I GROVE KNOW HURTADO
I JONES KNOW LAIRD I LIMON
I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
OKOBOJI.
NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH, I
RUBIO, I SATO.
NO.
SKINNER I SMILED CUEVAS I STERN
I UMBERG I I WIENER I WILK.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
EXCUSE ME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
NO.
EGGMAN.
GLASER.
WILK.
NO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
EGGMAN I.
GLAZER.
ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 9, THE
MEASURE CARRIES.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
EXCUSE ME.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE
BACK
TO UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
BRADFORD.
YES, MR.
PRESIDENT, I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR RECONSIDERATION
ON SB 171 AND SB 140 FILE ITEM,
I SHOULD SAY, UM, FILE ITEM 171
AND FILE ITEM 140.
&GT;&GT; EXCUSE ME.
GOOD, GOOD.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS.
SENATOR BRADFORD HAS ASKED, UH,
TO RECONSIDER FILE ITEMS 171.
YEAH.
UH, BUT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THEM
ONE AT A TIME.
SO SENATOR BRADFORD IS ASKING
FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON FILE ITEM
171.
THIS IS SB 1331.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
RECONSIDERATION?
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS.
UH, WE'RE GOING TO NOW, UH,
CALL ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0.
WE HAD A MEMBER OFF THE FLOOR.
I THINK IT'S THE REASON WHY
WE'RE
BRINGING THESE TWO BILLS BACK.
ALL RIGHT.
SO LET ME JUST REPEAT.
SO EVERYBODY'S UP TO SPEED.
SENATOR, UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS,
SENATOR BRADFORD IS ASKING THAT
WE RECONSIDER FILE ITEM 171.
THAT'S SB 1331.
I'M ASKING IF THAT OBJECTION
THAT OBJECTION.
THAT'S A 39 TO 0.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL
ON THAT ITEM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 171.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL A ARCHULETA
I ASHBY ATKINS I BECKER
I BLAKE I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ.
DALLY DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN
I GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HURTADO I JONES KNOW LAIRD I
NEWMAN I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN NEWMAN I WAIN.
NO.
NEELA.
OKOBO NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO NO.
SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN
I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I
WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ASHBY I CORTEZ I DALLEY.
NO.
GROVE.
MIN.
WILK.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
MIN.
WILK.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 7, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR BRADFORD IS ALSO RISEN
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
ASKED THAT WE RECONSIDER FILE
ITEM 140.
THIS.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1050.
UH.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SEEING SEEING.
NO OBJECTION.
THAT'S EYES 39.
NO, ZERO.
SO WE'RE NOW GOT IT.
SO WE'RE NOW GOING A MOMENT.
CALL UP FILE ITEM 140 FOR
ANOTHER
VOTE ON THE ON THE MAIN,
ON THE MAIN MOTION, ON THE MAIN
RESOLUTION,
ON THE MAIN MEASURE.
EXCUSE ME.
WE'LL GET IT RIGHT THE THIRD
TIME.
MEMBERS.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP THE
THE BILL.
SENATE BILL 1050.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER
I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I TALLY
I DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE
I HURTADO I JONES NO LAIRD
I LIMON I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I
MIN NEWMAN I WIN.
NO.
NILO NO CHOBOQ PADILLA I
PORTANTINO
I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
AYES.
MANUEL.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB,
I WIENER, I WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
I'LL RODA-GIL MIN OKOBO WILK I.
ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 4, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
UH, MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
185.
FILE 185, THIS IS SENATE BILL
1380 BY SENATOR DODD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE, PLEASE READ
THE MEASURE.
SENATE BILL 1380 BY SENATOR
DODD.
AN ACT RELATING TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS.
&GT;&GT; SB 1380 IS FIRST AND
FOREMOST ABOUT
THE FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND STABILITY OF OUR CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THE BILL HELPS PROTECT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AGAINST INSOLVENCY
WHEN EVALUATING PETITIONS ONLY
FOR NEW CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
APPROPRIATIONS
SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWED THE BILL
AND FOCUSED ON DISTRICTS THAT
ARE
TRULY IN FINANCIAL DISTRESS.
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL INDEPENDENT
CERTIFICATION THAT APPROVING
A NEW CHARTER FOR THESE
DISTRICTS
WOULD HARM THEIR BUDGET.
SO AN INDEPENDENT CERTIFICATION,
UH, THAT WOULD BE NEEDED.
THEIR EXISTING LAW IMMEDIATELY
REMOVES
THE ABILITY OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
EXITING RECEIVERSHIP TO CONSIDER
THE IMPACT OF A NEW CHARTER
SCHOOL,
EVEN WHEN APPROVING THE SCHOOL
WOULD RESULT IN
THE DISTRICT BEING PULLED BACK
INTO RECEIVERSHIP.
THERE'S A FIVE YEAR PERIOD AFTER
EXITING RECEIVERSHIP,
WHERE THERE'S ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS ON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO DEMONSTRATE STABLE
FINANCES,
AND THIS BILL SIMPLY MIRRORS
THAT
BY ALLOWING DISTRICTS TO
CONSIDER THE FINANCIAL IMPACT
OF A NEW CHARTER SCHOOL.
THIS ABILITY IS FURTHER LIMITED
BY
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT,
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
COUNTY'S INDEPENDENT
FISCAL CRISIS AND MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAM,
CERTIFY THAT APPROVING THE
CHARTER WOULD RESULT
IN QUALIFIED OR NEGATIVE INTERIM
BUDGET,
SO THAT KIND OF TAKES OUT
THE POLITICS ON A SCHOOL BOARD,
BECAUSE IT HAS TO BE APPROVED BY
AN INDEPENDENT
FISCAL CRISIS AND MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAM.
LASTLY, THE BILL AUTHORIZES
FISCALLY
DISTRESSED DISTRICTS WHO
HAVE CLOSED OR CONSOLIDATED
SCHOOLS
WITHIN THE FIVE YEAR,
FIVE FISCAL YEARS IMMEDIATELY
PRECEDING
THE SUBMISSION OF A PETITION FOR
A NEW CHARTER TO CONSIDER THE
FISCAL IMPACT
OF THE COUNTY'S FISCAL CRISIS,
TEAM CERTIFIES APPROVING THE
CHARTER WOULD RESULT
IN A QUALIFIED OR NEGATIVE
INTERIM BUDGET.
AMENDMENTS ADDRESSED ASSERTIONS
THAT THE BILL WAS OVERLY BROAD,
AND MADE CLEAR THAT THE
PROVISIONS ONLY APPLY
TO NEW CHARTER PETITIONS AND NOT
RENEWALS.
CAN I REPEAT THAT THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO
NEW CHARTER SCHOOLS AND NOT TO
RENEWALS,
AND I JUST FEEL LIKE IT'S
APPROPRIATE
AT THIS POINT IN
TIME TO JUST CALL OUT TO OUR
PAST ESTEEMED GOVERNOR,
UH, BROWN, THAT THIS BILL IN NO
WAY,
SHAPE AND FORM WILL IMPACT YOUR
OAKLAND MILITARY ACADEMY.
AND I EVEN OFFER THAT IF YOU
REALLY DO THINK IT IS,
LET'S COME INTO THE OFFICE AND
LET'S
GET SOME AMENDMENTS ON THIS,
BECAUSE I HAVE 12 HIGH
PERFORMING
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT,
AND I DO NOT WANT TO DO ANY HARM
TO ANY OF THEM.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DODD.
SENATOR UMBERG.
&GT;&GT; WELL, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I HAD A QUESTION.
THE AUTHOR, BUT I THINK THE
AUTHOR
HAS ANSWERED THE QUESTION.
BUT JUST TO MAKE THINGS CLEAR
THAT WITH RESPECT
TO CERTAIN HIGH PERFORMING
CHARTER SCHOOLS,
FOR EXAMPLE, IN ORANGE COUNTY,
WE HAVE A SCHOOL OF THE ARTS,
WHICH IS AN ABSOLUTELY STELLAR
PERFORMER,
BUT IT'S BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
IF THEY SHOULD REVISE THEIR
CHARTER, UH,
COULD IT POSSIBLY BE DENIED AT
THAT POINT?
NOT.
NOT BECAUSE OF ANYTHING THAT
IS IN THIS BILL CURRENTLY.
IF YOU HAVE REVISIONS, I THINK,
IS IT 1505 1505 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FROM LONG BEACH,
UH, IN YEARS GONE BY,
UH, THAT DOES ALLOW A SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO REVIEW THEM,
BUT NOTHING IN THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THAT.
IN FACT, WE'VE PUT LANGUAGE IN
THERE
JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE
COMING BACK TO US SAYING WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
SENATOR, UM, LET ME JUST REMIND
MEMBERS
WE HAVE A PROCESS ON THE FLOOR.
IF YOU WANT TO ASK THE AUTHOR A
QUESTION,
YOU FIRST ASK FOR PERMISSION,
AND THEN I GET AN OKAY OR NOT
FROM THE AUTHOR,
AND THEN WE PROCEED FROM THERE.
SENATOR AYZENBERG, ON YOUR OWN
TIME.
WELL, I WANTED TO ASK THE AUTHOR
ANOTHER QUESTION.
SENATOR DODD, WOULD YOU TAKE
ANOTHER QUESTION?
ABSOLUTELY, YES.
JUST TO TO UNDERLINE, I
UNDERSTAND YOU SAID
THAT THE FORMER GOVERNOR HAS
BEEN IN TOUCH,
AND HE'S INFORMED ME THAT THIS
IS HIS LIFE'S
WORK IN ANY WAY, SHAPE OR
FASHION.
WILL THIS IMPINGE IMPAIR THE
OPERATION
OF THAT MILITARY SCHOOL IN
OAKLAND?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH.
WELL, EXCUSE ME.
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
PRESIDENT DODD.
YES, YOU MAY ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR AABERG.
YOU'VE COMPLETED YOUR YOUR VIEWS
TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS, QUESTIONS,
DISCUSSION,
DEBATE MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
SENATOR DODD, YOU MAY CLOSE.
MEMBERS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL.
THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK OUT FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THAT.
AND WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE LOW
PERFORMING.
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT
DECLINING ENROLLMENT AND
FINANCIALLY
AREN'T ABLE TO MAKE IT.
AND I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE CO-MINGLING THAT IDEA
THAT THESE ARE LOW PERFORMING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
AND THEY ABSOLUTELY NEED CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO UPLIFT.
I'M TALKING ABOUT ONLY CHARTER
SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE DECLINING ENROLLMENT,
THAT ARE FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED,
AND ONLY BY AN INDEPENDENT,
CERTIFIED, EXCUSE ME,
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY CAN MAKE
THAT
CLAIM TO THE TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN.
ALVARADO GIL.
NO.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY.
ATKINS.
BECKER.
BLACKSBURG.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
CORTAZZI.
HI, DOLLY.
DUD I TORAZO I EGGMAN.
GLASER.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
NO.
HER DAUGHTER.
I JONES.
NO.
LAIRD.
LEMON.
MCGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
MAN I.
NEWMAN.
WHEN?
NO NILO.
NO OJOBO, NO PADILLA.
I PORTANTINO.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER.
SMALL QUAVERS.
STERN.
UMBERG.
I HAVE A WIENER.
WORLK?
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
ASHBY.
ATKINS.
BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR.
BRADFORD CABALLERO.
DALLY?
NO.
EGGMAN.
GLASER.
LAIRD.
LEMON.
MENGIBAR.
NEWMAN.
BERNARDINO.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
SKINNER.
BY.
SMALL REQUIRES A STERN.
WIENER.
SENATOR DODD MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 102.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1303 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO.
SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1303 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC WORKS.
SENATOR CABALLERO.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT 1303,
AN IMPORTANT BILL TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY
ON PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS.
THE LABOUR CODE GOVERNING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS MANDATES THAT ALL
WORKERS
RECEIVE PREVAILING WAGE AND
PUBLIC AGENCIES
MUST ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE LAWS.
BUT INCREASINGLY THIS
ENFORCEMENT
IS DELEGATED TO PRIVATE,
FOR PROFIT THIRD PARTY
COMPLIANCE COMPANIES.
IF THE COMPLIANCE COMPANIES FIND
EVIDENCE OF A VIOLATION,
THEY CAN TAKE PUNITIVE ACTION
AGAINST THE CONTRACTOR
BY WITHHOLDING PAYMENT WITHOUT
DUE PROCESS.
THE COMPLIANCE COMPANIES
FUNCTION
WITH MINIMAL AND INCONSISTENT
PROCESSES DESPITE RECEIVING
PUBLIC
DOLLARS TO DO THIS WORK.
ADDITIONALLY, THE LACK OF RULES
REGARDING CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST AND PRIOR
AFFILIATIONS
WITH CONTRACTORS CAN COMPROMISE
INFORMAL ENFORCEMENT INTEGRITY.
SB 1303 WILL REQUIRE THIRD PARTY
COMPLIANCE
COMPANIES TO DISCLOSE ANY
CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST TO THE DIVISION OF
LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT AND TO AWARDING
AGENCIES,
AND WILL PROHIBIT THIRD PARTY
COMPLIANCE
COMPANIES FROM RECEIVING
CONTRACTS.
IF CONFLICTS OF INTEREST EXIST,
THE BILL WILL ESTABLISH
A STRUCTURED PROCESS FOR THIRD
PARTY COMPLIANCE
COMPANIES TO FOLLOW IF THEY
BELIEVE
A VIOLATION HAS OCCURRED,
ENSURING FAIRNESS AND
TRANSPARENCY.
FINALLY, THE BILL MANDATES THAT
AWARDING AGENCIES AND THIRD
PARTY COMPLIANCE COMPANIES SEEK
RESOLUTION OF DISPUTED
LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS BY
CONFERRING
WITH CONTRACTORS BEFORE
WITHHOLDING FUNDS AND STALLING
PUBLIC PROJECTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SHAPIRO.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE.
MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
COLORADO.
GAIL I.
ARCHULETA.
I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKE.
SPEER.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ.
DALLY.
NO.
DODD, I.
DURAZZO I.
EGGMAN.
GLASER I I GONZALEZ, I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
I JONES.
NO LAIRD I LEMAN I MAGUIRE I
MENGIBAR.
MEN I NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO NO NO NO NO NO NO.
I PORTANTINO.
HI, ROD.
HI, RUBIO.
I SEE NO SKINNER.
A SMALL QUAVERS I STERNE I
AMBURG I WAHHAB.
A WIENER.
I WILL.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
EGGMAN.
MENGIBAR.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL ONE
LAST TIME.
I'D LIKE TO ASK MEMBERS,
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO ARE NOT
ON THE BILL,
TO PAY ATTENTION SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE IF THEY
WISH.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
EGGMAN.
I MENGIBAR.
I.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 103.
FILE ITEM 103.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1304 BY
SENATOR LEHMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1304 BY SENATOR
LEHMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO OIL AND GAS.
SENATOR LEHMAN.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
SB 1304 ESTABLISHES REQUIREMENTS
FOR STATE APPROVAL
OF AN AQUIFER EXEMPTION BY
REQUIRING
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TO CONDUCT
AT LEAST ONE DECISION MAKING
PUBLIC HEARING,
ALLOWING THE PUBLIC AN
OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON AN EXEMPTION
PROPOSAL FROM BELGIUM AND PRIOR
TO SENDING IT TO THE US.
EPA, REQUIRING THAT THE PUBLIC
HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN.
FOLLOWING THE STATE WATER BOARD
FINDINGS ENSURES
THAT THE PUBLIC CAN OFFER THEIR
OPINION
ON HOW THEIR POTENTIAL DRINKING
WATER MAY
BE AFFECTED BY OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LEMON.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL KNOW ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLY KNOW DODD.
DAD.
I DURAZZO, I EGMAN, I GLASER.
GONZALEZ.
GROVE.
NO.
JONES.
LAIRD I NAMEMY I.
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN, I.
NEWMAN.
WHEN?
NO.
NILO.
NO OKOBO.
NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
I ROD I RUBIO.
SATO.
NO SKINNER A SMALL CUEVAS I
STERN
I UMMAT I WAHAB I WIENER.
I WILL KNOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLAN GLASER.
NEWMAN I RUBIO I.
I 28.
NOSE TEN.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 104.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1321 BY
SENATOR WAHAB.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1321 BY SENATOR
WAHAB.
AN ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT.
SENATOR WAHAB, THANK YOU.
&GT;&GT; I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1321.
SB 1321 WILL ENSURE TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FUNDED
THROUGH THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL.
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKERS.
ETP FUNDS PROJECTS THAT PROJECTS
THAT CREATE HIGH WAGE,
HIGH SKILLED CAREER PIPELINES
FOR WORKERS IN MANUFACTURING,
CONSTRUCTION, CLEAN ENERGY AND
OTHER INDUSTRIES.
THIS BILL PROMOTES A HEALTHY
LABOR
MARKET AND HELPS BUSINESSES
INCREASE THEIR COMPETITIVENESS
TO SECURE FEDERAL,
PRIVATE SECTOR, AND OTHER
NON-STATE FUNDS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN.
I THANK YOU, SENATOR WAHAB.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS, ON THIS MEASURE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
NO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I
BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I.
COURTESY I DALLY NO DODD I
TERRAZZO.
EGGMAN.
I GLASER I, I.
GONZALEZ.
I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO, I.
JONES.
NO LAIRD I.
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE, I MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
AKOBO.
NO.
PODIA.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH, I RUBIO.
CRITO.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE I STERNE I
UMBER, I WAHHAB I WINER.
I WILL NOW.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
BECKER I.
CABALLERO I.
TERRAZZO I RUBIO I.
I HAD A VOTE OF 30 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS, LET ME GIVE YOU THE
NEXT RUN OF SHOW HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO NEXT MOVE TO FILE
ITEM
107 FOLLOWED BY 108, 112 AND
113.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO FILE ITEM 107.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1340 BY
SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ THE MEASURE.
SENATE BILL 1340 BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS,
AN ACT RELATING TO
DISCRIMINATION.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND GOOD AFTERNOON,
MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING,
UH, ALL OF THIS, UH, GREAT,
UH, CHAMBER FOR ITS SUPPORT
AROUND SB 150,
WHICH WE PASSED.
AND I'M THRILLED TO PRESENT
1340, UM, FOR YOU TODAY.
THIS BILL BASICALLY ENSURES THAT
WE USE OUR
INCOMING FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS THE JOBS
ACT,
THE INFLATION IN INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT,
AND THE CHIPS AND SCIENCE ACT
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT,
QUALITY JOBS, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY,
EQUITY BENEFITS THAT HELP ENSURE
ALL
ACCESS TO THESE OPPORTUNITIES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S GUIDELINES
CALL FOR CALIFORNIA
TO BE COMPETITIVE AND TO ENSURE
THIS,
THESE MUST BE GOOD JOBS WITH
REAL LABOR
STANDARDS AND HAVE A PATHWAY
FOR UNDERREPRESENTED POPULATIONS
TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE OPPORTUNITY.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT, WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS EXISTING BARRIERS.
SB 1340 AUTHORIZES THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT
TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL AGENCIES
TO INVESTIGATE AND ENFORCE CASES
OF EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION.
ACCORDING TO OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT'S RECENT
REPORTS THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
OVER 23,000
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION
COMPLAINTS
JUST IN THE LAST YEAR, 2022.
UM, AND THAT IS UP TO 24,000
AS WE LOOK AT THIS YEAR,
THE HIGH VOLUME OF THESE
COMPLAINTS,
IN ADDITION TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
RESPONSIBILITIES,
LEAVE CRD OVERBURDENED AND
UNDERSTAFFED.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT
IN MY DISTRICT IS STAFFED
AND READY TO SUPPORT THE STATE
TO ADDRESS CLAIMS,
BUT EXISTING LAW PREEMPTS THEM
FROM
INVESTIGATING THE LARGE MAJORITY
OF CLAIMS THEY RECEIVE AND
REQUIRES
THAT THEY FORWARD,
UH, TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT,
WHICH IS ALREADY HAVING
AN INCREASING BACKLOG WITH
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND OTHER FEDERAL FUNDING
SOURCES COMING TO
CALIFORNIA TO CREATE MILLIONS OF
NEW JOBS.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT WILL
NEED LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS TO
ENSURE THAT WORKERS ARE ABLE
TO HAVE THEIR CASES HEARD,
AND TO GET THEM TO WORK IN A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE WAY.
THIS BILL WOULD ADDITIONALLY
REQUIRE
CONTRACTORS TO REPORT
DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA TO OUR CALIFORNIA CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT,
WHICH WILL TRACK AND MONITOR
AND REPORT THIS PUBLICLY.
AND LASTLY, SB 1340 WOULD
ESTABLISH
A PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
TASK FORCE MADE UP OF COMMUNITY
AND LABOR WORKFORCE EXPERTS
TO ACT AS AN INTERMEDIARY
BETWEEN
THE STATE AND CONTRACTORS
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
STRENGTHENED RECRUITMENT,
RETENTION AND PROTECTION FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE,
VULNERABLE AND UNDERREPRESENTED
WORKERS
IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE SECTOR.
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE
COMING TO CALIFORNIA
TO CREATE GOOD JOBS AND NEW
OPPORTUNITIES,
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT
REACHES
OUR HARDEST HIT CALIFORNIANS.
SB 1340 IS A WAY TO ENSURE THAT
AND ENSURE THAT HISTORICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES GET
THE OPPORTUNITY THEY DESERVE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTAZZI, I DALLY.
NO DODD.
I THOUGHT ALSO I EGGMAN.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO.
RIDOTTO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE, I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NILO.
NO KOBO, NO PODIUM I PORTANTINO.
THY WRATH, I RUBIO.
I SEE NO SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS.
I STERN, I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
A WIENER.
I WOKE?
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN RODA-GIL.
WHEN?
NO.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 108.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1375 BY
SENATOR DURAZZO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1375 BY SENATOR
DURAZZO.
AN ACT RELATING TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
SENATOR DURAZZO.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
SB 1375 RESERVES 2% OF FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE
MONEY FOR AN EQUITY,
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND QUALITY
JOBS FUND TO SUPPORT SECTOR
BASED WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
THROUGH HIGH ROAD TRAINING,
PARTNERSHIPS AND OTHER QUALITY
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT REACH
COMMUNITIES WITH THE HIGHEST
BARRIERS TO ECONOMIC EQUITY.
AGAIN, IT SETS ASIDE 2% OF OUR
FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS.
THIS BILL WILL ASSIST STATE
AGENCIES WITH APPLYING HIGH
ROAD STANDARDS FOR THE BENEFIT
OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA HAS LABOR STANDARDS
IN CONSTRUCTION.
FEDERAL DOLLARS INCLUDE
PREVAILING
WAGE AND PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS,
BUT IT LEAVES US WITH A GAP FOR
MANUFACTURING,
OPERATIONS,
MAINTENANCE AND SERVICES,
AND THERE IS A PRESSING NEED TO
TRAIN THE WORKFORCE NEEDED TO
REACH OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
THESE FEDERAL DOLLARS ARE
CRITICAL TO KEEPING
OUR WORKFORCE PROGRAMS FUNDED,
ESPECIALLY DURING A DIFFICULT
BUDGET YEAR.
SB 1375 WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA
COMPETITIVE
FOR EVEN MORE FEDERAL FUNDING.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN PENNSYLVANIA,
THE GOVERNOR
CREATED THE PROGRAM BY RESERVING
3% OF ALL THE FUNDING IT
RECEIVES
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE NEED BOTH INVESTMENTS IN
TRAINING AND STANDARDS
EMBEDDED IN OUR PUBLIC
CONTRACTS.
CALIFORNIA TAX DOLLARS COULD
GO TO OUT OF STATE COMPANIES
INSTEAD OF BENEFITING CALIFORNIA
WORKERS.
OUR WORK ON HIGH ROAD LABOR AND
EQUITY
STANDARDS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
AND THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION,
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
HAS BEEN CLEAR THAT FEDERAL
INVESTMENTS ARE MEANT
TO IMPACT JOBS, THE ECONOMY AND
POVERTY.
THEY EXPECT STATES TO INCLUDE
LABOR STANDARDS
AND EQUITY WHEN USING FEDERAL
DOLLARS.
THANK YOU.
AND I ASK FOR AN EYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GAROZZO.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR I.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLY.
NO.
DODD I DURAZZO.
I EGGMAN.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE NO.
HURTADO.
I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD, I.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I.
NEWMAN.
I WHEN?
NO NILO.
NO AKOBO.
NO BADILLO I PORTANTINO.
I ROD I RUBIO I CIERTO NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE I STERN I UMMER,
I WAHAB.
BY WIENER.
I WOKE NO.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 112.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1402 BY
SENATOR MINH.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1402 BY SENATOR MEN
AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION.
SENATOR MEN.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
SB 1402 WOULD REQUIRE ALL STATE
AGENCIES TO
CONSIDER 30 BY 30 GOALS WHEN
ADOPTING,
REVISING OR ESTABLISHING PLANS,
POLICIES AND REGULATIONS THAT
DIRECTLY AFFECT LAND USE,
NATURAL RESOURCES MANAGEMENT,
WATER USE AND QUALITY AND
BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION.
THIS BILL BUILDS ON PREVIOUS
ACTIONS,
INCLUDING GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND 8220,
AS WELL AS MY BILL LAST YEAR, SB
337,
THAT ESTABLISHED THE 30 BY 30
GOALS
AS PART OF CALIFORNIA LAW.
ON CALIFORNIA, OF COURSE, IS
HOME TO ONE
OF 25 GLOBAL BIODIVERSITY
HOTSPOTS.
BUT THIS BIODIVERSITY CONTINUES
TO BE
UNDER THREAT FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE,
HABITAT LOSS AND FRAGMENTATION,
INVASIVE SPECIES,
DISEASE, PESTS AND POLLUTION.
WE'VE MADE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
IN CONSERVATION
TO FURTHER THE 30 BY 30 GOAL,
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS
GOAL
ALSO BE ROOTED IN THE PLANS,
POLICIES AND REGULATIONS OF OUR
STATE AGENCIES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, SENATOR.
DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM?
DO NOT SEE ANY SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO I.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER I.
BLAKE.
SPEER I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CABALLERO.
CORTEZ.
I.
DALY.
NO.
DODD I.
DURAZZO, I.
EGGMAN.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE NO.
HURTADO I JONES.
NO LAIRD I NAMEMY.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NEELO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
I ROD I RUBIO I CIERTO NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG
I WAHAB I WIENER.
I WOKE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN WILK.
WORK NOW.
EYEBROW TO GUILD EYE TO NO.
AYES 30, NOES NINE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE NEXT
TWO BY OUR PRESIDING OFFICER OF
THE DAY.
FILE ITEM 113 AND FILE ITEM 178.
SENATOR GLAZER.
ARE YOU PREPARED?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1404 BY SENATOR
GLAESER.
AN ACT RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF 1974,
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION,
THEREFORE.
SENATOR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL TRANSFERS THE DUTY OF
PERFORMING LOBBYING AUDITS FROM
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO THE
FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION,
AND IT ESTABLISHES A LOBBYIST
AND LOBBYIST EMPLOYER
REGISTRATION
FEE TO COVER THE COST OF OF THE
AUDITING SYSTEM.
LET ME GIVE YOU SOME BACKGROUND.
UNDER THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT
OF 1974,
FOR WHATEVER REASON, THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
WAS REQUIRED TO RANDOMLY AUDIT
25% OF OF LOBBYISTS
AND LOBBYISTS EMPLOYERS EVERY
TWO YEARS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD HAS
ESSENTIALLY FAILED TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW,
AS SHOWN DURING THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS LAST YEAR.
IN FACT, DURING THE TESTIMONY,
IT BECAME CLEAR THAT ALMOST
NO AUDITS WERE BEING DONE OVER A
TEN YEAR PERIOD.
IN SOME YEARS, 3 OR 4 WERE DONE.
IN SOME YEARS, NONE AT A TIME
IN WHICH THEY SHOULD HAVE
AUDITED OVER A THOUSAND
LOBBYISTS AND LOBBYISTS.
EMPLOYERS.
AUDITORS IS AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY TOOL.
THE FAILURE TO HOLD LOBBYING
FIRMS ACCOUNTABLE HAS MAJOR
IMPLICATIONS FOR HOW LEGISLATORS
DO THEIR WORK.
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE A SYSTEM
OF HONEST REPORTING ON
MONEY SPENT TO INFLUENCE
LEGISLATORS
AND LEGISLATION.
I KNOW THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
LOBBYISTS
AND LOBBYIST FIRMS PRACTICE
LEGALLY,
ETHICALLY AND WITHIN THE SPIRIT
OF THE LAW,
BUT IT IS A MATTER OF ENSURING
PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN THE WORK THAT THEY
DO.
THAT I ASK YOU TO VOTE I ON THIS
MEASURE TODAY.
DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION?
I DON'T SEE ANY SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLAN OVER OTAGO.
GUY ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS.
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DALLY.
DUD.
TORAZO I EGGMAN.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
OR DODO I.
JONES.
LAIRD I.
LEMON.
HI, MAGUIRE.
I MEAN, JABBAR, I MEAN.
NEWMAN.
WHEN?
NILO.
OKOBO PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
I RUBIO, I SATO.
SKINNER.
I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN.
I UMBERG I WAHAB, I WIENER.
I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ELLEN ATKINS, I.
DALLY DODD.
GROVE.
JONES.
NO.
MAN.
NEWMAN.
WHEN?
NILO.
SERATO.
WELL, NO.
EYES 28.
NOSE TWO.
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 178.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1482 BY SENATOR
GLAZER.
AN ACT RELATING TO FINANCING
SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
COMMERCIAL FINANCE PROVIDERS
AND BROKERS TO REGISTER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION BEFORE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIA'S SMALL
BUSINESSES.
THE BILL IS A RESPONSE TO
PROVIDERS
AND BROKERS USING
EXPLOITIVE PRACTICES TO MAXIMIZE
THEIR PROFITS,
AND LENDING PRACTICES THAT
RESEMBLE THOSE
DURING THE 2008 FINANCIAL
CRISIS.
THE BILL WAS RECENTLY AMENDMENT
IN SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
TO ADDRESS FINANCIAL CONCERNS,
CHANGING THE SCOPE OF OF THE
BILL FROM A LICENSING
SCHEME TO A REGISTRATION SCHEME.
THE BILL PASSED POLICY
COMMITTEES
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITHOUT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
SENATOR GROVE, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
UM, QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
WOULD THE AUTHOR TAKE A
QUESTION?
YES, SENATOR GROVE, YOU MAY
PROCEED.
JUST A CURIOUS QUESTION.
WERE THESE SUBSTANTIAL
SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
ALTERED IN APPROPRIATIONS OR
MINOR AMENDMENTS?
SENATOR, I WOULD SAY THAT THERE
WOULD
BE CONSIDERED SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE HAD A
LICENSING
SCHEME IN THE BILL BEFORE,
WHICH IS A WHOLE REGULATORY
REQUIREMENT
THAT IS MORE COMPLEX NOW.
IT'S SIMPLY IT'S BEEN CHANGED TO
A REGISTRATION
SCHEME MUCH MORE SIMPLE
AND STREAMLINED IN RESPONSE TO
THE CONCERNS FROM FROM
OPPONENTS.
AND THOSE AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
IN APPROPRIATIONS.
YES.
THANK YOU SIR.
SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
&GT;&GT; MEMBERS, I VOTED NO ON
THIS BILL IN APPROPRIATIONS,
BUT BECAUSE OF THE AMENDMENTS I
AM VOTING I TODAY.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE, SENATOR GLAZER, YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CONSIDERATION
TODAY.
WE TRIED TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED ON THIS
BILL.
IT'S ALL ABOUT TRYING TO PROTECT
SMALL BUSINESSES,
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT DON'T
HAVE
THE FINANCIAL WHEREWITHAL
TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE
UNDERSTANDING
THE COST OF FINANCING.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
AYE.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY.
I ATKINS.
I BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CORTEZI.
I DALLI.
I DIED.
I TORAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I OTERO.
JOE HURTADO I.
JONES.
I.
LAIRD.
I THE MOM I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
I NILO.
I OKOBO.
I PADILLA.
I PORTANTINO.
I.
ROD.
I RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER, I
SMALL CUEVAS.
STERN.
I UMMER.
WAHAB.
DIE WIENER.
I WILL I?
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
BRADFORD I.
SMALL.
CUEVAS, I.
UMBERG I.
AYES 39.
NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT THREE UP.
WE HAVE 116, 117 AND 118
COLLEAGUES.
I'M ASKING THAT WE STAY ON THE
FLOOR.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE LIFTING
THE CALLS.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH 116
CENTER.
ASHBY, ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
FIRE?
ITEM 116 SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE.
BILL 1498 BY SENATOR ASHBY
AND ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO.
&GT;&GT; PRESENT SB 1498
CANNABIS ADVERTISING ACT.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A NECESSARY
ENFORCEMENT
TOOL TO ADDRESS THE ILLEGAL
MARKETING
OF CANNABIS AND CANNABIS
PRODUCTS
THAT ARE ATTRACTIVE TO CHILDREN.
CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS CANNABIS.
I'M SORRY, CANNABIS LICENSEES
FROM ADVERTISING
PRODUCTS THAT ARE ATTRACTIVE TO
CHILDREN.
HOWEVER, SOME CANNABIS OPERATORS
CHOOSE TO WILLFULLY VIOLATE
THAT LAW BY CONTINUING TO
ADVERTISE THESE PRODUCTS,
LEAVING THE PROMISE OF PROP 64
UNFULFILLED.
SB 1498 ALLOWS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL,
A DISTRICT ATTORNEY, COUNTY
COUNSEL,
OR A CITY ATTORNEY TO ENFORCE
THE LAW WHEN A CANNABIS OPERATOR
IS IN VIOLATION OF EXISTING
YOUTH PROTECTION LAWS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO KEEP OUR KIDS
SAFE AND ENSURE
THAT PROP 64 IS IMPLEMENTED AS
ATTENDED.
THIS BILL ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT
AND HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION.
URGENT.
I VOTE THANK YOU, SENATOR.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM?
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
FIRST ITEM OF THE DAY ELIGIBLE
FOR UNITED'S.
UM, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ELLEN.
I'LL RATHER GO I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKE SPERM I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZI.
I DALLY.
I DIED.
I TORAZO I EGGMAN.
GLASER.
GLASER, I.
GONZALEZ, I.
GROVE.
I ADATO.
JONES I.
LAIRD, I.
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN I NILO I OKOBO
I PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT A RUBIO.
I SATO, I SKINNER.
A SMALL QUAKE WAS A STERN.
AYZENBERG I WAHAB.
I WIENER I WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
EGGMAN.
RIDOTTO I.
AYES 38.
NO, ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR, ARE YOU PREPARED?
SHE IS PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM
117.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1500 BY SENATOR
TORRAZZO.
AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING AND
MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION, THEREFORE.
PLEASE PROCEED, SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
THE COST OF HOUSING HAS BECOME
AN EXTREMELY LARGE BURDEN,
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR LOW AND
EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
TO HELP PROVIDE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES
FOR LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS,
CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES PROVIDE
VOUCHER PROGRAMS TO INCENTIVIZE
DEVELOPERS TO HOUSE SUCH LOW
INCOME PROSPECTIVE TENANTS.
MAYOR BASS HAS BEEN WORKING
EXTREMELY
HARD TO ADDRESS THE
HOMELESSNESS,
AND THIS COULD BE ONE TOOL.
IN 2023, US DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING
GRANTED WAIVERS TO THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF LA FOR GREATER
FLEXIBILITY
TO MOVE UNHOUSED,
UNHOUSED PEOPLE INTO TEMPORARY
HOUSING.
HOUSING PROVIDERS, HOWEVER,
HAVE EXPRESSED A RISK WITH
THE CURRENT HOUSING VOUCHER
SYSTEMS AND RULES.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF THESE PROVIDERS
HOUSE FAMILIES
BASED ON THEIR CURRENT ECONOMIC
SITUATION,
ONCE THEY HAVE FORMAL
DOCUMENTATION,
THEY MAY LATER FIND
DISCREPANCIES.
SB 1500 ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE
BY PROVIDING THESE VOUCHERS
WITH MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
THE DEVELOPERS AND OPERATORS.
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION, ANY
DISCUSSION, SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN ALVARADO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLY
KNOW DODD I DURAZZO EGGMAN
DURAZZO I EGGMAN
I GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE KNOW
HURTADO.
JONES KNOW LAIRD I LIMON I
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN,
I NEWMAN I WIN KNOW.
NILO KNOW A.
PODIUM I KNOW I ROTH I RUBIO
I SATO KNOW SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK KNOW.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL I HURTADO.
NO.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE
SECOND PAUSE.
SENATOR DURAZZO MOVES A CALL FOR
ITEM 118.
SENATOR WIENER, HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 951 BY SENATOR
WIENER.
AN ACT RELATING TO COASTAL
RESOURCES.
&GT;&GT; SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, SB 951 RELATES TO
THE COASTAL ZONE.
IT DOES TWO THINGS.
FIRST, IT ALIGNS THE TIMETABLE,
UH, FOR LOCAL COASTAL PLAN
AMENDMENTS WITH THE TIMETABLE
FOR HOUSING ELEMENT UH.
IN ADDITION, IT CLARIFIES THAT
FOR PURPOSES
OF APPEALABILITY TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION,
A CITY AND COUNTY WILL BE
TREATED
AS A CITY INSTEAD OF AS A
COUNTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION ON ITEM
118?
HERE WE GO.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
WE'LL KEEP TRYING.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GIL A ARCHULETA
HIGH.
ASHBY HIGH.
ATKINS HIGH.
BECKER, BLAKE.
SPEER HIGH.
BRADFORD HIGH.
CABALLERO HIGH.
CORTEZ HIGH.
DOLLY HIGH.
DODD HIGH.
TORRAZZO HIGH.
EGGMAN HIGH.
GLASER, HIGH.
GONZALEZ.
HIGH.
GROVE HIGH.
HURTADO.
JONES I, LAIRD I.
LEMON.
I.
MCGUIRE.
I MEAN GERARD, I MEAN I NEWMAN I
WAYNE,
I NILO I OCHOA BOGH I PODIUM I
PORTANTINO.
ROTH.
I RUBIO.
HI SATO I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS
I STERN
I UMBERG I WAHAB I WEINER I WILK
I.
SEN WEINER MOVES A CALL FOR ITEM
NEXT THREE
ARE FIVE ITEM 121, 127 AND 128
SEN.
NEWMAN.
KICK US OFF WITH ITEM 121.
HE IS READY.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
&GT;&GT; SENATE BILL 1202 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO WORKPLACE
SAFETY.
&GT;&GT; PLEASE PROCEED,
SENATOR.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1202,
WHICH WILL REQUIRE CAL HR TO
ISSUE
AN ANNUAL REPORT ON WORKPLACE
ASSAULTS
AGAINST PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE,
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES EXPERIENCED
WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE INCIDENTS AT RATES
THREE TIMES
HIGHER THAN PRIVATE EMPLOYEES.
SB 1202 WILL ENSURE GREATER
OVERSIGHT
OF THESE INCIDENTS BY REQUIRING
CAL HR TO REPORT SUCH INCIDENTS
ANNUALLY TO THIS LEGISLATURE.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 553,
AUTHORED BY SENATOR CORTESE AND
PASSED LAST YEAR,
WILL HELP REMEDY THIS ISSUE BY
MANDATING
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PLANS AND THE MAINTENANCE OF
RECORDS
RELATED TO VIOLENT INCIDENTS
SO THAT UNION REPRESENTATIVES
MAY
ACCESS AND UTILIZE THIS DATA.
SB 1202 SEEKS TO FURTHER ADVANCE
THE INTENT
OF SB 553 BY REQUIRING AN ANNUAL
REPORT OF WORKPLACE ASSAULTS ON
PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYEES TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
I AM RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
YOUR.
I VOTE THIS AFTERNOON.
ANOTHER ONE BITES THE DUST.
THIS WAS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL,
BUT NOT EVERYONE IS HERE.
SO, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA BY ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ.
BY DALLY.
I DAD, I TORAZO I EGGMAN.
I.
GLASER.
I GONZALEZ, I GROVE.
I HURTADO.
JONES I.
LAIRD I.
LEHMAN.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
I KNEEL, I BOW, I PODIUM.
I PORTANTINO.
A ROD.
I RUBIO.
ACIERTO I.
SKINNER.
SMALL QUAVERS.
I STERNE I UMBERG.
I WAHAB I WIENER.
I WILK I.
SENATOR NEWMAN MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON TO ITEM 127.
MAJORITY LEADER IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 934 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS,
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB 934,
WHICH WILL COORDINATE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILDOUT NEEDED TO TRANSITION
CALIFORNIA'S FREIGHT SECTOR TO
ZERO EMISSIONS TECHNOLOGY.
ONE OF THE MAJOR IMPEDIMENTS TO
THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
REGULATION
IS THE LACK OF A AVAILABLE
CHARGING
AND REFUELING INFRASTRUCTURE,
ESPECIALLY FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES.
SB 934 WILL HELP ADDRESS THIS
BARRIER
TO ADOPT THE TO ADOPTION BY
ESTABLISHING A CENTRAL DELIVERY
TEAM FOR FREIGHT ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE
CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION AND THE CTC,
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
ON SB 934.
THANK YOU.
ANY DISCUSSION FOR ITEM 127?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY.
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZI.
I DALLY DODD.
I DURAZZO I EGMOND I GLASER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
RIDOTTO.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD, I.
HI, MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NIILO OKOBO.
PEDDUR I PORTANTINO.
ROD.
I RUBIO I CIERTO NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED AS I STERN I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WOKE?
NO.
SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SENATOR GONZALEZ MOVES A CALL.
THE NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE ITEM
128, 129 AND 132.
SENATORS SKINNER IS PREPARED
WITH FILE ITEM 128.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 941 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
AN ACT RELATING TO GREENHOUSE
GASES.
SENATOR SKINNER.
&GT;&GT; UM, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
SB 941 DIRECTS OUR CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO IN THEIR NEXT RELEASE,
SCHEDULED SCOPING PLAN.
SO PART OF CARB STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE TO UPDATE THE SCOPING
PLAN UNDER AB 32 PERIODICALLY IN
THE NEXT UPDATE WOULD BE IN
2027.
AND THIS WOULD REQUIRE THEM TO
INCLUDE
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION
IN THAT NEXT SCHEDULED SCOPING
PLAN.
THE BILL DOES NOT SPECIFY
PARTICULAR
ASPECTS OF INDUSTRIAL
DECARBONISATION THAT THEY HAVE
TO TAKE UP,
BUT RATHER IT JUST ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT AS
WE ARE MOVING TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS FROM
OUR ELECTRICITY SECTOR BECAUSE
WE ARE
INCREASING RENEWABLE GENERATION,
AND AS WE ARE REDUCING EMISSIONS
FROM OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR BECAUSE WE ARE MOVING OFF
OF FOSSIL FUELS,
THEN THE INDUSTRIAL SECTOR, AND
THESE ARE THINGS
LIKE CEMENT AND OTHERS, THEIR
EMISSIONS GO UP.
SO IT'S JUST TO BRING THAT
ATTENTION TO ARB,
TO ASK THEM TO INCORPORATE THAT
IN THEIR SCOPING PLAN.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE, SENATOR GROVE.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT.
UM, THE COMMENTS THAT WE ARE
TRANSITIONING
OFF OF FOSSIL FUELS ARE JUST
INCORRECT.
WE CONSUME 1.8
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
WE'RE JUST GETTING THEM FROM
COUNTRIES LIKE IRAQ,
ECUADOR, SAUDI ARABIA, RUSSIA.
AND I JUST WANT YOU TO THINK
ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THE POLICIES THAT COME OUT OF
THIS,
UH, THIS BUILDING.
I MEAN, OUR POLICIES CREATE
GLOBAL PROBLEMS
AND INSECURITIES WHEN IT COMES
TO
THE DOMESTIC ENERGY PRODUCTION
THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT CARBON
EMISSIONS,
WHICH THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS
CARB
TO REDUCE IN THE SCOPING PLAN,
WE RECENTLY REQUESTED SOME
INFORMATION FROM
CARB BECAUSE WE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE,
UH, BUNKER FUEL ON THESE SHIPS
THAT BRING
THESE THIS OIL PRODUCT THAT WE
USE EVERY
SINGLE DAY FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES INTO THIS
STATE AND OFFLOAD THEM ON OUR
PORTS.
UM, CARB GAVE US SOME MINUSCULE,
I THINK IT WAS 7 MILLION METRIC
TONS.
AND WE KNOW THAT IT TAKES
APPROXIMATELY 126
MILLION METRIC TONS TO BRING A
SHIP HERE.
SO WE ASKED THEM WHY WE ARE NOT.
THIS WAS NOT ACCURATE
INFORMATION
AND WHERE THEY WERE GETTING IT.
WE WERE INFORMED THAT THEY JUST
TAKE
THE WORD OF THE FOREIGN
OPERATOR.
SO WHOEVER'S BRINGING US THAT
PRODUCT
THAT WE USE EVERY DAY,
THEY JUST TAKE THE WORD OF THE
CARBON EMISSIONS
THAT THEY SPEW HUNDREDS OF
MILES,
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF MILES
ACROSS OUR ECOSYSTEM
TO BRING US THE OIL THAT WE
NEED.
AND THEN THEY ALSO ONLY COUNT 12
MILES OFF OUR COASTLINE SO THEY
DON'T EVEN COUNT POINT OF ORIGIN
TO POINT OF DESTINATION.
SO IF YOU'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
THE CARBON EMISSIONS
REDUCTION AND INQUIRING AND
HAVING CARB DO
A TRUE TRADITIONAL SCOPING PLAN
ON THE TRUE CARBON
EMISSIONS THAT CALIFORNIA IS
ACTUALLY, UM,
ACTUALLY PRODUCING BECAUSE OF
THEIR IMPORT POLICIES
AND THE COST OF IMPORTING THAT
WHICH ADDS TO EVERY
DOLLAR OF OR EVERY GALLON OF GAS
THAT WE SELL IN
THIS STATE FOR IMPORT AND
TRANSPORTATION COST.
IT'S WE NEED TO DO A SCOPING
PLAN OR INSTRUCT
CARB TO HAVE THE CORRECT AND
PROPER DATA.
THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
CORRECT AND PROPER DATA
OF WHAT THESE POLICIES CREATE IN
THIS STATE.
IT DOES NOT.
IT IS NOT TRUE DATA WHEN THEY
PRODUCE THIS SCOPING PLAN.
BECAUSE IF IT WAS TRUE DATA, YOU
WOULD INCORPORATE
ALL OF THESE CARBON EMISSIONS
THAT ARE BEING CREATED BY
POLICIES
THAT GET OUT OF THIS BUILDING.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
UM, APOLOGIES THAT I, UH,
MADE THE REFERENCE TO TRANSITION
OFF
FOSSIL FUELS TO PROMPT THE
PARTICULAR,
UH, FLOOR DEBATE.
BUT, UM, THIS BILL DOES NOT
ADDRESSING THAT.
IT IS RATHER ADDRESSING, UM,
THE INDUSTRIAL PROCESSES LIKE
CEMENT MANUFACTURE,
FOOD PROCESSING AND OTHERS AND
ASKING ARB TO
INCLUDE THOSE IN THE UPDATED
SCOPING PLAN.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY.
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR
I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY.
DODD.
BARROSO.
I, EGGMAN.
I.
GLASER.
I GONZALEZ I GROVE, NO OR DATO.
I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NILO.
PATROL BOAT.
PADILLA.
I PORTENTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO I CIERTO NO
SKINNER I SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBER I WAHAB I
WEINER.
I WOKE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
DOLLY.
DONE.
I.
WHEN?
NO.
NILO.
ATROPOS.
WORLK.
EYES 31.
NOSE FIVE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM 132 129 129.
SENATOR BECKER IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 942 BY SENATOR
BECKER.
AN ACT RELATING TO CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
SEN.
BECKER.
&GT;&GT; I THANK YOU.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 942.
THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA
ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TRANSPARENCY ACT.
A BILL TAKES AN IMPORTANT STEP
TO ADDRESSING
THE PROLIFERATION OF AI
GENERATED CONTENT.
AS AI TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES,
DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN HUMAN AND
MACHINE
GENERATED CONTENT IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY CHALLENGING,
AND THIS AMBIGUITY POSES
SIGNIFICANT SOCIETAL RISKS,
INCLUDING DISINFORMATION,
HARASSMENT, AND FRAUD.
WE ALL KNOW ABOUT RECENT
DEEPFAKE INCIDENTS,
INCLUDING CLONED VOICEMAILS OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN,
HIGHLIGHTING HOW EASILY THIS CAN
BE USED FOR
HARASSMENT OR POLITICAL
MANIPULATION.
THERE'S A FAMILY IN MY DISTRICT.
THEY GOT A CALL, THEY THOUGHT IT
WAS FROM THEIR SON,
AND THEY TALKED TO HIM FOR A
LONG TIME.
HE GOT IN A CAR ACCIDENT.
THEY PUT THE LAWYERS ON THE
PHONE.
THEY WIRED BAIL MONEY.
IT TURNS OUT IT WASN'T HIM AT
ALL.
SO WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS AND
CLEARLY
TRANSPARENCY IS NEEDED.
THIS BILL IS IN SYNC WITH THE
RECENT EU AI ACT,
AND IT SERVES TO ADDRESS THE
AMBIGUITY
BY DOING THREE THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, LABEL AI GENERATED
CONTENT WITH VISIBLE
AND IMPERCEPTIBLE EMBEDDED
DISCLOSURES.
NUMBER TWO SUPPLY AN AI
DETECTION TOOL FOR USERS
TO QUERY WHERE THE CONTENT WAS
CREATED BY AI.
AND THIRD, ENFORCE THIRD PARTY
LICENSEES
TO THE EXTENT TECHNICALLY
FEASIBLE TO PREVENT UNDISCLOSED
CONTENT PUBLICATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY DISCUSSION ON ITEM 129?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY, I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER, I.
BLAKE.
SPEER.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ.
DALY.
DAD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN.
GLASER.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
POTATO.
UH.
JONES.
LAYERED.
A LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
I MEAN, JABBAR, I MEAN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NILO I OKOBO.
BY PURDUE.
I PORTENTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SATO.
SKINNER, I SMILED QUAVERS.
I STERN I UMMER.
I WAHAB.
I.
WINNER.
I WOKE?
NO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
DOLLY.
EGGMAN.
GLASER.
I.
GROWTH.
JONES.
WHEN SUHARTO.
AYES 32 NOES.
ONE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR PORTENTINO, ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR FIVE ON 132?
HE IS SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 971 BY SENATOR
PORTENTINO.
AN ACT RELATING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
SENATOR.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
SADLY, WE KNOW THERE ARE A
NUMBER
OF REGIONAL MILITARY CONFLICTS
AROUND THE GLOBE DISPLACING
THOUSANDS OF REFUGEES.
MY OWN DISTRICT HAS BEEN QUITE
AFFECTED
BY THE 90,000 TO 100,000
REFUGEES FROM ARTSAKH WHO HAVE
HAD
TO FLEE THEIR HOME COUNTRIES.
I WAS RECENTLY INVITED TO A
PROGRAM
AT GLENDALE COLLEGE,
WHERE THE STUDENTS WERE RAISING
MONEY
TO PAY FOR THE COLLEGE EDUCATION
OF SOME OF THE REFUGEE STUDENTS
WHO HAVE COME TO GLENDALE.
AND LATER AFTER THAT, UH, VERY,
VERY POWERFUL EXPERIENCE OF
SEEING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
GIVING BACK TO THEIR COMPATRIOTS
FROM ARTSAKH
TO HELP STUDENTS GET EDUCATED.
I WAS APPROACHED BY THE COLLEGE
TO SAY,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHY DON'T WE ALLOW THESE
REFUGEES TO ATTEND COLLEGE
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN-STATE
TUITION RATES?
AND SO SO THIS BILL AS IT LEFT
THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HAS ONE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE
IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF OUR
STATE,
ONE IN THE CENTRAL PART OF OUR
AND ONE IN THE NORTHERN PART OF
OUR STATE,
TO TRY TO SEE IF WE
CAN PROVIDE THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY
TO THESE REFUGEES.
I STRONGLY, AGAIN, I APPRECIATE
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WERE SO,
UH,
ALTRUISTIC IN THEIR APPROACH TO
LIFE
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
&GT;&GT; ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEE NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL I.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS I.
BECKER I.
BLAKE.
SPERM.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ.
DALY.
NO.
DODD.
I THOUGHT I.
NACHMAN GLASER I.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
RIDOTTO I JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I NAMEMY I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I.
MEN I.
NEWMAN.
I.
WAYNE.
NILO.
NO KOBO.
I.
PADILLA I.
PORTANTINO I.
ROTH, I.
RUBIO.
I KNOW SKINNER.
SMALL QUAVERS.
I STERNE, I UMBER.
HI, WAHAB.
I WIENER I WILK I.
HE'S CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN DURAZZO I EGGMAN, I GROVE
WIN.
SKINNER I.
ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 4.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 133.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 977 BY
SENATOR LAIRD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 977 BY SENATOR
LAIRD.
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS.
SENATOR LAIRD.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR.
PRESIDENT.
SENATE BILL 977 WILL ESTABLISH
AN INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY FOR THE FIVE COUNTY
SUPERVISORIAL SEATS
THAT MAKE UP THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
WE HAVE TAKEN RECENT TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS
THAT CLARIFY INCLUSION OF ALL
THE ELECTIONS CODE SECTION
21130,
IN REGARD TO THE FAIR MAPS ACT,
TO ENSURE DISTRICTS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY
EQUAL IN POPULATION ADOPTED
BOUNDARIES THAT COMPLY WITH
THE CONSTITUTIONS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE UNITED STATES AND
THE FEDERAL VOTING RIGHTS ACT,
AND THAT THE COMMISSION REPORT
ON
ITS DECISIONS WITHIN 21 DAYS.
THE COMMISSION IS CREATED IN
ALIGNMENT
WITH OTHER REDISTRICTING
COMMISSIONS,
SUCH AS THOSE IN THE COUNTIES OF
LOS ANGELES AND SACRAMENTO.
THIS IS A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
CENTRAL
COAST LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
THE BILL, SUPPORTED BY THE
COUNTY
OF SAN LUIS OBISPO AND AFSCME.
THERE'S NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR LAIRD, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY.
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLY KNOW DODD I DURAZZO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROVE KNOW HURTADO I JONES
KNOW LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR MEN I NEWMAN I WIN
KNOW NILA KNOW.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH
I RUBIO SOURTOE KNOW SKINNER
I SMILED CUEVAS I STERN I UMMAR
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN MENGIBAR I OKOBO NO RUBIO
I.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8.
THE MEASURE CARRIES MEMBERS.
HERE'S THE PROGRAM AHEAD.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR GOOD WORK TODAY.
A LOT OF SERIOUS ISSUES THAT
WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS AND ACT UPON ON CALL.
THE PLAN NOW IS TO TAKE BILLS
OFF OF CALL.
SO WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT TO GET
EVERYTHING LINED UP FOR BILLS
OFF OF CALL.
WE'D LIKE TO ASK ALL THE MEMBERS
TO RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
BE AT YOUR DESKS REQUIRES A LOT
OF ATTENTION
TO GO THROUGH SO MANY BILLS
THAT ARE ON CALL THAT WE CAN WE
CAN
RESOLVE BEFORE THE DINNER BREAK.
OKAY, MEMBERS, WE'RE READY
TO PULL BILLS OFF OF CALL.
HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW HOW TO FIND
YOUR BILLS THAT YOU'RE NOT ON
AND YOUR COMPUTER THERE THAT CAN
CAN CREATE THAT LIST FOR YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO GO FAIRLY
QUICKLY.
SO WE NEED EVERYBODY'S
ATTENTION.
I'D LIKE TO ASK ALL
CONVERSATIONS TO CEASE
WHILE WE TAKE THESE BILLS OFF OF
CALL.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH WITH
FILE ITEM 35.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1280.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I DALY.
DODD.
GLASER.
I I MCGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR I METRO BOGUE.
NO.
PORTANTINO I RUBIO I UMBERG I.
DODD I MEAN I TO NO.
DALY.
NO.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO DO
THIS ONCE,
BUT WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE
SECRETARY THIS TIME
TO TO CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME.
JUST.
ALAN.
THAT'S RIGHT.
JUST SAY.
ALAN.
&GT;&GT; EVERYBODY VOTED.
ALLEN ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 7.
THE MEASURE CARRIES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 38.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1140 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN.
DOLLY GLASER I I GROVE.
MCGUIRE.
WAYNE.
NO.
NIELLO.
RUBIO, I UMBERG I.
ALL RIGHT, WELL, I BROKE MY
RULE.
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT ONE MORE
TIME.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN.
DALLY.
NO.
GROVE, NO MCGUIRE, I.
ALL RIGHT, I VOTED 32 TO 7.
THE MEASURE CARRIES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 39,
SB 904 BY SENATOR DODD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL GLASER I I MAGUIRE I MIN.
RUBIO I UMBERG I.
ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 8, THE
MEASURE CARRIES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 40 BY SENATOR BECKER.
SB 1018.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ELLEN BRADFORD.
DODD, I.
GLASER, I.
I.
HURTADO, I.
MAGUIRE I.
BUT HERE I AM.
I.
MEASURE CARRIES 30 TO 8.
MEASURE PASSES 30 TO 8.
IT'S GOING TO BE IN MY
EVALUATION.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM.
42.
THIS IS SB 1341.
EXCUSE ME, THIS IS SB 1249 BY
SENATOR ROTH.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO.
DELHI.
GLASER I I.
GROVE.
MAGUIRE I WHEN?
NILO.
OJOBO.
BUT YEAH, I.
SUHARTO.
HAMBURG I.
WILK.
ALL RIGHT.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 0.
EXCUSE ME.
ALL RIGHT, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DOWN.
I'LL RODA-GIL.
DELHI GROVE.
WHEN?
NILO.
PATROL BOAT I.
SEE ALSO.
WELK.
ALL RIGHT.
ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM 42.
THIS IS SB 1337 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN CABALLERO.
I.
DODD.
GLASER.
MAGUIRE I.
RUBIO.
I.
LUMBERGH I.
ON A VOTE OF 28 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 43 BY SENATOR HURTADO.
THIS IS SB 1367.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DOWN.
GLASER, I I.
MCGUIRE I.
UMBERG, I.
ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
I'M GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 46.
THIS IS SB 1184 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ALAN.
GLASER, I I.
MCGUIRE, I.
UMBERG I.
A VOTE OF 39 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 47 BY SENATOR
MINH 1174.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GLASER, I I.
MCGUIRE, I.
UMBERG I.
ON A VOTE OF 3830 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 52.
THIS IS SB 1210 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
OR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL.
GLASER, I.
I.
GROVE.
NO.
JONES.
MAGUIRE I NILO I.
OKOBO I.
UMBERG I.
ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 5.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 53.
THIS IS SB 1211 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
BECKER.
GLASER I.
MCGUIRE.
I.
PORTANTINO.
ALL RIGHT.
ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 8, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 56 BY SENATOR
WILK, 1495.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLAN GLASER I, I.
MCGUIRE.
I MEAN.
RUBIO A.
SMALL QUAVERS.
SMALL CREVICE I.
ALL RIGHT.
ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM 57.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 898 BY,
EXCUSE ME, 45.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
FIRST BEGIN WITH 45.
SENATE FILE ITEM 45.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 940 BY
SENATOR UMBERG.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN BRADFORD.
DUD I.
GLASER.
I I.
GROVE.
NO.
JONES.
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
I RUBIO.
GUY WIENER I.
BRADFORD I ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 57.
THIS IS SB 898 BY SENATOR
SKINNER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND I'LL GO.
NO.
CABALLERO.
I.
DUD.
GLASER.
ODOARDO.
GUY MCGUIRE.
I PORTANTINO.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
STERN.
WIENER I.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME.
ELLEN DODD.
GLASER.
BORN DINO ROTH RUBIO.
RUBIO I STERN I.
ON A VOTE OF 26 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 58.
THIS IS SB 1350 BY SENATOR
DURAZO SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLAN GLASER, I I.
MCGUIRE.
I RUBIO.
I.
WIENER I.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 64.
THIS IS SB 1137 BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
DOLLY.
GLASER, I.
GROVE.
MCGUIRE, I.
NILO.
A JO'BURG.
RUBIO I.
WINNER.
I.
DALLY?
NO.
GROVE?
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 6.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT UP, FILE ITEM
44.
THIS IS SB 1170 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
CABALLERO.
I DOD.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
I.
MCGUIRE, A DOD.
I PORTANTINO.
BY RUBIO, A SMALL CUEVAS.
I WIENER.
I.
I VOTE OF 31 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 59.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1103 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO.
NO.
ARCHULETA.
BLAKE SPEAR.
BRADFORD.
CORTAZZI.
GLASER.
MCGUIRE.
I.
NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
I SMILED CUEVAS I WIENER.
I THOUGHT, I DON'T KNOW.
ON A VOTE OF 22 TO 10.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 65 BY
SENATOR BECKER.
THIS IS SB 1223.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
DARLIN.
I'LL GO.
I.
CORTAZZI.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I.
WHICH HOBO I RUBIO I CIERTO.
WIENER I.
WILK I.
ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
AND THEN MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
66.
THIS IS SB 1224 BY SENATOR OCHOA
BOGH.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ELLEN MAGUIRE WINNER.
MAGUIRE II WINNER.
I.
A VOTE OF 39 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 63 BY SENATOR
WEINER.
THIS IS SB 1037.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL ARCHULETA.
BECKER.
GLASER.
LEMON.
MCGUIRE.
NEWMAN.
NO.
GORDON, GINO.
RUBIO.
GLASER I.
A VOTE OF 23 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP HIGHLIGHT OF 85 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
THIS IS SB 1045.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN DULLI.
MCGUIRE.
RUBIO.
I.
DOLLY?
NO.
SMALL QUAVERS.
I.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 7.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 88.
THIS IS SB 1066 BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN BRADFORD.
DUD I, EGGMAN.
I.
MAGUIRE.
RUBIO.
I.
BRADFORD I.
ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 89.
THIS IS SB 1094 BY SENATOR
LIEBERMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN.
BRADFORD.
DOLLY.
EGGMAN.
HI.
BRADFORD, I.
GROVE.
NO.
MAGUIRE.
WIN.
NO.
RUBIO.
I WAHAB I.
ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 4.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 93.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1142 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER.
HI, DOLLY.
NO!
EGGMAN!
I GROVE.
NO JONES, NO.
MAGUIRE.
WAYNE.
NO.
NEELO.
OKOBO.
RUBIO.
HIGH ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 8.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
94.
THIS IS SB 1178 BY SENATOR
PADILLA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN CORTEZ, A EGGMAN.
I GROVE.
NO.
MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I WIN?
NO, RUBIO.
I SMILED CUEVAS.
I.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
I'M GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
95.
THIS IS SB 1213 BY SENATOR
ATKINS.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN EGGMAN.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I.
NEWMAN I RUBIO.
I SMILED CUEVAS I.
ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0 THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
I MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 96 BY
SENATOR MINH.
THIS IS SB 1221.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW AND I'LL RODA-GIL KNOW
ARCHULETA I.
EGGMAN.
GONZALEZ.
GROVE?
NO.
HURTADO.
I MAGUIRE, MENGIBAR.
I RUBIO.
I SMALL CUEVAS.
I UMBERG.
I.
ON A VOTE OF 27 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT WE'LL TAKE UP FILE ITEM 90.
THIS IS SB 1116 BY SENATOR
PORTENTINO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
GROVE.
NO.
MCGUIRE.
MAIN.
BUT I.
RUBIO.
XTERM.
UMBERG WAHAB I.
SHOULD WE DO A CALL?
SENATOR PORTENTINO MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP FILE.IT OF 97 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN.
THIS IS SB 1238.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN CABALLERO I EGGMAN, I
MAGUIRE, I RUBIO.
HIGH ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 98.
THIS IS SB 1255 BY SENATOR
DURAZZO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ASHBY I DALLY.
NO.
MCGUIRE.
I.
WAYNE.
NO.
UMBERG.
NIGH ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 6.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, THIS IS SENATE BILL
1380,
FILE ITEM 185 BY SENATOR DODD.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ASHBY.
ATKINS.
BECKER, BLAKE.
SPEER.
BRADFORD CABALLERO EGMUND
GLASER.
NO.
LAIRD.
LEMON.
MENGIBAR.
NEWMAN.
PORTENTINO BRAD RUBIO.
STERNE.
WIENER.
ON A VOTE OF 13 TO 10.
THE MEASURE FAILS.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM ONE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 117.
THIS IS SB 1500 BY SENATOR
TERRAZZO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN HURTADO.
A.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
118.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 951 BY
SENATOR WIENER.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER HURTADO, A LEMONY.
PORTANTINO.
BECKER, I.
IT'S CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ONE LAST TIME.
ALLAN.
LEMONY.
PORTANTINO.
ALL RIGHT.
ON A VOTE OF 37 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILL OUT OF 121.
THIS IS SB 1202 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
HURTADO, I.
SKINNER.
I.
ON A VOTE OF 39 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
ONE LAST MEASURE ON CALL.
THIS IS FILE 127.
SB 934, BY SENATOR GONZALEZ.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ELLEN DOLLY.
GLASER.
GROVE OR DOTTO?
I WIN.
NILO.
OCHOA.
PORTENTINO I.
GLASER, I.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 3.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM 90.
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM 90.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BECKER.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
MCGUIRE I MEAN ROTH.
RUBIO I STERN.
BRADFORD.
I HAMBURG.
ON A VOTE OF 22 TO 12, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS.
UM.
FANTASTIC WORK.
TODAY.
WE ARE WELL ON OUR WAY TO TO
COMPLETING 110 BILLS,
WHICH IS OUR GOAL FOR THE
EVENING.
WE'RE GOING TO BE BREAKING
FOR 45 MINUTES FOR DINNER.
WE'D ASK THAT NO MEMBERS LEAVE
THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS TO STAY HERE, PLEASE.
DINNER WILL BE PROVIDED.
PLEASE DO NOT RETURN TO YOUR
OFFICES.
SO WE'RE IN RECESS FOR 45
MINUTES.
WE SHOULD BE BACK HERE AT SIX
3630.
WE'LL BE BACK IN SESSION.
MEMBERS, WE'RE IN RECESS.
THE SENATE WILL CONVENE IN 30S.
THE SENATE WILL BE BACK FROM
RECESS IN 30S.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WELCOME
BACK.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
THIRD READING.
LET ME MAKE A COUPLE OF MENTIONS
BEFORE WE GET TO THIRD READING.
WE HAVE COMPLETED 75 BILLS THUS
FAR TODAY.
CAN I GET A YEEHAW?
I WAS DOING THAT.
I WAS TRYING TO CHANNEL THE PRO
TEM THERE.
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO WORK THE
FILE THIS EVENING
UNTIL WE DISPENSE WITH A TOTAL
OF 110 BILLS.
NOW, EVERYBODY HAS A GOAL THAT
WE CAN WORK TOWARDS.
UH.
THE MORE WORK WE DO TODAY,
THE EARLIER WILL MAKE OUR WORK
WEEK LATER.
SO THAT HOPEFULLY IT GIVES SOME
ENTHUSIASM TO
OUR WORK THAT WE'RE GOING TO NOW
BEGIN WITH.
SENATOR WAHAB, IS THE FIRST BILL
UP.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 984, FILE
ITEM 134.
THE SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 984 BY SENATOR
WAHAB,
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS.
SENATOR WAHAB, KICK US OFF HERE
IN THE EVENING SESSION.
&GT;&GT; UH.
THANK YOU.
GIVE ME TWO SECONDS.
SORRY.
ALL RIGHT.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 984 PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS.
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS PROVIDE
PROPER COMPENSATION, BENEFITS,
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS,
INCLUDING WOMEN, VETERANS,
BIPOC,
AND JUVENILE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS
IN OUR CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE.
SB 984 REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY
AND THE CALIFORNIA COURTS TO
IDENTIFY
THREE MAJOR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS TO BE
GOVERNED BY A PLA BEGINNING IN
2029.
SB 984 WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES
TO REPORT PROGRESS OF COMMUNITY
BENEFIT GOALS,
APPRENTICESHIPS AND PROJECT
LABOR
AGREEMENTS ON THEIR PROJECTS.
SB 984 ENSURES THAT THE STATE'S
INVESTMENTS
IN PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
ARE PROTECTED FROM COSTLY DELAYS
AND PROMOTE HIGH QUALITY JOBS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WAHAB.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEMBERS ON
THIS MEASURE.
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I'LL RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR I.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLY.
NO.
DODD I DORADO I.
EGGMAN.
NO.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
HURTADO I.
JONES.
NO, NO, LAIRD I NAMEMY.
MAGUIRE.
I MEAN, JABBAR, I MEAN I NEWMAN,
I WIN.
NO NEELO, NO OKOBO, NO PADILLA I
PORTANTINO.
ROD A RUBIO.
SATO.
NO, SKINNER A SMALL QUAVERS.
STERN I.
UMBER I.
WAHAB, I.
WIENER.
WORLK I.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
WE DO HAVE A FULL HOUSE, SO
WE'RE NOT
PLANNING TO PUT ANYTHING ON
CALL.
UH, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO.
NO GROVE, NO LEMON.
I PORTANTINO.
I RUBIO.
I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
WIENER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS.
COLIN SMALLWOOD QUIVERS I.
WIENER.
ON A VOTE OF 28 TO 10.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM 135.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1016 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1016 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
AN ACT RELATING TO DATA
COLLECTION.
SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB 1016,
WHICH WILL HELP UNCOVER TRENDS
AND DISPARITIES
THAT ARE OFTEN HIDDEN IN
AGGREGATED HEALTH DATA
FOR LATINOS AND INDIGENOUS
MESOAMERICANS.
THESE DISTINCTIONS HIDE IN
THE MONOLITHIC TERM OF LATINO,
WHICH LEADS TO LESS DETAILED
AND NUANCED HEALTH INFORMATION.
SB 1016 WILL ADDRESS THESE
SHORTCOMINGS BY
REQUIRING THAT EACH DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO COLLECT AND RELEASE
DISAGGREGATED
DATA FOR SPECIFIED LATINO
SUBGROUPS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
OF SB 1016.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GONZALEZ.
DOES ANY SENATOR WISH TO BE
HEARD ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ I DALLY.
DAD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
OR DODO I.
JONES.
LAIRD I.
NIMAN.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I.
MEN.
NEWMAN.
I.
WHEN I KNEEL, I BOW.
PEDDUR ARE UPON.
I.
I RUBIO I CIERTO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL.
STARTING.
I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS?
ALAN DARLEY.
GROVE.
JONES.
MCGUIRE.
I.
MAKOTO SATO, SMALL CREVICE I.
ON A VOTE OF 34 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT STEP.
FILE ITEM 136.
THIS IS SB 1032 BY SENATOR
PADILLA.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1032 BY SENATOR
PADILLA.
AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING.
SENATOR PADILLA.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, SB 1032 WOULD
PROVIDE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WITH THE AUTHORITY
TO
FORGIVE LOANS PROVIDED TO
HOUSING
PROVIDERS IF THE LOANS ARE
IMPEDING
THE BORROWER'S ABILITY TO
MAINTAIN
AND OPERATE PROJECTS FOR
AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OR SENIOR HOUSING.
IN THE 1980S AND 1990S,
HCD PROVIDED SEVERAL LOAN
PROGRAMS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVIDERS TO PRESERVE
EXISTING
UNITS ACROSS THE STATE.
WHILE IT WAS EASY TO OBTAIN THE
LOAN,
REPAYING THEM HAS PROVEN MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT.
THE PREMISE WAS THAT HOUSING
DEVELOPERS
WOULD BE ABLE TO REPAY LOAN
BALANCE
THROUGH HIGH PROFITS MADE ON
AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
HOWEVER, THERE IS OFTEN LITTLE
TO NO PROFIT TO BE MADE
AND PROVIDERS FIND THEMSELVES
CARRYING LONG TERM DEBT.
SB 1032 WILL HELP ADDRESS
THE HOUSING SHORTAGE BY ALLOWING
PERMISSIVELY HCD TO FORGIVE
THESE LOANS TO HELP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROVIDERS
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AND GET
MORE ACCESS TO CAPITAL UNDER
SPECIFIC CONDITIONS.
THIS IS CRITICAL FOR MANY OF THE
HOUSING AGENCIES
THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
LOAN FORGIVENESS.
SERVE AS THE MAIN OR SOLE
AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVIDER IN THEIR
REGION.
THE BILL WILL MAINTAIN
THE AFFORDABILITY OF THE UNITS
AND INCREASE ACCESS TO CAPITAL
SO THE DEVELOPERS
CAN MAINTAIN THE SUPPLY THEY
ALREADY
OPERATE AND POTENTIALLY
BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR PADILLA.
ANY MEMBER WISHES WISHES TO
BE HEARD ON THIS MEASURE.
ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA.
I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKE.
SPEER.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ.
DALY.
NO.
DODD, I.
DURAZZO.
I, EGGMAN.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
FURTADO.
I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD, I.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NEELO.
I BET YOU I PONTINO I RAAD.
RUBIO.
I SAY NO.
SKINNER.
I SMALL QUAVERS.
I STERN.
HI, AMBER.
HI, WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN GROVE.
NO.
BROUGHT.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 7.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 139.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1047 BY
SENATOR WEINER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1047 BY SENATOR
WIENER.
AN ACT RELATING TO ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
SENATOR WIENER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
&GT;&GT; I THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR.
PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1047.
THIS LEGISLATION HAS TWO MAIN
GOALS
PROMOTING THE RESPONSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT OF FRONTIER
ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE MODELS LARGE,
VERY POWERFUL MODELS, AND ALSO
SUPPORTING
COMPETITION AND INNOVATION IN
AI.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE HAS
ENORMOUS
POTENTIAL TO BENEFIT CALIFORNIA,
OUR NATION, AND THE ENTIRE WORLD
IN SO MANY WAYS.
AT THE SAME TIME, SCIENTISTS,
ENGINEERS,
AND BUSINESS LEADERS AT THE
FOREFRONT
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY,
INCLUDING TWO OF THE MOST CITED
MACHINE LEARNING
RESEARCHERS OF ALL TIME WHO
SUPPORT THIS BILL,
HAVE REPEATEDLY WARNED POLICY
MAKERS THAT FAILURE TO TAKE
APPROPRIATE PRECAUTIONS COULD
HAVE SEVERE CONSEQUENCES.
WITH CONGRESS NOT MOVING
FORWARD,
AND WITH THE FUTURE OF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN DOUBT,
CALIFORNIA HAS AN INDISPENSABLE
ROLE TO PLAY IN ENSURING THAT
WE DEVELOP THIS EXTREMELY
POWERFUL
TECHNOLOGY WITH BASIC
SAFETY GUARDRAILS SO THAT WE CAN
ALLOW SOCIETY
TO EXPERIENCE AI'S SIGNIFICANT,
MASSIVE BENEFITS IN A SAFE WAY.
SB 1047 SETS OUT CLEAR STANDARDS
FOR DEVELOPERS
OF EXTREMELY POWERFUL AI
SYSTEMS.
SYSTEMS THAT MEET THE BILL'S
THRESHOLD WOULD CURRENTLY
COST MORE THAN $100 MILLION TO
TRAIN,
AND WOULD BE SUBSTANTIALLY MORE
POWERFUL
THAN ANY SYSTEM THAT EXISTS
TODAY.
SPECIFICALLY, SB 1047 CLARIFIES
THAT DEVELOPERS
OF THESE MODELS MUST TAKE BASIC
PRECAUTIONS
SUCH AS PRE-DEPLOYMENT SAFETY
TESTING
AND CYBERSECURITY PROTECTIONS.
THE BILL ALSO HELPS ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA
REMAINS THE WORLD LEADER IN AI
INNOVATION,
OF WHICH WE SHOULD ALL BE PROUD
BY
ESTABLISHING A PROCESS TO CREATE
A PUBLIC CLOUD COMPUTING CLUSTER
CALLED
CAL COMPUTE THAT WILL CONDUCT
RESEARCH
INTO THE SAFE AND SECURE
DEPLOYMENT
OF LARGE SCALE AI MODELS.
IN RESPONSE TO FEEDBACK FROM KEY
STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE OPEN SOURCE AND STARTUP
COMMUNITIES,
I CONTINUE TO MAKE A COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE SOLICITING
AND INCORPORATING CONSTRUCTIVE
FEEDBACK AS THIS BILL,
I HOPE, MOVES OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY
TO ENSURE THAT ONLY THE TRULY
LARGEST AND MOST POWERFUL MODELS
ARE AFFECTED BY THE BILL.
THAT WHICH HAS ALWAYS BEEN OUR
INTENT.
WE HAVE THE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL
FROM A NUMBER OF AI STARTUPS,
FROM THE LOS ANGELES CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE,
FROM AI SAFETY ORGANIZATIONS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER.
IS THERE A MEMBER OF THE SENATE
THAT
WANTS TO BE HEARD ON THIS
MEASURE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I'LL RODA-GIL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ I DALLY.
DODD.
I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO, I.
JONES.
LAIRD I NAMEMY.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
MEN I KNEW MEN.
HI, WAYNE.
NILO.
A JOB.
PEDDUR.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I CIERTO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL QUAVERS.
I STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT.
MEMBERS?
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
DOLLY.
JONES MENGIBAR I.
WHEN?
NILO OKOBO I SATO.
AYES 32.
NOES ONE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
141.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1053 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1053 BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR.
AN ACT RELATING TO SOLID WASTE.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1053,
WHICH WILL FINALLY ELIMINATE
THOSE THICK PLASTIC
FILM BAGS THAT WE SEE AT GROCERY
STORES
TO CARRY HOME OUR GROCERIES.
IT WAS A DECADE AGO WHEN THIS
VERY BODY PASSED SB 270,
AND VOTERS VOTED TO APPROVE,
MAKING CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
STATE TO
PHASE OUT SINGLE USE PLASTIC
BAGS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, A LOOPHOLE
IN THE DEFINITION OF REUSABLE
AND RECYCLABLE OPENED THE DOOR
TO THICKER PLASTIC BAGS,
WHICH ARE IMPOSSIBLE TO RECYCLE
IN ANY FACILITY IN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS CLEAR FROM THE DATA THAT
WE HAVE FALLEN SHORT.
WE HAVE SEEN A 47% INCREASE IN
ANNUAL
PLASTIC BAG WASTE INTO OUR
LANDFILLS
SINCE THE ORIGINAL LAW WAS
PASSED IN 2014,
COMPARED TO 2022.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE AND WHY SB
1053 IS IMPORTANT TO
ADDRESS THIS PLASTIC WASTE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
GLOBALLY, WE USE AN ESTIMATED 5
TRILLION PLASTIC BAGS A YEAR,
WITH THE AVERAGE AMERICAN USING
ONE PLASTIC BAG A DAY.
A PLASTIC BAG HAS AN AVERAGE
LIFESPAN OF JUST 12 MINUTES,
AND THEN IT IS DISCARDED,
OFTEN CLOGGING SEWAGE DRAINS,
CONTAMINATING OUR DRINKING
WATER,
AND DEGENERATING INTO TINY
MICROPLASTICS THAT FESTER IN
OUR OCEANS AND LANDFILLS.
AND IF WE ONLY ACCOUNT FOR
COASTAL REGIONS ALONE,
SOME £18 BILLION OF PLASTIC
WASTE FLOWS
INTO OUR OCEANS FROM THESE
REGIONS.
THIS IS THE EQUIVALENT OF FIVE
GROCERY BAGS SITTING
ON EVERY FOOT OF COASTLINE
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE DESERVE BETTER AND WE MUST
DEMAND BETTER.
THIS IS NOW A BIPARTISAN EFFORT,
AND INTERNATIONAL PAPER HAS
RECENTLY
COME ON IN SUPPORT.
OUR COALITION OF SUPPORT RANGES
FROM STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS TO THE
GROCERY
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER BUSINESSES
WHO WANT
TO DO BETTER FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR I VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BREAKSPEAR.
I SEE MICROPHONES UP FROM
SENATOR
LEHMAN AND SENATOR DURAZZO.
WILL BEGIN FIRST WITH SENATOR
LEHMAN.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS, I RISE AS A CO-AUTHOR
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1053.
SB 54 WAS INTENDED TO ONLY APPLY
TO SINGLE USE PACKAGING.
THE THICK PLASTIC PLASTIC
GROCERY BAGS AVAILABLE
AT STORES ARE NOT INCLUDED IN SB
54.
FOR THESE THICK PLASTIC BAGS
TO BE USED IN THE STATE,
THEY MUST BE CERTIFIED BY
MULTIPLE USES
AND BE RECYCLED IN CALIFORNIA.
WHILE THESE BAGS ARE LEGALLY
CONSIDERED REUSABLE,
WE KNOW CONSUMERS RARELY RETURN
THEM
TO THE STORE TO USE THEM AGAIN,
AND WE KNOW THEY ARE NOT
RECYCLED.
MANUFACTURERS HAVE ASKED TO
AMEND SB 1053
TO ADD THESE THICK PLASTIC BAGS
TO SB 54,
INSTEAD OF BANNING THEM
OUTRIGHT.
MEMBERS.
WHEN SB 270 PASSED, THE
LEGISLATURE VOTED TO BAN
SINGLE USE PLASTIC BAGS AT
GROCERY STORES.
VOTERS THEN UPHELD THIS POLICY
AT THE BALLOT BOX.
CALIFORNIANS WERE CLEAR IN
ASKING STORES
TO SELL REUSABLE, RECYCLABLE
BAGS.
AFTER TEN YEARS, THESE BAGS HAVE
FAILED ON BOTH ACCOUNTS.
ADDING THESE BAGS TO SB 54 NOW
WOULD DRAW OUT
THE USE OF THESE UNWANTED BAGS
LONGER,
UNDERMINING THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS.
THESE BAGS ARE A CONTAMINANT
IN THE RECYCLING STREAM.
PRECISELY THE TYPE OF MATERIAL
WE
WANT OUT OF THE SYSTEM TO
IMPROVE
THE RECYCLING POTENTIAL OF
TRULY RECYCLABLE MATERIAL.
WE HAVE HAD THESE THICKER BAGS
FOR A DECADE AND THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN COLLECTED AND
RECYCLED SUCCESSFULLY.
WE DON'T NEED TO WAIT ANOTHER
TEN YEARS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LANCMAN.
SENATOR GAROZZO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
WILL THE AUTHOR TAKE A QUESTION?
THE AUTHOR WILL.
OKAY.
SENATOR GAROZZO, PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU.
I JUST WANT TO SAY BEFORE MY
QUESTION THAT I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN
THIS BILL.
THERE'S NO DISAGREEMENT THERE.
UM, WHAT WAS BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION
BY THE GROCERY WORKERS
IS ABOUT THE INFORMATION ON THE
REUSABLE BAG SALES.
UM, AND THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
AGGREGATE
THE INFORMATION PER RETAILER AND
ALSO REMOVE
LOCAL PREEMPTION TO ALLOW
JURISDICTIONS TO
REQUIRE REPORTING OF REUSABLE
BAG SALES.
SO IF YOU COULD RESPOND TO THAT
CONCERN.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
SHAKESPEARE.
YOU MAY RESPOND.
YES.
THANK YOU.
SO THE QUESTION OF WHERE IS THE
$0.10 GOING,
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY THE
QUESTION BEING
POSED TO ME BY MY COLLEAGUE.
UM, I SEE THAT AS A COMPLETELY
UNRELATED
ISSUE TO BANNING PLASTIC BAGS.
SO AT THE GROCERY STORE,
WHEN YOU BUY YOUR GROCERIES,
IF YOU BRING YOUR REUSABLE BAG,
YOU CAN TAKE THEM HOME IN THAT.
OR YOU COULD BUY A TEN CENT
PAPER
BAG AND TAKE THEM HOME.
THIS IS TRADER JOE'S IS ALREADY
DOING THIS.
THE QUESTION OF ELIMINATING
PLASTIC
AS AN OPTION IS UNRELATED
TO THE ISSUE OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THAT $0.10.
I'LL ALSO NOTE THAT THAT WAS A
STANDALONE BILL
LAST YEAR THAT WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
SO INSERTING THAT INTO THIS
BILL,
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY ABOUT
PLASTIC REDUCTION,
IS A POISON PILL THAT WE WERE
UNWILLING TO ACCEPT.
SO, UM, HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS
THE QUESTION.
IT SEEMS TO HAVE SENATOR DROSSOS
MIKE IS DOWN.
I SEE SENATOR DOLLY, UH, TO BE
HEARD.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
SPEAKER.
UH, SPEAKER.
MR.
PRESIDENT, THE OTHER HALF.
EXCUSE ME, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I JUST WANT TO MAYBE ADD A
LITTLE LIGHT TO THIS.
I SAW THIS BILL IN EC AND I WAS
SOMEBODY WHO WAS
I DON'T LIKE PLASTIC BAGS
BLOWING AROUND.
I CARE ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND QUITE FRANKLY, PAPER BAGS
ARE GOOD FOR MY DISTRICT
BECAUSE WE GROW TREES AND PAPER
IS GREAT WITH ME.
BUT WHAT REALLY I THINK
FRUSTRATES
ME ABOUT THE BATTLE
OVER PLASTIC BAGS IS THE MONEY
PART OF IT.
I WAS HAPPEN TO BE IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN
WE HAD THE DEBATE OVER PLASTIC
BAGS,
AND THE GROCERS FOUGHT THE
PLASTIC BAG BAN UNTIL.
THEY GOT TO MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
THEY BUY THE BAGS FOR A COUPLE
CENTS,
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO SELL THEM
AS HIGH AS $0.25,
AND THAT MONEY WENT IN THEIR
POCKET.
AND THEN MY FRIENDS ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL
SIDE SUPPORTED THAT.
IT DIDN'T DO ANYTHING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT,
AND THE MONEY ACTUALLY WENT TO
THE STORE SO THEY COULD PROFIT.
SO FOR ME, I WAS VERY FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO SEE THE BAGS
BLOWING AROUND.
AND I'M ALSO FRUSTRATED WITH MY
FRIENDS ON THE ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE THEY JUST WANT TO DRIVE
THE COST UP.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO IN HOUSING.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO IN ALL KINDS
OF THINGS,
IS JUST DRIVE THE COST UP SO WE
CAN'T AFFORD IT,
AND THAT'S THE ONE WAY OF
STOPPING IT.
SO.
THIS BILL.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS BILL FOR A
MOMENT.
THIS BILL STILL ALLOWS THE
GROCER TO MAKE MONEY
OFF OF THE PAPER BAG AT YOUR
EXPENSE.
THERE'S NO MONEY GOING TO THE
ENVIRONMENT HERE.
AND SO FOR ME, THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
IT'S LIKE, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WE'RE JUST FORCING PEOPLE.
WITH MONEY TO MAKE THE DECISION
INSTEAD OF
DOING THE RIGHT THING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M GOING TO
OPPOSE THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE FROM MEMBERS?
I DON'T SEE ANY MICROPHONES UP.
SENATOR SHAKESPEARE, YOU MAY
CLOSE.
YES.
THANK YOU.
SO TEN YEARS AGO, $0.10
MIGHT HAVE RESULTED IN A PROFIT
FOR GROCERS.
BUT MANY GROCERS SAY THAT BAGS
ARE COSTING MORE THAN $0.10
AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY LOSING
MONEY ON THIS.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT
EVERYTHING IN THAT
GROCERY STORE IS SOLD FOR A
PROFIT.
SO THE IDEA THAT THEY WOULD SELL
A BAG ALONG WITH
SELLING EVERY OTHER ITEM IN THE
GROCERY STORE,
TO ME, IT DOESN'T SEEM AS IF
THAT'S
A REASON TO OPPOSE THIS.
SO OUR HOPE IS THAT MORE PEOPLE
BRING THEIR REUSABLE BAGS.
AND PART OF THE ORIGINAL, UM,
THE ORIGINAL COMPROMISE WAS THAT
THE MONEY WAS BEING USED FOR
EDUCATION.
SO THE MONEY WAS WAS COLLECTED
FROM THE BAGS AND PART
OF IT WAS BEING USED FOR
TRAINING AND EDUCATION.
AND THEN WE HAD COVID HIT AND WE
RETURNED TO USING
SINGLE USE PLASTICS IN MUCH
GREATER NUMBERS.
SO THERE ARE STILL SIGNS AROUND
THESE GROCERY STORES.
IF YOU LOOK THAT SAY BRING YOUR
REUSABLE BAG,
THERE ARE FEWER OF THEM, OF
COURSE,
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN MANY YEARS.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE
GROCERY STORES
ARE OVER DECIDING BETWEEN
PLASTIC AND PAPER.
THEY ARE IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE
IT SIMPLIFIES THEIR LIFE.
THEY'RE ONLY STOCKING ONE TYPE
OF BAG.
SO THE QUESTION OF WHERE IS THAT
$0.10 GOING?
THAT IS A SEPARATE QUESTION,
WHICH I THINK COULD BE A
SEPARATE BILL.
AGAIN, IF SOMEBODY WANTED TO RUN
THAT BILL.
AND THE GOVERNOR, OF COURSE,
VETOED IT,
BUT MAYBE THERE WOULD BE A
DIFFERENT
WAY TO ANALYZE IT.
BUT THIS BILL IS ABOUT PLASTIC
REDUCTION.
THIS BILL IS THERE ARE THERE IS
A GOOD ALTERNATIVE FOR PEOPLE,
WHICH IS PAPER.
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT THE WAY
GROCERY
STORES RUN THEIR BUSINESS.
SO I URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BECAUSE
WE ARE DROWNING IN THE SCOURGE
OF PLASTIC,
AND WE DO NOT NEED TO BE
COLLECTING
SO MANY PLASTIC BAGS THAT ARE
USED
ONLY ONE TIME FOR 12 MINUTES
BEFORE
THEY END UP IN OUR LANDFILLS,
IN OUR OCEAN AND MICROPLASTICS
IN OUR BODIES
AND IN THE MOUNTAINS AND
EVERYWHERE ELSE.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN ALVARADO GILL.
I I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKE SPERM I
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
COURTESY.
DELI?
NO DOD, I THOUGHT OSO.
EGGMAN.
I GLASER I, I.
GONZALEZ.
I.
GROVE.
ODOARDO.
I JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I NIMMO, I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
MILO.
NO.
NO, BUDDY.
I KNOW I BROUGHT.
BY RUBIO.
CIERTO.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE I STERN, I
UMBERG, I WAHAB.
A WINNER.
I WILL.
TIME, PLEASE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN BRADFORD.
CABALLERO, I.
CORTAZZI.
TERRAZZO.
GROVE.
NO.
MCGUIRE.
WHEN NO RUBIO BY.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ABSENT.
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME.
MEMBERS, PLEASE.
PLEASE STAY ENGAGED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN BRADFORD I CORTEZI I
TORRAZZO.
MCGUIRE.
ALL RIGHT.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 7, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 155.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1180 BY
SENATOR ASHBY.
EXCUSE ME.
SENATE BILL 1180.
BUT, SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
BILL.
SENATE BILL 1180 BY SENATOR
ASHBY.
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE.
SENATOR ASHBY.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1180.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
REIMBURSEMENT ACT.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT HEALTH
PLANS ESTABLISH
A PROCESS TO REIMBURSE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES,
SUCH AS COMMUNITY PARAMEDICINE
TRIAGE,
TO ALTERNATE DESTINATIONS AND
MOBILE INTEGRATED
HEALTH FOR OUR EMS PROVIDERS.
IT ALSO REQUIRES MEDI-CAL TO
COVER THESE PROGRAMS.
SB 1180 ENSURES THAT OUR EMS
PROVIDERS
CAN RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR TRANSPORTS TO SOBERING
CENTERS
TO MENTAL HEALTH FACILITIES.
PRIORITIZES APPROPRIATE HEALTH
CARE FOR SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
RECENT AMENDMENTS MAKE THE
BILL'S
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT
CONTINGENT ON FEDERAL APPROVALS
AND APPROPRIATIONS.
I URGE AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ASHBY.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD
ON THIS BILL?
SEEING.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OWEN.
OH, RODRIGO, I ARCHULETA, I
ASHBY,
I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ.
I DALLY, I DIED, I DARAZO I
EGGMAN.
GLASER, I.
GONZALEZ, I.
GROVE.
HIGH OR LOW.
BY JONES.
BY LAIRD.
I LEMONY I MAGUIRE.
MENJIVAR, I MEAN.
UH, NEWMAN, I WIN.
HELLO?
AKOBO.
PEDDUR.
I PORTANTINO.
I, ROD.
HI, RUBIO.
ACIERTO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED.
WAS I STERN?
I UMBERG.
I HAVE A WIENER.
I WILL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
EGGMAN.
RAY MCGUIRE.
WHEN?
NILO MOKHOBO.
SATO.
ON A VOTE OF 34 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 156.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1182 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1182 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
AN ACT RELATING TO SCHOOL
FACILITIES.
SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS,
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB 1182,
WHICH WILL REQUIRE CROSS-AGENCY
COLLABORATION AND COMMUNICATION
ON HOW CALIFORNIA CAN KEEP ITS
SCHOOLS SAFE IN
AN ERA OF EXTREME IMPACTS FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA MAINTAINS OVER
125,000
ACRES OF SCHOOL GROUNDS,
730,000,000FT² OF FACILITY
SPACE,
AND OVER 10,000 SCHOOL
FACILITIES
THAT ARE AMONG OVER 50 YEARS
OLD.
SB 1182 WILL ESTABLISH A
STATEWIDE PLAN THAT WILL
BETTER POSITION CALIFORNIA'S
SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO TACKLE THE GENERATIONAL
CHALLENGE OF TRANSITIONING
TO CLIMATE RESILIENT FACILITIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
ON SB 1182.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GONZALEZ.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD
ON THIS BILL?
SEE.
NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL A ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER
I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
I DALLY.
DUD I DARAZO I EGGMAN.
I.
GLASER.
I GONZALEZ, I GROVE.
OTERO.
JONES I.
LAIRD I.
LEHMAN.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NILO.
A TROUBLED.
I PODIUM, I PORTANTINO.
I ROD I RUBIO I CIERTO.
SKINNER A SMALL.
CUEVAS A STERN.
AYZENBERG.
FOR GOD I WAHAB I WINNER.
I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN DARLEY, I.
GROVE.
I.
RIDOTTO I.
MCGUIRE.
WHEN?
NILO.
SATO.
WOKE A.
LOT.
A VOTE OF 35 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
157.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1188 BY
SENATOR LAIRD.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1188 BY SENATOR
LAIRD.
AN ACT RELATING TO DRINKING
WATER.
SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT.
UH, SENATE BILL 1188 WOULD
REQUIRE
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
DEVELOP AND ADOPT MINIMUM
STANDARDS
RELATED TO TECHNICAL,
MANAGERIAL AND FINANCIAL
CAPACITY OF SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS WITH LESS THAN 3000
CONNECTIONS.
I HAVE A POSTER CHILD FOR THE
REASON THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY IN MY
DISTRICT.
WHEN THE CCU FIRE RIPPED THROUGH
MY DISTRICT AND PARTICULARLY
THE AREA COVERED BY THE BIG
BASIN WATER DISTRICT.
IT CUT OFF ACCESS TO WATER FOR
RESIDENTS.
IT EXACERBATED THE FUNDAMENTAL
FAILINGS WITHIN THE DISTRICT.
RESIDENTS WERE FORCED TO GO
TO TEMPORARY FILL STATIONS
TO ACCESS WATER TO COOK AND
SHOWER WITH.
IT WAS LATER REVEALED THE SYSTEM
DID NOT
KNOW WHERE THEIR SERVICE
TERRITORY WAS,
OR WHO THEIR CUSTOMERS WERE,
OR EVEN HOW TO CONTACT OR BILL
THEIR CUSTOMERS.
DUE TO THIS FAILING FOR THIS ONE
PARTICULAR
WATER SYSTEM, $900,000
WAS CONTRIBUTED BY THE STATE AND
LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO TRY TO MITIGATE
IT.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS JUST
BASICALLY
SAYS THERE SHOULD BE FUNDAMENTAL
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPABILITIES TO
RUN A WATER SYSTEM.
THAT'S A SMALL WATER SYSTEM.
WE TOOK AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE,
AND THEY ADDRESSED THE MAIN
ISSUES RAISED BY OPPONENTS.
AS A RESULT, THEY ARE
REEVALUATING
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
IT'S SUPPORTED BY SAFE WATER
AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GROUPS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD
ON THIS BILL?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I'LL GO.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY.
I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I BLAKESBERG I BRADFORD, I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
HI, DOLLY.
NO, DODD.
I THOUGHT OSO I EGGMAN.
GLASER.
GUY GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
NO OR DATO.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
I.
MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
BY NEWMAN.
I WHEN?
NO NIILO.
NO OKOBO.
NO.
PADILLO.
I PONCENO.
HI, ROD.
HI, RUBIO.
I SEE NO SKINNER.
SMALL QUAVERS.
I STERN.
AYZENBERG.
UMMER.
WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EXCUSE ME.
WE HAVE A MEMBER OFF THE FLOOR.
SO AT THE REQUEST OF SENATOR
LAIRD,
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THIS ON CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 159.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1201 BY
SENATOR DURAZZO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1201 BY SENATOR
DURAZZO,
AN ACT RELATING TO CORPORATIONS.
SENATOR DURAZZO.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
UH.
SB 1201, WHICH REQUIRES
CORPORATIONS AND LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES TO REPORT
INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR BENEFICIAL OWNERS WHEN
THOSE BUSINESS ENTITIES
FILE WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE.
THIS GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL IS
SUPPORTED
BY OVER 130 HOUSING,
ENVIRONMENTAL, LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS,
LABOR, AS WELL AS THE OAKLAND,
SAN DIEGO AND SAN FRANCISCO CITY
ATTORNEYS.
UNDER EXISTING LAW, LLCS
AND SIMILAR ENTITIES PROVIDE
LEGAL PROTECTION FOR ASSETS NOT
OWNED BY THE LLC.
THIS IS IMPORTANT AND CAN
PROTECT
AN OWNER'S FAMILY FROM
LIQUIDATION DURING A BUSINESS
BANKRUPTCY,
FOR EXAMPLE.
HOWEVER, OWNERS CAN ABUSE LLCS
TO SHIELD NOT
ONLY THEIR ASSETS BUT ALSO THEIR
IDENTITIES.
MANY LLCS ARE OWNED IN THE NAME
OF ANOTHER LLC,
WHICH CREATES ADDITIONAL LAYERS
OF ANONYMITY.
NONE OF THIS IS NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE
THE LEGAL AND FINANCIAL
PROTECTIONS AFFORDED BY FORMING
THE LLC IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE ABILITY FOR LLCS TO ABUSE
THE STRUCTURE TO REMAIN
ANONYMOUS ENDS UP PRESENTING
NUMEROUS ISSUES,
AND EVEN ENABLES DISHONEST AND
ILLEGAL PRACTICES.
THE LACK OF OWNER TRANSPARENCY
ENABLES
UNSCRUPULOUS AND ILLEGAL
PRACTICES.
FOR INSTANCE, SOME BUSINESS
OWNERS USE
LLCS TO SKIRT WORKER PROTECTION
LAWS OR AVOID ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR SUBSTANDARD HOUSING.
IT CAN TAKE YEARS FOR
ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO CONNECT THE DOTS,
TO SHOW THAT A SINGLE PERSON IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR
REPEATED VIOLATIONS ACROSS
MULTIPLE LLCS.
IT DRAINS PUBLIC RESOURCES AND
ALLOWS
ABUSES TO CONTINUE LARGELY
UNIMPEDED,
WHICH OFTEN HAPPEN AMONG THE
LOWEST PAID INDUSTRIES.
THE LACK OF OWNER TRANSPARENCY
ALSO PROVIDES AN AVENUE
TO SKIRT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
SUBSTANDARD HOUSING,
WHEN PROPERTY OWNERS CAN HIDE
BEHIND A WEB OF LLCS.
TENANTS AND LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS ARE OFTEN
FRUSTRATED IN THEIR ATTEMPTS TO
OBTAIN REPAIRS,
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT FIND THE
TRUE OWNER
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PROPERTY.
AB 1201 WILL MAKE IT EASIER TO
ENFORCE
EXISTING LAWS TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE AND WORK IN
OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE,
INCREASE GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY,
AND ULTIMATELY SAVE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DURAZZO.
SENATOR DAWLEY.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS.
I HAVE TO RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
WHY DO WE HAVE LLCS IN
CALIFORNIA?
LIMITED LIABILITY.
THE WORD LIABILITY IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
IN CALIFORNIA, IF YOU'RE A SOLE
PROPRIETOR AND YOU DON'T
HAVE A LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANY
AS YOUR FRONT,
UH, THEIR LAWS ARE NOT IN YOUR
FAVOR.
YOU CAN BE SUED, UH,
AND YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT YOUR HOUSE
AND YOUR AND THINGS THAT AREN'T
RELATED TO YOUR BUSINESS.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE LLCS.
THIS BILL IS IS ANOTHER ATTACK
ON
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THE ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO INSULATE YOURSELF
FROM FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS.
THERE MAY BE SOME ABUSES IN IN
SOME AREAS.
ABSOLUTELY.
THERE'S ABUSES IN EVERY
BUSINESS.
THERE'S BAD FARMERS, THERE'S
GREAT FARMERS,
THERE'S BAD DOCTORS,
THERE'S GOOD DOCTORS, AND
THERE'S SOME ABUSES.
I'M SURE THERE'S SOME ABUSES IN
THIS AREA.
BUT CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT
FOR BUSINESS IS HORRIBLE.
JUST IN THE IN THE SENATOR'S
DISTRICT
THAT REPRESENTS THIS BILL.
53 COMPANIES LEFT HER DISTRICT
LAST SINCE 2020 18 AND 19.
680 BUSINESSES LEFT CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S THE REASON WE HAVE A
BUDGET
DEFICIT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IS BECAUSE WE ARE NOT BUSINESS
FRIENDLY IN CALIFORNIA,
AND WE ARE KILLING THE PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY PAY THE TAXES.
SO THIS BILL, I THINK, GOES WAY
TOO FAR.
IT'S ALLOWING YOU TO REPORT IF
YOU HAVE 25%.
WHY DO WE HAVE TO REPORT?
YOU CAN GO AFTER THE LLCS.
THERE'S A STRUCTURE IN PLACE
ALREADY.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER ATTACK ON
BUSINESS OWNERS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE NO
VOTE ON SB 1201.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
FROM MEMBERS?
ANY OTHER MEMBER WANT TO BE
HEARD ON THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR DURAZZO, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK INTO
MY DISTRICT
AND SEE THE STATUS OF ALL THESE
BUSINESSES,
BECAUSE I SEE FAR MORE COMING IN
THAN LEAVING.
BUT WHAT THIS TODAY'S BILL IS
ABOUT IS THOSE WHO ARE
UNSCRUPULOUS AND THE ONES THAT
HIDE BEHIND THE LLCS.
IT DOES NOTHING TO CHANGE THE
PURPOSE
AND THE PROTECTIONS OF AN LLC.
COLLEAGUES, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YEAH.
ALAN, I'LL.
ARCHULETA.
THE ASHBY.
ATKINS.
BECKER.
I LIKE SPERM.
BRADFORD I.
COURTESY.
DOLLY!
NO!
GOD, NO!
I.
EGGMAN!
GLASER.
GONZALEZ.
A GROVE.
NO RETARDO.
UH.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD, I THE MONEY.
BY MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
MEN I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
AKOBO.
NO.
PADILLA.
I PONCENO, I ROTH.
RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER.
SMALL QUAVERS.
A STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL.
NO.
SENATOR DURAZZO MOVES A CALL.
YOU STILL HAVE A ONE MEMBER OFF
THE FLOOR MEMBERS.
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM 161.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1220 BY
SENATOR LAMONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1220 BY SENATOR
LEHMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS.
SENATOR LEHMAN.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES SB ONE.
SB 1220 WILL ENSURE THAT CALL
CENTERS THAT SERVE
OUR MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
ENROLLING
AND CALLING PROGRAMS LIKE
CALWORKS, CALFRESH,
MEDI-CAL, HEALTHY FAMILIES,
AND COVERED CALIFORNIA, OR
CALLING LOCAL,
STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE SIMILAR BENEFITS,
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REACH AND
CONNECT WITH
A HUMAN TO TROUBLESHOOT
PROBLEMS.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THERE IS
HUMAN
ASSISTANCE AND WORKERS
AVAILABLE WHEN PEOPLE ARE
CALLING TO RECEIVE HELP,
BUT DOES NOT PRECLUDE AI FROM
BEING USED.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LEMON.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DARLIN, I'LL RODA-GIL.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY.
I I ATKINS, I BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO.
COURTESY.
DELHI.
GOD.
I BARROSO I EGGMAN.
I GLASER.
I I.
GONZALEZ.
A GROVE.
POTATO.
BY JONES.
LAIRD I.
LEHMAN, I.
MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO NO NO NO.
JOBO.
NO.
PADILLA.
I PORTANTINO.
ROD.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO?
NO.
SKINNER.
SMILED CUEVAS.
BY STERN I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL I.
SENATOR LEMON MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO FILE
THAT IN 162.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1253 BY
SENATOR GONZALES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1253 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
AN ACT RELATING TO FIREARMS.
SENATOR GONZALES.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TO PRESENT SB 1253,
WHICH MAKES ESSENTIAL UPDATES TO
THE FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS SAFE.
HOW CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN
RECENT DECADES TO REDUCE GUN
VIOLENCE.
HOWEVER, ACCIDENTAL AND
UNINTENTIONAL
SHOOTINGS CONTINUE TO BE
A LEADING CAUSE OF FIREARM
RELATED
INCIDENTS IN THE STATE,
PARTICULARLY FOR CHILDREN,
CONTRIBUTING TO ROUGHLY 30% OF
ALL
FIREARM RELATED DEATHS AND
INJURIES
FROM 2016 TO 2022.
SB 1253 WILL INCREASE FIREARM
SAFETY BY
REQUIRING INDIVIDUALS WHO MOVE
INTO
CALIFORNIA AND REPORT THEIR
FIREARMS
TO ALSO OBTAIN A VALID
CERTIFICATE.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
FIREARM IMPORTERS
HAVE THE NECESSARY SAFETY,
SKILLS AND COMPREHENSION IN OUR
UP TO DATE
ON ALL OF THE LAWS AND BEST
PRACTICES,
INCLUDING SAFE HANDLING AND
STORAGE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
OF SB 1253.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GONZALEZ.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD
ON THIS BILL?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
I'LL GO.
NO.
ARCHULETA.
I ASHBY, I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I, BLAKE SPEAR.
HI, BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CORTEZ.
I DALLY.
NO.
DODD.
TERRAZZO.
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I I GONZALEZ I
GROVE.
NO.
AUTO.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD, I LAMENT.
I.
MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO NIILO.
NO METRO, NO PODIUM.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
RUBIO.
HI, SATO.
NO, SKINNER.
SMALL QUAVERS.
I STERN.
I UMMAT.
I.
A WIENER.
I WILL.
NO.
SENATOR GONZALEZ MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 165.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1263 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1263 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO TEACHER
CREDENTIALING,
SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I'M PLEASED TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB
1263,
WHICH WILL ELIMINATE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR TEACHER
CANDIDATES IN CALIFORNIA TO
UNDERGO
A FORMAL TEACHER PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT,
GENERALLY REFERRED TO AS A TPA.
TEACHER CANDIDATES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE REQUIRED TO
FULFILL MULTIPLE REQUIREMENTS AS
A CONDITION
OF BEING ISSUED A PRELIMINARY
TEACHING CREDENTIAL,
INCLUDING SUBJECT MATTER
PROFICIENCY,
TEACHER PREPARATION, COURSE
REQUIREMENTS,
600 HOURS OF CLINICAL PRACTICE,
READING INSTRUCTION COMPETENCY,
AND A TEACHER PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT.
THE TPA HAS BECOME AN UNDULY
ONEROUS
PORTFOLIO ASSESSMENT,
WHICH HAS OFTEN HAS THE NET
IMPACT OF DETRACTING FROM
TEACHER CANDIDATES ABILITY TO
FOCUS ON APPLYING
THE CONCEPTS AND SKILLS OF
TEACHER PREPARATION
COURSEWORK IN REAL CLASSROOMS,
AS OVERSEEN BY MENTOR TEACHERS
DURING
SUPERVISED CLINICAL PRACTICE.
WHILE WELL-INTENTIONED, THE
DEMANDS CURRENTLY
PLACED UPON TEACHING CANDIDATES
IN PREPARING FOR THE TPA HAVE
HAD
THE PERVERSE IMPACT OF ACTUALLY
REDUCING
THE OVERALL QUALITY OF TEACHER
PREPARATION
IN CALIFORNIA BY UNDERMINING
THE CAPACITY OF TEACHER
CANDIDATES TO
FOCUS ON THEIR CLINICAL
PRACTICE.
AS A PRACTICAL MATTER, THE
TEACHER
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
AND CLINICAL PRACTICE
ASSESSMENTS
ARE EFFECTIVELY DUPLICATIVE.
THE TPA ASSESSES TEACHER
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY ASSESSED
THROUGH COURSEWORK,
CONTENT, AND ASSESSMENT,
AS WELL AS DURING CLINICAL
PRACTICE,
AND THERE ARE OBVIOUS NEGATIVE
IMPACTS
ON TEACHER PREPARATION.
AND THESE IMPACTS HAVE ARE
HAVING A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON TEACHERS OF COLOR.
IN LIGHT OF THAT, AND
CONSIDERING
THE BROADER CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED
WITH EXPANDING AND IMPROVING
CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATED WORKFORCE,
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
DIVERSITY,
REMOVING THE TPA WILL EMPHASIZE
THE VALUE OF CLINICAL PRACTICE
AND ULTIMATELY SUPPORT THE
GROWTH
OF A BETTER PREPARED,
MORE DIVERSE TEACHING WORKFORCE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR OCHOA.
BOGH.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, COLLEAGUES, I RISE IN
RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB 1263.
I SUPPORTED THIS BILL IN
EDUCATION
COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT ORIGINALLY
SOUGHT TO REPEAL TEACHER
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS.
DURING THE HEARING, WE HEARD
MANY EDUCATION
STAKEHOLDERS EXPRESS HOW TPUS
ARE BURDENSOME AND DUPLICATIVE
OF EXISTING
ASSESSMENT PLACED ON TEACHERS,
SUCH AS THE READING INSTRUCTION
COMPETENCE ASSESSMENT,
WHICH IS REFERRED TO AS REKHA.
HOWEVER, THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
TAKE THIS BILL ONE STEP FURTHER
BY REMOVING THE REKHA.
NOW, GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
MAJORITY
OF STUDENTS ARE UNABLE
TO MEET THE STATE STANDARDS
IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS,
SHOULDN'T TEACHER CANDIDATES BE
ASSESSED TO ENSURE
THEY'RE COMPETENT IN LITERACY
INSTRUCTION?
SO BASICALLY, WE ARE NOW
CURRENTLY REMOVING BOTH.
BOTH ASSESSMENTS FOR TEACHERS.
SO WE'RE WE WERE REPLACING
THE TPA WITH THE RICA OR I'M
SORRY
WE WERE WE WERE GIVING THE
THE THE TPA INSTEAD OF THE RICA.
AND NOW WE'RE REMOVING THE RICA
AS WELL BASED
ON WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
COMMITTEE.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
UM, JUST BASED ON THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE,
UH, RECENTLY, UH, ADDED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, WE'LL
RECOGNIZE SENATOR RUBIO.
&GT;&GT; YES.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE,
I, I STAND JUST WITH CONCERNS.
UM, YOU KNOW, I WAS THE AUTHOR
OF
THE BILL THAT WOULD WALK AWAY
FROM RICA
TO GIVE TEACHERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO
HAVE SUCCESS AS IT PERTAINS TO,
YOU KNOW, PASSING THE TEST
AND HAVING REAL LIFE EXPERIENCE,
UH, ACTUALLY HAVING CLASSROOM
EXPERIENCE.
BUT I KNOW THAT WE SPENT THREE
YEARS
TRYING TO PERFECT THAT BILL.
WE MET WITH STAKEHOLDERS,
TEACHERS, INCLUDING,
YOU KNOW, UM, TEACHERS UNIONS,
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT IT
RIGHT,
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
TEACHERS
HAD A VOICE, PARENTS HAD A
VOICE.
AND, YOU KNOW, OTHER EDUCATION
ADVOCATES HAD A VOICE.
AND SO, AGAIN, MY BILL WAS THE
ONE
THAT TOOK I WALKED AWAY FROM
RICA TO ENSURE THAT IT WAS
EASIER
THAT WE PUSHED FOR DIVERSITY,
MADE IT EASIER TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE QUALIFIED TEACHERS.
AND SO I'M NOT OPPOSING THE BILL
TODAY,
BUT I DO WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS,
BECAUSE I ALSO DO HAVE A CONCERN
THAT.
&GT;&GT; NOW WE'RE REMOVING EVEN
MORE, UM, UH, REQUIREMENTS.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE QUALIFIED
TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM.
SO AGAIN, I WOULD ASK THE AUTHOR
TO TO CONSIDER WHAT I JUST SAID.
WE WORKED THREE YEARS TO TRY AND
GET IT RIGHT,
AND WE ENGAGED ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
AND NOW WE'RE MOVING FROM THAT
TO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE WORKED HARD ON
IT.
AND SO WITH THAT, I'LL JUST SAY
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT.
BUT I HOPE HE CONTINUES TO
CONSIDER IT.
THANK YOU.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, SENATOR
RUBIO.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE?
CLOSE.
SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU MAY CLOSE
THE DEBATE.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
SO I DO APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS,
PARTICULARLY THE INPUT OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN PARK.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS,
AND I AM ACTUALLY GLAD TO
AND WILL COMMIT TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE SENATOR AND
WITH OTHERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO GET THIS
RIGHT.
AS I MENTIONED, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE INCLUDED A WHOLE HOST OF
REQUIREMENTS
FOR TEACHING CANDIDATES IN
CALIFORNIA OFTEN,
I THINK, IN MANY WAYS
OVERLOADING THEM TO
THE DETRIMENT OF THE QUALITY OF
THAT PRACTICE.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO REVISIT THIS
IN A WAY THAT
ONE PROVIDES FOR EXCELLENCE IN
TEACHING,
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
LITERACY SKILLS,
BUT ALSO MAKES SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT UNINTENTIONALLY
DISSUADING PRECISELY
THE PEOPLE THAT WE WANT TO
BECOME
TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA,
PARTICULARLY THOSE TEACHERS WHO
BEST REFLECT
THE DIVERSITY OF THE STUDENTS
THAT THEY WOULD TEACH.
SO GLAD TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION,
BUT ASKING FOR YOUR I VOTE THIS
EVENING.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
&GT;&GT; ELLEN ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY, I ATKINS.
BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO, I
CORTEZ.
I DALLY.
NO, DODD, I DURAZZO.
I, EGGMAN.
GLASER I.
GONZALEZ, I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
HI, JONES.
NO, LAIRD, I NEED THE MONEY.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I.
MEN I.
NEWMAN I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
AKOBO.
NO.
BIDIA.
I PORTANTINO.
ROTH.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG
I WAHAB.
WIENER.
WELL, NO.
UH, MEMBERS, WE HAVE, UH,
EVERYONE BACK HERE ON THE FLOOR.
SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE
SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN AL RODA-GIL I ATKINS I
BECKER,
I EGGMAN, I MCGUIRE.
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO I.
WAHAB.
WIENER.
I.
WAHAB I.
ON A VOTE OF 29 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 168.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1318 BY
SENATOR WAHAB.
SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1318 BY SENATOR
WAHAB.
AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE
HEALTH.
SENATOR WAHAB.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
SB 1318 CHILD SUICIDE PREVENTION
ENSURES THAT
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS
ON SCHOOL CAMPUS RECEIVE CARE
FROM A QUALIFIED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL.
WE ARE EXPERIENCING AN
UNPRECEDENTED
SURGE IN CHILD SELF-HARM
AND IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
TAKE ACTION.
SB 1318 REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO
REVISE THEIR MODEL YOUTH SUICIDE
PREVENTION
POLICY TO INCLUDE CRISIS
INTERVENTION PROCEDURES
THAT PRIORITIZE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
PROFESSIONALS CLARIFY THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT,
INCLUDING RESOURCE OFFICERS,
SHOULD ONLY BE INVOLVED WHERE
THERE IS
AN IMMINENT THREAT TO THE
STUDENT'S LIFE.
SB 1318 IS A STEP TOWARDS
THE PROTECTION OF OUR CHILDREN,
CONNECTING THEM TO THE RESOURCES
AND PROFESSIONALS THEY NEED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR WAHAB.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO I ARCHER
ARCHULETA, I ASHBY.
I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR I.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ.
BY DALLY.
NO.
DODD.
I TORRAZZO.
I EGMOND.
I GLASER I.
I GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
NO.
RIDOTTO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I.
MEN.
NEWMAN.
I WHEN?
NEITHER KNOW MUCH ABOUT.
PEDDUR I.
PORTANTINO.
A ROD.
I RUBIO.
ACIERTO.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER I WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
MCGUIRE.
WHEN?
WHICH OBOE.
SMALL.
CUEVAS.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE LAST TIME.
ELLEN MAGUIRE WIN.
NO AKOBO, NO SMALL GUAVAS.
I WANT A VOTE OF 31 TO 7.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 179 BY
SENATOR EGGMAN.
179 BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
SB 1491 SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1491 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR EGGMAN.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR.
SPEAKER.
PRESIDENT.
1491 WILL INFORM STUDENTS ABOUT
IF THEIR COLLEGE THEY'RE
ATTENDING IS EXEMPT FROM THE
HIGHER EDUCATION
ACT AND TITLE NINE AND REQUIRES
TO DESIGNATE
A LGBTQ PERSON FOR CONFIDENTIAL
SERVICES.
I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE HEARD ON
THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA.
I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKE.
SPEER.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLEY.
DODD, I THOUGHT I.
I, EGGMAN.
BY GLASER I I.
GONZALEZ.
I.
GROVE.
FURTADO I JONES NO.
LAIRD I LEMAN I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR
I MEN I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
VIDEO.
I PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
HI, RUBIO.
I SAY NO.
SKINNER.
I SMOKE CUEVAS.
STERN I.
HAMBURG, I.
WAHHAB I.
WIENER I WOKE.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN DAWLEY.
NO.
GROVE NOW.
MCGUIRE SMILED.
CUEVAS I.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS, I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A
HEADS UP OF
THE NEXT FIVE MEASURES WE'RE
GOING TO DEAL WITH.
TODAY, TONIGHT THAT I'M GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM 25,
FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM 26, 36, 49
AND 54.
IF YOU'RE FOLLOWING ALONG AT
HOME.
SO LET US BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
25.
THIS IS SB 1209 BY SENATOR
CORTEZ.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1209 BY SENATOR
CORTESE,
AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES,
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB 1209,
WHICH WOULD EXPLICITLY AUTHORIZE
LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSIONS
LAFCOS TO
ADD INDEMNIFICATION AGREEMENTS
TO THEIR
CONTRACTS WITH APPLICANTS FOR
MOST APPLICATIONS TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES,
SUCH AS THOSE FOR LAND USE.
PRIVATE PARTIES DO INDEMNIFY
THE INVOLVED CITY OR COUNTY.
LAFCOS ALSO WERE INDEMNIFIED BY
APPLICANTS UNTIL
THE SECOND DISTRICT COURT OF
APPEALS DETERMINED THAT
LAFCOS COULD NOT REQUIRE
INDEMNIFICATION BECAUSE
IT'S NOT EXPRESSLY AUTHORIZED IN
THE CORTEZ,
KNOX, HERTZBERG LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ACT OF 2000,
ALLOWING LAFCOS TO USE
INDEMNIFICATION
WILL PREVENT THE EXPENSE OF ONE
ENTITY FROM BEING SHIFTED.
EXCUSE ME?
THE EXPENSE OF ONE ENTITY FROM
BEING SHIFTED TO
ALL REPRESENTATIVE AGENCIES THAT
FUND A LAFCO.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON OR DEBATE ON
THIS MEASURE.
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I'S 38.
NO, ZERO.
THE MEASURE CARRIES.
&GT;&GT; WHAT'S THAT?
WHAT'S THAT?
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE MOMENTUM
GOING HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO NEXT TURN TO ITEM
26,
FILE ITEM 26 SB 1225 BY SENATOR
JONES.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1225 BY SENATOR
JONES.
AN ACT RELATING TO REAL ESTATE
APPRAISERS.
SENATOR JONES, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
IT IS AN HONOR TO RISE AND
PRESENT
A BILL TO THIS BODY.
I AM PRESENTING SENATE BILL
1225,
WHICH ALLOWS THE BUREAU OF REAL
ESTATE APPRAISERS TO REMOVE
NOTICES OF DISCIPLINARY ACTION
FROM THEIR
WEBSITE IF CERTAIN CONDITIONS
ARE MET.
IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
REMOVAL,
THE DISCIPLINARY INFORMATION
MUST BE AT LEAST TEN YEARS
OLD AND DETERMINED BY THE BUREAU
TO NO LONGER
BE NECESSARY TO ENSURE CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
OUTDATED DISCIPLINARY RECORDS
DRAW ATTENTION
AWAY FROM THE CURRENT ONES
THAT ARE USEFUL IN IDENTIFYING
ACTIVE
THREATS TO CONSUMER PROTECTION.
SB 1225 WILL GIVE THE BUREAU THE
AUTHORITY IT NEEDS
TO DECLUTTER AND STREAMLINE ITS
DATABASE.
I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD
ON THIS MEASURE?
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I'S 38.
NO, ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, WITH THIS GREAT
MOMENTUM WE HAVE GOING.
FILE ITEM 36, THIS IS SENATE
BILL
1490 BY SENATOR DURAZZO.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1490 BY SENATOR
DURAZZO.
AN ACT RELATING TO FOOD
DELIVERY.
SENATOR DURAZZO.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1490,
WHICH WILL STRENGTHEN THE FAIR
FOOD DELIVERY ACT BY REQUIRING
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORMS
TO DISCLOSE TO RESTAURANTS AND
CUSTOMERS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IN CONNECTION WITH
THEIR SERVICES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW RESTAURANTS
TO REQUEST REMOVAL FROM
THE DELIVERY PLATFORM IN
A TIMELY MANNER, SUBJECT TO,
OF COURSE, TO ANY PRE-EXISTING
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS
BETWEEN THE PLATFORM AND A FOOD
FACILITY.
IT ALSO REQUIRES PLATFORMS TO
PROVIDE
RESTAURANTS DETAILS ON
THE PROCESS FOR DISPUTING
ERRONEOUS
CHARGES AND PLATFORM ERRORS,
AND IT REQUIRES THE FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORMS TO
PROVIDE TIMELY AND TRANSPARENT
COMMUNICATIONS.
CUSTOMERS WANT TO KNOW WHEN
THEIR FOOD WILL ARRIVE
AND IF IT DOESN'T, WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE?
THESE CHANGES ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY
AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESTAURANTS TO HAVE CLEAR
INFORMATION
ABOUT FOOD DELIVERY PROCESSES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
ENGAGEMENT
AND WORKING WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO STRIKE
THE RIGHT BALANCE WHERE NEEDED,
TO PROTECT SMALL RESTAURANTS
FROM BEING
UNFAIRLY TREATED ON THE APPS.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DURAZZO.
IS THERE A MEMBER WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE HEARD ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY, I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ I DALLY I.
NO.
DODD.
I THOUGHT I SAW A EGGMAN.
I GLAZER.
I I GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
UH.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD I.
LEMONY.
I WIRE MENGIBAR.
I MEAN, I NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO.
NEELO.
XIAOBO.
NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH.
HI RUBIO.
I CIERTO KNOW SKINNER.
I SMILED WAVERS.
STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WILL HAVE.
A WIENER.
I WOKE?
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
COLIN MCGUIRE.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
I WANT A VOTE OF 30 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 49,
THE SENATE BILL 1251 BY SENATOR
STERN.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1281 BY SENATOR
STERN.
AN ACT RELATING TO MOSQUITO
ABATEMENT.
SENATOR STERN.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
UM, MEMBERS, MOSQUITOES JUST
MAY SEEM LIKE A PESKY ISSUE,
BUT I ASSURE YOU, THIS BILL IS
ANYTHING BUT.
IT'S DEAD SERIOUS.
UH, IN 2023, WE SAW 428 CASES OF
WEST NILE
AND 34 COUNTIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
IN OCTOBER, PASADENA REPORTED
THE FIRST CASE OF
LOCALLY TRANSMITTED DENGUE FEVER
IN 12 DAYS.
LATER, A SECOND CASE WAS MADE IN
LONG BEACH.
THIS IS ONE OF FOUR STATES IN
THE NATION
WITH CASES OF LOCALLY
TRANSMITTED DENGUE
AND MOSQUITO BORNE ILLNESS IS
REALLY AT
THE CENTER OF THIS DISEASE AND
ILLNESS CRISIS.
UH, UTILITY VAULTS ARE AT THE
CENTER OF THIS BILL.
UH, THOSE ARE UNDER MANHOLE
COVERS AROUND
MANY OF OUR HOMES AND ON OUR
STREETS.
THEY'RE OFTEN TOUGH TO GET TO.
AND STANDING WATER HAS BEEN AN
ONGOING ISSUE
THAT MOSQUITO CONTROL
PROFESSIONALS REPORT.
ACCESS ISSUES.
THIS WOULD.
REQUIRE OUR ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS
TO ENTER INTO JOINTLY DEVELOPED
VECTOR MANAGEMENT AGREEMENTS
WITH THESE MOSQUITO
CONTROL AGENCIES SO THAT THEY
CAN TREAT AND POST,
TREAT AND INSPECT THESE
POTENTIALLY VERY DANGEROUS.
PIECES OF OUR LOST
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I DID COMMIT TO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES WOULD
ALSO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
LEGISLATION,
AND I WANT TO ASSURE MEMBERS,
THOSE OF YOU WHO DO NOT HAVE AN
IOU IN YOUR AREA,
BUT A PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY
LIKE I DO WITH DWP,
THAT WE WILL BE MAKING THAT
AMENDMENT IN THE ASSEMBLY.
SO I WANT TO PROVIDE MY
COMMITMENT ON THAT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR STERN.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO BE HEARD
ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GUILLERM I.
ARCHULETTA I.
ASHBY, I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKE.
SPERM.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
I.
CORTEZ.
DALLY.
I.
DODD.
DURAZZO I.
EGGMAN.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HI, HURTADO.
HI, JONES.
I LAIRD I LEMAN I MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR
I MEN I NEWMAN I WIN.
NILO.
I.
PEDDUR.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROD.
I RUBIO.
I SATO, I SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG
I WAHHAB I WIENER, I WILL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN MCGUIRE WHEN I.
XIAOBO I ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 54.
THIS IS SB 1216 BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1216 BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR.
AN ACT RELATED TO
TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1216,
WHICH WILL IMPROVE SAFETY FOR
BICYCLISTS ON OUR
ROADWAYS BY LIMITING THE OVERUSE
OF
SHARROWS AND CLASS THREE
BIKEWAYS.
THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM, OR ATP,
HELPS FUND SAFE BIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY, ATP IS EXPECTED
TO FACE SIGNIFICANT
CUTS DUE TO THE DEVASTATING
DEFICIT.
THESE LIMITED FUNDS SHOULDN'T BE
USED FOR PROJECTS
THAT DON'T ACTUALLY MAKE BIKING
SAFER,
LIKE SIMPLY ADDING SHARROWS
WITHOUT
INCLUDING OTHER FEATURES,
FOR EXAMPLE, SLOWING TRAFFIC TO
SAFER SPEEDS.
SB 1216 WILL PROHIBIT ATP FUNDS
FROM
BEING USED TO CREATE SHARROWS.
WHEN THE DESIGN SPEED IS GREATER
THAN 25MPH.
IT WILL ALSO PROHIBIT SHARROWS
ON HIGHWAYS
WITH A POSTED SPEED LIMIT OVER
30MPH.
BIKING NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERED A
VIABLE OPTION,
AND WHEN THERE IS LIMITED
PHYSICAL SEPARATION
OR ACTUALLY THE MINGLING
OF BICYCLES AND FAST MOVING
VEHICLES
TOGETHER IN ONE LANE,
IT MAKES IT LESS LIKELY THAT
PEOPLE
WILL FEEL SAFE BIKING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD ON
THIS THIS MEASURE.
ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD.
OKAY, WE DO HAVE A MEMBER OFF
THE FLOOR,
SO WE'LL BE GOING THROUGH THE
ROLL ONLY
ONE TIME AND THEN IT'LL BE PUT
ON CALL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN RODA-GIL.
NO ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR I
BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY NO
DODD I DURAZZO.
EGGMAN I GLASER I I GONZALEZ I
GROVE.
NO.
I.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD, I LAMENT.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
NO OKOBO.
NO.
PADILLA.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CLOSE.
GUY STERN I UMMAT.
I.
I WIENER, I WILL.
NO.
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE AGAIN,
SO WE WILL CALL THE ROLL THE
ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME.
SO, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
DURAZZO.
I MAGUIRE.
MINE.
I.
A VOTE OF 29 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO NEXT MOVE TO FILE
ITEM
72 FOLLOWED BY 7387 AND 110.
SO FILE ITEM 72, SENATE BILL
1410 BY SENATOR OCHOA,
BOGH SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1410 BY SENATOR
OKOBO
AN ACT RELATING TO PUPIL
INSTRUCTION.
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS,
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB 1410,
WHICH REQUIRES THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AT ITS NEXT
MATHEMATICS CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK
REVISION,
TO RECOMMEND THAT ALGEBRA ONE
AND MATHEMATICS
ONE COURSES BE OFFERED TO EIGHTH
GRADERS.
LAST SUMMER, THE BOARD APPROVED
A REVISED MATHEMATICS
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK THAT
SUGGESTED
ALGEBRA COURSES ARE ADVANCED AND
SHOULD
ONLY BE TAUGHT IN HIGH SCHOOL.
BECAUSE CSU REQUIRES FIVE YEARS
OF MATH FOR INCOMING
FRESHMEN ENTERING A MATH
INTENSIVE MAJOR,
THAT DECISION TO NOT OFFER
ALGEBRA
TO EIGHTH GRADERS IMMEDIATELY
PUT
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO PURSUE A
STEM
RELATED MAJOR AT A DISADVANTAGE.
IN 2014, SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
WAS THE FIRST TO EXPERIMENT
WITH MOVING ALGEBRA ONE
EXCLUSIVELY TO HIGH SCHOOL.
IN MARCH, AFTER NEARLY TEN YEARS
OF DECLINING RESULTS,
SAN FRANCISCO'S PROPOSITION G,
WHICH URGED THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO OFFER ALGEBRA
ONE TO EIGHTH GRADERS, PASSED
WITH 81% SUPPORT,
DELAYING ALGEBRA UNTIL HIGH
SCHOOL
DOESN'T SERVE ALL STUDENTS WELL,
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO WANT TO
ATTEND COLLEGE,
SO IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE
FRAMEWORKS
CURRENT SUGGESTION
TO DELAY ALGEBRA UNTIL HIGH
SCHOOL IS REVERSED.
SB 1410 HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE,
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION.
FOR THESE REASONS, I
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WEINER.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU.
FIRST, I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE
FOR ADVANCING THIS.
ADVANCING THIS LEGISLATION.
UM, YOU KNOW, IN SAN FRANCISCO,
WE WENT THROUGH A DECADE LONG,
RIDICULOUS SITUATION WHERE OUR
BOARD OF
EDUCATION A DECADE AGO
ELIMINATED,
UH, EIGHTH GRADE ALGEBRA.
UM, IT DIDN'T ACHIEVE ANY OF THE
EQUITY GOALS THAT
THE DISTRICT HAD CLAIMED IT
WOULD ACHIEVE.
INSTEAD, WHAT IT MEANT WAS THAT
EIGHTH GRADERS WITH, UH,
FROM WEALTHIER FAMILIES WERE
SIMPLY
ABLE TO PAY FOR PRIVATE TUTORING
OR TO GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
SOME
OTHER WAY TO ACCESS ALGEBRA.
AND LOWER INCOME KIDS WERE NOT
ABLE TO ACCESS THAT.
SO I WAS VERY PROUD THAT
THE VOTERS OF SAN FRANCISCO,
UH, UH, SPOKE AS AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED,
WITH OVER 80% OF THE VOTE IN
FAVOR
OF EIGHTH GRADE ALGEBRA,
IF A CHILD IS ABLE IS WANTING
AND ABLE TO ACCESS ACCELERATED
MATH,
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO.
AND I ASKED FOR AN I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE.
IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
SEE.
NO OBJECTION.
AYES 38.
NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 73.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1441 BY
SENATOR ALLEN.
SENATOR UMBERG IS GOING TO TAKE
IT UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1441 BY SENATOR
ALLEN.
AN ACT RELATING TO PETITIONS.
SENATOR UMBERG.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR ALLEN IS NOT HERE.
APPARENTLY HE IS BIRTHING A
BABY,
OR AT LEAST IN THE PROCESS
OF PARTICIPATING IN THE BIRTHING
OF A BABY RIGHT NOW.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT HE'S
ACTUALLY WATCHING US.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST HE TURN OFF
HIS COMPUTER
AND FOCUS ON THE TASK AT HAND.
BUT MEANTIME, WE'LL FOCUS ON
THE TASK AT HAND CONCERNING SB
1441,
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE CLEAR
TIMELINES
IN THE ELECTION PETITION REVIEW
PROCESS AND HELP GOVERNMENTS
HANDLE
THE COSTS FROM ADDED WORKLOAD.
WHEN A PETITION FAILS TO QUALIFY
FOR
THE BALLOT DUE TO INSUFFICIENT
SIGNATURES,
PROPONENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
EXAMINE THE PETITION
AND THE REASONS FOR THE
SIGNATURE REJECTIONS.
STATE LAW CURRENTLY ESTABLISHES
A TIMELINE
FOR THE INITIAL REVIEW PROCESS,
BUT IS SILENT ON THE TIMELINE
FOR
CONCLUDING THE EXAMINATION.
WHILE MOST PETITION REVIEWS TAKE
BETWEEN
A FEW DAYS TO A COUPLE OF WEEKS,
ONE RECENT CASE IN LOS ANGELES
LASTED 14
MONTHS AND COST THE COUNTY $1.5
MILLION.
THE LACK OF A CLEAR DEADLINE IN
LAW ALLOWED FOR THIS REVIEW
TO BE DRAGGED ON FOR A
SIGNIFICANT PERIOD OF TIME.
SB 1441 ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
ESTABLISHING A REASONABLE 60
DAY TIME LIMIT FOR PROPONENTS
TO EXAMINE A FAILED PETITION,
AND ENABLING COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS
TO RECOVER THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ADDITIONAL
PERSONNEL AND RESOURCES.
I URGE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
ALLEN AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR ELLENBERG, DOES ANY
MEMBER OF
THE SENATE WANT TO BE HEARD ON
THIS MEASURE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY, I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BY BLAKE SPEAR I.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ.
I.
DALLY.
NO.
DODD I.
DURAZZO I.
EGGMAN.
I.
GLAZER I I.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
NO.
RIDOTTO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
LEMON I.
MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I.
MEN.
I.
NEWMAN.
WYNN.
NO NILO.
NO.
AKOBO.
PEDDUR BY PORTENTINO I.
ROTH I.
RUBIO.
ISOTHERM.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMALL QUAVERS.
I STERN I UMBERG.
I.
I WIENER, I WILL.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN MCGUIRE.
A NO ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 87.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1061 BY
SENATOR LAMONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1061 BY SENATOR
LEHMAN.
AN ACT RELATED TO CONSUMER DEBT.
SENATOR LEHMAN.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES,
I PRESENT TO YOU SB 1061,
WHICH WOULD REMOVE MEDICAL DEBT
FROM
CONSUMER CREDIT REPORTS AND
IMPROVE
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE EFFECTS
OF
MEDICAL DEBT COLLECTION
LITIGATION.
MEDICAL DEBT IS OFTEN DRIVEN BY
FACTORS
COMPLETELY OUTSIDE OF OUR
CONTROL.
THIS BILL DOES NOT FORGIVE DEBT,
RATHER IT REMOVES IT JUST FROM
CREDIT REPORTING.
WHILE THIS BILL DOES NOT SOLVE
ALL
THE PROBLEMS WITH MEDICAL DEBT,
REMOVING MEDICAL DEBT FROM
CREDIT REPORTS WILL
GIVE CONSUMERS A BETTER CHANCE
TO RESTORE
THEIR FINANCIAL HEALTH WHILE
THEY TAKE CARE
OF THEIR PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA.
I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKE.
SPEER, I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I.
CORTAZZI I.
DALLY.
NO.
DODD.
I ALSO.
I, EGGMAN.
I GLASER I, I.
GONZALEZ.
I.
GROVE.
NO.
AUTO.
I JONES NO LAIRD I LEMAN I
MAGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MEN I NEWMAN I WIN.
NO.
NILO NO.
OKOBO NO PODIUM I PORTANTINO
I ROBB, I RUBIO, I SATO.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG.
I HAVE A WIENER.
I WILL KNOW.
BRADFORD I ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 8.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 110,
FOLLOWED BY 111,
114 AND ONE 2110 IS SB 1396
BY SENATOR ALVARADO GILL.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1396 BY SENATOR
ALVARADO GILL.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES.
SENATOR.
UH.
ALVARADO.
GIL, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT AND FELLOW MEMBERS, I
WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1396.
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL UNLOCK
THE FULL POTENTIAL OF THE CAL
WORKS
HOME VISITING PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF A CHILD'S LIFE IN
THEIR OVERALL DEVELOPMENT.
IN FACT, 90% OF THE CHILD'S
BRAIN DEVELOPS BY AGE FIVE.
SENATE BILL 1396 WILL GUARANTEE
THAT
PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS, PARENTS,
CARETAKER RELATIVES AND CHILDREN
RECEIVE
THAT SUPPORT FOR A MINIMUM OF 24
MONTHS,
ALIGNING WITH THE DURATION OF
THE RESPECTIVE
HOME VISITING PROGRAM MODEL.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED ZERO NO
VOTES
AND HAS NO RECORDED OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
&GT;&GT; ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
MEMBERS.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM?
HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE.
AYES 38.
NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW NEXT UP, MEMBERS, IS FILE
ITEM 111.
SB 1400 BY SENATOR STERN.
HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 1400 BY SENATOR
STERN.
AN ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE.
SENATOR STERN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS.
IN 2021, I PASSED A BILL CALLED
SB 317
THAT OFFERED MISDEMEANOR
DEFENDANTS
WHO WERE FOUND INCOMPETENT TO
STAND
TRIAL DUE TO SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS,
THE ABILITY TO GET CREDIT FOR
TIME
IN TREATMENT IN LIEU OF JAIL
TIME.
BUT THE BILL ALSO REMOVED THE
ABILITY TO ENSURE
THAT THESE FOLKS WOULD FIND
TREATMENT.
AND IN FACT, THERE WAS WHAT I
CONSIDER A LOOPHOLE
IN MY OWN LEGISLATION THAT HAS
NOW RESULTED
IN THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS HAVING THEIR CASES
DISMISSED.
BEING SENT OUT ON THE STREETS
WITHOUT
TREATMENT AND RECYCLING BACK
THROUGH THE SYSTEM IN WHAT IS
AN INCREDIBLY INHUMANE CYCLE.
THESE FOLKS ARE ALSO NOT BEING
PROVIDED MEDICAL
TREATMENT WHILE THEY'RE IN JAIL.
AND THAT DECOMPENSATION, WHETHER
YOU'RE SUFFERING FROM ACUTE
PSYCHOSIS OR SCHIZOPHRENIA
DISORDER, ONLY GETS WORSE.
AND THEN WHEN YOU END UP ON
THE STREET WITHOUT ANY TREATMENT
AND THE COUNTY HAS NO WAY TO
CONTACT YOU.
YOU FALL INTO DEEP HOMELESSNESS,
OR EVEN WORSE.
WE'RE HOPING TO REMEDY THOSE
LOOPHOLES
IN THIS LEGISLATION,
WHICH I ADMIT WAS A FAULT OF MY
OWN,
IN IN FAILING TO SEE HOW THIS
WOULD PLAY OUT,
THAT THE EASY WAY OUT IS JUST
DISMISSAL
AND FORGET ABOUT THESE FOLKS,
BUT WE CAN'T AFFORD TO DO THAT.
SB 1400 WOULD HOPEFULLY START
TO CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE,
AND AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD,
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT OTHER WAYS
TO ENSURE MEDICAL
TREATMENTS DELIVERED WHILE FOLKS
ARE IN PRISON.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, THAT WE
FIND DIVERSION AND OTHER
ALTERNATIVE TREATMENTS BESIDES
THE JAIL SYSTEM,
WHICH IS REALLY THE WORST PLACE
TO PUT SOMEONE WHO'S SUFFERING
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS OTHER THAN
BACK ON THE STREET.
SO, UM, I WOULD URGE YOUR I VOTE
TODAY AND.
LOOK TO ALL YOUR COUNTIES AND
ASK THEM WHAT
THEY'RE DOING ABOUT MISS
DEFENDANTS,
THIS IS A HUGE GROWING CRISIS
AND WE NEED TO MOVE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON.
I'LL RODA-GIL.
I ARCHULETTA.
I ASHBY.
I ATKINS.
I BECKER.
I BLAKE.
SPEER.
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ.
HI, DADDY.
HI, DAD.
I THOUGHT ALSO I EGGMAN.
GLASER.
GONZALEZ A GROVE.
I DUNNO.
I JONES, I LAIRD.
I THE MONEY.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
HI, NEWMAN.
HI, WAYNE.
I NILO I OKOBO I PODIUM I
PORTANTINO.
I BROUGHT.
HI, RUBIO.
HI, SATO.
HI, SKINNER.
I SMOKE WAVERS, I STERN, I
UMBERG, I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL I.
SENATOR STERN MOVES THE CALL.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE
ITEM 114 BY SENATOR DURAZZO.
SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY.
YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 1460 BY SENATOR
DURAZZO.
AN ACT RELATING TO BROADBAND.
SENATOR DURAZZO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
SB 1460 WILL HELP ESTABLISH
STANDARDS
FOR ACCESS TO HIGH PAID
JOBS AND SAFE WORKING CONDITIONS
IN OUR BROADBAND BUILDOUT.
THIS BILL SUPPORTS AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN
STATE AGENCIES FOR THE CREATION
OR RETENTION OF HIGH QUALITY
JOBS
IN THE COMMUNICATIONS SECTOR,
AND EQUITABLE ACCESS THROUGH
HIGH QUALITY TRAINING.
THESE ARE THE WORKERS WHO RUN
THE FIBER OPTIC LINES,
WHO SPLICE THE LINES AND CONNECT
THE BROADBAND NETWORK TO HOMES,
AND A MAJOR PART OF THIS NEED IS
FOR
WORKERS WHO CAN MAINTAIN AND
REPAIR
THE FIBER OPTIC LINES AND
NETWORK
ONCE THERE IS CONNECTIVITY.
WHEN CALIFORNIA ROLLED OUT
BILLIONS OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND FUNDED MIDDLE MILE
PROJECTS,
LABOR STANDARDS WERE NOT
INCLUDED
IN THE STATUTORY LANGUAGE.
EXPERIENCES IN OTHER STATES
SHOWS US
THAT WITHOUT STRONG LABOR
STANDARDS,
THESE CONTRACTORS,
WHO OFTEN COME FROM OUT OF
STATE,
BRING WORKERS FROM OUT OF STATE
WITHOUT ADEQUATE TRAINING.
THIS THREATENS THE SAFETY OF
WORKERS AND
THE QUALITY OF THE BROADBAND
NETWORK ITSELF.
IF WE DO NOT TAKE STEPS NOW TO
GET PEOPLE INTO THIS
WORKFORCE THROUGH AN INTERAGENCY
COORDINATION,
WE RUN THE RISK OF THE NETWORK
NOT
BEING BUILT OUT ON THE FRONT END
OR NOT HAVING ENOUGH WORKERS TO
KEEP IT RUNNING AND REPAIRED.
IN THE LONG RUN, WE NEED LOCAL
HIRES
TO NOT ONLY BUILD OUT BROADBAND,
BUT TO BUILD OUT THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF EIGHT
HEARING.
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 114.
ALAN I RODRIGO I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEAR I BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DALLY KNOW DODD.
I DURAZZO I EGMOND.
GLASER.
GONZALEZ A GROVE.
NO RETARDO.
I.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD.
I NAMAN I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
NO OKOBO.
NO PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO I CIERTO NO
SKINNER.
A SMALL.
STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WINNER.
I WILL.
NO.
SENATOR DURAZZO MOVES TO CALL.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON
THE FOUL LINE IN 120.
SENATOR NEWMAN, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 1119 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO HOSPITALS AND
DECLARING
THE URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1119, WHICH
WOULD AUTHORIZE
A LIMITED NUMBER OF NARROW CASE
SPECIFIC EXTENSIONS
OF THE 2025 SEISMIC COMPLIANCE
DEADLINES MANDATED
BY AB 21 2190 FOR THREE
HOSPITALS,
WHICH ARE PART OF THE PROVIDENCE
HEALTH GROUP,
EACH OF WHICH IS ACTIVELY
WORKING
TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE.
MORE SPECIFICALLY, SB 1119
WOULD AUTHORIZE EXTENSIONS
OF TWO ADDITIONAL YEARS FOR
PROVIDENCE
SAINT JUDE MEDICAL CENTER IN
FULLERTON AND PROVIDENCE
SAINT JOSEPH HOSPITAL IN EUREKA,
AND AN EXTENSION OF ONE
ADDITIONAL
YEAR FOR PROVIDENCE
CEDARS-SINAI TARZANA MEDICAL
CENTER IN LOS ANGELES.
AS WITHIN SO MANY OTHER AREAS,
THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC CAUSED
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES
IN THE FINANCIAL PRIORITIES AND
CONDITIONS
OF HOSPITALS ACROSS THE STATE,
REQUIRING MANY HOSPITALS TO
FOCUS ON ENSURING
ADEQUATE CAPACITY AND PATIENT
CARE,
IN MANY CASES AT THE EXPENSE OF
OTHER PRIORITIES OR MANDATES.
THIS WAS THE CASE WITH RESPECT
TO THE THREE
PROVIDENCE FACILITIES COVERED BY
THIS BILL,
WITHOUT THE EXTENSIONS PROVIDED
FOR BY THIS.
BY THIS LEGISLATION, AS A RESULT
OF FAILING
TO MEET THE PRESCRIBED
DEADLINES,
THESE HOSPITALS WILL LOSE THEIR
LICENSURE AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE WILL LOSE ACCESS TO
VITAL CARE.
THE LIMITED EXTENSIONS PROVIDED
FOR BY THIS BILL
ARE NARROWLY TAILORED TO ENSURE
THAT NONE
OF THESE THREE IMPORTANT AREA
HOSPITALS ARE
FORCED TO CLOSE VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE,
WHILE MAINTAINING THE
REQUIREMENTS
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS RIGHTFULLY PLACED ON
HOSPITALS ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS PREVIOUSLY
RECOGNIZED
THAT SUCH EXTENSIONS ARE
REASONABLE
AND WILL ALLOW FOR THE
COMPLETION OF THIS
TYPE OF ESSENTIAL INFRASTRUCTURE
WORK,
WHILE ENSURING CONTINUOUS
PATIENT
CARE AT EACH FACILITY
IN COMMUNITIES WHERE THAT CARE
IS DESPERATELY NEEDED.
I AM RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
YOUR I VOTE THIS EVENING.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE.
SECRETARY.
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 120.
ALAN ALVARADO GAIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY I ATKINS I.
BECKER I.
BLAKESBERG I.
BRADFORD I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ.
I.
DALY.
I DIED.
I THOUGHT ALSO I EGGMAN.
I, EGGMAN.
HI, GLASER.
GONZALEZ A GROVE.
I.
JONES.
HI THERE.
I.
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR A MAN.
I NEWMAN I WIN I NILO I AKOBO I
PODIUM.
I PONTINO.
I ROTH, I RUBIO.
I SEE OTTO.
ITES.
SKINNER.
I SMOKE, I STERN I UMMER.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WILL I.
SENATOR NEWMAN.
NEWMAN MOVES THE CALL.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 131.
SENATOR MINJERRIBAH.
SHE IS READY.
SECRETARY.
YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 959 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR.
AN ACT RELATING TO TRANS
INCLUSIVE CARE.
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
SB 959 WILL ESTABLISH A WEBSITE
RESOURCE FOR TRANSGENDER,
GENDER DIVERSE AND INTERSEX
PEOPLE
AND THEIR FAMILIES TO ACCESS
RELIABLE INFORMATION
ABOUT ACCESS TO TRANS INCLUSIVE
HEALTHCARE,
EXISTING LEGAL PROTECTIONS FOR
PATIENTS
AND HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS,
ALONG WITH OTHER SUPPORT
SERVICES.
IDENTIFYING HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS WHO
OFFER GENDER AFFIRMING CARE
WITHIN
THEIR HEALTH PLAN CAN BE VERY
HARD FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS POPULATION.
THESE ACCESS ISSUES EXACERBATE
EXISTING HEALTH
AND DISPARITIES AMONG
CALIFORNIANS,
WHO ARE MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS
AND EXPERIENCE HIGHER RATES OF
HEALTH
CONCERNS RELATED TO HIV,
SUBSTANCE USE, MENTAL ILLNESS,
AND SEXUAL AND PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE.
THE WEBSITE WILL SHOWCASE
EXISTING LEGAL PROTECTIONS
FOR PATIENTS AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS,
HOW TO ACCESS HEALTH PLAN
PROVIDER DIRECTORIES FOR
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE PAYMENT
SUPPORT RESOURCES,
INCLUDING COVERAGE OPTIONS
AND FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS.
SUPPORT SERVICES INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION
AND FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM?
HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE.
ITEM 131.
ELLEN ALVARADO.
GILL I.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY.
I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I BLAKE SPEAR.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
I CORTEZ I DALLY.
NO, DODD.
I THOUGHT OSO I EGGMAN, I
GLASER.
GONZALEZ A GROVE.
NO POTATO.
I.
JONES.
NO LAIRD I.
LEMON.
I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
I, NEWMAN, I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
PADILLA.
I PORTENTINO.
I ROD I RUBIO.
I SAY NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL CREVICE.
A STERN.
A.
I.
WAHAB.
I WIENER, I WOKE.
NO.
SENATOR RIVERA MOVES, MOVES THE
CALL.
NEXT UP, MEMBERS.
IN THE FOLLOWING ORDER, WE'LL BE
TAKING
UP FILE ITEM 137150 AND 151.
SENATOR LAMONE.
SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 1036 BY SENATOR
LAMONT.
AN ACT RELATING TO GREENHOUSE
GASES.
SENATOR LAMONT.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TO PRESENT SB 1036,
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
PROTECTIONS
FOR PURCHASERS OF CARBON
OFFSETS.
CARBON OFFSETS ARE TRADABLE
FINANCIAL
INSTRUMENTS THAT CLAIM TO
REPRESENT A REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE
GASES IN THE ATMOSPHERE.
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS AND
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTERS
HAVE UNCOVERED MANY EXAMPLES OF
OFFSETS,
PROJECTS THAT SIMPLY FAIL TO
DELIVER
THE CLAIMED CARBON REDUCTIONS OR
REMOVALS.
LOW QUALITY OFFSETS HARM
THE PURCHASER OF THE OFFSET,
AS WELL AS UNDERMINE OUR CLIMATE
MITIGATION EFFORTS.
WITH SUCH A STEEP HILL TO CLIMB
TO
ADDRESS OUR CLIMATE CHALLENGES,
WE SIMPLY CANNOT ALLOW FOR LOW
QUALITY
OFFSETS TO GET IN THE WAY.
SB 1036 PROVIDES LEGALLY
ENFORCEABLE STANDARDS
FOR VOLUNTARY CARBON CARBON
OFFSETS,
NOT COMPLIANCE OFFSETS, A POLICY
THAT IS LONG
OVERDUE FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
AND CLIMATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM?
HEARING.
SEEING.
NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 137.
ALAN.
ARRUDA.
GIL NO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DELI.
DODD.
I TORAZO, I EGMAN, I GLASER.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
ODOARDO.
TY JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I.
LEHMAN I.
MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I.
MEN.
I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO.
NILO.
NO AKOBO.
PEDDUR I.
PORTANTINO.
HI, ROD I RUBIO.
CIERTO.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILE, CLEVER'S EYES TURN.
I UMMAT.
WAHAB.
A WIENER.
I WILL I.
SENATOR LAMONT MOVES THE CALL.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
SENATE BILL 1131 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
AN ACT RELATING TO MEDI-CAL.
SENATOR GONZALEZ.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1131 WHICH
WILL ENSURE ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES FOR LOW
INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE.
SB 1131 WILL STREAMLINE THE
PROGRAM BY CLARIFYING
THAT THE PACK PROGRAM BY
CLARIFYING THAT
A SITE CERTIFIER CAN BE ANY
CLINICIAN THAT
OVERSEES FAMILY PACK SERVICES AT
THE SITE.
IT PROVIDERS SHALL, AT LEAST SIX
MONTHS,
SHALL AT LEAST USE SIX
MONTHS TO COMPLETE PROGRAM
ORIENTATION
AFTER ENROLLMENT,
AND THAT DCS MUST OFFER
TRAININGS
VIRTUALLY ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
THESE ARE CRITICAL CHANGES TO
ENSURING THAT FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ARE ACCESSIBLE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE ON SB 1131.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM?
HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY.
YOU MAY CALL THE ROLE ON FILE
ITEM 150.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL I.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS, I.
BECKER, I.
BLAKE.
SPEER, I.
BRADFORD.
I.
CABALLERO, I.
CORTEZ.
I.
DALLY.
NO.
DODD I DURAZZO I EGMOND I
GLASER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE, NO.
HURTADO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I LEMON.
I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
NEWMAN I WIN.
NO NO NO NO NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH, I RUBIO.
I.
SATO.
NO, SKINNER.
SMALL CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I
WAHAB.
I WIENER, I WOKE.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
GLASER.
MAGUIRE, I MEAN, I.
SKINNER.
I.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME.
ALAN.
GLASER.
SENATOR GLASER, ARE YOU?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
ALLAN.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
EYES 31.
NOSE EIGHT.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP WE HAVE SENATOR SKINNER
FOR SENATOR ALAN.
&GT;&GT; WELL.
NO.
I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY.
MY.
MY BAD.
SENATOR SKINNER, WE HAVE FIRST
UP, WE HAVE.
SENATOR BECKER WOULD FILE ITEM
151,
FOLLOWED BY 152 BY SENATOR
SKINNER FOR ALAN,
AND THEN ONE SIX, THREE BY
BECKER AGAIN.
SO, SENATOR BECKER, SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1133 BY SENATOR
BECKER.
AN ACT RELATING TO BAIL.
&GT;&GT; I THANK YOU.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1133, THE
REASONABLE
RECONSIDERATION ACT.
THE BILL TAKES A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO IMPROVING
THE PRETRIAL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHEN A PERSON APPEARS BEFORE
THE COURT FOR THE FIRST TIME,
A JUDGE TYPICALLY SETS THEIR
BAIL IN
A MATTER OF MINUTES OR EVEN
SECONDS,
AND WITHOUT MUCH INFORMATION IN
FRONT
OF THEM TO INFORM THAT DECISION.
THANK YOU.
AS A RESULT, THERE ARE MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT CAN ARISE AFTER THE INITIAL
HEARING THAT MAY JUSTIFY A
MODIFICATION
OF THE INITIAL BAIL AMOUNT,
BUT IT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY TO GET
BACK INTO
COURT AND ARGUE FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN.
THIS BILL DOES TWO THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, IT ALIGNS THE
EVIDENTIARY
STANDARD FOR BAIL
REVIEW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT STANDARD.
AND TWO, IT CREATES AN AUTOMATIC
REVIEW
OF NON-MONETARY PRETRIAL
CONDITIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BECKER.
ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD ON
THIS MEASURE?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
NO.
ARCHULETA, I.
ASHBY.
HI, ATKINS.
HI, BECKER.
HI, BLAKE.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I.
CORTAZZI I.
DALLEY.
NO.
DODD.
DURAZZO I.
EGGMAN.
I.
GLASER.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
NO.
OTOTO.
GOT.
JONES.
NO LAYERED.
I THE MONEY.
I MAGUIRE, I MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
NEW NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO NILO.
NO OKOBO, NO PIDIO.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO I CIERTO NO SKINNER I
SMALL CUEVAS I STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WOKE?
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN BRADFORD A.
DONE.
I.
FURTADO.
MEN.
AYES 28.
NOES NINE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 152.
SENATE BILL 1143 BY SENATOR
ALAN.
SENATOR SKINNER, PRESENTING.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1143 BY SENATOR
ALLEN.
AN ACT RELATING TO HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS.
SENATOR SKINNER, THANK YOU.
&GT;&GT; I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB 1143
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR ALLEN.
AND, UH, ALMOST, UH, ARRIVED,
BABY, UM.
ALL OF US KNOW THAT WE ANY TIME
WE'RE
AT HOME AND WE OPEN A CUPBOARD,
WE OPEN THAT CUPBOARD UNDER
THE SINK OR IN OUR LAUNDRY ROOM.
WE HAVE MANY, MANY GOODS OR
MATERIALS THAT ARE
CLASSIFIED AS HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE.
BUT MOST OF US DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO WITH THOSE
PRODUCTS.
AND WHILE THOSE OF US WHO MAY
KNOW THAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED WE CAN'T THROW THEM IN
THE TRASH,
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BRING THEM TO
A EITHER TO HAVE THEM COLLECTED
IN THE HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE
COLLECTION,
OR BRING THEM TO A PROPER
DISPOSAL SITE.
IT'S NOT EASY.
SOMETIMES OUR COMMUNITIES DON'T
HAVE THAT COLLECTION.
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES DON'T
HAVE THOSE DISPOSAL SITES,
AND IT'S GETTING INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT.
BUT IF THEY'RE PUT IN THE TRASH
AND THEY GO TO
OUR REGULAR LANDFILLS OR OTHER
FACILITIES,
THEY CAN CREATE GREAT PROBLEMS.
NOW, CALRECYCLE OFFERS GRANTS TO
COMMUNITIES
TO BUILD NEW FACILITIES,
BUT THE FUNDING HAS FALLEN FAR
SHORT OF WHAT'S NEEDED.
CAL RECYCLES GRANT PROGRAM IS
CAPPED AT
5 MILLION A YEAR, AND, FOR
EXAMPLE,
THE EXPECTED CONSTRUCTION OF A
NEW FACILITY
IN SONOMA IS BETWEEN 13 TO $16
MILLION.
SO TO ADDRESS BOTH THE CRUSHING
COSTS AND THE LACK
OF CONVENIENT ACCESS TO A PROPER
DISPOSAL SYSTEM,
SB 1143 REQUIRES PRODUCERS OF
THE MOST TOXIC
CONSUMER PRODUCTS TO FORM A
PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY ORGANIZATION THAT
WILL BE TASKED WITH ENHANCING
THE ACCESSIBILITY AND FULLY
FUNDING
THE SAFE COLLECTION,
TRANSPORTATION, AND DISPOSAL OF
OUR HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE.
IT ALLOWS PRODUCERS TO COST
EFFECTIVELY IMPROVE ACCESS
TO CONVENIENT HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE DISPOSAL.
THEY CAN EITHER FUND AN IMPROVED
LOCAL SYSTEM
OR CREATE AN ALTERNATIVE SYSTEM.
IT'S AN OUTCOMES BASED APPROACH
AND IT GIVES PRODUCERS
FLEXIBILITY.
SB 1143 ALSO REQUIRES ROBUST
EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH TO ENSURE THAT WE
ALL KNOW HOW,
WHICH PRODUCTS ARE TOXIC
AND HOW TO HANDLE THEM PROPERLY.
SB 1143 ENCOURAGES PRODUCERS TO
INVEST
IN LESS TOXIC ALTERNATIVES,
AND IF A PRODUCER WOULD PREFER
NOT TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
ORGANIZATION,
THEY CAN REFORMULATE THEIR
PRODUCT
TO A NON-TOXIC ALTERNATIVE.
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE
PRODUCTS ARE
TOO WIDESPREAD TO TACKLE THIS
PROBLEM.
PRODUCT BY PRODUCT.
SB 1143 ESTABLISHES A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM TO
ADDRESS THE MOST DANGEROUS
CONSUMER PRODUCTS,
AND SHIFTS THE BURDEN OF PAYING
THEIR END OF LIFE MANAGEMENT
AWAY FROM OUR LOCAL COUNTIES AND
CITIES,
WHICH IS US AND TO THE
PRODUCERS.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER,
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR ALLEN.
SENATOR DOLLY.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I, I SAW THIS BILL IN
EC
AND I'M OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
THIS IS THE NEW THEME.
NOW POLLUTER PAYS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHAT
THE THE TALK WAS IN THE
COMMITTEE.
POLLUTERS PAY AND BUT THESE ARE
HOUSEHOLD
PRODUCTS WE USE EVERY DAY.
THESE ARE.
THESE ARE JUST WINDEX.
THIS IS BLEACH.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
KEEP SANITARY.
THESE ARE PRODUCTS WE USE EVERY
DAY IN OUR HOMES.
AND THIS BILL IS ANOTHER REASON
WHY CALIFORNIA IS UNAFFORDABLE.
THIS IS GOING TO TRICKLE DOWN TO
THE CONSUMER AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A MANDATE
PUT ON BY THIS BILL,
AND THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
ACTION TAKEN,
ANOTHER REGULATION THAT'S GOING
TO FORCE CALIFORNIANS
TO HAVE TO PAY FOR THE THINGS
THEY CONSUME.
SO I JUST WANT TO GO ON RECORD
AS SAYING THIS IS
ANOTHER HIGH COST OF LIVING
CALIFORNIA BILL,
WHICH IN MY MIND WON'T DO MUCH
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I OPPOSE
THE BILL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DOLLY.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE?
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
UM.
THANK YOU.
I THINK I GAVE A PRETTY GOOD
EXPLANATION.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GILL.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
I BLAKESBURG I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLY NO DODD I THOUGHT OSO I
EGGMAN I GLASER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO OR DATO.
I.
JONES.
NO, LAIRD, I LAMENT.
I MAGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN, I
NEWMAN I WIN.
NO NILO, NO OJOBO, NO PADILLA I
PORTENTINO.
I WROTE.
I RUBIO.
CIERTO.
NO SKINNER, A SMALL CUEVAS,
A STERN, A UMBERG, A WAHAB.
A WIENER.
I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL.
ARCHULETA I.
GLASER I, I.
RUBIO, I WILL.
EYES 30.
NOSE SEVEN.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 163 BY
SENATOR BECKER, SB 1254.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1254 BY SENATOR
BECKER.
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES.
SENATOR BECKER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE,
SB 1254 WILL ALLOW INCARCERATED
PEOPLE TO
SIGN UP FOR CALFRESH BENEFITS UP
TO 90
DAYS BEFORE THEIR RELEASE AND
UPSET.
I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD
ON THIS MEASURE?
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
OH, RODRIGO I ARCHULETA.
ASHBY.
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
CORTEZI.
I.
DALLI.
GOD.
I THOUGHT ALSO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
UH, JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I LEMAN I MAGUIRE I
MENGIBAR.
HI, MAN.
HI, NEWMAN.
I WIN.
NO NILO.
NO AQUEBOGUE.
BUT HERE I WANT TO KNOW.
I RATHER.
I RUBIO I CIERTO NO.
SKINNER.
A SMALL QUAVERS I STERNE I
HAMBURG
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ARCHULETA I.
CABALLERO I.
DALLY I.
A THROWBACK.
ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 5.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 164.
THIS IS SB 1261 BY SENATOR
ALVARADO GILL.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1261 BY SENATOR
ALVARADO GILL.
AN ACT RELATING TO HORSE RACING.
SENATOR.
SENATOR ALVARADO GILL.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I'VE WAITED ALL NIGHT FOR THIS
ONE.
SENATE BILL 1261 WOULD ADJUST
THE PERCENTAGE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE
BUDGET THAT'S DEDICATED TO FAIRS
AND EXPOSITION
FUND FROM THREE FOURTHS OF 1% TO
3%.
THIS IS NOT NEW MONEY.
THIS IS A REALLOCATION OF MONEY
THAT'S ALREADY IN EXISTENCE.
THE FAIRS AND EXPOSITION FUND
SUPPORTS PROJECT OF THE FAIRS
THAT ADDRESS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE,
EMERGENCY SERVICES,
PROTECTION OF FAIR PROPERTY, AND
THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF ALL ITS VISITORS.
I JUST CAME BACK FROM THE FAIR
THIS WEEKEND
AND ONLY HALF OF THEM LIVED IN
MY DISTRICT.
THE OTHER HALF, YES,
ABOUT 50% LIVED IN ALL OF YOUR
DISTRICTS,
SO I WAS VERY HAPPY TO HOST THEM
AT OUR ANNUAL FAIR.
WITHOUT THE ADJUSTED PERCENTAGE
DEDICATED
TO THE FAIRS AND EXPOSITION
FUND,
CALIFORNIA'S FAIRS WILL RUN A
RISK OF NOT RECEIVING
THE NECESSARY FUNDING THEY NEED.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE THIS IS NOT NEW MONEY.
THIS IS NOT TAKING MONEY FROM
PREVIOUS CUTS.
THIS IS READJUSTING CUTS OR
READJUSTING
MONIES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR EGGMAN ON THIS MEASURE.
UH, JUST A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR.
THE AUTHOR TOOK A QUESTION.
UH, YES, SENATOR EGGMAN.
UH, SO IT SAYS THE FISCAL
EFFECT.
THIS BILL IS ESTIMATED TO RESULT
IN
AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT ADDITIONAL
8.5
MILLION, UM, FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO CDFA.
SO YOU'RE SAYING.
WHAT'S THE QUESTION?
I'M SORRY.
THE QUESTION IS THIS IS NOT.
YOU'RE SAYING THIS IS NOT NEW
MONEY?
WHERE IS IT COMING FROM?
YEAH, IT'S NOT NEW MONEY.
SO THE MONEY WAS ALREADY IN
EXISTENCE.
THESE ARE ALREADY REVENUES THAT
ARE
GENERATED AT THE FAIR LEVEL.
SO WHEN FAIRGOERS GO TO THE FAIR
AND THEY PURCHASE ITEMS,
THEY PURCHASE THEIR CRAFTS
AND THEY CONTRIBUTE TO TAXES.
THOSE TAXES THEN GET SHIFTED
OVER
TO THE STATE AND GET ALLOTTED
TO,
UM, TO THE FAIRS AND ALLOCATION
FUND.
RIGHT.
SO THIS IS A SHIFT OF THAT MONEY
THAT'S
ALREADY MOVING TO THAT FUND.
MHM.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MATTER?
SENATOR DALI BAI MAY TRY TO HELP
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
THE BEAN COUNTERS DON'T COUNT
THE MONEY COMING IN.
AND SO IT'S THE ISSUE IS THAT
THEY DO GENERATE THE MONEY,
BUT IT GOES INTO THE FUND,
INTO THE GENERAL FUND AND THEN
HAS TO BE ALLOCATED OUT.
BUT IT IS FAIR MONEY THAT COMES
IN.
THAT'S I THINK, A BETTER WAY TO
LOOK AT IT.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
ARGUING FOR MANY YEARS.
SOME OF WHO REPRESENTS NOW
15 COUNTIES AND 15 AFFAIRS
OR ACTUALLY MORE THAN THAT, I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DALI.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE?
HE ASKED FOR AN I VOTE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
THERE IS AN OBJECTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL A ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS
I BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR I
BRADFORD.
I.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ I.
DALLY.
I.
DODD.
DORADO I.
EGGMAN.
GLASER I.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE.
I OR DATO.
I JONES I LAIRD, I LEHMAN, I
MCGUIRE.
A MENGIBAR.
MEN I KNEW, MEN I WIN.
I NILO I OKOBO I PODIUM.
I PORTENTINO.
I BROUGHT I RUBIO I CIERTO I
SKINNER.
IT'S MY OLD QUAVERS.
ICE CHURN.
I UMBERG.
I.
WIENER.
I WILL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN BRADFORD A.
EGGMAN.
I MENGIBAR.
WAHAB.
AYES 37.
NO, ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS.
AT LEAST I'M SHOWING UP HERE
THAT WE HAVE ABOUT
FOUR MEASURES LEFT TO CONSIDER
TONIGHT.
PLUS MEASURES ON CALL.
SO THAT CAN CHANGE, SUBJECT TO
CHANGE.
BUT THAT'S WHAT I SHOW HERE ON
MY DOCKET.
THE FOUR ITEMS THAT WERE
SCHEDULED
TO STILL HERE TONIGHT.
OUR FILE ITEM 176, FOLLOWED BY
FILE ITEM 177,
FILE ITEM 180 AND FILE ITEM 223.
OKAY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
FILE ITEM 176.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1433 BY
SENATOR LAMONE.
SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE.
READ SENATE BILL 1433 BY SENATOR
LEHMAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO OIL AND GAS
WELLS.
SENATOR LEHMAN.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES,
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
HAS PROJECTED THAT WE WILL NEED
ABOUT 52,000MW
OF ENERGY STORAGE CAPACITY BY
TO MEET ELECTRICITY DEMAND.
TO REACH THIS GOAL, WE WOULD
NEED
A VARIETY OF TYPES OF ENERGY
STORAGE,
LARGE AND SMALL, ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE STATE ALSO HAS 39,000 IDLE
OIL WELLS.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM
TO STUDY THE USE OF GRAVITY
WELLS,
AND HOW THIS TECHNOLOGY CAN USE
IDLE OIL
WELLS TO CREATE MORE ENERGY
STORAGE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
PERMITTING OF GRAVITY WELLS
WITH APPROPRIATE TESTING AND
REPORTING AFTERWARDS.
TO DETERMINE THE IMPACTS OF THIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LEMON.
ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD ON
THIS MEASURE?
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE
HEARD?
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA.
I.
ASHBY.
BY ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR
I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALY.
DAD I TORAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ.
A GROVE.
HURTADO I.
JONES.
NO.
LAIRD I LYMAN I MCGUIRE.
MENJIVAR I.
MAGUIRE I.
MEN I.
NEWMAN.
I WHEN?
NILO.
AKOBO.
NO.
BUT YOU.
I PORTANTINO.
I ROD I RUBIO.
ISOTHERM?
NO.
SKINNER.
A SMILE QUIVERS A STERN.
I UMBERG.
I WAHAB.
UH, WIENER I WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
DALY.
GROVE.
WHEN?
NILO.
NO.
I'S 32 NOS FOR THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 177.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1446 BY
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1446 BY SENATOR
SAMUEL CUEVAS.
AN ACT RELATING TO PRIVATE
EMPLOYMENT.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND GOOD EVENING,
COLLEAGUES.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB 1446,
THE RETAIL THEFT PREVENTION AND
SAFE STAFFING ACT.
THIS ACT WILL PROTECT WORKERS
AND THE PUBLIC
BY ENSURING SAFE STAFFING LEVELS
AT STORES,
WHICH UTILIZE SELF-CHECKOUT AND
ESTABLISHED
GUARDRAILS TO PREVENT
WORKER DISPLACEMENT WHEN
EMPLOYERS
ADOPT NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
AS AMENDED, THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE STORES
AS DEFINED IN THE LABOR CODE,
INCLUDING WALMART, TARGET,
RALEY'S,
AND ANY RETAIL DRUG
ESTABLISHMENTS WITH 75 STORES
OR MORE TO ENACT SAFE STAFFING
MEASURES,
INCLUDING ENSURING AT LEAST ONE
MANUAL CHECKOUT
LANE IS OPEN BEFORE SELF
CHECKOUT STANDS.
REQUIRE STAFFING RATIOS OF TWO
CHECKOUT STANDS
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF A
SINGLE EMPLOYEE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT IT ONLY
BE THE POLICY
OF THE STORE TO ADOPT A 15 ITEM
LIMIT POLICY
THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE WORKERS TO
POLICE CUSTOMERS
TO ENSURE SAFETY IN THE
CHECKOUT.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
BILL TONIGHT,
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AND
I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR UMBERG FOR HIS
TIME,
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL THAT HAD TO DO WITH THE
ASSESSMENTS,
THAT WE REMOVED, THAT LANGUAGE
FROM
THE BILL AND WHAT WE HAVE, UH,
COME TO SOME UNDERSTANDING ON IS
THAT
IF AN EMPLOYER INTENDS TO
IMPLEMENT
CONSEQUENTIAL WORKPLACE
TECHNOLOGY
THAT SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS,
ELIMINATES OR AUTOMATES THE JOB
FUNCTIONS AGREED
UPON BETWEEN AN EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE,
UPON HIRE, OR FOLLOWING A
SUBSEQUENT
CHANGE IN POSITION OR
DEPARTMENT.
THE EMPLOYER MUST NOTIFY THE
WORKERS,
THEIR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING REPRESENTATIVE AND
THE PUBLIC.
60 DAYS IN ADVANCE, WITH A
GENERAL DESCRIPTION
OF THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE
INTENDED PURPOSE.
CONSEQUENTIAL WORKPLACE
TECHNOLOGY INCLUDES,
BUT IS NOT LIMITED TO SELF
CHECKOUT,
ROBOTICS, WEARABLE SENSORS,
SCANNERS,
OR ELECTRONIC MONITORING.
IN RECENT YEARS, AUTOMATION IN
OUR RETAIL,
GROCERY AND DRUG STORES HAVE
DRAMATICALLY CUT WORKERS,
CONTRIBUTING TO CHRONIC
UNDERSTAFFING IN OUR STORES.
LONE FRONT LINE CLERKS ARE
FORCED TO SERVE CUSTOMERS
WHILE MONITORING SEVERAL
SELF-CHECKOUT STANDS,
LEAVING THESE STORES EASY
TARGETS
FOR THEFT AND WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE.
ALL THE WHILE, RETAIL RETAILERS
CONTINUE
TO EXPRESS CONCERNS THAT
RISING RATES OF THEFT CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
DATA AND REPORTING HAVE SHOWN
THAT SELF-CHECKOUT
HAS CONTRIBUTED TO THE RISE IN
RETAIL THEFT.
IN OUR STATE.
AN ESTIMATED 20 MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE
STOLEN FROM A SELF-CHECKOUT
KIOSK,
WITH ANOTHER 8.8 MILLION SAYING
THEY PLAN TO DO IT AGAIN.
STUDIES AND REPORTS BY THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY
ALSO FIND THAT THERE IS FAR LESS
LOSS IF THERE IS A STAFF PRESENT
OBSERVING
THE CHECKOUT LANES AND AISLES.
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY FROM THE
COMPUTER,
COMPUTER AND COMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION STATED THAT
MERCHENDISE LOSS THROUGH
SELF-CHECKOUT CAUSES MORE
SHRINK THAN ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME IN MANY STORES.
MANY STORES, INCLUDING WALMART
AND TARGET AND DOLLAR GENERAL,
HAVE RECOGNIZED THESE CHALLENGES
AND HAVE BEGUN TO
REGULATE AND ELIMINATE
SELF-CHECKOUT ALTOGETHER.
UH, I WANT TO CONCLUDE AGAIN BY
SAYING THAT I HAVE
CONTINUED TO WORK UP UNTIL
THROUGH DINNER,
UP UNTIL THE VERY MINUTE ON THIS
BILL,
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS ABOUT THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING,
MAKING SURE THAT CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS ARE SAFE,
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING
RETAIL THEFT UP STREAM AS WELL
AS,
YOU KNOW, WE ARE DEALING WITH
IT,
AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A LOT
OF THOSE BILLS ON TOMORROW,
DEAL WITH IT DOWNSTREAM,
BUT THAT WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT
BRINGS EVERYONE TO THE TABLE.
AND I THINK WE CAME TO A POINT
TODAY THAT
AND I APPRECIATE AGAIN, SENATOR
UMBERG,
THE MOST IMPORTANT POINT HERE AS
WE THINK ABOUT THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS HOW DO WE PROTECT FOLKS
AGAINST JOB LOSS?
THAT IS THE MAIN THING.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE TOPIC OF AI.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE TOPIC OF WHAT
THE GENERAL IMPACTS WILL BE.
BUT WHEN WE ARE INTRODUCING THAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE ARE DOING,
SO RECOGNIZING THAT THAT
TECHNOLOGY
HAS AN IMPACT ON WORKERS.
AND SO FOR ME, I FEEL THAT WE
HAVE DONE ALL
THE WORK THAT WE COULD POSSIBLY
DO ON THIS BILL.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT
AS IT MOVES TO THE ASSEMBLY.
I HOPE THAT YOU ALL ARE TRUSTING
IN THIS COMPROMISE
THAT WE STRUCK TONIGHT AND THAT
WE CONTINUE.
YOU TO SEE IT THROUGH.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
I SEE A MICROPHONE UP FROM
SENATOR UMBERG FIRST.
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
AND COLLEAGUES AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES IS
CORRECT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING UP TO THE LAST
TEN MINUTES ON THIS ISSUE WITH A
ROBUST DISCUSSION
CONCERNING THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL.
THE COMPONENT THIS THIS BILL HAS
TWO SIGNIFICANT ELEMENTS TO IT.
ONE IS WITH RESPECT TO KIOSKS
AND HOW THAT PERSONNEL WILL
BE ADDRESSED IN TERMS OF
OPERATION
OF KIOSK AND SO FORTH.
AND THE SECOND COMPONENT IS THE
BILL IN PRINT
ADDRESSED WAS ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE, AS
WE'VE HEARD HERE TODAY,
IS OF GREAT CONSEQUENCE TO
THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT.
IT'S OF GREAT CONSEQUENCE TO
THE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA.
UH, I HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE COMPONENTS OF THIS
BILL.
UM, THE REFERENCE TO ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE HAS BEEN REMOVED.
THE ASSESSMENT PRE THE
EMPLOYMENT
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
INTELLIGENCE HAS BEEN REMOVED.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS,
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES,
IS CORRECT THAT THE BILL NOW AND
I RECOGNIZE
NO ONE HAS SEEN IT IN PRINT.
BUT THIS IS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES.
HIS COMMITMENT IS TO AMEND
THE BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY TO
REMOVE
THOSE PROVISIONS AND INSERT A
NOTICE PROVISION THAT,
AS YOU HEARD, SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS
REVIEWED THAT THAT NOTICE
PROVISION.
UH, THIS BILL HAS SOME STILL HAS
SOME CHALLENGES,
BUT BUT I AM GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL WITH THE COMMITMENT.
AND SENATOR CUEVAS HAS WORKED IN
GOOD FAITH WITH THE COMMITMENT
TO TAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND WITH THAT,
WITH WITH THAT COMMITMENT, I
WOULD URGE AN I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE.
SENATOR DASCHLE AND SENATOR
CIERTOS.
SENATOR DASCHLE.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE
VOTING
ON SOME STUFF WE HAVEN'T SEEN,
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT WOULD
CONVINCE
ME TO VOTE FOR THE BILL ANYWAY.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, AS SOMEBODY
WHO
RUNS A BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA,
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF YOU ON
THIS FLOOR HAVE EMPLOYEES.
I KNOW THERE'S AT LEAST ONE
OTHER MEMBER THAT
ACTUALLY RUNS A BUSINESS AND HAS
EMPLOYEES,
BUT OUR BUSINESSES ARE ABOUT
COMPETITION
AND OUR BUSINESSES ARE ABOUT THE
BOTTOM LINE,
AND OUR BUSINESSES ARE ABOUT
SERVICE.
WE HAVE TO COMPETE AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
AND THIS BILL IS IS WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS OR LAST
8 OR 9 YEARS,
IS THAT TECHNOLOGY AND
REGULATIONS CHANGE,
QUITE FRANKLY,
MORE REGULATIONS THAN
TECHNOLOGY.
AND WE HAVE TO COMPETE.
WE HAVE TO STAY WITH IT.
SO WHEN WE DOWNSIZE OR UPSIZE,
WE USE WE WE MAKE OUR BUSINESSES
MORE EFFICIENT.
TO BE COMPETITIVE.
AND THEN WE COME BACK WITH BILLS
THAT SAY, NO,
YOU CAN'T LAY THESE PEOPLE OFF
AND YOU
CAN'T MAKE YOUR BUSINESS
EFFICIENT.
SO WE LEGISLATE THEN TO CONTROL,
YOU KNOW,
CERTAIN SIZE OF BUSINESSES HAVE
TO DO THESE THINGS.
WE SAW THAT WITH THE $20 AN HOUR
FOR FAST
FOOD RESTAURANTS JUST LAST YEAR.
MEMBERS.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT IN
CALIFORNIA TO RUN A BUSINESS
AND BUSINESSES ARE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA,
AND THE COST OF ALL PRODUCTS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE GOING UP.
I DON'T THINK THAT I'M THE ONLY
ONE THAT'S
HEARING FROM MY CONSTITUENTS.
WE TALK ABOUT INFLATION AND IT
IS HAPPENING.
AND THIS TYPE OF REGULATION
DRIVES IT UP
EVEN MORE WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THEFT.
THE AUTHOR TALKED ABOUT THEFT
AND THEFT IN THIS BILL.
PROPOSITION 47 CAUSES THEFT.
PEOPLE GO IN THE STORE, STOLE
$150,
AND WE'VE SEEN VIDEOS OF THAT.
WE ALL PAY FOR THAT.
THAT DRIVES UP THE COST OF.
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR THE STORE.
WE PAY FOR THAT.
AND YES, THEY DO MAKE.
I'VE MADE AN ACCIDENT AT THE
TRYING TO BUY
THE FRUIT AND GETTING THE RIGHT
NUMBER
IN THE IN THE SELF-CHECKOUT
CAUGHT IT
THANKFULLY WAS ABLE TO RECTIFY
IT.
BUT I KNOW THAT THERE'S PEOPLE
THAT STEAL
AND AND USE THAT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THE BUSINESS MAKES THE DECISION
WHETHER
IT'S CHEAPER TO HAVE LOSE SOME
OF
THE PRODUCT OR PUT A BODY THERE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY, IF YOU LOSE
SOME OF SOME OF YOUR
PRODUCT AND YOU DON'T HAVE A
PERSON THERE,
PEOPLE IN BUSINESS EMPLOYEES
ARE THE BIGGEST LIABILITY.
THEY CAN SUE YOU.
THEY DON'T SHOW UP ON TIME.
SOMETIMES.
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF REASONS
THAT PEOPLE, PERSONS.
ARE VERY DIFFICULT A MACHINE.
YOU TURN THE BUTTON ON AND IT
WORKS.
IF IT'S BROKE DOWN, YOU FIX IT.
IT DOESN'T SHOW UP LATE, IT
DOESN'T GET SICK.
THAT'S COMPETITION.
SO.
WE.
WE SHOULDN'T BE GETTING IN THE
MIDDLE OF ALL THAT.
LET THE BUSINESSES FIGURE OUT
HOW TO RUN THEIR BUSINESSES,
DRIVE THE COST OF PRODUCTS DOWN
SO CALIFORNIANS
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE HERE.
AND WE CAN HAVE THRIVING
BUSINESSES
THAT WILL STAY IN CALIFORNIA.
SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS AND
MANY MORE,
I WILL BE VOTING AGAINST
AND URGE A NO VOTE ON SB 1446.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
SENATOR SATO.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I TOO AM.
&GT;&GT; RISING IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
UH, FIRST, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THIS
BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
RETAIL THEFT.
THIS HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
TRYING
TO FIX THE DAMAGE THAT WE HAVE
DONE
TO THE EMPLOYMENT OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE
BY CREATING EMPLOYMENT LAWS.
THEY REMOVED THEIR JOBS AND MAKE
IT MORE OR MORE PROFITABLE.
BUT BUT FROM A SURVIVABILITY FOR
BUSINESSES,
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THEY SWITCH
OVER TO SOMETHING ELSE
THAT DOESN'T COST AS MUCH AS OF
AS AN EMPLOYEE DOES.
AND WHAT ARE SOME OF THESE
EXPENSES?
WORKER'S COMP DISABILITY.
HIGH MINIMUM WAGE DEMANDS.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IS GOING
UP.
PARGA.
THE THE AND THAT'S BASICALLY
IT'S THE,
THE LEGAL ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
ARE
CREATING FOR OUR BUSINESSES.
THE EXPOSURE THAT WE ARE GIVING
THOSE BUSINESSES MAKES IT
A LOT LESS EXPENSIVE TO INVEST
IN EXPENSIVE MACHINERY,
BUT THAT MACHINERY IS NOT GOING
TO SUE THEM LATER ON.
SO.
ALSO INCREASING LEAVE TIME.
WE'VE SHIFTED THE BURDEN OF
RAISING
FAMILIES AND FINDING
BABYSITTERS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
TO THE EMPLOYER.
SO THERE'S ANOTHER COST THAT
THEY ARE BEARING.
THAT IS MAKING IT MORE EXPENSIVE
FOR THEM TO HAVE EMPLOYEES
THAN TO INVEST IN MACHINES TO DO
THE JOB FOR THEM.
I'VE BEEN TO SEVERAL MARKETS.
THEY THE ONES THAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF MARKETS THAT
HAVE INCORPORATED THESE IN,
AND YES, THERE'S A LOT LESS
PEOPLE
THERE AND THAT'S SAD.
I LIKE TO INTERACT WITH PEOPLE.
AND IN FACT, IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS
I'VE BEEN IN SEVERAL OF
THE DIFFERENT DISTRICTS BELONG
TO MY COLLEAGUES IN HERE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT OUT THERE.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW MUCH
IT
COSTS FOR THEM TO PAY FOR A
MEAL,
FOR THEM TO GO THROUGH THE
REGISTER AT A STORE.
I HEARD ONE YOUNG MAN TALKING
ABOUT
HE'S JUST SAVING ENOUGH MONEY
TO GET OUT OF TOWN BECAUSE HE
CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE HERE.
ALL DAY LONG.
YOU'VE SEEN ME VOTE NO, NO, NO.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE EVERYTHING WE DO IN
THIS, IN THIS BUILDING,
IS ABOUT RAISING THE COST OF
LIVING.
ON OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE THING
THAT THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
I WAS STANDING IN A RESTAURANT
DOWN BY
THE BEACH THE OTHER DAY IN BEACH
CLOTHES.
NOBODY KNOWS ME FROM ADAM.
THIS LADY WALKS UP TO ME AND
SAYS,
HEY, SHE GOES, ARE YOU NEXT?
AND I SAID, NO.
AND SHE GOES, THAT'S WHAT
I WAS AFRAID YOU WOULD SAY.
AND I SAID, WHY?
AND SHE SAID, BECAUSE I HATE
GOING UP TO THE REGISTER.
I'M TERRIFIED AT WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE CHARGING ME.
AND I LOOKED AT HER AND I
THOUGHT,
WHY ARE YOU TELLING ME THIS?
THIS IS.
I'M A COMPLETE STRANGER.
AND THE SAME THING HAPPENED AT
THE STORE.
THAT'S WHEN I TALKED TO THAT
YOUNG MAN WHO'S
GOING TO LEAVE TOWN AS SOON AS
HE SAVES UP.
ENOUGH.
THEY DON'T KNOW THAT I'M A
SENATOR.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT IT OUT
THERE, FOLKS.
LISTEN TO THEM.
STOP DOING THIS TO THEM.
THIS IS ABOUT LABOR.
THIS IS ABOUT TRYING TO SAVE
MORE JOBS
WHILE WE AND WE KEEP INCREASING
THE AMOUNT THAT IT COSTS FOR US
TO EMPLOY PEOPLE.
WE'RE MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
BUSINESSES TO EMPLOY
THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT WE
NEED THEM TO EMPLOY.
AND IF WE FORCE THEM VIA THIS
TYPE OF LEGISLATION,
IF WE FORCE THEM TO TO HIRE
PEOPLE,
WELL, THEN THOSE BUSINESSES GO
OUT OF BUSINESS
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY EMPLOYEES.
AND EVERYBODY MOVES OUT.
FOLKS, WE'RE COLLAPSING THE
ECONOMY
WITH THIS KIND OF LEGISLATION.
WE HAVE TO STOP.
AT SOME POINT WE HAVE TO LET
THIS SETTLE SO
WE CAN SEE WHAT THE DAMAGE IS
AND FIX IT.
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T,
IT'S GOING TO BE TOO LATE PRETTY
SOON.
SO WITH THAT, I WOULD URGE THAT
YOU VOTE NO ON THIS.
AND WE TAKE A HARD LOOK AT ALL
OF
THE BILLS THAT WE ARE PASSING,
BECAUSE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
HAS A COST TO IT.
AND IT'S GOING UP AND UP AND UP.
AND PRETTY SOON NONE OF US WILL
BE ABLE TO AFFORD HERE.
TO LIVE HERE.
I URGE.
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEE NO MICROPHONES UP, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
AND I WANT TO THANK MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY FOR FOR HIS HIS
COMMENTS.
UH, SENATOR UMBERG.
UM.
IT'S SAD THAT OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM ACROSS THE AISLE
SEEM TO THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE
THE PROBLEM.
IT'S SAD.
THAT OUR COLLEAGUES SEEM TO
THINK THAT ENSURING THAT
WORKERS AND WORKING PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT WE RELY ON TO WORK EVERY
DAY,
THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
THE PROBLEM.
THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL IS SIMPLY
DOING,
IS TO SAY THAT WE HAVE TO
PROTECT WORKERS.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
LOOK AT TECHNOLOGIES AND WE
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE TO BE
INTEGRATED
INTO OUR WORK SITES,
THAT WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT
LIFTS UP THE HUMAN ASSET,
THE HUMAN ASSET THAT PAYS
PROPERTY TAX,
THE HUMAN ASSET THAT PAYS INCOME
TAX,
THE HUMAN ASSET THAT PAYS SALES
THAT ACTUALLY SUSTAIN OUR
ECONOMY
ALONG WITH BUSINESS.
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
WORK
FOR A LIVING ARE PROTECTED WHEN
THEY
ARE SHOPPING IN THE STORES.
WE WANT OUR CONSUMERS TO HAVE
AN IN-STORE EXPERIENCE.
WE KNOW THE COMPETITION THAT
EXISTS ONLINE,
BUT WHEN THEY COME INTO A STORE
THAT THEY BE SAFE.
WHEN THEY COME INTO A STORE,
THAT THE WORKERS WHO ARE THERE
ARE SAFE.
WHEN THEY COME INTO A STORE,
THAT THERE IS A PLACE WHERE
FOLKS CAN
ACTUALLY BUY THE GOODS THAT THEY
NEED TO TO BUY IN A SAFE MANNER,
AND THAT ENSURES THAT THE WORKER
AND THE CONSUMER
AND OUR SOCIETY IS ADDRESSING
WHAT HAS
BEEN LABELED AS OUR CRISIS OF
RETAIL THEFT,
THAT WE ARE ALSO ADDRESSING THAT
AS WELL.
I THINK THIS BILL IS A WIN WIN
WIN.
I THINK THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
I HAD AND THE COMPROMISE
THAT WE HAVE WORKED SO HARD FOR
AND WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK TOWARD ON THIS BILL ARE
ACCOMPLISHED
IN THIS VOTE FOR TONIGHT,
AND LET'S VOTE FOR THE PEOPLE.
LET'S VOTE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO WORK,
WHO WE BELIEVE IN AND WHO WE
KNOW THIS
BILL ULTIMATELY WILL PROTECT.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK AND CALL
ENTHUSIASTICALLY
FOR AN I VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN ALVARADO.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER, I BLAKE SPEER.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
COURTESY.
UH, DELI?
NO DOD.
NO.
I, EGGMAN.
GLASER.
NO.
GONZALEZ.
I.
GROVE.
AUTO.
GUY JONES.
NO.
LAIRD, I.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
MAN.
I.
NEWMAN.
I WIN?
NO, NEIL.
NO AKABOGU.
NO PODIUM.
I PONTINA.
I BROUGHT.
HI, RUBIO.
LET'S SAY.
NO.
SKINNER.
I SMILED CUEVAS A STERN.
BY HAMBURG.
I.
WAHAB.
I WIENER.
I WOKE.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
ALL RODA-GIL.
NO.
BLAKE SPEAR.
BRADFORD.
TY COBB.
GROVE.
NO.
MENGIBAR BY RUBIO.
I.
ON A VOTE OF 25 TO 12.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE TWO MEASURES LEFT ON OUR
DOCKET TONIGHT.
NEXT ONE UP IS FILE ITEM 180.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 1504 BY
SENATOR STERN.
SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1504 BY SENATOR
STERN.
AN ACT RELATING TO SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS.
SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS.
UM, BIPARTISAN MEASURE HERE TO.
TACKLE THE ISSUE OF
CYBERBULLYING
TO REQUIRE A REPORTING
MECHANISM TO BE PROMINENTLY
SHOWN ON A PLATFORM.
SO IF THERE ARE INCIDENTS OF
CYBERBULLYING,
NOT ONLY CAN YOU REPORT IT,
BUT A TEACHER COULD REPORT IT,
A PARENT COULD REPORT IT,
AND THAT THE PLATFORMS WILL BE
REQUIRED
TO ACTUALLY REQUIRE WRITTEN
CONFIRMATION OF RECEIPT OF
THE REPORT WITHIN 36 HOURS,
AS WELL AS A STATEMENT OF
DETERMINATION WITHIN
TEN DAYS OF RECEIPT OF THE
REPORT.
AND THEN IF THAT REPORT IS
ACTUALLY NOT RESPONDED TO,
OR IF THAT CLICK GOES NOWHERE,
PARENTS AND TEACHERS AND
GUARDIANS
WILL HAVE SOME KIND OF RECOURSE.
THIS IS THE BARE MINIMUM KIND OF
RESPONSE WE NEED FOR AN EPIDEMIC
THAT'S GOING ON ON OUR PLATFORMS
WITH OUR CHILDREN.
SPILLS RECEIVED NO.
NO VOTES.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR STERN.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD
ON THIS BILL?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO I ARCHULETA.
I ASHBY.
I ATKINS, I BECKER.
I BLAKESBURG.
I BRADFORD.
I OTTO.
I CORTEZ.
I DELHI.
DONE.
I THOUGHT ALSO I.
EGGMAN.
I GLASER.
I I.
GONZALEZ.
I GROVE OR DATO I JONES.
I LAIRD I LEMON.
I MAGUIRE.
I MENGIBAR.
I MEN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN.
NILO.
AKOBO.
I PEDDUR.
I DON'T KNOW.
I ROTH, I RUBIO, I SATO.
SKINNER I SMALL I.
STERN I UMBERG I.
I WINNER, I WILL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN DARLEY.
GROVE.
WHEN?
NIILO SATO.
ON A VOTE OF 34 TO 0.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE ONE LAST ITEM ON OUR
DOCKET FOR TONIGHT
BEFORE WE GO TO MEASURES ON
CALL.
THAT'S FILE ITEM 223,
SENATE BILL 1262 BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1262 BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA.
AN ACT RELATING TO SUPERVISED
RELEASE.
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
&GT;&GT; THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN AND BRING YOU SENATE
BILL
1262 TO MAKE MODEST CHANGES TO
THE CALIFORNIA POST-RELEASE
SUPERVISION
LAW TO ALLOW LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT
AND PUBLIC SAFETY PROFESSIONALS
ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS IN DETERMINING THE
PROPER
RESPONSE FOR REPEAT OFFENDERS.
ENHANCING OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY
WITHIN THE POST-RELEASE
COMMUNITY.
SUPERVISION WOULD HELP ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO SUCCESSFULLY
FACILITATE
TRANSITION OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY LIFE.
THE BILL PRIORITIZES
ACCOUNTABILITY TO PREVENT
REPEAT OFFENDERS ON COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION
AND NEEDED OVERSIGHT INFORMATION
TO ENSURE THE APPROPRIATE
PERSONS RECEIVE THIS TYPE OF
RELEASE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD
ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE.
THE SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA.
I.
ASHBY I.
ATKINS.
I.
BECKER.
BLAKE.
SPEER.
I.
BRADFORD.
CABALLERO.
COURTESY I DALLY, I DOT.
I THOUGHT ALSO I EGMOND I GLASER
I I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
I OTERO I JONES, I LAIRD, I
LAMONT.
I MAGUIRE, I MENGIBAR.
I MEAN.
I NEWMAN, I WIN.
A NEW LOW.
I AJOBA I PADAM.
I PORTANTINO.
I BRAD.
I RUBIO.
I SOURTOE.
UH.
SKINNER.
I SMALL QUAVERS.
I STERN.
I UMMAR.
I WAHAB.
I WIENER I WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN CABALLERO I AYES 39.
NO, ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO
NOW GO BACK TO BILLS ON CALL.
LIKE TO ASK EVERYONE TO TAKE
THEIR SEATS.
AND BECAUSE IT CAN GET A LITTLE
CONFUSING HERE,
I'M GOING TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN FIRST WITH.
FILE ITEM 157.
THIS IS THE SENATE BILL 1188 BY
SENATOR LAIRD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
PLEASE CALL THE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
EXCUSE ME.
ALAN.
ALVARADO GILL.
EGGMAN.
I HURTADO.
MCGUIRE.
I.
SKINNER.
AYES 29.
NOES EIGHT.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 159 BY
SENATOR DURAZZO.
THIS IS SB 1201.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN AL ROJO.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY.
ATKINS I.
BLAKESBURG.
CABALLERO I.
CORTEZ I.
EGGMAN I GLAZER.
MAGUIRE I MENGIBAR.
I ROTH.
RUBIO.
SKINNER.
I.
JUST NEED TO KNOW.
UH, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ALAN.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY.
BLAKE.
SPERM.
GLASER.
I I.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
ON A VOTE OF 23 TO 10.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 161 BY
SENATOR LEMON.
THIS IS SB 1220.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN.
I'LL RODA-GIL.
I.
BECKER I, BLAKE.
SPEER.
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I.
DALLY?
NO.
GROVE?
JONES.
NO.
RUBIO I.
MAGUIRE I.
PORTENTINO I SKINNER I.
ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 7.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 162.
SENATE BILL 1253 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN BRADFORD.
GOD.
HURTADO.
MAGUIRE I MENGIBAR.
HI, ROD.
SKINNER.
I.
ON A VOTE OF 26 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 111.
THIS IS SB 1400 BY SENATOR
STERN.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN EGGMAN.
I GLASER I, I.
MCGUIRE I.
THAT MEASURE PASSES 39 TO 0.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 114.
SB 1460 BY SENATOR DURAZZO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN EGGMAN.
GLASER, I.
I.
MCGUIRE, I.
SMALL QUAVERS.
I.
BOB RODA-GIL, I DON'T KNOW.
EGGMAN I.
ON A VOTE OF 30 TO 9.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 120.
THIS IS SB 1119 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ARCHULETA.
GLASER I, I.
ARCHULETA I.
MCGUIRE I.
THAT'S 39 TO 0.
AND THE URGENCY.
39 TO 0.
ON THE MEASURE.
NEXT.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 131.
THIS IS SB 959 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ELLEN GLASER, I, I.
MCGUIRE, I.
THAT PASSES WITH A VOTE OF 31 TO
8.
NEXT UP, FILE ITEM 137 BY
SENATOR LEMON.
THIS IS SB 1036.
ELLEN DOLLY GLASER.
GROVE.
GLASER I.
GLASER, I.
MCGUIRE.
I.
AKOBO.
RUBIO I UMBERG.
I.
ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 5.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
&GT;&GT; WOW.
HEY, FIRST AND FOREMOST, THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT.
AND TO ALL THE SENATORS,
IT'S BEEN ONE HECK OF A DAY.
CANNOT SAY THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR
THE TREMENDOUS WORK.
AND WE CONTINUE TO RUN A BIT
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
113 BILLS WERE DISPENSED WITH
TODAY,
WHICH WE ARE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL
FOR.
IF WE DO THE SAME TOMORROW,
THURSDAY,
FRIDAY, EVERYONE KNOCK ON WOOD.
IF WE DO THE SAME TOMORROW,
WE WILL BE IN GOOD SHAPE.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
MAJORITY LEADER.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE ASSISTANT MAJORITY LEADERS.
THE FLOOR TEAM AND OF COURSE,
THE DESK STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK
AND THE PRESIDING OFFICERS.
WE GOT A BIG DAY AHEAD OF US
TOMORROW.
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED
FOR WEDNESDAY, MAY 22ND AT 10
A.M..
NICE WORK, MR.
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU, MR.
PRO TEM.
THE SENATE IS ADJOURNED.
WE WILL RECONVENE WEDNESDAY,
MAY 22ND, 2024 AT 10 A.M..